foreign
S have a lot of misconceptions about
machine learning many say using machine
learning humans can do timetable machine
learning is not a magic the term machine
learning is everywhere these days from
self-driving cars to voice recognition
software and robotic activities the
study of machine learning focuses on
software that can learn from examples
the growth in technology has led to
increasing demand for professionals who
can understand and use a vast amount of
data every day companies like Facebook
Google Tesla and many more are
constantly hiring machine learning
professionals with salaries going as
high as 250 000 today we present you the
machine learning full course you will
begin with the fundamentals of machine
learning and walk you through the
advanced machine learning Concepts and
algorithms used in the process we will
be briefing you with a detailed
introduction to machine learning that
covers the sources of data types of
machine learning and applications post
that we'll dive deep into understanding
the fundamental differences between AI
ML and deep learning as their own have
similar roles and responsibilities
proceeding with the course will teach
you different machine learning
algorithms with Hands-On demo
explanations and python up ahead we'll
get into applications of machine
learning proceeding we will walk you
through some amazing projects like fake
news detection object detection and mask
detection these projects will serve you
as the finest portfolios for your future
interviews speaking of interviews we
have covered you along with the most
frequent asked machine learning
interview questions to help you track
the toughest interviews if you are an
aspiring machine learning engineer
looking for online training and
certifications from prestigious
universities and in collaboration with
leading experts then search no more
simple lens professional certification
program in Ai and machine learning from
Purdue University in collaboration with
IBM should be a right choice for more
details use the link in the description
box below with that in mind or to our
training experts we know humans learn
from their past experiences
and machines follow instructions given
by humans
but what if humans can train the
machines to learn from their past data
and to what humans can do act much
faster well that's called machine
learning but it's a lot more than just
learning it's also about understanding
and reasoning so today we will learn
about the basics of machine learning
so that's Paul he loves listening to new
songs
he either likes them or dislikes them
Paul decides this on the basis of the
song's Tempo Jonah intensity and the
gender of voice for Simplicity let's
just use Tempo and intensity for now so
here Tempo is on the x-axis ranging from
relaxed to fast whereas intensity is on
the y-axis ranging from light to Soaring
we see that Paul likes the song with
fast tempo and soaring intensity while
he dislikes a song with relaxed Tempo
and light intensity so now we know
Paul's choices let's say Paul listens to
a new song Let's name it as song a song
a has fast tempo and a soaring intensity
so it lies somewhere here looking at the
data can you guess whether Paul will
like the song or not correct so Paul
likes this song by looking at Paul's
past choices we were able to classify
the unknown song very easily right let's
say now Paul is reasons to a new song
Let's label it as song b so song b lies
somewhere here with medium Tempo and
medium intensity neither relaxed nor
fast neither light nor soaring now can
you guess where the ball likes it or not
not able to guess where this ball will
like it or dislike it other choices
unclear correct we could easily classify
song A but when the choice became
complicated as in the case of song b yes
and that's where machine learning comes
in let's see how in the same example for
song p if you draw a circle around the
song b we see that there are four votes
for like whereas one vote for dislike if
we go for the majority votes we can say
that Paul will definitely like the song
that's all this was a basic machine
learning algorithm also it's called K
nearest neighbors so this is just a
small example in one of the many machine
learning algorithms quite easy right
believe me it is but what happens when
the choices become applicated as in the
case of song b that's when machine
learning comes in it learns the data
builds the prediction model and when the
new data point comes in it can easily
project for it more the data better the
model higher will be the accuracy there
are many ways in which the machine
learns it could be either supervised
learning unsupervised learning or
reinforcement learning let's first
quickly understand supervised learning
suppose your friend gives you 1 million
coins of three different currencies say
one rupee one Euro and one dirham each
coin has different weights for example a
coin of one rupee weighs 3 grams one
Euro weighs 7 grams and one dirham
weighs 4 grams your model will predict
the currency of the coin here your
weight becomes the feature of coins
while currency becomes their label when
you feed this data to the machine
learning model it learns which feature
is associated with which sleep for
example it will learn that if a coin is
of 3 grams it will be a 1 rupee Point
let's give a new coin to the machine on
the basis of the weight of the new coin
your model will predict the currency
hence supervised learning uses labels
data to train the model here the machine
knew the features of the object and also
the labels associated with those
features on this note let's move to
unsupervised learning and see the
difference suppose you have Cricut data
set of various players with their
respective scores and wickets taken when
you feed this data set to the machine
the machine identifies the pattern of
player performance so it plots this data
with the respective wickets on the
x-axis while it runs on the y-axis by
looking at the data you will clearly see
that there are two clusters the one
cluster are the players who scored High
runs and took less wickets while the
other cluster is of the players who
scored less runs but took many wickets
so here we interpret these two clusters
as batsman and Bowlers the important
point to note here is that there were no
labels of batsman and Bowlers hence the
learning with only labeled data is
unsupervised learning so we saw
supervised learning where the data was
labeled and the unsupervised learning
where the data was unlabeled and then
there is reinforcement learning which is
reward-based learning or we can say that
it works on the principle of feedback
here let's say you provide the system
with an image of a dog and ask it to
identify it the system identifies it as
a cat so you give a negative feedback to
the machine saying that it's a dog's
image the machine will learn from the
feedback and finally if it comes across
any other image of a dog it will be able
to classify it correctly that is
reinforcement learning to generalize
machine learning model let's see a
flowchart input is given to a machine
learning model which then gives the
output according to the algorithm
applied if it's right we take the output
as a final result else we provide
feedback to the training model and ask
it to predict until it learns I hope
you've understood supervised and
unsupervised learning so let's have a
quick quiz you have to determine whether
the given scenarios uses supervised or
unsupervised learning simple right
scenario 1 Facebook recognizes your
friend in a picture from an album of
tagged photographs
scenario 2 Netflix recommends new movies
based on someone's Past movie choices
scenario 3 analyzing Bank data for
suspicious transactions and flagging the
fraud transactions think wisely and
comment below your answers moving on
don't you sometimes wonder how is
machine learning possible in today's era
well that's because today we have
humongous data available everybody's
online either making a transaction or
just surfing the internet and that's
generating a huge amount of data every
minute and that data my friend is the
key to analysis also the memory handling
capabilities of computers have largely
increased which helps them to process
such huge amount of data at hand without
any delay and yes computers now have
great computational Powers so there are
a lot of applications of machine
learning out there to name a few machine
learning is used in healthcare where
Diagnostics are predicted for doctor's
review the sentiment analysis that the
tech Giants are doing on social media is
another interesting application of
machine learning fraud detection in the
finance sector and also to predict
customer churn in the e-commerce sector
while booking a cab you must have
encountered search pricing often where
it says the fare of your trip has been
updated continue booking yes please I'm
getting late for office well that's an
interesting machine learning model which
is used by Global Taxi giant Uber and
others where they have differential
pricing in real time based on demand the
number of cars available bad weather
Rush R Etc so they use the search
pricing model to ensure that those who
need a cab can get one also it uses
predictive modeling to predict where the
demand will be high with a goal that
drivers can take care of the demand and
search pricing can be minimized great
hey Siri can you remind me to book a cab
at 6 pm today okay I'll remind you
thanks no problem here we have our
today let me tell you what is machine
learning machine learning works on the
development of computer programs that
can access data and use it to
automatically learn and improve from
experience watch a robot builder
construct a house in two days this was
back in July 29th
2016. so that's pretty impressive this
amount of time to continue to grow in
its development and it's smart enough to
leave spaces in the brickwork for wiring
and plumbing and can even cut and shape
bricks to size
Amazon Echo relies on machine learning
and with more data it becomes more
accurate play your favorite music order
pizza from Domino's voice control your
home request rides from Uber have you
ever wondered the difference between AI
machine learning and deep learning
artificial intelligence a technique
which enables machines to mimic human
behavior
which is really important because this
is how we are able to gauge how well our
computations or what we're working on
works is the fact that we're mimicking
human behavior we're using this to
replace human work and make it more
efficient and make it more streamlined
and more accurate and so the center of
artificial intelligence is the big
picture of all this put together IBM
deep blue chess electronic game
characters those are just a couple
examples of artificial intelligence
machine learning a technique which uses
statistical methods enabling machines to
learn from their past data so this means
if you have your input from last time
and you have your answer you use that to
help prove the next guess it makes for
the correct answer IBM Watson Google
search algorithm email spam filters
these are all part of machine learning
and then deep learning which is a subset
of machine learning composing algorithms
that allow a model to trade itself and
perform tasks alphago natural speech
recognition these are a couple examples
deep learning is associated with tools
like neural networks where it's kind of
a black box as it learns it changes all
these things that are as a human we
would have a very hard time tracking and
it's able to come up with an answer from
that now let's see how machine learning
works first we start with training the
data once we've trained the data the
train we go into the machine learning
algorithm which then puts the data into
a processing which then goes down to
machine another machine learning
algorithm and then we take new data
because you have to test whatever you
did to make sure it works correctly and
we put that into the same algorithm once
we do that we check our prediction we
check our results and from the
prediction if we've set aside some
training date and we find out it didn't
do a good job predicting it and it gets
a thumbs down as you see then we go back
to the beginning and we retrain the
algorithm and a lot of times it's not
just about getting the wrong answer it's
about continually trying to get a better
answer so you'll see the first time you
might be like oh this is not the answer
I want depending on what domain you're
working in whether it medical economical
business stocks whatever you try out
your model and if it's not giving you a
good answer you retrain it if you think
you can get a better answer you retrain
it and you keep doing that until you get
the best answer you can if you are an
aspiring machine learning engineer
looking for online training and
certifications from prestigious
universities and in collaboration with
leading experts then search no more
simply learns professional certification
program in Ai and machine learning from
Purdue University in collaboration with
IBM should be a right choice for more
details use the link in the description
box below with that in mind
human versus artificial intelligence
humans are amazing let's just face it
we're amazing creatures we're all over
the planet we're exploring every Nick
Chinook we've gone to the Moon uh we've
gone into outer space we're just amazing
creatures we're able to use the
available information to make decisions
to communicate with other people
identify patterns and data remember what
people have said adapt to new situations
so let's take a look at this so you can
get a picture you're a human being so
you know it's like to be human let's
take a look at artificial intelligence
versus the human artificial intelligence
develops computer systems it can
accomplish texts that require human
intelligence
so we're looking at this one of the
things that computers can do is they can
provide more accurate results this is
very important recently I did a project
on cancer whereas identifying markers
and as a human being you look at that
and you might be looking at all the
different images and the data that comes
off of them and say I like this person
so I want to give them a very good
outlook and the next person you might
not like so you want to give them a bad
Outlook well with artificial
intelligence you're going to get a
consistent prediction of what's going to
come out interacts with humans using
their natural language we've seen that
as probably the biggest development
feature right now that's in the
commercial Market that everybody gets to
use as we saw with the example of Alexa
they learn from their mistakes and adapt
to new environments so we see this
slowly coming in more and more and they
learn from the data and automate
repetitive learning repetitive learning
has a lot to do with the neural networks
you have to program thousands upon
thousands of pictures in there and it's
all automated so as today's computers
evolve it's very quick and easy and
affordable to do this
what is machine learning and deep
learning all about
imagine this say you had some time to
waste not that any of us really have a
lot of time anymore to just waste in
today's world
and you're sitting by the road and you
have a whole lot and a whole lot of time
passes by there's a few hours
and suddenly you wonder
how many cars buses trucks and so on
passed by in the six hours
now chances are you're not going to sit
by the road for six hours and count
buses cars and trucks unless you're
working for the city and you're trying
to do City Planning and you want to know
hey do we need to add a new truck route
maybe we need a bicycle length we have a
lot of bicyclists here that kind of
thing so maybe City Planning would be
great for this
machine learning well the way machine
Learning Works is we have labeled data
with features okay so you have a truck
or a car a motorcycle a bus or a bicycle
and each one of those are labeled it
comes in and based on those labels and
comparing those features it gives you an
answer it's a bicycle it's a truck it's
a motorcycle this is a little bit more
in depth on this
and the model here it actually the
features we're looking at would be like
the tires someone sits there and figures
out what a tire looks like takes a lot
of work if you try to try to figure a
difference between a car tire a bicycle
tire a motorcycle tire uh so in the
machine learning field this could take a
long time if you're going to do each
individual aspect of a car and try to
get a result on there and that's what
they did do that was a very this is
still used on smaller amounts of data we
figure out what those features are and
then you label them
deep learning so with deep learning one
of our Solutions is to take a very large
unlabeled data set
and we put that into a training model
using artificial neural networks and
then that goes into the neural network
itself when we create a neural network
and you'll see the arrows are actually
kind of backward but uh which actually
is a nice point because when we train
the neural network
we put the bicycle in and then it comes
back and says if it's a truck it comes
back and says well you need to change
that to bicycle and then it changes all
those weights going backward they call
it back propagation and let it know it's
a bicycle and that's how it learns
once you've trained the neural network
you then put the new data in and they
call this testing the model so you need
to have some data you've kept off to the
side where you know the answer to and
you take that and you provide the
required output and you say okay is this
is this neural network working correctly
did it identify a bike as a bike a truck
is a truck a motorcycle as a motorcycle
let's just take a little closer look at
that
determining what objects are present in
the data so how does deep learning do
this and here we have the image of the
bike it's 28 by 28 pixels that's a lot
of information there could you imagine
trying to guess that this is a bicycle
image by looking at each one of those
pixels and trying to figure out what's
around it and we actually do that as
human beings it's pretty amazing we know
what a bicycle is and even though it
comes in as all this information and
what this looks like is the image comes
in
it converts it into a bunch of different
nodes in this case there's a lot more
than what they show here and it goes
through these different layers and
outcomes and says okay this is a bicycle
a lot of times they call this the magic
Black Box why because as we watch it go
across here all these weights and all
the math behind this and it's not it's a
little complicated on the math side you
really don't need to know that when
you're programming or doing working with
the Deep learning but it's like magic
you don't know you really can't figure
out what's going to come out by looking
what's in each one of those dots and
each one of those lines are firing and
what's going in between them so we like
to call it the magic box so that's where
deep learning comes in
and in the end it comes up and you have
this whole neural network it comes up
and it says okay we fire all these
different pixels and we connect all
these different dots and gives them
different weights and it says okay this
is a bicycle and that's how we determine
what the object is present in the data
with deep learning
machine learning we're going to take a
step into machine learning here and
you'll see how these fit together in a
minute the system is able to make
predictions or take decisions based on
past data that's very important for
machine learning is that we're looking
at stuff and based on what's been there
before we're creating a decision on
there we're creating something out of
there we're coloring a beach ball we're
telling you what the weather is in
Chicago
what's nice about machine learning is a
very powerful processing capability it's
quick and accurate outcomes so you get
results right away once you program the
system the results are very fast and the
decisions and predictions are better
they're more accurate they're consistent
you can analyze very large amounts of
data some of these data things that
they're analyzing now are petabytes and
terabytes of data it would take hundreds
of people hundreds of years to go
through some of this data and do the
same thing that the machine learning can
do in a very short period of time and
it's inexpensive compared to hiring
hundreds of people so because a very
affordable way to move into the future
is to apply the machine learning to
whatever businesses you're working on
and deep Learning Systems think and
learn like humans using artificial
neural networks again it's like a magic
box performance improves with more data
so the more data the Deep learning gets
the more it gives you better results
it's scalability so you can scale it up
you can scale it down you can increase
what you're looking at currently you
know we're limited by the amount of
computer processing power as to how big
that can get but that envelope
continually gets pushed every day on
what it can do
problem solved in an end-to-end method
so instead of having to break it apart
and you have the first piece coming in
and you identify tires and the second
piece is identifying labeling handlebars
and then you bring that together that if
it has handlebars and tires it's a
bicycle and if it has something that
looks like a large Square it's probably
a truck the neural networks does this
all in one network you don't really know
what's going on in all those weights and
all those little bubbles but it does it
pretty much in one package that's why
the neural network systems are so big
nowadays and coming into their own
best features are selected by the system
and it this is important they kind of
put it's on a bullet on the side here
it's a subset of machine learning this
is important when we talk about deep
learning it is a form of machine
learning there's lots of other forms of
machine learning data analysis but this
is the newest and biggest thing that
they apply to a lot of different
packages and they use all the other
machine learning tools available to work
with it and it's very fast to test you
put in your information you then have
your group of tests and then you held
some aside you see how does it do it's
very quick to test it and see what's
going on with your deep learning and
your neural network
are they really all that different
AI versus machine learning versus deep
learning concepts of AI
so we have a concepts of I I you'll see
natural language processing machine
learning and approach to create
artificial intelligence so it's one of
the subsets of artificial intelligence
knowledge representation automated
reasoning computer vision robotics
machine learning versus AI versus deep
learning or Ai and machine learning and
deep learning
so we look at this we have ai with
machine learning and deep learning and
so we're going to put them all together
we find out that AI is a big picture we
have a collection of books it goes
through some deep learning the Digital
Data is analyzed text mining comes
through the particular book you're
looking for maybe it's a genre books is
identified and in this case we have a
robot that goes and gives a book to the
patron I have yet to be at a library
that has a robot bring me a book but
that will be cool when it happens so
we'll look at some of the pieces here
this information goes into uh there's as
far as this example the translation of
the handwritten printed data to digital
form
that's pretty hard to do that's pretty
hard to go in there and translate
hundreds and hundreds of books and
understand what they're trying to say if
you've never read them so in this case
we used a deep learning because you can
already use examples where they've
already classified a lot of books and
then they can compare those texts and
say oh okay this is a book on automotive
repair this is a book on robotic
building the Digital Data is in analyzed
then we have more text mining using
machine learning so maybe we'd use a
different program to do a basic classify
what you're looking for and say oh
you're looking for auto repair and
computers so you're looking for
automated cars once it's identified then
of course it brings you the book
so here's a nice summation of what we
were just talking about AI with machine
learning and deep learning deep learning
is a subset of machine learning which is
a subset of artificial intelligence
so you can look at artificial
intelligence as the big picture how does
this compare to The Human Experience in
either doing the same thing as a human
we do or it does it better than us and
machine learning which has a lot of
tools is something that learns from data
past experiences it's programmed it
comes in there and it says hey we
already had these five things happen the
sixth one should be about the same and
then there's a lot of tools in machine
learning but deep learning then is a
very specific tool in machine learning
it's the artificial neural network which
handles large amounts of data and is
able to take huge pools of experiences
pictures and ideas and bring them
together
real life examples
artificial intelligence news generation
very common nowadays as it goes through
there and finds the news articles or
generates the news based upon the news
feeds or the back end coming in and it
says okay let's give you the actual news
based on this there's all the different
things Amazon Echo they have a number of
different Prime music on there of course
there's also the Google command and
there's also Cortana there's tons of
smart home devices now where we can ask
it to turn the TV on or play music for
us that's all artificial intelligence
from front to back you're having a human
experience with these computers and
these objects that are connected to the
processing machine learning spam
detection very common machine learning
doesn't really have the human
interaction part
so this is the part where it goes and
says okay that's a Spam that's not a
Spam and it puts it in your spam folder
search engine result refining another
example of machine learning whereas it
looks at your different results and it
Go and it is able to categorize them as
far as this had the most hits this is
the least viewed this has five stars you
know however they want to weight it all
exam good examples of machine learning
and then the Deep learning deep learning
another example is as you have like a
exit sign in this case is translating it
into French sorti I hope I said that
right
neural network has been programmed with
all these different words and images and
so it's able to look at the exit in the
middle and it goes okay we want to know
what that is in French and it's able to
push that out in France French and learn
how to do that
and then we have chat Bots I remember
when Microsoft first had their little
paper clip
um boy that was like a long time ago
they came up and you would type in there
and chat with it these are growing you
know it's nice to just be able to ask a
question and it comes up and gives you
the answer and instead of it being were
you just doing a search on certain words
it's now able to start linking those
words together and form a sentence in
that chat box
types of AI and machine learning
types of artificial intelligence this in
the next few slides are really important
so one of the types of artificial
intelligence is reactive machines
systems that only react they don't form
memories they don't have past
experiences they have something that
happens to them and they react to it
my washing machine is one of those if I
put a ton of clothes in it and they had
all clumped on one side it automatically
adds a weight to re-sitter it so that my
washing machine is actually a reactive
machine working with whatever the load
is and keeps it nice and so when it
spins it doesn't go thumping against the
side limited memory another form of
artificial intelligence systems look
into the past information is added over
a period of time and information is
short-lived when we're talking about
this and you look at like a neural
network that's been programmed to
identify cars it doesn't remember all
those pictures it has no memory as far
as hundreds of pictures you process
through it all it has is this is the
pattern I use to identify cars as the
final output for that neural network we
looked at
so when they talk about limited memory
this is what they're talking about
they're talking about I've created this
based on all these things but I'm not
going to remember anyone specifically
theory of Mind systems being able to
understand human emotions and how they
affect decision making to adjust their
behaviors according to their human
understanding
this is important because this is our
page mark this is how we know whether it
is an artificial intelligence or not is
it interacting with humans in a way that
we can understand
without that interaction is just an
object so we talk about theory of mind
we really understand how it interfaces
that whole if you're in web development
user experience would be the term I
would put in there so the theory of mine
would be user experience how's the whole
UI connected together and one of the
final things is as we get into
artificial intelligence is systems being
aware of themselves understanding their
internal States and predicting other
people's feelings and act appropriately
so as artificial intelligence continues
to progress we see ones they're trying
to understand well what makes people
happy how would they increase our
happiness how would they keep themselves
from breaking down if something's broken
inside they have that self-awareness to
be able to fix it and just based on all
that information predicting which action
would work the best what would help
people if I know that you're having a
cup of coffee first thing in the morning
is what makes you happy as a robot I
might make you a cup of coffee every
morning at the same time to help your
life and help you grow that'd be the
self-awareness is being able to know all
those different things
types of machine learning and like I
said on the last slide this is very
important this is very important if you
decide to go in and get certified in
machine learning or know more about it
these are the three primary types of
machine learning the first one is
supervised learning systems are able to
predict future outcome based on past
data requires both an input and an
output to be given to the model for it
to be trained
so in this case we're looking at
anything where you have 100 images of a
bicycle
and those hundred images you know are
bicycle so they're preset someone
already looked at 100 images and said
these are pictures of bicycles and so
the computer learns from those and then
it's given another picture
and maybe the next picture is a bicycle
and it says oh that resembles all these
other bicycles so it's a bicycle and the
next one's a car and it says that's not
a bicycle that would be supervised
learning because we had to train it we
had to supervise it unsupervised
learning systems are able to identify
hidden patterns from the input data
provided by making the data more
readable and organized the patterns
similarities or anomalies become more
evident you'll heard the term cluster
how do you cluster things together some
of these things go together some of
these don't this is unsupervised where
it can look at an image and start
pulling the different pieces of the
image out
because they aren't the same the human
all the parts of the human are not the
same as a fuzzy tree behind them just
slightly out of focus which is not the
same as the beach ball it's unsupervised
because we never told it what a beach
ball was we never told it what the human
was and we never told it that those were
trees all we told it was hey separate
this picture by things that don't match
and things that do match and come
together
and finally there's reinforcement
learning systems are given no training
it learns on the basis of the reward
punishment it received for performing
its Last Action it helps increase the
efficiency of a tool function or a
program reinforced learning a
reinforcement learning is kind of you
give it a yes or no yes you gave me the
right response no you didn't and then it
looks at that and says oh okay so based
on this data coming in what I gave you
was a wrong response so next time I'll
give you a different one
comparing machine learning and deep
learning so remember that deep learning
is a subcategory of machine learning so
it's one of the many tools and so they
were grouping a ton of machine learning
tools all together linear regression K
means clustering there's all kinds of
cool tools out there you can use in
machine learning enables machines to
take decisions to make decisions on
their own based on past data enables
machines to make decisions with the help
of artificial neural networks so it's
doing the same thing but we're using an
artificial neural network as opposed to
one of the more traditional machine
learning tools needs only a small amount
of training data this is very important
when you're talking about machine
learning
they're usually not talking about huge
amounts of data we're talking about
maybe your spreadsheet from your
business and your totals for the end of
the year when you're talking about
neural networks you usually need a large
amount of data to train the data so
there's a lot of training involved if
you have under 500 points of data that's
probably not going to go into machine
learning or maybe you have like the case
of one of the things 500 points of data
and 30 different fields it starts
getting really confusing there and
artificial intelligence or machine
learning and the Deep learning aspect
really shines when you get to that
larger data that's really complex
works well on a low end systems so a lot
of the machine learning tools out there
you can run on your laptop with no
problem and do the calculations there
where with the machine learning usually
needs a higher end system to work it
takes a lot more processing power to
build those neural networks and to train
them it goes through a lot of data we're
talking about the general machine
learning tools most features need to be
identified in advanced and manually
coded so there's a lot of human work on
here the machine learns the features
from the data it is provided so again
it's like a magic box you don't have to
know what a tire is it figures it out
for you
the problem is divided into parts and
solved individually and then combined so
machine learning you usually have all
these different tools and use different
tools for different parts and the
problem is solved in an end-to-end
manner so you only have one neural
network or two neural networks that is
bringing the data in and putting it out
it's not going through a lot of
different processes to get there and
remember you can put machine learning
and deep learning together so you don't
always have just the Deep learning
solving the problem I have installing
one piece of the puzzle
with regular machine learning emotional
machine learning tools out there they
take longer to test and understand how
they work
and with the Deep learning it's pretty
quick once you build that neural network
you test it and you know
so we're dealing with very crisp rules
limited resources you have to really
explain how the decision was made when
you use most machine learning tools but
when you use the Deep learning tool
inside the machine learning tools the
system takes care of it based on its own
logic and reasoning and again it's like
a magic Black Box you really don't know
how it came up with the answer you just
know it came up with the right answer a
glimpse into the future so a quick
glimpse into the future artificial
intelligence be using it to detecting
crimes before they happen humanoid AI
helpers which we already have a lot of
there'll be more and more maybe it'll
actually be Androids that'd be cool to
have an Android that comes and get stuff
out of my fridge for me machine learning
increasing efficiency in healthcare
that's really big in all the forms of
machine learning better marketing
techniques any of these things if we get
into the Sciences it's just off the
scale machine learning and artificial
intelligence go everywhere and then the
subcategory Deep learning increased
personalization in so what's really nice
about the Deep learning is it's going to
start now catering to you that'll be one
of the things we see more and more of
and we'll have more of a hyper
intelligent personal assistant I'm
excited about that if you are an
aspiring machine learning engineer
looking for online training and
certifications from prestigious
universities and in collaboration with
leading experts then search no more
simply learns professional certification
program in Ai and machine learning from
Purdue University in collaboration with
IBM should be a right choice for more
details use the link in the description
box below with that in mind
now let's look into the types of machine
learning
machine learning is primarily of three
types first one is supervised machine
learning as the name suggests you have
to supervise your machine learning while
you train it to work on its own it
requires label training data next up is
unsupervised learning wherein there will
be training data but it won't be labeled
finally there is reinforcement learning
wherein the system learns on its own
let's talk about all these types in
detail let's try to understand how
supervised Learning Works look at the
pictures very very carefully the monitor
depicts the model or the system that we
are going to train
this is how the training is done we
provide a data set that contains
pictures of a kind of a fruit say an
apple
then we provide another data set which
lets the model know that these pictures
where that of a fruit called Apple
this ends the training phase now what we
will do is we provide a new set of data
which only contains pictures of Apple
now here comes the fun part the system
can actually tell you what fruit it is
and it will remember this and apply this
knowledge in future as well
that's how supervised Learning Works you
are training the model to do a certain
kind of an operation on its own
this kind of a model is generally used
into filtering spam mails from your
email accounts as well yes surprise
aren't you
so let's move on to unsupervised
learning now let's say we have a data
set which is cluttered in this case we
have a collection of pictures of
different fruits we feed these data to
the model and the model analyzes the
data to figure out patterns in it in the
end it categorizes the photos into three
types as you can see in the image based
on their similarities
so you provide the data to the system
and let the system do the rest of the
work simple isn't it this kind of a
model is used by Flipkart to figure out
the products that are well suited for
you honestly speaking this is my
favorite type of machine learning out of
all the three and this type has been
widely shown in most of the Sci-Fi
movies lately let's find out how it
works imagine a newborn baby
you put a burning candle in front of the
baby the baby does not know that if it
touches the flame its fingers might get
burnt
so it does that anyway and gets hurt the
next time you put that candle in front
of the baby it will remember what
happened the last time and would not
repeat what it did that's exactly how
reinforcement learning works
we provide the machine with a data set
wherein we ask it to identify a
particular kind of a fruit in this case
an apple
so what it does as a response it tells
us that it's a mango but as we all know
it's a completely wrong answer so as a
feedback we tell the system that it's
wrong it's not a mango it's an apple
what it does it learns from the feedback
and keeps that in mind
when the next time when we ask a same
question it gives us the right answer it
is able to tell us that it's actually an
apple that is a reinforced response so
that's how reinforcement learning works
it learns from his mistakes and
experiences this model is used in games
like Prince of Persia or Assassin's
Creed or FIFA wherein the level of
difficulty increases as you get better
with the games
just to make it more clear for you let's
look at a comparison between supervised
and unsupervised learning firstly the
data involved in case of supervised
learning is labeled as we mentioned in
the examples previously
we provide the system with a photo of an
apple and let the system know that this
is actually an apple
that is called label data so the system
learns from the label data and makes
future predictions
now unsupervised learning does not
require any kind of label data because
its work is to look for patterns in the
input data and organize it
the next point is that you get a
feedback in case of supervised learn
that is once you get the output the
system tends to remember that and uses
it for the next operation
that does not happen for unsupervised
learning and the last point is that
supervised learning is mostly used to
predict data whereas unsupervised
learning is used to find out hidden
patterns or structures in data
I think this would have made a lot of
things clear for you regarding
supervised and unsupervised learning
data denotes the individual pieces of
factual information collected from
various sources it is stored process and
later used for analysis
and so we see here uh just a huge
grouping of information a lot of tech
stuff money dollar signs numbers uh and
then you have your performing analytics
to drive insights and hopefully you have
a nice share your shareholders gather it
at the meeting and you're able to
explain it in something they can
understand
so we talk about data types of data we
have in our types of data we have a
qualitative categorical
you think nominal or ordinal and then
you have your quantitative or numerical
which is discrete or continuous
and let's look a little closer at those
data type vocabulary always people's
favorite is the vocabulary words okay
not mine
but let's dive into this what we mean by
nominal nominal they are used to label
various uh label our variables without
providing any measurable value
uh country gender race hair color Etc
it's something that you either mark true
or false this is a label it's on or off
either they have a red hat on or they do
not uh so a lot of times when you're
thinking nominal data labels uh think of
it as a true false kind of setup and we
look at ordinal this is categorical data
with a set order or a scale to it and
you can think of salary range as a great
one movie ratings Etc you see here the
celery rains if you have ten thousand to
twenty thousand number of employees
earning that rate is 150 20 000 to 30
000 100 and so forth some of the terms
you'll hear is bucket uh this is where
you have ten different buckets and you
want to separate it into something that
makes sense into those 10 buckets and so
when we start talking about ordinal a
lot of times when you get down to the
breastbones again we're talking true
false so if you're a member of the 10 to
20K Reigns so forth those would each be
either part of that group or you're not
but now we're talking about buckets and
we want to count how many people are in
that bucket
quantitative numerical data falls into
two classes discrete or continuous and
so data with a final set of values which
can be categorized class strength
questions answered correctly and runs
hit and Cricut a lot of times when you
see this you can think integer and a
very restricted integer I.E you can only
have 100 questions on a test so you can
it's very discreet I only have a hundred
different values that it can attain so
think usually you're talking about
integers but within a very small range
they don't have an open end or anything
like that
uh so discrete is very solid simple to
count set number continuous on the other
hand continuous data can take any
numerical value within a range so water
pressure weight of a person Etc usually
we start thinking about float values
where they can get phenomenally small in
their in what they're worth and there's
a whole series of values that falls
right between discrete and continuous
you can think of the stock market you
have dollar amounts it's still discrete
but it starts to get complicated enough
when you have like you know jump in the
stock market from
525.33 to
580.67 cents there's a lot of Point
values in there it'd still be called
discrete but you start looking at it as
almost continuous because it does have
such a variance in it now we talk about
no we did we went over nominal and
ordinal almost true false charts and we
looked at quantitative and numerical
data data which we'll start to get into
numbers discrete you can usually a lot
of times discrete will be put into it
could be put into true false but usually
it's not so we want to address this
stuff and the first thing we want to
look at is the very basic which is your
algebra so we're going to take a look at
linear algebra you can remember back
when your euclidean geometry we have a
line well let's go through this we have
a linear algebra as the domain of
mathematics concerning linear equations
and their representations in Vector
spaces and through matrixes I told you
we're going to talk about Matrix is
so a linear equation is simply
2x plus 4y minus 3z equals 10. very
linear 10x plus 12.4 y equals z and now
you can actually solve these two
equations by combining them unless we're
talking about a linear equation
and the vectors we have a plus b equals
c now we're starting to look at a
direction and these values usually think
of an x y z plot so each one is a
direction and the actual distance of
like a triangle a b is C and then your
Matrix can describe all kinds of things
I find matrixes confuse a lot of people
not because they're particularly
difficult but because of the magnitude
and the different things they're used
for
and a matrix is a chart or a you know
think of a spreadsheet but you have your
rows and your columns and you'll see
here we have a times b equals c very
important to know your counts uh so
depending on how the math is being done
what you're using it for making sure you
have the same rows and number of columns
or a single number there's all kinds of
things that play in that that can make
matrixes confusing but really it has a
lot more to do with what domain you're
working in are you adding in multiple
polynomials where you have like uh a x
squared plus b y plus you know you start
to see they can be very confusing versus
a very straightforward Matrix and let's
just go a little deeper into these
because these are such primary this is
what we're here to talk about is these
different math mathematical computations
that come up
so we're looking at linear equations
let's dig deeper into that one an
equation having a maximum order of one
is called a linear equation
so it's linear because when you look at
this we have ax plus b equals c which is
a one variable
we have two variable ax plus b y equals
c a X plus b y plus z c z equals D and
so forth but all of these are to the
power of one you don't see x squared you
don't see X cubed so we're talking about
linear equations that's what we're
talking about in their addition if you
have already dived into say neural
networks you should recognize this ax
plus b y plus c z
setup plus The Intercept which is
basically your your neural network each
node adding up all the different inputs
and we can drill down into that most
common formula is your y equals MX plus
c
so you have your y equals the M which is
your slope your X Value Plus C which is
your y-intercept it kind of labeled it
wrong here
sue me for a loop but the the C would be
your y-intercept so when you set x equal
to 0 y equals c and that's that's your
y-intercept right there uh and that's
they they just had a reverse value of y
when x equals zero equals the
y-intercept which is C and your slope
gradient line which is your M so these
are y equals two X plus three and
there's lots of easy ways to compute
this this way this is why we always
start with the most basic one when we're
solving one of these problems and then
of course the uh one of the most
important takeaways is the slope
gradient of the line so the slope is
very important that M value in this case
we went ahead and solved this
if you have y equals two X plus three
you can see how it has a nice line graph
here on the right
so matrixes a matrix refers to a
rectangular representation of an array
of numbers arranged in columns and rows
so we're talking M rows by n columns
here a11 is denotes the element of the
first row in the First Column similarly
a 12 and it's really pronounced a11 in
this particular setup so it's a row one
column one a 12 is a of Row one column
two first row and second column and so
on
and there's a lot of ways to denote this
I've seen these as like a capital letter
a smaller case a for the top row or I
mean you can see where they can go all
kinds of different directions as far as
the value
you just take a moment to realize there
needs to be some designation as far as
what row it's in and what column it's in
and we have our basic operations we have
addition so when you think about
addition you have uh two matrixes of two
by two and you just add each individual
number in that Matrix and then when you
get to the bottom you have in this case
the solution is 12 10 plus 2 is 12 5
plus 3 is 8 and so on and the same thing
with subtraction
now again your counting Matrix is you
want to check your dimensions of the
Matrix the shape you'll see shape come
up a lot in programming so we're talking
about Dimensions we're talking about the
shape if the two shapes are equal this
is what happens when you add them
together or subtract them
and we have multiplication when you look
at the multiplication you end up at the
very a slightly different setup going
now if we look at our last one where uh
we're like why this always gets to me
when we get to matrixes they don't
really say why you multiply matrixes
um you know my first thought is one
times two four times three but if you
look at this we get 1 times 2 plus 4
times 3 1 times 3 plus 4 times 5
uh six times two plus three times three
six times three plus three times five if
you're looking at these matrixes uh
think of this more as an equation and so
we have if you remember when we back up
here for our multiple line equations
let's just go back up a couple slides
where we were looking at uh two
variables so this is a two variable
equation ax plus b y equals c
um and this is a way to make it very
quick to solve these variables and
that's why you have the Matrix and
that's why you do
the multiplication the way they do and
this is the dot product of one times two
plus four times three
one times three plus four times five
six times two plus three times three
six times three plus three times five
and it gives us a nice little uh 14 23
21 and 33 over here which then can be
used and reduced down to a sample
formula as far as solving the variables
as you have enough inputs uh and then in
Matrix operations when you're dealing
with a lot of matrixes now keep in mind
multiplying matrixes is different than
finding the product of two matrixes okay
so we're talking about multiplication
we're talking about solving for
equations when you're finding the
product you are just finding one times
two keep that in mind because that does
come up I've had that come up a number
of times where I'm altering data and I
get confused so what I'm doing with it
transpose flipping the Matrix over its
diagonal comes up all the time where you
have you still have 12 but instead of it
being a 12 8 it's now 12 14 821 you're
just flipping the columns in the rows
and then of course you can do an inverse
changing the signs of the values of
across this main diagonal and you can
see here we have the inverse a to the
minus 1 and ends up with uh instead of
12 8 14 12 is now minus 22 minus 12.
vectors Vector just means we have
a value and a Direction
and we have down four numbers here on
our vector
in mathematics a one-dimensional matrix
is called a vector so if you have your X
plot and you have a single value that
value is along the x axis and it's a
single Dimension if you have two
Dimensions you can think about putting
them on a graph you might have X and you
might have y and each value denotes a
direction and then of course the actual
distance is going to be the hypothesis
so that triangle and you can do that
with three dimensionals X Y and Z and
you can do it all the way to nth
Dimensions so when they talk about the K
means for categorizing and how close
data is together they will compute that
based on the Pythagorean theorem so you
would take the square of each value add
them all together and find the square
root and that gives you a distance as
far as where that point is where that
Vector exists or the actual point value
and then you can compare that point
value to another one and it makes a very
easy comparison versus comparing
50 or 60 different numbers and that
brings us up to I Gene vectors and I
Gene values uh hygiene vectors the
vectors that don't change their span
while transformation
and hygiene values the scalar values
that are associated to the vectors
conceptually you can think of the vector
as your picture you have a picture it's
two Dimensions X and Y
and so when you do those two dimensions
and those two values or whatever that
value is
um that is that point but the values
change when you skew it and so if we
take and we have a vector a
and that's a set value uh B is your is
your you have a and b which is your I
Gene Vector 2 is the I Gene value so
we're altering all the values by two
that means we're maybe we're stretching
it out One Direction making it tall if
you're doing picture editing
um that's one of the places this comes
in but you can see when you're
transforming uh your different
information how you transform it is then
your hygiene value and you can see here
a vector after line Transit transition
we have 3A a a is the I Gene Vector
three is the iodine value so a doesn't
change that's whatever we started with
that's your original picture and three
is skewing in One Direction and maybe uh
B is being skewed another Direction and
so you have a nice tilted picture
because you've altered it by those by
the hygiene values
so let's go ahead and pull up a demo on
linear algebra and to do this I'm going
to go through my trusted Anaconda into
my Jupiter notebook
and we'll create a new uh notebook
called linear algebra
since we are working in Python we're
going to use our numpy I always import
that as NP or numpy array probably the
most popular
module for doing matrixes and things in
given that this is part of a series I'm
not going to go too much into numpy we
are going to go ahead and create two
different variables a for a numpy array
10 15 and b 29
. we'll go ahead and run this and you
can see there's our two arrays 10 15 29
and I went and added a space there in
between
so it's easier to read
and since it's the last line we don't
have to put the print statement on it
unless you want we can simply but we can
simply do a plus b so when I run this we
have 10 15 29 and we get 30 24 which is
what you expect 10 plus 20 15 plus 9 you
could almost look at this addition as
being
um
just adding up the columns on here
coming down and if we wanted to do it a
different way we could also do a DOT t
plus b dot T remember that t flips them
and so if we do that we now get them we
now have 30 24 going the other way we
could also do something kind of fun
there's a lot of different ways to do
this
uh as far as a plus b I can also do a
plus b dot t
and you're going to see that that will
come out the same the 3024 whether I
transpose A and B or transpose them both
at the end
and likewise we can very easily subtract
two vectors I can go a minus B
and we run that and we get minus 10 6.
now remember this is the last line in
this particular section that's why not
to put the print around it
and just like we did before
we can transpose either the individual
or we can transpose the main setup and
then we get a minus 10 6 going the other
way
now we didn't mention this in our notes
but you can also do a scalar
multiplication
let me just put down the scalar so you
can remember that
and what we're talking about here is I
have this array here U and if I go a
times U
H we'll take the value 2 we'll multiply
it by every value in here so 2 times 30
is 60 2 times 15
and just like we did before
this happens a lot because when you're
doing matrixes you do need to flip them
you get 60 30 coming this way
so in numpy uh we have what they call
Dot product
and uh with this this is in a
two-dimensional vectors it is the
equivalent of two matrix multiplication
remember we were talking about matrix
multiplication uh where it is the
well let's walk through it
we'll go ahead and start by defining two
numpy arrays we'll have uh 10 20 25 6 or
our U and our V and then we're going to
go ahead and do if we take
the values and if you remember correctly
an array like this would be 10 times 25
plus 20 times 6. we'll go ahead and
print that
there we go
and then we'll go ahead and do the NP
dot dot of U comma
V
and we'll find when we do this we go and
run this we're going to get
370. so this is a strain multiplication
where they use it to solve
linear algebra when you have multiple
numbers going across and so this could
be very complicated we could have a
whole string of different variables
going in here but for this we get a nice
value for our Dot multiplication
and we did addition earlier which is
just your basic addition and of course
the Matrix you can get very complicated
on these or in this case we'll go ahead
and do let's create two complex matrixes
this one is a matrix of
um you know 12 10 4 6 4 31. we'll just
print out a so you can see what that
looks like here's print a
we print a out you can see that we have
a
two by three layer Matrix for a and we
can also put together always kind of fun
when you're playing with print values we
could do something like this we could go
in here
there we go we could print a we have it
end with equals a run and this kind of
gives it a nice look here's your Matrix
that's all this is comma N means it just
tags it on the end that's all all that
is doing on there and then we can simply
add in what is a plus b and you should
already guess because this is the same
as what we did before there's no
difference we do a simple vector
addition we have 12 plus 2 is 14 10 plus
8 is 18 and so on
and just like we did The Matrix addition
we can also do a minus B and do our
Matrix subtraction
and we look at this we have what 12
minus 2 is 10 10 minus eight uh where
are we
oh there we go eight minus ah
confusing what I'm looking at I should
have reprinted out the original numbers
but we can see here 12 minus 2 is of
course 10 10 minus 8 is 2 4 minus 46 is
minus 42 and so forth so same as its
attraction as before we just call it
Matrix subtraction it's identical
now if you remember up here we had a
scalar addition we're adding just one
number
to a matrix you can also do scalar
multiplication and so simply if you have
a single value a and you have B which is
your array we can also do a times B
when we run that you can see here we
have 2 times 4 is 8 5 times 4 is 20 and
so forth you're just multiplying the 4
across each one of these values and this
is an interesting one that comes up a
little bit of a brain teaser is Matrix
and Vector multiplication
and so when we're looking at this
we are let's do a regular arrays it
doesn't necessarily have to be a numpy
array we have a
which has our array of arrays and B
which is a single array and so we can
from here
do the DOT
a b
and this is going to return two values
and the verse value is that it's you
could say it's like uh we're doing the
this array B array
first with a and then with a second one
and so it splits it up so you have a
matrix of vector multiplication and you
can mix and match when you get into
really complicated uh back end stuff
this becomes more common because you're
now you've got layers upon layers of
data and so you you'll end up with a
matrix and a set of vector matrices do
you want to multiply
now keep in mind that if you're doing
data science a lot of times you're not
looking at this this is what's going on
behind the scenes so if you're in the
site kit looking at sklearn where you're
doing linear regression models this is
some of the math that's hidden behind
the scenes that's going on
other times you might find yourself
having to do part of this and manipulate
the data around so it fits right and
then you go back in and you run it
through the psy kit and if we can do
um
up here we did a matrix and Vector
multiplication we can also do Matrix to
matrix multiplication and if we run this
where we have the two matrixes you can
see we have a very complicated array
that of course comes out on there for
our DOT and just to reiterate it we have
our transposer Matrix which is your dot
t
and so if we create a matrix a and then
we do transpose it you can see how it
flips it from 5 10 15 20 25 30 to 5 15
25 10 20 30. rows and columns
and certainly with the math this comes
up a lot it also comes up a lot with X Y
plotting when you put into Pi plot you
have one format where they're looking at
Pairs and numbers and then they want L
of x's and all y's so you know the
transpose is an important tool both for
your math and for plotting and all kinds
of things
another tool that we didn't discuss uh
is your identity Matrix
and this one is more definition
uh the identity Matrix we have here one
where we just did two so it comes down
as one zero zero one one zero zero zero
one zero it creates a diagonal of one
and what that is is when you're doing
your identities you could be comparing
all your different features to the
different features and how they
correlate and of course when you have a
feature one compared to feature one to
itself it is always one where usually
it's between zero one depending on how
well correlates so when we're talking
about identity Matrix that's what we're
talking about right here is that you
create this preset Matrix and then you
might adjust these numbers depending on
what you're working with and what the
domain is and then another thing we can
do to kind of wrap this up we'll hit you
with the most complicated uh piece of
this puzzle here is an inverse a matrix
and let's just go ahead and put the um
that's a lengthy description
let's go and put the description this is
straight out of the
the website for numpy so given a square
Matrix a here's our Square Matrix a
which is two one zero zero one zero one
two one keep in mind three by three it's
Square it's got to be equal it's going
to return the Matrix a inverse
satisfying dot a
um a inverse so here's our matrix
multiplication
um and then of course it equals the dot
uh yeah a inverse of a with an identity
shape of a DOT shape zero this is just
reshaping the identity
that's a little complicated there uh so
we're going to have our here's our array
uh we'll go ahead and run this and you
can see what we end up with is we end up
with uh an array 0.5 minus 0.5 and so
forth with our two one one going down
two one zero zero one zero one two one
um getting into a little deep on the
math understanding when you need this is
probably really is is what's really
important when you're doing data science
versus uh handwriting this out and
looking up the math and handwriting all
the pieces out you do need to know about
the linear algorithm inverse of a so if
it comes up you can easily pull it up or
at least remember where to look it up we
took a look at the algebra side of it
let's go ahead and take a look at the
calculus side of what's going on here
with the machine learning so calculus oh
my goodness and differential equations
you got to throw that in there because
that's all part of the bag of tricks
especially when you're doing large
neural networks but it also comes up in
many other areas the good news is most
of it's already done for you in the back
end so when it comes up you really do
need to understand from the data science
not data analytics data analytics means
you're digging deep into actually
solving these math equations in a neural
network is just a giant differential
equation
uh so we talk about calculus uh we're
going to go ahead and understand it by
talking about cars versus time and speed
uh so it helps to calculate the
spontaneous rate of change
so suppose we plot a graph with a speed
of a car with respect to time so as you
can see here going down the highway
probably merged into the highway from an
on-ramp so I had to accelerate so my
speed went way up
stuck in traffic merged into the traffic
traffic opens up and I accelerate again
up to the speed limit and maybe Peter's
off up there so you can look at this as
as
the speed versus time I'm getting faster
and faster because I'm continually
accelerating and if I hit the brakes it
go the other way
so the rate of change of speed with
respect to time is nothing but
acceleration how fast are we
accelerating
the acceleration is the area between the
start point of X and the endpoint of
Delta X
so we can calculate a simple if you had
X and Delta X we could put a line there
and that slope of the line is our
acceleration
now that's pretty easy when you're doing
linear algebra but I don't want to know
it just for that line in those two
points I want to know it across the
whole of what I'm working with that's
where we get into calculus
so we talk about the distance between X
and Delta X it has to be the smallest
possible near to zero in order to
approximate the acceleration
so the idea is that instead of I mean if
you ever did took a basic calculus class
they would draw bars down here and you
would divide this area up let's go back
up a screen you divide this area up of
this time period up into maybe 10
sections and you'd use that and you
could calculate the acceleration between
each one of those 10 sections kind of
thing and then we just keep making that
space smaller and smaller until Delta X
is almost
infantismally small
and so we get a function of a equals a
limit as H goes to 0 of a function of a
plus h minus a function of a over H and
that is your Computing the slope of the
line
we're just Computing that slope under
smaller and smaller and smaller samples
uh and that's what calculus is calculus
is the integral you can see down here we
have our nice uh integral sign looks
like a giant s and that's what that
means is that we've taken this down to
as small as we can for that sampling
so we're talking about calculus we're
finding the area under the slope is the
main process in the integration similar
small intervals are made of the smallest
possible length of X Plus Delta X where
Delta X approaches almost an
infinitesimally small space
and then it helps to find the overall
acceleration by summing up all the links
together so we're summing up all the
accelerations from the beginning to the
end
and so here's our integral we sum of a
of x times D of x equals a plus c
that is our basic calculus here
so when we talk about multivariate
calculus
multivariate calculus deals with
functions that have multiple variables
and you can see here we start getting
into some very complicated equations
change in W over change of time equals
change of w over change of Z the
differential of Z to DX differential of
x to DT it gets pretty complicated and
it really translates into the
multivariate integration using double
integrals and so you have the the sum of
the sum of f of x or y of D of a equals
the sum from C to D and A to B of f of x
or y d x d y equals the sum of a to B
sum of C to D of f x or y d y d x
understanding the very specifics of
everything going on in here and actually
doing the math is use the calculus one
calculus two and differential equations
uh so you're talking about three full
length courses to dig into and solve
these math equations what we want to
take from here is we're talking about
calculus we're talking about summing of
all these different slopes and so we're
still solving a linear uh expression
we're still solving y equals m x plus b
but we're doing this for infantismally
small x's and then we want to sum them
up that's what this integral sign means
the sum of a of x d of x equals a plus c
and when you see these very complicated
uh multivariate differentiation using
the chain rule when we come in here and
we have the change of w to the change of
T equals a change of w DZ uh and so
forth that's what's going on here that's
what these means we're basically looking
for the area under the curve which
really comes to how is the change
changing speeds going up how is that
changing and then you end up with a
multiple layer so if I have three layers
of neural networks how is a third layer
changing based on the second layer
changing which is based on the first
layer changing and you get the picture
here that now we have a very complicated
multivariate integration with integrals
the good news is we can solve this
mathematically and that's what we do
when you do neural networks in Reverse
propagation so the nice thing is that
you don't have to solve this on paper
unless you're a data analysis and you're
working on the back end of integrating
these formulas and building the script
to actually build them so we talk about
applications of calculus it provides us
the tools to build an accurate
predictive model so it's really behind
the scenes we want to guess at what the
change or the change of the change is
that's a little goofy I I know I just
threw that out there's kind of a meta
term but if you can guess how things are
going to change then you can guess what
the new numbers are
multivariate calculus explains the
change in our Target variable in
relation to the rate of change in the
input variables
so there's our multiple variables going
in there if one variable is changing how
does it affect the other variable
and then in gradient descent calculus is
used to find the local and Global Maxima
and this is really big we're actually
going to have a whole section here on
gradient descent because it is really I
mean I talked about neural networks and
how you can see how the different layers
go in there but gradient descent is one
of the most key things for trying to
guess the best answer to something
so let's take a look at the code behind
gradient descent and before we open up
the code let's just do real quick
gradient descent
let's say we have a curve like this and
most common
is that this is going to represent your
error oops
error there we go error uh hard to read
there and I want to make the error as
low as possible
and so when I'm looking at it is I want
to find this line here
which is the minimum value so we're
looking for the minimum
and it does that by sampling there
and then it based on this it guesses it
might be someplace here and it goes hey
this is still going down it goes here
and then goes back over here and then
goes a little bit closer and it's just
playing a high low until it gets to that
spot that bottom spot
and so we want to minimize the error in
on the flip note you could also want to
be maximizing something you want to get
the best output of it that's simply
minus the value so if you're looking for
where the peak is this is the same as a
negative for where the valley is I'm
looking for that Valley that's all that
is and this is a way of finding it so
the cool thing is all the heavy
lifting's done I actually ended up
putting together one of these a while
back as when I didn't know about
sidekick and I was just starting boy
it's a long while back and uh is playing
high low how do you play high low not
get stuck in The Valleys figure out
these curves and things like that well
you do that and the back end is all the
calculus and differential equations to
calculate this out the good news is you
don't have to do those
uh so instead we're going to put
together the code and let's go ahead
and see what we can do with that
so uh guys in the back put together a
nice little piece of code here which is
kind of fun uh some things we're gonna
note and this is this is really
important stuff because when you start
doing your data science and digging into
your machine learning models uh you're
gonna find these things are stumbling
blocks the first one is current X where
do we start at keep in mind
your model that you're working with is
very generic so whatever you use to
minimize it the first question is where
do we start and we started at this
because the algorithm starts at x equals
three so we arbitrarily picked five
learning rate is how many bars to skip
going one way or the other I'm in fact
I'm going to separate that a little bit
because these two are really important
if we're dealing with something like
this where we're talking about well
here's our here's the function we're
going to use our gradient of our
function 2 times X plus five keep it
simple so that's a function we're going
to work with so if I'm dealing with
increments of a thousand point one is
going to be a very long time and if I'm
dealing with increments of 0.001
0.1 is going to skip over my answer so I
won't get a very good answer and then we
look at Precision this tells us when to
stop the algorithm so again very
specific to what you're working on if
you're working with money
and you don't convert it into a float
value you might be dealing with 0.01
which is a penny that might be your
Precision you're working with
and then of course the previous step
size Max iterations we want something to
cut out at a certain point usually
that's built into a lot of minimization
functions and then here's our actual
formula we're going to be working with
and then we come in we go while previous
step size is greater than precision and
itters is less than Max and Max itters
say that 10 times fast
um
we're just saying if it's uh if we're if
we're still greater than our Precision
level we still got to keep digging
deeper and then we also don't want to go
past a thou or whatever this is a
million or ten thousand running that's
actually pretty high I almost never do
Max iterations more than like 100 or 200
rare occasions you make up to four or
five hundred if it's depending on the
problem you're working with uh so we
have our previous equals our current
that way we can track time wise uh the
current now equals the current minus the
rate times the formula of our previous X
so now we've generated our new version
uh previous step size equals the
absolute current previous
so we're looking for the change in x
errors equals iterations plus one that's
how we know to stop if we get too far
and then we're just going to print the
local minimum occurs at axon here and if
we go ahead and run this
uh you can see right here it gets down
to this point and it says hey
um local minimum is minus
3.322 for this particular series we
created and this is created off of our
formula here Lambda X2 times X Plus 5.
now
when I'm running this stuff you'll see
this come up a lot
in with the sklearn kit and one of the
nice reasons of breaking this down the
way we did is I could go over those top
pieces those top pieces are everything
when you start looking at these
minimization toolkits in built-in code
and so from
um we'll just do it's actually Docs
got
scipy.org and we're looking at
the scikit
there we go optimize minimize
you can only minimize one value you have
the function that's going in this
function can be very complicated so we
used a very simple function up here it
could be there's all kinds of things
that could be on there and there's a
number of methods to solve this as far
as how they shrink down and your X
naught there's your there's your start
value so your function your start value
there's all kinds of things that come in
here that you can look at which we're
not going to
optimization automatically creates
constraints bounds some of this it does
automatically but you really the big
thing I want to point out here is you
need to have a starting point you want
to start with something that you already
know is mostly the answer if you don't
then it's going to have a heck of a time
trying to calculate it out
or you can write your own little script
that does this and does a high low
guessing and tries to find the max value
that brings us to statistics what this
is kind of all about is figuring things
out a lot of vocabulary and statistics
uh so statistics well I guess it's all
relative it's definitely not an adult
class uh so a bunch of stuff going on
statistics statistics concerns with the
collection organization analysis
interpretation and presentation of data
that is a mouthful so we have from end
to end where where does it come from is
it valid what does it mean how do we
organize it how do we analyze it and
then you got to take those analysis and
interpret it into something that people
can use kind of reduce it to
understandable and nowadays you have to
be able to present it if you can't
present it then no one else is going to
understand what the heck you did
so we look at the terminologies uh there
is a lot of terminologies depending on
what domain you're working in so clearly
if you're working in a domain that deals
with
viruses and T cells and and how does you
know where does that come from you're
studying the different people then you
can have a population if you are working
with
um
mechanical gear you know a little bit
different if you're looking for the
wobbling statistics to know when to
replace a rotor on a machine or
something like that that can be a big
deal you know we have these huge fans
that turn
in our sewage processing systems and so
those fans they start to wobble and hum
and do different things that the sensors
pick up at one point do you replace them
instead of waiting for it to break in
which case it costs a lot of money
instead of replacing a bushing you're
replacing the whole fan unit
an interesting project that came up for
our city a while back so population all
objects are measurements whose
properties are being observed so that's
your population all the objects it's
easy to see it with people because we
have our population in large but in the
case of these sewer fans we're talking
about how the fan units that's the
population of fans that we're working
with
you have a parameter a matrix that is
used to represent a population or
characteristic
you have your sample a subset of the
population studied you don't want to do
them all because then you don't have a
if you come up with the conclusion for
everyone you don't have a way of testing
it so you take a sample sometimes you
don't have a choice you can only take a
sample of what's going on you can't
study the whole population and a
variable a metric of interest for each
person or object in a population
types of sampling we have probabilistic
approach selecting samples from a larger
population using a method based on the
theory of probability
and we'll go into a little bit more
deeper on these we have random
systematic stratified and then you have
non-probabalistic approach selecting
samples based on the subjective Judgment
of the researcher rather than random
selection it has to do with convenience
trying to reach a quota or snowball
and they're very biased that's one of
the reasons you'll see this big stamp on
it says biased so you got to be very
careful on that
so probabilistic sampling when we talk
about a random sampling we select random
size samples from each group or category
so we it's as random as you can get we
talk about systematic sampling
we're selecting random size samples from
each group or category with a fixed
periodic interval
uh so we kind of split it up this would
be like a Time setup or our different
categories and you might ask your
question what is a category or a group
uh if you look at I'm going to go back a
window let's say we're studying um
economics of different of an area
um we know pretty much that based on
their culture where they came from they
might need to be separated and so they
might say separate I don't mean
separated from their their place where
they live I mean as far as the analysis
we want to look at the different groups
and make sure they're all represented
so if we had like an 80 percent uh of a
group that is say Hispanic and or Indian
and also in that same area we have 20 20
who are let's call our expatriates they
left America and they're nice and uh
your Caucasian group we might want to
sample a group that is representative of
both so we're talking about stratified
sampling and we're talking about groups
those are the groups we're talking about
and it brings us to stratified sampling
selecting approximately equal size
samples from each group or category
uh this way we can actually separate the
categories and give us an insight into
the different cultures and how that
might affect them in that area
uh so you can see these are very very
different kind of depends on what you're
working with as far as your data and
what you're studying and so we can see
here just a little bit more we'd have
selecting 25 employees from a company of
250 employees randomly don't care
anything about them what groups are in
which office they're in nothing
and we might be selecting one employee
from every 50 unique employees in a
company of 250 employees and then we
have selecting one employee from every
branch in the company office so we have
all the different branches there's our
group or our categories by the branch
and the category could depend on what
you're studying so it has a lot of
variation on there you see this kind of
grouping and categorizing is also used
to generate a lot of misinformation
so if you only study one group and you
say this is what it is then everybody
assumes that's what it is for everybody
and so you've got to be very careful of
that and it's very unethical thing to
kind of do
so types of Statistics we talk about
statistics we're going to talk about
descriptive and inferential statistics
there are so many different terms and
statistics to break it up so we so we're
talking about a particular setup
so we're talking about descriptive and
inferential uh statistics the base of
the word describe is pretty solid you're
describing the data what does it look
like with inferential statistics we're
going to take that from the small
population to a large population so if
you're working with a drug company you
might look at the data and say these
people were helped by this drug they did
80 better as far as their health or 80
percent better survival rate than the
people
who did not have the drug so we can
infer that that drug will work in the
greater populace and will help people so
that's where you get your inferential so
we are predicting how it's going to
affect the greater population
so descriptive statistics it is used to
describe the basic features of data and
form the basis of quantitative analysis
of data
so we have a measure of central
Tendencies we have your mean median and
mode
and then we have a measure of spread
like your range your interquartile range
your variance in your standard deviation
and we're going to look at all these a
little deeper here in a second but one
of them you can think of is
how the data difference
differences you know what's the max Min
range all that stuff is your spread and
anything that's just a single number is
usually your central Tendencies measure
of central tendencies
so we talk about the mean it is the
average of the set of values considered
what is the average outcome of
whatever's going on
and then your median separates the
higher half and the lower half of data
so where's the center point of all your
different data points so your mean might
have some a couple really big numbers
that skew it so that the average is much
higher than if you took those outliers
out where the median would by separating
the high from the low might give you a
much lower number you might look at and
say oh that's that's odd Y is the
average so much higher than the median
well it's because you have some outliers
or why is it so much lower
and then the mode is the most frequent
appearing value this is really
interesting if you're studying economics
and how people are doing you might find
that the most common income like in the
U.S was at 1.24
000 a year
where the average was closer to 80 000
and it's like wow what a difference well
there's some people have a lot of money
and so that skews that way up so the
average person is not making that kind
of money and then you look at the median
income and you're like well the median
income is a little bit closer to the
average so it does create a very
interesting way of looking at the data
again these are all uh Central
Tendencies single numbers you can look
at for the whole spread of the data
and we look at the measure of central
Tendencies the mean is the average marks
of a student's in a classroom so here we
have the mean some of the marks of the
students total number of students and as
we talked about the median if we have 0
through 10 and we take half the numbers
and put them on one side of the line
half the numbers on the other side of
the line we end up with five in the
middle and then the mode what Mark was
scored by most of the students in a test
in a simple case where most people
scored like an 82 percent and got
certain problems wrong easy to figure
out uh not so easy when you have
different areas where like you have like
the um oh let's go back to economy a
little bit more difficult to calculate
if you have a large group of scores that
makes 30 000 and a slightly bigger group
that makes twenty six thousand so what
do you put down for the mode uh
certainly there's a number of ways to
calculate that and there's actually a
different variations depending on what
you're doing so now we're looking at a
measure of spread uh range what's the
difference between the highest and the
lowest value first thing you want to
look at you know it's uh we had
everybody in the test scored between 60
and 100 so we got 100 or maybe 60 to 90
percent it was so hard that a lot of
people could not get a hundred percent
um you have your interquartile range
quartiles divide a rank ordered data set
into four equal parts
very common thing to do as part of all
the basic packages whether you're
working in data frames with pandas
whether you're working in Scala whether
you're working in R you'll see this come
up where they have range your men your
Max and then it'll have your
interquartile range how does it look
like in each quarter of data variants
measures how far each number in the set
is from the mean and therefore from
every other number in the set
uh so you have like how much turbulence
is going on in this data
and then the standard deviation it is a
measure the variance or the dispersion
of a set of values from the mean
and you'll usually see if I'm doing a
graph I might have the value graphed and
then based on the the error I might grab
graph the standard deviation in the
error on the graph as a background so
you can see how far off it is
so standard deviation is used a lot
so measurement of spread marks of a
student out of 100 we have here from 50
to 63 or 50 to 90 so the range maximum
marks minimum marks we have 90 to 45 and
the spread of that is 45 90 minus 45 and
then we have the interquartile range
using the same marks over there you can
see here where the median is and then
there's a first quarter the second
quarter and the third quarter based on
splitting it apart by those values and
to understand the variance and standard
deviation we first need to find out the
mean so here's our you know calculating
the average there we end up
approximately 66 for the average and
then we look at that in the variance
once we know the means we can do equals
the marks minus the mean squared Y is a
squared because one you want to make
sure it's you don't have like if you if
you're putting all this stuff together
you end up with an error as far as one's
negative one's positive one's a little
higher one's a little lower uh so you
always see the squared value and over
the total observations and so the
standard deviation equals the square
root of the variance which is
approximately 16. and if you were
looking at a predictable model you would
be looking at the deviation based on the
error how much error does it have that's
again really important to know if you're
if your prediction is predicting
something what's a chance of it being
way off or just a little bit off
now that we've looked at the tools as
far as some of the basics for doing your
statistics and what we're talking about
let's go ahead and pull up a little demo
and show you what that looks like in
Python code so you can get some little
Hands-On here for that let's go back
into our jupyter notebook in Python now
almost all of this you can do in numpy
last time we worked in numpy this time
we're going to go ahead and use pandas
and if you remember from pandas on here
this is basically a data frame rows
columns let's just go ahead and do a
print df.head
and run that
and you can see we have the name Jane
Michael William Rosie Hannah sat in
their salaries on here and of course
instead of having to do all those hand
calculations and add everything together
and divide by the total we can do
something very simple on this uh like
use the command mean in pandas and so if
I go ahead and do this print DF pick our
column salary because we want to find
the means of that calorie
we want to find the means of that column
and we go and print this out and you can
see that the average income on here is
000.
and let's just go ahead and do this
we'll go ahead and put in means
and if we're going to do that we also
might want to find the median
and the median is very similar
except it actually is just median we're
used to means in average it's kind of
interesting that those are they use the
two different words
there can be in some computation slight
differences but for the most part the
means is the average and then the median
oops let's put a
medium here do you have salary that way
it displays a little better we can see
the median is 54
000. so the halfway mark is
significantly below the average why
because we have somebody in here who
makes 189 000. darn you Rosie for
throwing off our numbers but that's
something you'd want to notice this is
this is the difference between these is
huge and so is what is the meaning
behind that when you're studying a
populist and looking at the different
data coming in and of course we also
want to find out hey what's the most
common
income that people make
in this little tiny sample and so we'll
go ahead and do the mode
and you can see here with the mode uh
it's at fifty thousand
so this is this is very telling that
most people are making 50 000 the middle
point is at fifty four thousand so half
the people are making more than that
what that tells me is that if the most
common income is way is below the median
then there's a few there's a you know
there's a lot of high salaries going up
but there's some really low salaries in
there and so this trend which is very
common in statistic and when you're in
analyzing the economy in different
people's income is pretty common and the
bigger difference between these is also
very important when we're studying
statistics uh and when you hear someone
just say hey the average income was you
might start asking questions at that
point why aren't you talking about the
median income why aren't you talking
about the mode the most common income
what are you hiding and if you're doing
these analysis you should be looking at
these saying hey why are this
discrepancies why are these so different
and of course with any analysis it's
important to find out the minimum
and the maximum so we'll go ahead it's
just simply
dot min
so pull up your minimum and then dot Max
pulls up the maximum pretty
straightforward on as far as
translating it and knowing what you're
you know put the your lowest value and
what your highest value is here
which you'll use to generate like a
spread later on and real quick on no
mode note that it puts mode zero like I
said there's a couple different ways you
can compute the mode
um although the standard one's pretty
good we can of course do the range which
is your max minus your Min so now we
have a range of 149 000 between the
upper end and the lower end and you
might want to be looking at the
individual values on all of these but it
turns out there is a describe
feature in pandas
and so in pandas we can actually do DF
salary describe if we do this you can
see we have that there's seven setups
here's our mean our standard deviation
which we didn't compute yet which would
just be a DOT STD and you gotta be a
little careful because when it computes
it it looks for axes and things like
that we have our minimum value and
here's our quartiles
our maximum value and then of course the
name salary uh so these are these are
the basic statistics you can pull them
up and like just describe this is a
dictionary so I could actually do
something like um
and here I could actually go uh count
and run and now it just prints the count
so because this is a dictionary you can
pull any one of these values out of here
it's kind of a quick and dirty way to
pull all the different information and
then split it up and depending on what
you need now if I just walked in and
gave you this information in a meeting
at some point you would just kind of
fall asleep that's what I would do
anyway
um so we want to go ahead and see about
graphing it here we'll go ahead and put
it into a histogram and plot that graph
on it
of the salaries and let's just go ahead
and put that in here so we do our
matplot inline remember that's a
Jupiter's notebook thing a lot of the
new version of the matplot library does
it automatically but just in case I
always put it in there import matplot
Library Pi plot is PLT that's my
plotting
and then we have our data frame I guess
I really don't need to respell the data
frame maybe we could just remind
ourselves what's in it so we'll go ahead
and just print
DF that way we still have it and then we
have our salary DF salary salary Dot
Plot history title salary distribution
color gray
uh plot axvline salary the mean value so
we're going to take the mean value
color violet line style Dash this is
just all making it pretty
uh what color dashed line line width of
two that kind of thing and the median
and let's go ahead and run this just so
you can see what we're talking about
and so up here we are taking on our plot
so here's the data here's our our data
frame printed out so you can see it with
the salaries we'll look at the salary
distribution and just look at this the
way there the salary is distributed
you have our in this case we did Let's
see we had red for the median
we have violet
for our average or mean and you can just
see how it really here's our outlier
here's our person who makes a lot of
money here's the average and here's the
median
um and so as you look at this you can
say wow based on the average it really
doesn't tell you much about what people
are really taking home all it does is
tell you how much money is in this you
know what the average salary is
so some of the things you want to take
away in addition to this is that it's
very easy to plot
um
an axv line these are these up and down
lines for your markers
um and as you just just play the data I
mean you can add all kinds of things to
this and get really complicated keeping
it simple is pretty straightforward I
look at this and I can see we have a
major outlier out here we can definitely
do a histogram and stuff like that but
you know pictures worth a thousand words
what you really want to make sure you
take away is that we can do a basic
describe which pulls all this
information out and we can print any of
the individual information from the
describe because this is a dictionary
and so if we want to go ahead and look
up
the mean value we can also do describe
means if you're doing a lot of
Statistics uh being able to
doesn't have the print on there so it's
only going to print the last one which
happens to be the mean you can very
easily reference any one of these and
then you can also if you're doing
something a little bit more complicated
and you don't need just the basics you
can come through and pull any one of the
individual
um
references from the from the pandas on
here so now we've had a chance to
describe our data let's get into
inferential statistics inferential
statistics allows you to make
predictions or inferences from data and
you can see here we have a nice little
picture movie ratings and
if we took this group of people and said
hey how many people like the movie
dislike it can't say and then you ask
just a random person who comes out of
the movie who hasn't been in the study
you can infer that 55 chance of saying
liked 35 chance of saying disliked or a
10 or 11 chance of can't say so that's
real basics of what we're talking about
is you're going to infer that the next
person is going to follow these
statistics
uh so let's look at Point estimation it
is a process of finding an approximate
value for a population's parameter like
mean or average from random samples of
the population let's take an example of
testing vaccines for covid-19 vaccines
and flu bugs all that it's a pretty big
thing of how do you test these out and
make sure they're going to work on the
populace
a group of people are chosen from the
population medical trials are performed
results are generalized for the whole
population so here's a protected there's
our small group up here where we've
selected them we run medical trials on
them and then the results work for the
population a nice diagram with the
arrows going back and forth in the very
scary covet virus in the middle of one
and let's take a look at the
applications of inferential statistics
very Central is what they call
hypotheses testing and the confidence
interval which go with that and then as
we get into
probability we get into our binomial
theorem our normal distribution in
central limit theorem hypothesis testing
hypothesis testing is used to measure
the plausibility of a hypothesis
assumption by using sample data
now when we talk about theorems Theory
hypothesis keep in mind that if you are
in a philosophy class theory is the same
as hypothesis where theorem is a
scientific uh statement that is
something that has been proven although
it is always up for debate because in
science we always want to make sure
things are up to debate so a hypothesis
is the same as a philosophical class
calling a theory where theory in science
is not the same theory in science says
this has been well proven gravity is a
theory so if you want to debate the
theory of gravity try jumping up and
down if you want to have a theory about
why the economy is collapsing in your
area that is a philosophical debate very
important I've heard people mix those up
and it is a pet peeve of mine when we
talk about hypotheses testing the steps
involved in the hypotheses testing is
first we formulate a hypothesis we
figure out the right test to test our
hypothesis we execute the test and we
make a decision it and so when you're
talking about hypothesis you're usually
trying to disprove it if you can't
disprove it and it works for all the
facts then you might call that ethereum
at some point
so in a use case let's consider an
example we have four students we're
given a task to clean a room every day
sounds like working with my kids they
decided to distribute the job of
cleaning the room among themselves they
did so by making four chits which has
their names on it and the name that gets
picked up has to do the cleaning for
that day Rob took the opportunity to
make chits and wrote everyone's name on
it so here's our four people Nick Rob
imlia imlia and summer
now Rick Emilia and summer are asking us
to decide whether Rob has done some
Mischief in preparing the chits I.E
whether Rob has written his name on one
of the chit for that we will find out
the probability of Rob getting the
cleaning job on first day second day
third day and so on till 12 days the
probability of Rob getting the job
decreases every day I.E his turn never
comes up then definitely he has done
some Mischief while making the chits so
the probability of Rob not doing work on
day one is three out of four there's a
0.75 chance that he didn't do work uh
two days three fourths times
three-fourths equals 0.56
three days you have three four three
fours three-fourths which equals 0.42
uh when you get to day 12 it's 0.032
Which is less than 0.05 remember this
0.05 that comes up a lot when we're
talking about certain values when we're
looking at statistics Rob is cheating as
he wasn't chosen for 12 consecutive days
that's a very high probability when on
day 12 he still hasn't gotten the job
cleaning the room
so we come up to our important important
terminologies we have null hypothesis
a general statement that states that
there is no relationship between two
measured phenomenon or no association
among the groups
alternative hypothesis contrary to the
null hypothesis it states whenever
something is happening a new theory is
preferred instead of an old one and so
the two hypotheses go hand in hand uh so
your null this is always interesting in
in when talking about data science and
the math behind it it's about proving
that the things have no correlation null
hypothesis says these two have zero
relation to each other where the
alternative hypothesis says hey we found
a relation this is what it is
we have p-value the p-value is a
probability of finding the observed or
more extreme results when the null
hypotheses of a study question is true
and the T value it is simply the
calculated difference represented in
units of standard error the greater the
magnitude of T the greater the evidence
against the null hypothesis and you can
look at the T values being specific to
the test you're doing
where the p-value is derived from your T
value and you're looking for what is
called a five percent or the 0.05
showing that it has a high correlation
so digging in deeper let's assume that a
new drug is developed with the goal of
lowering the blood pressure more than
the existing drug and this is a good one
because the null value here isn't that
you don't have any drug then null value
here is it is better than existing drug
the new drug doesn't lower the blood
pressure more than the existing drug
now if we get that that says our null
hypothesis is correct there is no
correlation and the new drug is not
doing its job the alternative hypothesis
the new drug does significantly lower
the blood pressure more than an existing
drug uh yay we got a new drug out there
and that's our alternative hypothesis or
the H1 or h a
and we look at the p-value results from
the evidence like medical trials showing
positive results which will reject the
null hypothesis
and again they're looking for a 0.05 or
5 percent and the T value comparing all
the positive test results and finding
means of different samples in order to
test hypothesis so this is specific to
the test how what percentage of increase
did they have
and this leads us to the confidence
intervals a confidence interval is a
range of values we are sure our true
values of observations lie in
let's say you asked a dog owner around
you and asked them how many cans of food
do you buy for your per year for your
dog
through calculations you've got to know
that the on an average around 95 percent
of the people bought around 200 to 300
cans of food hence we can say that we
have a confidence interval of 2 300
where 95 percent of our values lie in
that data spread and this the graph
really helps a lot so you can start
seeing what you're looking at here where
you have the 95 percent you have your
peak in this case it's a normal
distribution so you have the nice bell
curve equal on both sides it's not
asymmetrical and 95 percent of all the
values lie within a very small range and
then you have your outliers the 2.5
percent going each way
so we touched upon hypothesis and we're
going to move into probability so you
have your hypothesis once you've
generated your hypothesis we want to
know the probability of something
occurring probability is a measure of
the likelihood of an event to occur any
event can be predicted with total
certainty and can only be predicted as a
likelihood of its occurrence so any
event cannot be predicted with total
search and T can only be predicted as a
likelihood of its occurrence score
prediction how good you're going to do
in whatever sport you're in weather
prediction stock prediction if you've
studied physics and Chaos Theory even
the location of the chair you're sitting
on has a probability that it might move
three feet over
granted that probability is one in like
uh I think we calculated as under one in
trillions upon trillions so it's
the better the probability the more
likely it's going to happen there are
some things that have such a low
probability that we don't see them so we
talk about random variable a random
variable is a variable whose possible
values are numerical outcomes of a
random phenomena so we have the coin
tossed how many heads will occur in the
series of 20 coin flips probably you
know the on average they're 10 but you
really can't know because it's very
random how many times a red ball is
picked from a bag of balls if there's
equal number of red balls and blue balls
and green balls in there how many times
the sum of digits on two dice result are
five each
so you know there's how often you're
going to roll two fives on your pair of
Dives
so in a use case let's consider the
example of rolling two dice we have a
random variable outcome equals y you can
take values two three four five six
seven eight nine ten eleven twelve
so we have a random variable and a
combination of dice and instead of
looking at how many times both dice for
roll five let's go ahead and look at
total sum of five and you have in as far
as your random variables you can have a
one four equals five four one two three
three two
so four of those roles can be four if
you look at all the different options
you have four of those random roles can
be a five
and if we look at the total number
which happens to be 36 different options
uh you can see that we have four out of
36 chance every time you roll the dice
that you're going to roll a total of
five you're gonna have an outcome of
five
and uh we'll look a little deeper as to
what that means but you could think of
that at what point if someone never
rolls a five or they always roll a five
can you say hey that person's probably
cheating we'll look a little closer at
the math behind that but let's just
consider this is one of the cases is
rolling two dice and gambling
there's also a binomial distribution it
is a probability of getting success or
failure as an outcome in an experiment
or trial that is repeated multiple times
and the key is is by meaning two
binomial so passing or filling an exam
winning or losing a game and getting
either head or tails so if you ever see
binomial distribution it's based on a
true false kind of setup you win or lose
let's consider a use case and let's
consider the game of football between
two clubs Barcelona and Dortmund the
teams will have to play a total of four
matches and we have to find out the
chances of Barcelona winning the series
so we look at the total games and we're
looking at five different games or
matches let's say that the winning
chance for Barcelona is 75 or 0.75 that
means that each game they have a 75
chance that they're going to win that
game and losing chances are 25 or 0.25
clearly 0.75 plus 0.25 equals one so
that accounts for 100 of the game
probability for getting K wins in in
matches is calculated
and we we're talking like so if you have
five games uh and you want to know if I
play
um how many wins in those five games
should I get what's the percentage on
those and the probability for getting K
wins and N matches is calculated by p x
equals k equals nck P to the k q to the
N minus K here p is a probability of
success and Q is the probability of
failure and so we can do total games of
n equals five where k equals zero one
two three four five P which is the
chance of winning is 0.75 Q the chance
of losing equals 1 minus P which equals
1 minus 0.075 which equals 0.25 the
probability that Barcelona will lose all
of the matches can then just plug in the
numbers and we end up with a point zero
zero zero nine seven six five six two
five so very small chance they're going
to lose all their matches
and we can plug in the value for two
matches probability of the Barcelona
will win at least two matches is 0.0878
and of course we can go on to the
probability of the Barcelona will win
three matches the 0.26 and of course
four matches and so on and it's always
nice to take this information
um and let's find the accumulated
discrete probabilities for each of the
outcomes where Barcelona has won three
or more matches x equals three x equals
four x equals five
and we end up with the p equals 0.264
plus 0.395 plus 237 which equals 0.89
in reality
the probability of Barcelona winning the
series is much higher than 0.75 and it's
always nice to uh
put out a nice graph so you can actually
see the number of wins to the
probability and how that pans out with
our binomial case
continuing in our important terminology
location the location of the center of
the graph depends on the mean value and
this is some very important things so
much of the data we look at when you
start looking at probabilities almost
always has a normalized look like the
graph in the middle
uh but you do have left skewed where the
data is skewed off to the left and you
have more stuff happening out to the
left and you have right skewed data and
so when this comes up and these
probabilities come up where they're
skewed it's really important to take a
closer look at that mostly you end up
with a normalized set of data but you
got to also be aware that sometimes it's
a skewed data
and then the height height of the slope
inversely depends upon the standard
deviation
so you can see down here the standard
deviation is really large it kind of
squishes it out and if the standard
deviation is small then most of your
data is going to hit right there in the
middle you can have a nice Peak and so
being aware of this that you might have
a probability that fits certain data but
it has a lot of outliers so you're if
you have a really high standard
deviation if you're doing stock market
analysis this means your predictions are
probably not going to make you much
money where if you have a very small
deviation you might be right on Target
and set to become a millionaire which
leads us to the z-score z-score tells
you how far from the mean a data point
is it is measured in terms of standard
deviations from the mean around 68
percent of the results are found between
one standard deviation around 95 percent
of the results are found between two
standard deviations and you read the
symbols of course they love to throw
some Greek letters in there we have mu
minus two Sigma mu is just a quick ways
to kind of funky you it just means the
mean and then the sigma is the standard
deviation and that's the o with a little
arrow off to the right or the little
waggly Tail Going up the o with it with
a line on it so mu minus 2 Sigma is your
95 percent of the results are found
between two standard deviations
Central limit theorem
this goes back to the skew if you
remember we were looking at the skew
values on this previous slide have left
skewed normalized and right skewed when
we're talking about it being skewed or
not skewed the distribution of the
sample means will be approximately
normally distributed evenly distributed
not skewed if you take large random
samples from the population with the
mean mu and the standard deviation Sigma
with replacement
and you can see here of course we have
our mu minus two Sigma and the spread
down here the mean the median and the
mode and so you're talking about very
large populations
these numbers should come together and
you shouldn't have a skewed value if you
do that's a flag that something's wrong
that's why this is so important to be
aware of what's going on with your data
where your samples are coming from and
the math behind it and if you're going
to do all this we got to jump into
conditional probability
the conditional probability of an event
a is a probability that the event will
occur given the knowledge that an event
to be has already occurred and you'll
see this as Bayes theorem b-a-y-e-s Bays
and this is red
I mean you have these funky looking
little p brackets a b this is the
probability of a being true while B is
already true
and you have the probability of B being
true when a is already true so P B of A
probability of a being true divided by
the probability of B being true
and we talk about Bayes theorem which
occurred back in the 1800s when he
discovered this this is such an
important formula and it's really it's
not if you actually do the math you
could just kind of do
um
um x y equals J K and then you divide
them out and you're going to see the
same math but it works with
probabilities which makes it really nice
and so if you have a set you might have
uh eight or nine different studies going
on in different areas different people
have done the studies they brought them
together
if we look at today's covet virus the
virus spread certainly the studies done
in China versus the studies the way
they're done in the U.S that data is
different in each of those studies but
if you can find a place where it
overlaps where they're studying the same
thing together you can then compute the
changes that you need to make in one
study to make them equal
and this is also true if you have a
study of one group and you want to find
out more about it so this formula is
very powerful and it really has to do
with the data collection part of the
math and data science and understanding
where your data is coming from and how
you're going to combine different
studies in different groups
and we're going to go into a use case
let's find out the chance of a person
getting lung disease due to smoking and
this is kind of interesting the way they
word this let's say that according to
medical report provided by the hospital
states that around 10 percent of all
patients they treated suffered lung
disease so we have kind of a generic
medical report they further found out by
a survey that 15 percent of the patients
that visit them smoke
so we have 10 percent that are lung
disease and 15 of the patients smoke and
finally five percent of the people
continued smoke even when they had lung
disease not the brightest choice but you
know it is an addiction so it can be
really difficult to kick and so we can
look at the probability of a uh prior
probability of 10 percent people having
lung disease
and then probability B probability that
a patient smokes is 15 percent
uh and the probability of B if B then a
the probability of a patient smokes even
though they have lung disease is five
percent
and probability of a is B probability
that the patient will have lung disease
if they smoke and then when you put the
formulas together you get a nice
solution here you get the probability of
a of B probability that the patient will
have lung disease if they smoke
and you can just plug the numbers right
in and we get a 3.33 percent chance
hence there is a 3.33 chance that a
person who smokes will get a lung
disease
so we're gonna pull up a little python
code and always my favorite roll up the
sleeves
keep in mind we're going to be doing
this um kind of like the back end way
so that you can see what's going on and
then later on we're going to create
um we'll get into another demo which
shows you some of the tools are already
pre-built for this
let's start by creating a set so we're
going to create a set with curly braces
this means that our set has only unique
values so you have a list you have your
tuples which can never change and then
you have in this case the the set so
four seven you can't create a four seven
comma four it'll delete the four out so
it's only unique values and if you use
dictionaries
quick reminder this should look familiar
because it is a dictionary where you
have a value and that value is assigned
to or that key is assigned to a value
uh so you could have a key value set up
as a dictionary so it's like a
dictionary without the value it's just
the keys and they all have to be unique
and if we run this we have a set of four
seven
we can also take a list a regular setup
and I'm going to go ahead and just throw
in another number in here four
and run it and you can see here if I
take my list one two three four four and
I convert it to a set and here it is my
set from list equals set my list
the result is one two three four so it
just deletes that last four right out of
there
and with the sets you can also go in
there and print here is my set my set
three is in the set and then if you do
three in my set
that's going to be a logic function uh
and one in my set 6 is not in the set
and so forth if we run this
we get three is in the set true one is
in the set false because three five
seven is another one six is in the Set
uh six is not in the set so not in my
set
you can also use this with a list we
could have just used 357 and it would
have the same response on there is three
and usually you do if three is in but
three in my set is still works on just a
regular list
and we'll go ahead and do a little
iteration we're going to do kind of the
dice one remember
um uh one two three four five six and so
we're going to bring in that iteration
tool and import product as product
and I'll show you what that means in
just a second so we have our two dice we
have dice a
and it's going to be a set of values and
you can only have one value for each one
that's why they put it in a set and if
you remember from range it is up to
seven so this is going to be one two
three four five six it will not include
the seven and the same thing for our
dice B
and then we're going to do is we're
going to create a list
which is the product
of A and B so what's a plus b
and if we go ahead and run this it'll
print that out and you'll see in this
case when they say product because it's
an iteration tool
foreign we're talking about creating a
tuple of the two so we've now created a
tuple of all possible outcomes of the
dice where dice a is one two three one
to six and dice B is one to six and you
can see one to one one to two one to
three and so forth you remember we had a
slide on this earlier where we talked
about
um the different all the different
outcomes of a dice
we can play around with this a little
bit uh we can do in dice equals two dice
faces one two three four five six
uh another way of doing what we did
before and then we can create an event
space where we have a set which is the
product of the dice faces repeat equals
endice and we're going to just run this
and you can see here it just again puts
it through all the different possible
variables we can have
and then if we wanted to take the same
set on here and print them all out like
we had before we can just go through
four outcome and event space outcome and
equals
so the event space is creating
uh sequence and as you can see here when
we print it out it Stacks them versus
going through and putting them in a nice
line
and we'll go ahead and do something uh
let's go print
since we have the End Printing with a
comma that just means it's just gonna
it's not going to hit the return going
down to the next line uh and we'll go
ahead and do the links
of our event space uh I'll be an
important variable we're going to want
to know in a minute
and of course I get carried away with my
typing of length I will print it twice
and it'll give me an error so we have 36
different possible variations here
and we might want to calculate something
like what about the multiple of three
what if we want to have
the probability of the multiple of three
in our setup
and so we can put together the code for
the outcome and event space of X Y
equals outcome if X Plus y
remainder three so we're going to divide
by three and look at the remainder and
it equals zero
then it's a fable outcome we're going to
pop that outcome on the end there
and we'll turn it into a set so the
favor outcome equals a set not necessary
because we know it's not going to be
repeating itself but just in case we'll
go ahead and do that
and if we want to print out the outcome
we can go ahead and see what that looks
like and you can see here these are all
multiples of three one plus two is three
five plus four is nine which divided by
three is three and so forth
and just like we looked up the length of
the one before let's go ahead and print
the length
of our F outcome
so we can see what that looks like
there we go
and of course I did forget to add the
print in the middle because We're
looping through and putting an end on
the on the setup on there so we're going
to put the print in there and if I run
this you can see uh
we end up with 12. so we have 36 total
options
we have 12 that are multiple that add up
to a multiple of three
and we can easily convert the
probability of this by simply taking the
length of our favorable outcome over the
length of the event space
and if we print it out and we put that
in there probability
last lines we just type it in we end up
with the 0.33333 chance
and it's roughly a third
and we might want to make this look nice
so let's go ahead and put in another
line there the probability of getting
the sum which is a multiple of three is
0.333333
we can compute the same thing for five
dice
and if we do this for five dice and go
and run it you can see we just have a
huge amount of choices so just goes on
and on down here and we can look at the
length of the event space
and we have over
776 choices that's a lot of choices
if we want to ask the question like we
did above uh what is the sum where the
sum is a multiple of five but not a
multiple of three
we can go through all of these different
options and then you can see here D1 D2
D3 D4 D5 equals the outcome and if you
add these all together and the
division by five does not have a
remainder of zero but the remainder is
also of a division by three is not equal
to zero so the multiple of five is equal
to zero but the multiple three is not we
can just append that on here and then we
can look at that uh favorable outcome
we'll go ahead and set that and we'll
just take a look at this what's our
length
of our favorable outcome
it's always good to see what we're
working with and so we have 904 out of
6 and then of course we can just do a
simple division to get the probability
on here what's the probability that
we're going to roll a multiple of five
when you add them together
but not a multiple of three
and so we're just going to divide those
two numbers and you can see here we get
0.116255 or 11.62 percent
and so you can really have a nice visual
that this is not really complicated in
math right here on probabilities it's
just how many options do you have and
how many of those are you possibly going
to be able to come up with with the
solution you're looking for and this
leads us to a confusion Matrix
a confusion Matrix is a table which is
used to describe the performance of a
classification model on a set of test
data for which the True Values are known
and so you'll see on the left we have
the predicted and the actual and we have
a negative false negative positive true
positive
and then we have false positive and true
negative and you can think of this as
your predicted model what does that mean
that means if you divided your data and
you used two-third of us to create the
model
you might then test it against an actual
case for the last third and see how well
it comes out how many times was it true
positive versus uh
false positive we give a false positive
response and you can imagine in medical
situations this is a pretty big deal you
don't want to give a false positive so
you might adjust your model accordingly
so you don't have a false positive say
with the covet virus test it'd be better
to have a false negative when they go
back and get retested then to have 30
percent false positives where then the
test is pretty much invalid
so in a use case like cancer prediction
let's consider an example where a cancer
prediction model is put to the test for
its accuracy and precision actual result
of a person's medical report is compared
with the prediction made by the machine
learning model
and so you can see here here's our
actual predicted whether they have
cancer or not you know cancer a big one
you don't want to have a false positive
I mean a false negative in other words
you don't want to have it tell you that
you don't have cancer when you do so
that would be something you'd really be
looking for in this particular domain
you don't want a false negative
and this is again you know you've
created a model you have hundreds of
people or thousands of pieces of data
that come in there's a real famous case
study where they have the imagery and
all the measurements they take and
there's about 36 different measurements
they take and then if you run the a
basic model you want to know just how
accurate is how many negative results do
you have that are either telling people
they have cancer that don't or telling
people that don't have cancer that they
do and then we can take these numbers
and we can feed them into our accuracy
our precision and our recall
so accuracy precision and recall
accuracy metric to measure how
accurately the results are predicted
and this is your total true where you
got the right results you add them
together the true positive the true
negative over all the results so what
percentage of them were accurate versus
what were wrong
we're talking about Precision is a
metric to measure how many of the
correctly predicted cases are actually
turned out to be positive uh so we have
a Precision on true positive again if
you're talking about like uh covid
testing with the viruses uh you really
want this to be a high number you want
this true that to be the center point
where you might have the opposite if
you're dealing with cancer where you
want no false negatives
uh so this is your metric on here
Precision is your test positive true
positive plus uh false positive
and then your recall how many of the
actual positive cases we were able to
predict quickly with our model uh so
test positive is the test positive plus
the false negative on there if you are
an aspiring machine learning engineer
looking for online training and
certifications from prestigious
universities and in collaboration with
leading experts then search no more
simply learns professional certification
program in Ai and machine learning from
Purdue University in collaboration with
IBM should be a right choice for more
details use the link in the description
box below with that in mind so without
much further Ado let's get started so
deep learning is considered to be a part
of machine learning so this diagram very
nicely depicts what deep learning is at
a very high level you have the
all-encompassing artificial intelligence
which is more a concept rather than a
technology or a technical concept right
so it is it's more of a concept at a
very high level artificial intelligence
under the herd is actually machine
learning and deep learning and machine
learning is a broader concept you can
say or a broader technology and deep
learning is a subset of machine learning
the primary difference between machine
learning and deep learning is that deep
learning uses neural networks and it is
suitable for handling large amounts of
unstructured data and last but not least
one of the major differences between
machine learning and deep learning is
that in machine learning the feature
extraction or the feature engineering is
done by the data scientists manually but
in deep learning since we use neural
networks the feature engineering happens
automatically so that's a little bit of
a quick difference between machine
learning and deep learning and this
diagram very nicely depicts the relation
between artificial intelligence machine
learning and deep learning now why do we
need deep learning machine learning was
there for quite some time and it can do
a lot of stuff that probably what deep
learning can do but it's not very good
at handling large amounts of
unstructured data like images Voice or
even text for that matter so traditional
machine learning is not that very good
at doing this traditional machine
learning can handle large amounts of
structured data but when it comes to
unstructured data it's a big challenge
so that is one of the key
differentiators for deep learning so
that is number one and increasingly for
artificial intelligence we need image
recognition and we need to process
analyze images and voice that's recently
planning is required compared to let's
say traditional machine learning it can
also perform complex algorithms more
complex than let's say what machine
learning can do and it can achieve best
performance with the large amounts of
data so the more you have the data let's
say reference data or label data the
better the system will do because the
training process will be that much
better and last but not least with deep
learning you can really avoid the manual
process of feature extraction those are
some of the reasons why we need deep
learning some of the applications of
deep learning deep learning has made
major inroads and it is a major area in
which deep learning is applied is
Healthcare and within Healthcare
particularly oncology which is basically
cancer related stuff one of the issues
with cancer is that a lot of cancers
today are curable they can be cured they
are detected early on and the challenge
with that is when a Diagnostics is
performed let's say an image has been
taken of a patient to detect whether
there is cancer or not you need a
specialist to look at the image and
determine whether it is the patient is
fine or there is any onset of cancer and
the number of Specialists are limited so
if we use deep learning if we use
automation here or if we use artificial
intelligence here then the system can
with a certain amount of the good amount
of accuracy determine whether a
particular patient is having cancer or
not so the prediction or the detection
process of a disease like cancer can be
expedited the detection process can be
expedited can be faster without really
waiting for a specialist we can
obviously then once the application once
the artificial intelligence detects or
predicts that there is an onset of a
cancer this can be cross-checked by a
doctor but at least the initial
screening process can be automated and
that is where the current focus is with
respect to deep learning in healthcare
what else robotics is another area deep
learning is majorly used in robotics and
you must have seen nowadays robots are
everywhere humanoids the industrial
robots which are used for manufacturing
process you must have heard about Sophia
who got a citizenship with Saudi Arabia
and so on there are multiple such robots
which are knowledge oriented but there
are also industrial robots are used in
Industries in the manufacturing process
and increasingly in security and also in
defense for example image processing
video is fed to them and they need to be
able to detect objects obstacles and so
on and so forth so that's where deep
learning is used they need to be able to
hear and make sense of the sounds that
they are hearing that needs deep
learning as well so robotics is a major
area where deep learning is applied then
we have self-driving cars or autonomous
cars you must have heard of Google's
autonomous car which has been tested for
millions of miles and pretty much
incident free there were of course a
couple of incidents here and there but
it is considered to be fairly safe and
there are today a lot of Automotive
companies in fact pretty much every
automotive company worth its name is
investing in self-driving cars or
autonomous cars and it is predicted that
in the next probably 10 to 15 years
these will be in production and they
will be used extensively in real life
right now they are all in r d and in
test phases but pretty soon these will
be on the road so this is another area
where deep learning is used and how is
it used where is it used within
autonomous driving the car actually is
fed with video of surroundings and it is
supposed to process that information
process that video and determine if
there are any obstacles it has to
determine if there are any cars in the
site will detect whether it is driving
in the lane also it has to determine
whether the signal is green or red so
that accordingly it can move forward or
wait so for all these video analysis
deep learning is used in addition to
that the training overall training to
drive the car happens in a deep learning
environment so again a lot of scope here
to use deep learning couple of other
applications are mission translations
today we have a lot of information and
very often this information is in one
particular language and more
specifically in English and people need
information in various parts of the
world it is pretty difficult for human
beings to translate each and every piece
of information or every document into
all possible languages there are
probably at least hundreds of languages
or if not more to translate each and
every document into every language is
pretty difficult therefore we can use
deep learning to do pretty much like a
real-time translation mechanism so we
don't have to translate everything and
keep it ready but we train applications
or artificial intelligence systems that
will do the translation on the Fly for
example you go to somewhere like China
and you want to know what is written on
a signboard that is impossible for
somebody to translate that and put it on
the web or something like that so you
have an application which is train to
translate stuff on the fly so you
probably this can be running on your
mobile phone on your smartphone you scan
this the application will instantly
translate that from Chinese to English
that is one then there could be web
applications where there may be a
research document which is all in maybe
Chinese or Japanese and you want to
translate that to study that document or
in that case you need to translate so
therefore deep learning is used in such
situations as well and that is again on
demand so it is not like you have to
translate all these documents from other
languages into English in one shot and
keep it somewhere that is again and
pretty much an impossible task but on a
neat basis so you have systems that are
trained to translate on the fly so
Mission translation is another major
area where deep learning is used then
there are a few other upcoming areas
where synthesizing is done by neural
nets for example music composition and
generation of music so you can train a
neural net to produce music even to
compose music so this is a fun thing
this is still upcoming it needs a lot of
effort to train such neural land it has
been proved that it is possible so this
is a relatively new area and on the same
lines colorization of images so these
two images on the left hand side is a
grayscale image or a black and white
image this was colored by a neural net
or a deep learning application as you
can see it's done a very good job of
applying the colors and obviously this
was trained to do this colorization but
yes this is one more application of deep
learning what are the different types of
machine learning algorithms machine
learning algorithms are broadly
classified into three types the
supervised learning the unsupervised
learning and reinforcement learning
supervised learning in turn consists of
techniques like regression and
classification and unsupervised learning
we use techniques like Association and
clustering and reinforcement learning is
the recently developed technique and it
is very popular in gaming some of you
must have heard about alphago so this
was developed using reinforcement
learning primary difference between
supervised learning and unsupervised
learning supervised learning is used
when we have historical data and we have
labeled data which means that we know
how the data is classified so we know
the classes if we are doing
classification or we know the values
when we are doing regression so if we
have historical data with these values
which are known as labels then we use
supervised learning in case of
unsupervised learning we do not have
past labeled data historical labeled
data so we use techniques like
Association and clustering to maybe form
clusters or new classes maybe and then
we move from there in case of
reinforcement learning the system learns
pretty much from scratch there is an
agent and there is an environment the
agent is given a certain Target and it
is rewarded when it is moving towards
that Target and it is penalized if it is
moving in a direction which is not
achieving that Target so it's more like
a carrot and stick model so what is the
difference between these three types of
algorithms supervised algorithms or
supervised learning algorithms are used
when you have a specific Target value
that you would like to predict the
target could be categorical having two
or more possible outcomes or classes if
you will that is what is classification
or the target could be a value which can
be measured and that's where we use
regression like for example weather
forecasting you want to find the
temperature whereas in classification
you want to find out whether this is a
fraud or not a fraud or if it is email
spam whether it is Spam or not spam so
that is a classification example so if
you know or doesn't is known as labeled
information if you have the labeled
information then you use supervised
learning in case of unsupervised
learning we have input data but we don't
have the labels or what the output is
supposed to be so that is when we use
unsupervised learning techniques like
clustering and Association and we try to
analyze the data in case of
reinforcement learning it allows the
agent to automatically determine the
ideal Behavior within a specific context
and it has to do this to maximize the
performance like for example playing a
game so the agent is told that you need
to score the maximum score possible
without losing lives so that is a Target
that is given to the agent and it is
allowed to learn from scratch play the
game itself multiple times and slowly it
will learn the behavior which will
increase the score and keep the lives to
the maximum that's an example of
reinforcement learning we look at a
different machine learning algorithms we
can divide them into three areas
supervised unsupervised reinforcement
we're only going to look at supervise
today unsupervised means we don't have
the answers we're just grouping things
reinforcement is where we give positive
and negative feedback to our algorithm
to program it and it doesn't have the
information until after the fact but
today we're just looking at supervised
because that's where linear regression
fits in in supervised data we have our
data already there and our answers for a
group and then we use that to program
our model and come up with an answer the
two most common uses for that is through
the regression and classification now
we're doing linear regression so we're
just going to focus on the regression
side and in the regression we have
SIMPLE linear regression we have
multiple linear regression and we have
polynomial linear regression now on
these three simple linear regression is
the examples we've looked at so far
where we have a lot of data and we draw
a straight line through it multiple
linear regression means we have multiple
variables remember where we had the
rainfall and the crops we might add
additional variables in there like how
much food do we give our crops when do
we Harvest them those would be
additional information add into our
model and that's why it'd be multiple
linear regression and finally we have
polynomial linear regression that is
instead of drawing a line we can draw a
curved line through it now that you see
where regression model fits into the
machine learning algorithms and we're
specifically looking at linear
regression let's go ahead and take a
look at applications for linear
regression let's look at a few
applications of linear regression
economic growth used to determine the
economic growth of a country or a state
in the coming quarter can also be used
to predict the GDP of a country product
price can be used to predict what would
be the price of a product in the future
we can guess whether it's going to go up
or down or should I buy today housing
sales to estimate the number of houses a
builder would sell and what price in the
coming months score predictions Cricket
fever to predict the number of runs a
player would score in the coming matches
based on the previous performance I'm
sure you can figure out other
applications you could use linear
regression for so let's jump in and
let's understand linear regression and
dig into the theory understanding linear
regression linear regression is the
statistic technical model used to
predict the relationship between
independent and dependent variables by
examining two factors the first
important one is which variables in
particular are significant predictors of
the outcome variable and the second one
that we need to look at closely is how
significant is the regression line to
make predictions with the highest
possible accuracy if it's inaccurate we
can't use it so it's very important we
find out the most accurate line we can
get since linear regression is based on
drawing a line through data we're going
to jump back and take a look at some
euclidean geometry the simplest form of
a simple linear regression equation with
one dependent and one independent
variable is represented by y equals m
times X plus C and if you look at our
model here we plotted two points on here
X1 and y1 X2 and Y2 y being the
dependent variable remember that from
before and X being the independent VAR
variable so y depends on whatever X is m
in this case is the slope of the line
where m equals the difference in the Y2
minus y1 and X2 minus X1 and finally we
have C which is the coefficient of the
line or where it happens to cross the
zero axes let's go back and look at an
example we used earlier of linear
regression we're going to go back to
plotting the amount of crop yield based
on the amount of rainfall and here we
have our rainfall remember we cannot
change rainfall and we have our crop
yield which is dependent on the rainfall
so we have our independent and our
dependent variables we're going to take
this and draw a line through it as best
we can through the middle of the data
and then we look at that we put the red
point on the y-axis is the amount of
crop yield you can expect for the amount
of rainfall represented by the Green Dot
so if we have an idea what the rainfall
is for this year and what's going on
then we can guess how good our crops are
going to be and we've created a nice
line right through the middle to give us
a nice mathematical formula let's take a
look and see what the math looks like
behind this let's look at the intuition
behind the regression line now before we
dive into the math and the formulas that
go behind this and what's going on
behind the scenes
I want you to note that when we get into
the case study and we actually apply
some python script that this math you're
going to see here is already done
automatically for you you don't have to
have it memorized it is however good to
have an idea what's going on so if
people reference the different terms
you'll know what they're talking about
let's consider a sample data set with
five rows and find out how to draw the
regression line we're only going to do
five rows because if we did like the
rainfall with hundreds of points of data
that would be very hard to see what's
going on with the mathematics so we'll
go ahead and create our own two sets of
data and we have our independent
variable X and our dependent variable Y
and when X was one we got y equals 2
when X was 2 y was 4 and so on and so on
if we go ahead and plot this data on a
graph we can see how it forms a nice
line through the middle you can see
where it's kind of grouped going upwards
to the right the next thing we want to
know is whether the means is of each of
the data coming in the X and the Y the
means doesn't mean anything other than
the average so we add up all the numbers
and divide by the total so one plus two
plus three plus four plus five over five
equals three and the same for y we get
four if we go ahead and plot the means
on the graph we'll see we get three
comma four which draws a nice line down
the middle a good estimate here we're
going to dig deeper into the math behind
the regression line now remember before
I said you don't have to have all these
formulas memorized or fully understand
them even though we're going to go into
a little more detail of how it works and
if you're not a math whiz and you don't
know if you've never seen the sigma
character before which looks a little
bit like an e that's opened up that just
means summation that's all that is so
when you see the sigma character it just
means we're adding everything in that
row and for computers this is great
because as a programmer you can easily
iterate through each of the X Y points
and create all the information you need
so in the top half you can see where
we've broken that down into pieces and
as it goes through the first two points
it computes the squared value of x the
squared value of y and x times Y and
then it takes all of X and adds them up
all of Y adds them up all of x squared
adds them up and so on and so on and you
can see we have the sum of equal to 15
the sum is equal to 20. all the way up
to x times Y where the sum equals 66
this all comes from our formula for
calculating a straight line where y
equals the slope times X plus a
coefficient C so we go down below and
we're going to compute more like the
averages of these and we'll explain
exactly what that is in just a minute
and where that information comes from is
called the square means error but we'll
go into that in detail in a few minutes
all you need to do is look at the
formula and see how we've gone about
Computing it line by line instead of
trying to you have a huge set of numbers
pushed into it and down here you'll see
where the slope m equals and then the
top part if you read through the
brackets you have the number of data
points times the sum of x times Y which
we computed one line at a time there and
that's just the 66 and take all that and
you subtract it from the sum of x times
the sum of Y and those have both been
computed so you have 15 times 20. and on
the bottom we have the number of lines
times the sum of x squared easily
computed as 86 for the sum minus I'll
take all that and subtract the sum of x
squared and we end up as we come across
with our formula you can plug in all
those numbers which is very easy to do
on the computer you don't have to do the
math on a piece of paper or calculator
and you'll get a slope of 0.6 and you'll
get your C coefficient if you continue
to follow through that formula you'll
see it comes out as equal to 2.2
continuing deeper into what's going
behind the scenes let's find out the
predicted values of Y for corresponding
values of X using the linear equation
where m equals 0.6 and C equals 2.2
we're going to take these values and
we're going to go ahead and plot them
we're going to predict them so y equals
0.6 times where x equals 1 plus 2.2
equals 2.8 and so on and so on and here
the Blue Points represent the actual y
values and the brown points represent
the predicted y values based on the
model we created the distance between
the actual and predicted values is known
as residuals or errors the best fit line
should have the least sum of squares of
these errors also known as e-square if
we put these into a nice chart we can
see X and you can see Y what the actual
values were and you can see why it
predicted you can easily see where we
take y minus y predicted and we get an
answer what is the difference between
those two and if we square that y minus
y prediction squared we can then sum
those squared values that's where we get
the 0.64 plus the 0.36 plus 1 all the
way down until we have a summation
equals 2.4 so the sum of squared errors
for this regression line is 2.4 we check
this error for each line and conclude
the best fit line having the least e
Square value in a nice graphical
representation we can see here where we
keep moving this line through the data
points to make sure the best fit line
has the least squared distance between
the data points and the regression line
now we only looked at the most commonly
used formula for minimizing the distance
there are lots of ways to minimize the
distance between the line and the data
points like sum of squared errors sum of
absolute errors root mean square error
Etc which you want to take away from
this is whatever formula is being used
you can easily using a computer
programming and iterating through the
data calculate the different parts of it
that way these complicated formulas you
see with the different summations and
absolute values are easily computed one
piece at a time up until this point
we've only been looking at two values X
and Y well in the real world it's very
rare that you only have two values when
you're figuring out a solution so let's
move on to the next topic multiple
linear regression let's take a brief
look at what happens when you have
multiple inputs so in multiple linear
regression we have well we'll start with
the simple linear regression where we
had y equals M plus X plus C and we're
trying to find the value of y now with
multiple linear regression we have
multiple variables coming in so instead
of having just X we have X1 X2 X3 and
instead of having just one slope each
variable has its own slope attached to
it as you can see here we have M1 M2 M3
and we still just have the single
coefficient so when you're dealing with
multiple linear regression you basically
take your single linear regression and
you spread it out so you have y equals
M1 times X1 plus M2 times X2 so on all
the way to m to the nth x to the nth and
then you add your coefficient on there
implementation of linear regression now
we get into my favorite part let's
understand how multiple linear
regression works by implementing it in
Python if you remember before we were
looking at a company and just based on
its R and D trying to figure out its
profit we're going to start looking at
the expenditure of the company we're
going to go back to that we're going to
predict as profit but instead of
predicting it just on the R and D we're
going to look at other factors like
Administration cost marketing costs and
so on and from there we're going to see
if we can figure out what the profit of
that company is going to be to start our
coding we're going to begin by importing
some basic libraries and we're going to
be looking through the data before we do
any kind of linear regression we're
going to take a look at the data to see
what we're playing with then we'll go
ahead and format the data to the format
we need to be able to run it in the
linear regression model and then from
there we'll go ahead and solve it in and
just see how valid our solution is so
let's start with importing the basic
libraries now I'm going to be doing this
in Anaconda Jupiter notebook a very
popular IDE I enjoy because it's such a
visual to look at and it's so easy to
use just any ID for python will work
just fine for this so break out your
favorite python IDE so here we are in
our Jupiter notebook let me go ahead and
paste our first piece of code in there
and let's walk through what libraries
were importing first we're going to
import numpy as NP and then I want you
to skip one line and look at import
pandas as PD these are very common tools
that you need with most of your linear
regression the numpy which stands for
number python is usually denoted as NP
and you have to almost have that for
your SK learn toolbox you always import
that right off the beginning pandas
although you don't have to have it for
your sklearn libraries it does such a
wonderful job of importing data setting
it up into a data frame so we can
manipulate it rather easily and it has a
lot of tools also in addition to that so
so we usually like to use the pandas
when we can and I'll show you what that
looks like the other three lines are for
us to get a visual of this data and take
a look at it so we're going to import
matplotlibrary.pi plot as PLT and then
Seaborn as SNS Seabourn works with the
matplot library so you have to always
import matplot library and then Seaborn
sits on top of it and we'll take a look
at what that looks like you could use
any of your own plotting libraries you
want there's all kinds of ways to look
at the data these are just very common
ones and the Seabourn is so easy to use
it just looks beautiful it's a nice
representation that you can actually
take and show somebody and the final
line is the Amber signed matplot library
in line that is only because I'm doing
an inline IDE my interface in the
Anaconda Jupiter notebook requires I put
that in there or you're not going to see
the graph when it comes up let's go
ahead and run this it's not going to be
that interesting so we're just setting
up variables in fact it's not going to
do anything that we can see but it is
importing these different libraries and
setup the next step is load the data set
and extract independent and dependent
variables now here in the slide you'll
see companies equals pd.read CSV and it
has a long line there with the file at
the end one thousand companies.csv
you're going to have to change this to
fit whatever setup you have and the file
itself you can request just go down to
the commentary below this video and put
a note in there and simply learn we'll
try to get in contact with you and
Supply you with that file so you can try
this coding yourself so we're going to
add this code in here and we're going to
see that I have companies equals
pd.reader underscore CSV and I've
changed this path to match my computer C
colon slash simply learn slash 1000
underscore companies.csv and then below
there we're going to set the x equals to
companies under the I location and
because this is companies as a PD data
set I can use this nice notation that
says take every row that's what the
colon the first colon is comma except up
for the last column that's what the
second part is where we have a colon
minus one and we want the values set
into there so X is no longer a data set
a pandas data set but we can easily
extract the data from our pandas data
set with this notation and then y we're
going to set equal to the last row well
the question is going to be what are we
actually looking at so let's go ahead
and take a look at that and we're going
to look at the companies dot head which
lists the first five rows of data and
I'll open up the file in just a second
so you can see where that's coming from
but let's look at the data in here as
far as the way the pandas sees it when I
hit run you'll see it breaks it out into
a nice setup this is what pandas one of
the things pandas is really good about
is it looks just like an Excel
spreadsheet you have your rows and
remember when we're programming we
always start with zero we don't start
with one so it shows the first five rows
zero one two three four and then it
shows your different columns R and D
spend Administration marketing spend
State profit it even notes that the top
top are column names it was never told
that but pandas is able to recognize a
lot of things that they're not the same
as the data rows why don't we go ahead
and open this file up in a CSV so you
can actually see the raw data so here
I've opened it up as a text editor and
you can see at the top we have r d spend
comma Administration comma marketing
spin comma State comma profit carries
return I don't know about you but I'd go
crazy trying to read files like this
that's why we use the pandas you could
also open this up in an Excel and it
would separate it since it is a comma
separated variable file but we don't
want to look at this one we want to look
at something we can read rather easily
so let's flip back and take a look at
that top part the first five row now as
nice as this format is or can see the
data to me it doesn't mean a whole lot
maybe you're an expert in business and
Investments and you understand what 165
349.20 compared to the administration
cost of 136
897.80 so on so on helps to create the
the profit of 192 261 and 83 cents that
makes no sense to me whatsoever no pun
intended so let's flip back here and
take a look at our next set of code
where we're going to graph it so we can
get a better understanding of our data
and what it means so at this point we're
going to use a single line of code to
get a lot of information so we can see
where we're going with this let's go
ahead and paste that into our notebook
and see what we got going and so we have
the visualization and again we're using
SNS which is pandas as you can see we
imported the matplot Library dot Pi plot
is PLT which then the Seaborn uses and
we imported the Seaborn as SNS and then
that final line of code helps us show
this in our inline coding without this
it wouldn't display and you could
display it to a file in other means and
that's the matplot library in line with
the Amber sign at the beginning so here
we come down to the single line of code
Seaborn is great because it actually
recognizes the panda data frame so I can
just take the comp companies dot core
for coordinates and I can put that right
into the Seaborn and when we run this we
get this beautiful plot and let's just
take a look at what this plot means if
you look at this plot on mine the colors
are probably a little bit more purplish
and blue than the original one we have
the columns and the rows we have R and D
spending we have Administration we have
marketing spending and profit and if you
cross index any two of these since we're
interested in profit if you cross index
profit with profit it's going to show up
if you look at the scale on the right
way up in the dark why because those are
the same data they have an exact
correspondence so r d spending is going
to be the same as r d spending and the
same thing with Administration costs so
right down the middle you get this dark
row or dark diagonal row that shows that
this is the highest corresponding data
that's exactly the same and as it
becomes lighter there's less connections
between the data so we can see with
profit obviously profit is the same as
profit and next it has a very high
correlation with r d spending which we
looked at earlier and it has a slightly
less connection to marketing spending
and even less to how much money we put
into the administration so now that we
have a nice look at the data let's go
ahead and dig in and create some actual
useful linear regression models so that
we can predict values and have a better
profit now that we've taken a look at
the visualization of this data we're
going to move on to the next step
instead of just having a pretty picture
we need to generate some hard data some
hard values so let's see what that looks
like we're going to set up our linear
regression model in two steps the first
one is we need to prepare some of our
data so it fits correctly and let's go
ahead and paste this code into our
jupyter notebook and what we're bringing
in is we're going to bring in the
sklearn pre-processing where we're going
to import the label encoder and the one
hot encoder to use the label encoder
we're going to create a variable called
label encoder and set it equal to
capital L label capital E encoder this
creates a class that we can reuse for
transferring the labels back and forth
now about now you should ask what labels
are we talking about let's go take a
look at the data we processed before and
see what I'm talking about here if you
remember when we did the companies dot
head and we printed the top five rows of
data we have our columns going across we
have column zero which is R and D
spending column one which is
Administration column two which is
marketing spending and column three is
State and you'll see under State we have
New York California Florida now to do a
linear regression model it doesn't know
how to process New York it knows how to
process a number so the first thing
we're going to do is we're going to
change that New York California and
Florida and we're going to change those
to numbers that's what this line of code
does here x equals and then it has the
colon comma 3 in Brackets the first part
the colon comma means that we're going
to look at all the different rows so
we're going to keep them all together
but the only row we're going to edit is
the third row and in there we're going
to take the label coder and we're going
to fit and transform the X also the
third row so we're going to take that
third row we're going to set it equal to
a transformation and that transformation
basically tells it that instead of
having a New York it has a zero or a one
or a two and then finally we need to do
a one hot encoder which equals one hot
encode or categorical features equals
three and then we take the X and we go
ahead and do that equal to one hot
encoder fit transform X to array this
final transformation preps our data
Force so it's completely set the way we
need it is just a row of numbers even
though it's not in here let's go ahead
and print X and just take a look at what
this data is doing you'll see you have
an array of arrays and then each array
is a row of numbers and if I go ahead
and just do row zero you'll see I have a
nice organized row of numbers that the
computer now understands we'll go ahead
and take this out there because it
doesn't mean a whole lot to us it's just
a row of numbers
next on setting up our data we have
avoiding dummy variable trap this is
very important why because the computers
automatically transformed our header
into the setup and it's automatically
transformed all these different
variables so when we did the encoder the
encoder created two columns and what we
need to do is just have the one because
it has both the variable and the name
that's what this piece of code does here
let's go ahead and paste this in here
and we have x equals x colon comma one
colon all this is doing is removing that
one extra column we put in there when we
did our one hot encoder and our label
encoding let's go ahead and run that and
now we get to create our linear
regression model and let's see what that
looks like here and we're going to do
that in two steps the first step is
going to be in splitting the data now
whenever we create a predictive model of
data we always want to split it up so we
have a training set and we have a
testing set that's very important
otherwise we'd be very unethical without
testing it to see how good our fit is
and then we'll go ahead and create our
multiple linear regression model and
train it and set it up let's go ahead
and paste this next piece of code in
here and I'll go ahead and shrink it
down a size or two so it all fits on one
line so from the sklearn module
selection we're going to import train
test split and you'll see that we've
created four completely different
variables we have capital x train
capital X test smaller case y train
smaller case y test that is the standard
way that they usually reference these
when we're doing different models
usually see that a capital x and you see
the train and the test and the lowercase
Y what this is is X is our data going in
that's our RND spin our Administration
our marketing and then Y which we're
training is the answer that's the profit
because we want to know the profit of an
unknown entity so that's what we're
going to shoot for in this tutorial the
next part train test a split we take X
and we take y we've already created
those X has the columns with the data in
it and Y has a column with profit in it
and then we're going to set the test
size equals 0.2 that basically means 20
percent so twenty percent of the rows
are going to be tested we're going to
put them off to the side so since we're
using a thousand lines of data that
means that 200 of those lines we're
going to hold off to the side to test
for later and then the random State
equals zero we're going to randomize
which ones it picks to hold off to the
side we'll go ahead and run this it's
not overly exciting is it setting up our
variables but the next step is the next
step we actually create our linear
regression model now that we got to the
linear regression model we get that next
piece of the puzzle let's go ahead and
put that code in there and walk through
it so here we go we're going to paste it
in there and let's go ahead and since
this is a shorter line of code let's
zoom up there so we can get a good look
and we have from the sklearn dot linear
underscore model we're going to import
linear regression now I don't know if
you recall from earlier when we were
doing all the math let's go ahead and
flip back there and take a look at that
do you remember this or we had this long
formula on the bottom and we were doing
all this summarization and then we also
looked at setting it up with the
different lines and then we also looked
all the way down to multiple linear
regression where we're adding all those
formulas together all of that is wrapped
up in this one section so what's going
on here is I'm going to create a
variable called regressor and the
regressor equals the linear regression
that's a linear regression model that
has all that math built in so we don't
have to have it all memorized or have to
compute it individually and then we do
the regressor.fet in this case we do X
train and Y train because we're using
the training data X being the data n and
y being profit what we're looking at and
this does all that math for us so within
one click and one line we've created the
whole linear regression model and we fit
the data to the linear regression model
and you can see that when I run the
regressor it gives an output linear
regression it says copy x equals True
Fit intercept equals true in jobs equal
one normalize equals false it's just
giving you some general information on
what's going on with that regressor
model now that we've created our linear
regression model let's go ahead and use
it and if you remember we kept a bunch
of data aside so we're going to do a why
predict variable and we're going to put
in the X test and let's see what that
looks like scroll up a little bit paste
that in here predicting the test set
results so here we have y predict equals
regressor dot predict X test going in
and this gives us y predict now because
I'm in Jupiter in line I can just put
the variable up there and when I hit the
Run button it'll print that array out I
could have just as easily done print y
predict so if you're in a different IDE
that's not an inline setup like the
Jupiter notebook you can do it this way
print y predict and you'll see that for
the 200 different test variables we kept
off to the side is going to produce 200
answers this is what it says the profit
are for those 200 predictions but let's
don't stop there let's keep going and
take a couple look we're going to take
just a short detail here and calculating
the coefficients and the intercepts this
gives us a quick flash at what's going
on behind the line we're going to take a
short detour here and we're going to be
calculating the coefficient and
intercepts so you can see what those
look like what's really nice about our
regressor we created is it already has a
coefficients for us we can simply just
print regressor dot coefficient
underscore when I run this you'll see
our coefficients here and if we can do
the regressor coefficient we can also do
the regressor intercept and let's run
that and take a look at that this all
came from the multiple regression model
and we'll flip over so you can remember
where this is going into and where it's
coming from you can see the formula down
here where y equals M1 times X1 plus M2
times X2 and so on and so on plus C the
coefficient so these variables fit right
into this formula y equals slope one
times column one variable plus slope 2
times column two variable all the way to
the m into the n and x to the N plus C
the coefficient or in this case you have
minus 8.89 to the power of 2 etc etc
times the First Column and the second
column and the third column and then our
intercept is the minus one zero three
zero zero nine point boy it gets kind of
complicated when you look at it this is
why we don't do this by hand anymore
this is why we have the computer to make
these calculations easy to understand
and calculate now I told you that was a
short detour and we're coming towards
the end of our script as you remember
from the beginning I said if we're going
to divide this information we have to
make sure it's a valid model that this
model works and understand how good it
works so calculating the r squared value
that's what we're going to use to
predict how good our prediction is and
let's take a look at what that looks
like in code and so we're going to use
this from
sklearn.metrix we're going to import R2
score that's the r squared value we're
looking at the error so in the R2 score
we take our y test versus our y predict
y test is the actual values we're
testing that was the one that was given
to us so we know are true the why
predict of those 200 values is what we
think it was true and when we go ahead
and run this we see we get a
0.9352 that's the R2 score now it's not
exactly a straight percentage so it's
not saying it's 93 percent correct but
you do want that in the upper 90s oh and
higher shows that this is a very valid
prediction based on the R2 score and if
r squared value of 0.91 or 92 as we got
on our model could remember it does have
a random generation involved this proves
the model is a good model which means
success yay we successfully trained our
model with certain predictors and
estimated the profit of the companies
using linear regression so now that we
have a successful linear regression
model if you are an aspiring machine
learning engineer looking for online
training and certifications from
prestigious universities and in
collaboration with leading experts then
search no more simply lens professional
certification program in and machine
learning from Purdue University in
collaboration with IBM should be a right
choice for more details use the link in
the description box below with that in
mind all right what is logistic
regression as I mentioned earlier
positive regression is an algorithm for
performing binary classification so
let's take an example and see how this
works let's say your car has not been
serviced for quite a few years and now
you want to find out if it is going to
break down in the near future so this is
like a classification problem find out
whether your car will break down or not
so how are we going to perform this
classification so here's how it looks if
we plot the information along the X and
Y axis X is the number of years since
the last service was performed and why
is the probability of your car breaking
down and let's say this information was
this data rather was collected from
several car users it's not just your car
but several car users so that is our
labeled data so the data has been
collected and for for the number of
years and when the car broke down and
what was the probability and that has
been plotted along X and Y axis so this
provides an idea or from this graph we
can find out whether your car will break
down or not we'll see how so first of
all the probability can go from zero to
one as you all aware probability can be
between 0 and 1 and as we can imagine it
is intuitive as well as the number of
years are on the Lower Side maybe one
year two years or three years still
after the service the chances of your
car breaking down are very limited right
so for example chances of your car
breaking down on the probability of your
car breaking down within two years of
your last service are 0.1 probability
similarly three years is maybe 0.3 and
so on but as the number of years
increases let's say if it was six or
seven years there is almost a certainty
that your car is going to break down
that is what this graph shows so this is
an example of a application of the
classification algorithm and we will see
in little details how exactly logistic
regression is applied here one more
thing needs to be added here is that the
different variables outcome is discrete
so if we are talking about whether the
car is going to break down or not so
that is a discrete value the why that we
are talking about the dependent variable
that we are talking about what we are
looking at is whether the car is going
to break down or not yes or no that is
what we are talking about so here the
outcome is discrete and not a continuous
way so this is how the logistic
regression curve looks let me explain a
little bit what exactly how exactly we
are going to
determine the class or the outcome
rather so for a logistic regression
curve a threshold has to be set saying
that because this is a probability
calculation remember this is a
probability calculation and the
probability itself will not be zero or
one but based on the probability we need
to decide what the outcome should be so
there has to be a threshold like for
example 0.5 can be the threshold let's
say in this case so any value of the
probability below 0.5 is considered to
be 0 and any value above 0.5 is
considered to be 1. so an output of
let's say 0.8 will mean that the car
will break down so that is considered as
an output of 1 and let's say an output
of 0.29 is considered as 0 which means
that the car will not break down so
that's the way logistic regression works
now let's do a quick comparison between
logistic regression and linear
regression because they both have the
term regression in them so they can
cause confusion so let's try to remove
that confusion so what is linear
regression linear regression is a
process is once again an algorithm for
supervised learning however here you are
going to find a continuous value you are
going to determine a continuous value it
could be the price of a real estate
property it could be your height how
much height you're going to get or it
could be a stock price these are all
continuous values these are not discrete
compared to a yes or no kind of a
response that we are looking for in
logistic integration so this is one
example of a linear regression let's say
at the HR team of a company tries to
find out what should be the salary hike
of an employee so they collect all the
details of their existing employees
their ratings and their salary hikes
what has been given and that is the
labeled information that is available
and the system learns from us it is
strain and it learns from this labeled
information so that when a new
employee's information is fed based on
the rating it will determine what should
be the high so this is a linear
regression problem and a linear
regression example now salary is a
continuous value you can get five
thousand five thousand five hundred five
thousand six hundred it is not discrete
like a cat or a dog or an apple or a
banana these are discrete or a yes or a
no these are discrete values right so
this way you are trying to find
continuous values is where we use linear
regression so let's say just to extend
on the scenario we now want to find out
whether this employee is going to get a
promotion or not so we want to find out
that is the discrete problem right a yes
or no kind of a problem in this case we
actually cannot use linear regression
even though we may have labeled data so
this is the label data So based on the
employee rating these are the ratings
and then some people got the promotion
and this is the ratings for which people
did not get promotion that is a no and
this is the rating for which people got
promotion we just plotted the data about
whether a person has got an employer's
got promotion or not yes no right so
there is nothing in between and what is
the employees rating okay and ratings
can be continuous that is not an issue
but the output is discrete in this case
whether employee got promotion yes no
okay so if we try to plot that and we
try to find a straight line this is how
it would look and as you can see it
doesn't look very right because looks
like there will be lot of errors this
root mean square error if you remember
for linear regression would be very very
high and also the the values cannot go
beyond zero or Beyond one so the graph
should probably look somewhat like this
clipped at 0 and but still this straight
line doesn't look right therefore
instead of using a linear equation we
need to come up with something different
and therefore the logistic regression
model looks somewhat like this so we
calculate the probability and if we plot
that probability not in the form of a
straight line but we need to use some
other equation we will see very soon
what the depression is then it is a
gradual process right so you see here
people with some of these ratings are
not getting any promotions and then
slowly uh at certain rating they get
promotion so that is a gradual process
and this is how the math behind logistic
regression looks so we are trying to
find the odds for a particular event
happening and this is the formula for
finding the odd so the probability of an
event happening divided by the
probability of the event not happening
so P if it is the probability of the
event happening probability of the
person getting a promotion and divided
by the probability of the person not
getting a promotion that is 1 minus p
this is how you measure the odds now the
values of the odds range from 0 to
Infinity so when this probability is 0
then the odds will the value of the odds
is equal to zero and when the
probability becomes 1 then the value of
the odds is 1 by 0 that will be Infinity
but the probability itself remains
between 0 and 1. now this is how an
equation of a straight line love so Y is
equal to beta0 plus beta 1 x where beta0
is the y-intercept and beta 1 is the
slope of the line if we take the odds
equation and take a log of both sides
then this would look somewhat like this
and the term logistic is actually
derived from the fact that we are doing
this we take a log of p x by 1 minus p x
this is an extension of the calculation
of odds that we have seen right and that
is equal to beta0 plus beta 1 x which is
the equation of the straight line and
now from here if you want to find out
the value of p x we will see we can take
the exponential on both sides and then
if we solve that equation we will get
the equation of PX like this p x is
equal to 1 by 1 plus e to the power of
minus beta0 plus beta 1 x and recall
this is nothing but the equation of the
line which is equal to y y is equal to
beta0 plus beta 1 X so that this is the
equation also known as the sigmoid
function and this is the equation of the
logistic regression all right and if
this is plotted this is how the sigmoid
curve is obtained so let's compare
linear and logistic regression how they
are different from each other let's go
back so linear regression is solved or
used to solve regression problems and
logistic regression is used to solve
classification problems so both are
called regression but linear regression
is used for solving regression problems
where we predict continuous values
whereas logistic regression is used for
solving classification problems where we
have had to predict discrete values the
response variables in case of linear
regression are continuous in nature
whereas here they are categorical or
discrete in nature and linear regression
helps to estimate the dependent variable
when there is a change in the
independent variable whereas here in
case of logistic regression it helps to
calculate the probability or the
possibility of a particular event
happening and linear regression as the
name suggests is a straight line that's
why it's called linear regression
whereas logistic regression is a sigmoid
function and the curve is the shape of
the curve is s it's an s-shaped curve
this is another example of application
of logistic regression in weather
prediction whether it's going to rain or
not rain now keep in mind both are used
in weather prediction if we want to find
the discrete values like whether it's
going to rain or not rain that is a
classification problem we use logistic
regression but if we want to determine
what is going to be the temperature
tomorrow then we use linear regression
so just keep in mind that in weather
prediction we actually use both but
these are some examples of logistic
regression so we want to find out
whether it's going to be rain or not is
going to be sunny or not it is going to
snow or not these are all logistic
regression examples a few more examples
classification of objects this is a
again another example of logistic
regression now here of course one
distinction is that these are multi
class classification so logistic
regression is not used in its original
form but it is used in a slightly
different form so we say whether it is a
dog or not a dog I hope you understand
so instead of saying is it a dog or a
cat or a elephant we convert this into
saying so because we need to keep it to
Binary classification so we say is it a
dog or not a dog is it a cat or not a
cat so that's the way logistic
regression can be used for classifying
objects otherwise there are other
techniques which can be used for
performing multi-class classification
Healthcare plastic regression is used to
find the survival rate of a patient so
they take multiple parameters like drama
score and age and so on and so forth and
they try to predict the rate of survival
all right now finally let's take an
example and see how we can apply
logistic regression to predict the
number that is shown in the image so
this is actually a live demo I will take
you into jupyter notebook and show the
code but before that let me take you
through a couple of slides to explain
what we are trying to do so let's say
you have an 8x8 image and there the
image has a number one two three four
and you need to train your model to
predict what this number is so how do we
do this so the first thing is obviously
in any machine learning process you
train your model so in this case we are
using logistic regression so and then we
provide a training set to train the
model and then we test how accurate our
model is with the test data which means
that like any machine learning process
we split our initial data into two parts
training set and test set with the
training set we train our model and then
with the test set we test the model
didn't we get good accuracy and then we
use it for for inference right so that
is typical methodology of
training testing and then deploying of
machine learning models so let's take a
look at the code and see what we are
doing so I'll not go line by line but
just take you through some of the blocks
so first thing we do is import all the
libraries and then we basically take a
look at the images and see what is the
total number of images we can display
using matplotlib some of the images or a
sample of these images and then we split
the data into training and test as I
mentioned earlier and we can do some
exploratory analysis and then we build
our model we train our model with the
training set and then we test it with
our test set and find out how accurate
our model is using the infusion Matrix
the heat map and use heat map for
visualizing this and I will show you in
the code what exactly is the confusion
Matrix and how it can be used for
finding the accuracy in our exam people
we get an accuracy of about 0.94 which
is pretty good or 94 percent which is
pretty good all right so what is the
confusion Matrix this is an example of a
confusion Matrix and this is used for
identifying the accuracy of a
classification model or like a logistic
regression model so the most important
part in a confusion Matrix is that first
of all this as you can see this is a
matrix and the size of the Matrix
depends on how many outputs we
so the the most important part here is
that the model will be most accurate
when we have the maximum numbers in its
diagram like in this case that's why it
has almost 93 94 percent because the
diagonals should have the maximum
numbers and the others other than
diagnose the cells other than the
diagonal should have very few numbers so
here that's what is happening so there
is a two here there are there's a one
here but most of them are along the
diagonal this what does this mean this
means that the number that has been fed
is zero and the number that has been
detected is also zero so the predicted
value and actual value are the same so
along the diagonals that is true which
means that let's let's take this
diagonal right if the maximum number is
here that means that like here in this
case it is 34 which means that 34 of the
images that have been fed are rather
actually there are two
misclassifications in there so 36 images
have been fed which have number four and
out of which 34 have been predicted
correctly as number four and one has
been predicted as number eight and
another one has been predicted as number
nine so these are two missed
classifications okay so that is the
meaning of saying that the maximum
number should be in the diagonal so if
you have all of them so for an ideal
model which has let's say 100 accuracy
everything will be only in the diagonal
there will be no numbers other than zero
in all other cells so that is like a
hundred percent accurate model okay so
that's uh just of how to use this Matrix
how to use this confusion Matrix I know
the name uh is a little funny sounding
confusion Matrix but actually it is not
very confusing it's very straightforward
so you are just plotting what has been
predicted and what is the labeled
information on what is the actual data
that's also known as the ground truth
sometimes okay these are some fancy
terms that are used so predicted label
and the actual name that's all right
okay yeah so we are showing a little bit
more information here so 38 have been
predicted and here you will see that all
of them have been predicted correctly
there have been 38 zeros and predicted
value and the actual value is exactly
the same whereas in this case right it
has there are I think 37 plus 5 yeah 42
have been fed the images 42 images are
of Digit 3 and the accuracy is only 37
of them have been accurately predicted
three of them have been predicted as
number seven and two of them have been
predicted as number eight and so on and
so forth okay all right so with that
let's go into Jupiter notebook and see
how the code looks so this is the code
in in jupyter Notebook for logistic
regression in this particular demo what
we are going to do is train our model to
recognize digits which are the images
which have digits from let's say 0 to 5
or 0 to 9 and
um and then we will see how well it is
trained and whether it is able to
predict these numbers correct a or not
so let's get started so the first part
is as usual we are importing some
libraries that are required and then the
last line in this block is to load the
digits so let's go ahead and run this
code then here we will visualize the
shape of these digits so we can see here
if we take a look this is how the shape
is 1797 by 64. these are like eight by
eight images so that's that's what is
reflected in this shape now from here
onwards we are basically once again
importing some of the libraries that are
required like numpy and matplot and we
will take a look at some of the sample
images that we have loaded so this one
for example creates a figure and then we
go ahead and take a few sample images to
see how they look so let me run this
code and so that it becomes easy to
understand so so these are about five
images sample images that we are looking
at zero one two three four so this is
how the images this is how the data is
okay and based on this we will actually
train our logistic regression model and
then we will test it and see how well it
is able to recognize so the way it works
is the pixel information so as you can
see here this is an eight by eight pixel
kind of a image and the each pixel
whether it is activated or not activated
that is the information available for
each pixel now based on the pattern of
this activation and non-activation of
the various pixels this will be
identified as a zero for example right
similarly as you can see so overall each
of these numbers actually has a
different pattern of the pixel
activation and that's pretty much that
our model needs to learn for which
number what is the pattern of the
activation of the pixels right so that
is what we are going to train our model
okay so the first thing we need to do is
to split our data into training and test
data set right so whenever we perform
any training we split the data into
training and tests so that the training
data set is used to train the system so
we pass this probably multiple times and
then we test it with the test data set
and the split is usually in the form of
there and there are various ways in
which you can split this data it is up
to the individual preferences in our
case here we are splitting in the form
of 23 and 77 so when we say test size as
20.23 that means 23 percent of that
entire data is used for testing and the
remaining 77 percent is used for
training so there is a readily available
function which is called train test
split so we don't have to write any
special code for the splitting it will
automatically split the data based on
the proportion that we give here which
is test size so we just give the test
size automatically training size will be
determined and we pass the data that we
want to split and the the results will
be stored in X underscore train and Y
underscore train for the training data
set and what is X underscore train these
are these are the features right which
is like the independent variable and Y
underscore train is the label right so
in this case what happens is we have the
input value which is or the features
value which is in X underscore train and
since this is a labeled data for each of
them each of the observations we already
have the label information saying
whether this digit is a zero or a one or
a two so that that's this is what will
be used for compare Verizon to find out
whether the the system is able to
recognize it correctly or there is an
error for each observation it will
compare with this right so this is the
label so the same way X underscore train
y underscore train is for the training
data set X underscore test y underscore
test is for the test data set okay so
let me go ahead and execute this code as
well and then we can go and check
quickly what is the how many entries are
there and in each of this so X
underscore train the shape is
1383 by 64 and Y underscore train has
1383 because there is nothing like the
second part is not required here and
then X underscore test shape we see is
414 so actually there are 414
observations in test and 1383
observations in train so that's
basically what these four lines of code
are are saying okay then we import the
logistic regression library and which is
a part of scikit-learn so we we don't
have to implement the logistic
regression process itself we just call
these uh the function and let me go
ahead and execute that so that we have
the logistic regression Library imported
now we create an instance of logistic
regression right so logistic regr is uh
is an instance of logistic regression
and then we use that for training our
model so let me first execute this code
so these two lines so the first line
basically creates an instance of
logistic regression model and then the
second line way is where we are passing
our data the training data set right
this is our the the predictors and this
is our Target we are passing this data
set to train our model all right so once
we do this in this case the data is not
large but by and large and the training
is what takes usually a lot of time so
we spend in machine learning activities
in machine learning projects we spend a
lot of time for the training part of it
okay so here the data set is relatively
small so it was pretty quick so all
right so now our model has been trained
using the training data set and we want
to see how accurate this is so what
we'll do is we will test it out in
probably faces so let me first try out
how well this is working for one image
okay I will just try it out with one
image my the first entry in my test data
set and see whether it is uh correctly
predicting or not so and in order to
test it so for training purpose we use
the fit method there is a method called
fit which is for training the model and
once the training is done if you want to
test for a particular value new input
you use the predict method okay so let's
run the predict method and we pass this
particular image and we see that the
shape is or the prediction is four so
let's try a few more let me see for the
next 10 seems to be fine so let me just
go ahead and test the entire data set
okay that's basically what we will do so
now we want to find out how accurately
this has is performed so we use the
score method to find what is the
percentages of accuracy and we see here
that it has performed up to 94 percent
accurate okay so that's on this part now
what we can also do is we can
um also see this accuracy using what is
known as a confusion Matrix so let us go
ahead and try that as well so that we
can also visualize how well this model
has done so let me execute this piece of
code which will basically import some of
the libraries that are required and we
we basically create a confusion Matrix
an instance of confusion matrix by
running confusion Matrix and passing
these values so we have so this
confusion underscore Matrix method takes
two parameters one is the Y underscore
test and the other is the prediction so
what is the Y underscore test these are
the labeled values which we already know
for the test data set and predictions
are what the system has predicted for
the test data set okay so this is known
to us and this is what the system has
the model has generated so we kind of
create the confusion Matrix and we will
print it and this is how the confusion
Matrix looks as the name suggests it is
a matrix and the key point out here is
that the accuracy of the model is
determined by how many numbers are there
in the diagonal the more the numbers in
the diagonal the better the accuracy is
okay and first of all the total sum of
all the numbers in this whole Matrix is
equal to the number of observations in
the test data set that is the first
thing right so if you add up all these
numbers that will be equal to the number
of observations in the test data set and
then out of that the maximum number of
of them should be in the diagonal that
means the accuracy is pretty good if the
the numbers in the diagonal are less and
in all other places there are a lot of
numbers which means the accuracy is very
low the diagonal indicates a correct
prediction that so this means that the
actual value is same as the predicted
value here again actual value is same as
the predictive value and so on right so
the moment you see a number here that
means the actual value is something and
the predicted value is something else
right similarly here the actual value is
something and the predicted value is
something else so that is basically how
we read the confusion Matrix now how do
we find the accuracy you can actually
add up the total values in the diagonal
so it's like 38 plus 44 Plus 43 and so
on and divide that by the total number
of test observations that will give you
the percentage accuracy using a
confusion Matrix now let us visualize
this confusion Matrix tricks in a
slightly more sophisticated way using a
heat map so we will create a heat map
with some We'll add some colors as well
it's uh it's like a more visually
visually more appealing so that's the
whole idea so if we let me run this
piece of code and this is how the heat
map looks and as you can see here the
diagonals again are all the values are
here most of the values so which means
reasonably this seems to be reasonably
accurate and yeah basically the accuracy
score is 94 percent this is calculated
as I mentioned by adding all these
numbers divided by the total test value
so the total number of observations in
test data set okay so this is the
confusion Matrix for logistic regression
all right so now that we have seen the
confusion Matrix let's take a quick
sample and see how well the system has
classified and we will take a few
examples of the data so if we see here
we picked up randomly a few of them so
this is uh number four which is the
actual value and also the predicted
value both are four this is an image of
zero so the predicted value is also zero
actual value is of course zero then this
is the image of 9. so this has also been
predicted correctly nine and actual
value is 9 and this is the image of one
and again this has been predicted
correctly as like the actual value okay
so this was a quick demo of logistic
regression how to use logistic
regression to identify images if you are
an aspiring machine learning engineer
looking for online training and
certifications from prestigious
universities and in collaboration with
leading experts then search Nomo simple
lens professional certification program
in Ai and machine learning from Purdue
University in collaboration with IBM
should be a right choice for more
details use the link in the description
box below with that in mind there's all
kinds of regression models that come out
of this so we put them aside about side
we have our linear regression which is a
predictive number
used to predicted dependent output
variable based on Independent input
variable
accuracy is a measured using least
squares estimation
so that's where you take it you could
also use absolute value the least
squares is more popular there's reasons
for that mathematically and also for
computer runtime
uh but it does give you an an accuracy
based on the the least Square estimation
the best fit line is a straight line and
clearly that's not always used in all
the regression models there's a lot of
variations on that the output is a
predicted integer value
again this is what we're talking about
when we talk about linear regression and
we're talking about regression it means
the numbers coming out linear usually
means we're looking for that line
versus a different model and it's used
in business domain forecasting stocks
it's used as a basis of almost of most
predictions with numbers so if you're
looking at a lot of numbers you're
probably looking at a linear regression
model
for instance if you do just the high
lows of the stock exchange and you're
going to take a lot more of that if you
want to make money off the stock
you'll find that the linear regression
model fits uh probably better than
almost any of the other models or even
you know high-end neural networks and
all these other different machine
learning and AI models because they're
numbers they're just a straight set of
numbers you have a high value low value
volume that kind of thing so when you're
looking at something that's straight
numbers and are connected in that way
usually you're talking about a linear
regression model that's where you want
to start a logistic regression model
used to classify dependent output
variable based on Independent input
variable so just like the linear
regression model unlike all of our
machine learning tools you have your
features coming in and so in this case
you might have a label you know an image
or something like that is probably the
very popular thing right now labeling
broccoli and vegetables or whatever
accuracy is measured using maximum
likelihood estimation the best fit is
given by a curve and we saw that um
we're talking about linear regression
you definitely are talking about a
straight line although there is other
regression models that don't use
straight lines and usually when you're
looking at a logistic regression the
math as you saw was still kind of a
euclidean line but it's now got that
sigmoid activation which turns it into a
heavily weighted curve and the output is
a binary value between 0 and 1. and it's
used for classification image processing
as I mentioned is is what people usually
think of
although they use it for classification
of
um like a window of things so you could
take a window of stock history and you
could clap generate classifications
based on that and separate the data that
way if it's going to be that this
particular pattern occurs is going to be
upward trending or downward trending
in fact a number of stock
Traders use that not to tell them how
much to bid or what to bid but they use
it as to whether it's worth looking at
the stock or not whether the Stock's
going to go down or go up and it's just
a zero one do I care do I even want to
look at it so let's do a demo so you can
get a picture of what this looks like in
Python code let's predict the price at
which insurance should be sold to a
particular customer based on their
medical history
we will also classify on a mushroom data
set to find the poisonous and
non-poisonous mushrooms
and when you look at these two datas the
first one we're looking at the price so
the price is a number so let's predict
the price which the insurance should be
sold to and the second one is we're
looking at either as poisonous or it's
not poisonous so first off before we
begin the demo I'm in the Anaconda
Navigator
in this one I've loaded the python 3.6
and using the Jupiter notebook and you
can use jupyter notebook by itself you
can use the Jupiter lab which allows
multiple tabs it's basically the
notebook with tabs on it
but the Jupiter notebook is just fine
and it'll go into Google Chrome which is
what I'm using for my Internet Explorer
and from here we open up new and you'll
see python3 and again this is loaded
with python 3.6 and we're doing the
linear versus logic regression or logit
you'll see l-o-g-i-t
is one of the one of the names that kind
of pops up when you do a search on here
but it is a logic we're looking at the
logistic regression models
and we'll start with the linear
regression because it's easy to
understand you draw a line through stuff
and so in programming we got a lot of
stuff to unfold here in our in our
startup as we pre-load all of our
different parts
let's go ahead and break this up we have
at the beginning import pandas
so this is our data frame uh it's just a
way of storing the data think of a you
talk about a data frame think of a
spreadsheet you know rows and columns
it's a nice way of viewing the data
and then we have we're going to be
bringing in our pre-processing labeling
code coder I'll show you what that is
when we get down to it it's easier to
see in the data but there's some data in
here like sex it's male or female so
it's not like an actual number it's
either your one or the other that kind
of stuff ends up being encoded that's
what this label encoder is right here
we have our test split model
if you're going to build a model you do
not want to use all the data you want to
use some of the data and then test it to
see how good it is and if it can't have
seen the data you're testing on until
you're ready to test it on there and see
how good it is
and then we have our logistic regression
model our categorical one and then we
have our linear regression model these
are the two these right here let me just
um
clear all that there we go these two
right here are what this is all about
logistic versus linear is it categorical
are we looking for a true false or are
we looking for a specific number
and then finally usually at the very end
we have to take and just ask how
accurate is our model did it work if
you're trying to predict something in
this case we're going to be doing
um
Insurance costs how close to the
insurance cost does it measure that we
expect it to be you know if you're an
insurance company you don't want to
promise to pay everybody's medical bill
and not be able to
and in the case of the mushrooms you
probably want to know just how much at
risk you are for following this model as
to far as whether you're going to get a
poisonous mushroom and die or not
so we'll look at both of those and we'll
get talk a little bit more about the
shortcomings and the value of these
different processes so let's go ahead
and run this this is loaded the data set
on here and then because we're in
Jupiter notebook I don't have to put the
print on there we just do data set and
by and it prints out all the different
data on here and you can see here for
our insurance because we're starting
with we're loading that with our pandas
and it prints it in a nice format where
you can see the age sex body mass index
number of children smoker so this might
be something that the insurance company
gets from the doctor it says hey we're
gonna this is what we need to know
to give you a quote for what we're going
to charge you for your insurance
and you can see that it has 1 338 rows
and seven columns you can count the
columns one two three four five six
seven so there's seven columns on here
and the column we're really interested
in is charges I want to know what the
charges are going to be what can I
expect
not a very good Arrow drawn
what to expect them to charge on there
so is this going to be you know is this
person going to cost me uh 16 884
dollars or is this person only going to
cost me
3866. how do we guess that so that we
can guess what the minimal charge is for
their insurance
the thing you really need to notice on
this data and I mentioned it before but
I'm going to mention it again because
pre-processing data is so much of the
work in data science
sex well how do you how do you deal with
female versus male
um are you a smoker yes or no what does
that mean region how do you look at
regions not a number how do you draw a
line between Southwest and Northwest
um you know they're objects it's either
your Southwest or your Northwest just
not like I'm southwest I guess you could
do longitude and latitude but the data
doesn't come in like that it comes in as
true false or whatever you know it's
either your Southwest or your Northwest
so we need to do a little bit of
pre-processing of the data on here to
make this work
oops there we go okay so let's take a
look and see what we're doing with
pre-processing
and again this is really where you spend
a lot of time with data science is
trying to understand how and why you
need to do that and so we're going to do
you'll see right up here
label uh and then we're going to do the
do a label encoder one of the modules we
brought in so this is SK learns label
encoder
I like the fact that it's all pretty
much automated but if you're doing a lot
of work with label encoder you should
start to understand how that fits
um and then we have uh
label dot fit
right here where we're going to go ahead
and do the data set Dot
sex.dropduplicates and then for data set
sex we're going to do the label
transform the data set sex and so we're
looking right here at male or female
and so it usually just converts it to a
zero one because there's only two
choices on here
same thing with the smoker it's zero or
one so we're going to transfer the trans
change the smoker 0 1 on this
and then finally we did region down here
region does it a little bit different
we'll take a look at that and it it's I
think in this case it's probably going
to do it because we did it on this label
transform
with this particular setup it gives each
region a number like 0 1 2 3. so let's
go ahead and take a look and see what
that looks like I'm going to run this
and you can see that our new data set
has age that's still a number six is
zero or one so zero is female one is
male
number of children we left that alone uh
smoker one or zero says no or yes on
there we actually just do one for no
zero or no yeah one for no I'm not sure
how it organized them but it turns the
smoker into zero or one yes or no
uh and then Regent it did this as zero
one two three so there's three regions
now a lot of times in in when you're
working with data science and you're
dealing with uh regions or even word
analysis
um instead of doing one column and
labeling it zero one two three a lot of
times you increase your features and so
you would have region Northwest would be
one column yes or no region Southwest
would be one column yes or no true zero
one but for this this this particular
setup this will work just fine on here
now that we spend all that time getting
it set up uh here's the fun part uh
here's the part where we're actually
using our setup on this and you'll see
right here we have our
why linear regression data set drop the
charges because that's what we want to
predict
and so our X I'm sorry our X linear data
set drop the charges because that's what
we're going to predict we're predicting
charges right here so we don't want that
as our input for our features and our y
output is charges that's what we want to
guess we want to guess what the charges
are
and then what we talked about earlier is
we don't want to do all the data at once
so we're going to take
0.3 means 30 percent we're going to take
30 percent of our data and it's going to
be as the trade as the testing site so
here's our y test and our X test down
there
um and so that part our model will never
see it until we're ready to test to see
how good it is and then of course right
here you'll see our training set and
this is what we're going to train it
we're going to trade it on seventy
percent of the data
and then finally the big ones this is
where all the magic happens this is
where we're going to create our magic
setup and that is right here our linear
model we're going to set an equal to the
linear regression model
and then we're going to fit the data on
here
and then at this point I always like to
pull up
um if you if you if you're working with
the new models good to see where it
comes from and this comes from the
scikit learn
and this is the SK learn linear model
linear regression that we imported
earlier
and you can see they have different
parameters the basic parameter works
great if you're dealing with just
numbers I mentioned that earlier with
stock high lows this model will do as
good as any other model out there for do
if you're doing just the very basic high
lows and looking for a linear fit a
regression model fit
um and what you one of the things
when I'm looking at this as I look for
methods
and you'll see here's our fit that we're
using right now and here's our predict
and we'll actually do a little bit in
the middle here as far as looking at
some of the parameters hidden behind it
the math that we talked about earlier
and so we go in this we go ahead and run
this
you'll see it loads a linear regression
model and just has a nice output that
says hey I loaded the linear regression
model
and then the second part is we did the
fit and so this model is now trained our
linear model is now trained on the
training data
and so one of the things we can look at
is the for idx and column name and
enumerate X linear train columns
kind of an interesting thing this prints
out the coefficients so when you're
looking at the back end of the data you
remember we had that formula BX X1 plus
bxx2 plus the inner plus the intercept
and so forth these are the actual
coefficients that are in here this is
what it's actually multiplying these
numbers by
and you can see like region gets a minus
value so when it heads it up I guess
region you can read a lot into these
numbers uh it gets very complicated
there's ways to mess with them if you're
doing a basic linear regression model
usually don't look at them too closely
but you might start looking in these and
saying hey you know what uh smoker look
how smoker impacts the cost
it's just massive so this is a flag that
hey the value of the smoker really
affects this model
and then you can see here where the body
mass index so somebody who is overweight
is probably less healthy and more likely
to have cost money and then of course
age is a factor and then you can see
down here we have the sexist in a factor
also and it just it changes as you go in
there negative number it probably has
its own meaning on there
again it gets really complicated when
you dig into the workings and how the
linear model works on that and so we can
also look at the intercept this is just
kind of fun so it starts at this
negative number and then adds all these
numbers to it that's all that means
that's our intercept on there and that
fits the data we have on that
and so you can see right here we can go
back and
oops give me just a second there we go
we can go ahead and predict the unknown
data and we can print that out
and if you're going to create a model to
predict something we'll go ahead and
predict it here's our y prediction value
linear model predict
and then we'll go ahead and create a new
data frame
in this case from our X linear test
group
we'll go ahead and put the cost back
into this data frame and then the
predicted cost we're going to make that
equal to our y prediction
and so when we pull this up you can see
here that we have the actual cost and
what we predicted the cost is going to
be
there's a lot of ways to measure the
accuracy on there but we're going to go
ahead and jump into our mushroom data
and so in this you can see here we've
run our basic model we built our
coefficients you can see the intercept
the back end you can see how we're
generating a number here
now with mushrooms we want a yes or no
we want to know whether we can eat them
or not
and so here's our mushroom file we're
going to run this take a look at the
data and again you can ask for a copy of
this file send a note over to
simplylearn.com
and you can see here that we have a
class the cap shape cap surface and so
forth so there's a lot of feature in
fact there's 23 different columns in
here going across
and when you look at this I'm not even
sure what these particular like p e e p
e I don't even know what the class is on
this
I'm going to guess by the notes that the
class is poisonous or edible
so if you remember before we had to do a
little pre-coding on our data same thing
with here we have our cap shape which is
b or X or k
we have cap color these really aren't
numbers so it's really hard to do
anything with just a single number so we
need to go ahead and turn those into a
label encoder which again there's a lot
of different encoders with this
particular label encoder it's just
switching it to 0 1 2 3 and giving it an
integer value
in fact if you look at all the columns
all of our columns are labels and so
we're just going to go ahead and loop
through all the columns in the data and
we're going to transform it into a label
encoder and so when we run this you can
see how this gets shifted from
xbxx K to 0 1 2 3 4 5 or whatever it is
class is 0 1 1 being poisonous zero
looks like it's editable
and so forth on here so we're just
encoding it if you were doing this
project depending on the results you
might encode it differently like I
mentioned earlier you might actually
increase the number of features as
opposed to laboring 0 1 2 3 4 5. in this
particular example it's not going to
make that big of a difference how we
encode it
and then of course we're looking for the
class whether it's poisonous or edible
so we're going to drop the class in our
X Logistics model and we're going to
create our y Logistics model is based on
that class so here's our x y
and just like we did before we're going
to go ahead and split it
using 30 percent for test
70 percent to program the model on here
and that's right here whoops there we go
there's our train and test
and then you'll see here on this next
setup
this is where we create our model all
the magic happens right here
we go ahead and
create a logistics model I have up the
max iterations if you don't
change this for this particular problem
you'll get a warning that says this has
not converged
because that that's what it does is it
goes through the math and it goes hey
can we minimize the error and it keeps
finding a lower and lower error and it
still is changing that number so that
means it hasn't conversed yet it hasn't
find the lowest amount of error it can
and the default is 100. there's a lot of
settings in here so when we go in here
to let me pull that up from the sklearn
so we pull that up from the SK learn
model
you can see here we have our logistic it
has our different settings on here that
you can mess with most of these work
pretty solid on this particular setup so
you don't usually mess a lot usually I
find myself adjusting the iteration and
I'll get that warning and then increase
the iteration on there and just like the
other model you can go just like you did
with the other model we can scroll down
here and look for our methods
and you can see there's a lot of methods
available on here and certainly there's
a lot of different things you can do
with it
but the most basic thing we do is we fit
our model make sure it's set right and
then we actually predict something with
it so those are the two main things
we're going to be looking at on this
model is fitting and predicting there's
a lot of cool things you can do that are
more advanced but for the most part
these are the two which I use when I'm
going into one of these models and
setting them up
so let's go ahead and close out of our
sklearn setup on there and we'll go
ahead and run this
and you can see here it's now loaded
this up there we now have a
logistic model and we've gone ahead and
done a predict here also just like I was
showing you earlier
so here's where we're actually
predicting the data so we we've done our
first two lines of code as we create the
model we fit the model to our training
data and then we go ahead and predict
for our test data now in the previous
model we didn't dive into the test score
I think I just showed you a graph and we
can go in there and there's a lot of
tools to do this we're going to look at
the model score on this one and let me
just go ahead and run the model score
and it says that it's pretty accurate
we're getting a roughly 95 percent
accuracy well that's good one 95
accuracy
95 accuracy might be good for a lot of
things
but when you look at something as far as
whether you're going to pick a mushroom
on the side of the trail and eat it we
might want to look at the confusion
Matrix and for that we're going to put
in our y logistic test the actual values
of edible and unedible and we're going
to put in our prediction value
and if you remember on here let's see I
believe it's poisonous was one zero is
edible
so let's go ahead and run that 0 1 0 is
good so here is a confusion Matrix and
this is if you're not familiar with
these we have true true true false
true false false false so it says out of
the edible mushrooms we correctly
labeled 1201 mushrooms edible that were
edible
and we correctly measured
1113 poisonous mushrooms as poisonous
but here's the kicker
I labeled
56 edible mushrooms as being
poisonous well that's not too big of a
deal we just don't eat them
but I measured 68 mushrooms as being
edible that were poisonous
so probably not the best choice to use
this model to predict whether you're
going to eat a mushroom or not
and you'd want to dig a Little Deeper
before you start picking mushrooms off
the side of the trail so a little
warning there when you're looking at any
of these data models looking at the
error and how that error fits in with
what domain you're in domain in this
case being edible mushrooms
be a little careful make sure that
you're looking at them correctly
so we've looked at uh edible or not
edible we've looked at a regression
model as far as the N values what's
going to be the cost and what our
predicted cost is so we can start
figuring out how much to charge these
people for their insurance
and so these really are the fundamentals
of data science when you pull them
together when I say data science to talk
about your machine learning code
and hopefully you got a little bit out
of here again you can contact our simply
learned team and get a copy of these
files or get more information on this
if you are an aspiring machine learning
engineer looking for online training and
certifications from prestigious
universities and in collaboration with
leading experts then search Nomo simply
learns professional certification
program in Ai and machine learning from
Purdue University in collaboration with
IBM should be a right choice for more
details use the link in the description
box below with that in mind
a confusion Matrix represents a table
layout of the different outcomes of
prediction
and results of a classification problem
and helps visualize its outcomes
and so you see here we have our simple
chart predicted and actual
the confusion Matrix helps us identify
the correct predictions of a model for
different individual classes as well as
the errors so you'll see here that the
values predicted by our classifier are
along the rows this is what we're going
to guess it is or our model is guessing
what this is based on its training so
we've already trained the model to guess
whether it's spam or not spam or
whatever it is you're working on
and then the actual values of our data
set are along the columns
so this is the actual value that's
supposed to be
people who can speak English will be
classified as positives so because they
have a remember zero one do you speak
English yes no and you could extend this
that they might have do you speak French
do you speak whatever languages and so
you might have a whole lot of
classifiers that you would look at each
one of these people who cannot speak
English will be classified as negatives
so there'll be a zero so yeah zero ones
the number of times are actual positive
values are equal to predicted positive
values gives us true positive TP the
number of times our actual negative
values are equal to predictive negative
values gives us true negative TN
the number of times our model wrongly
predicts negative values as positives
gives us a false positive
FP
and you'll see when you're working with
these a lot you know memorizing that
it's false positive you can easily
figure out what that is and pretty soon
you're just looking at the FP or the TP
depending on what you're working on and
the numbers times our model wrongly
predicts positive values as negatives
and gives us a false negative FP
now I'm going to do a quick step out
here
let's say you're working in the medical
and we're talking about cancer
do you really want a bunch of false
negatives you want zero under false
negative
so when we look at this confusion Matrix
if you have five percent false positives
and five percent false negatives it'd be
much better to even have twenty percent
false positives because they go in and
test it in zero false negatives
the same might be true if you're working
on uh say a car driving is this a safe
place for the car to go well you really
don't want any false positives you know
yes this is safe right over the cliff
so again when you're working on the
project or what it is you're working on
this chart suddenly has huge value we
were talking about spam email how many
important emails say from your banking
overdraft charge coming in that you want
to be a a true false negative you don't
want it to go in the spam folder
likewise you want to get as much of the
spam out of there but you don't want to
miss anything really important
confusion Matrix metrics are performance
measures which help us find the accuracy
of our classifier there are four main
metrics accuracy precision recall and F1
score the F1 score is the one I usually
hear the most and accuracy is usually
what you put on your chart when you're
sending in front of the shareholders how
accurate is it people understand
accuracy
F1 score is a little bit more on the
math side and so you got to be a little
careful when you're quoting F1 scores in
the when you're sitting there with all
the shareholders because a lot of them
will just glaze over so confusion Matrix
metrics are performance measures which
help us find the accuracy of our
classifier there are four main metrics
accuracy the accuracy is used to find
the portion of the correctly classified
values it tells us how often our
classifier is right it is the sum of all
True Values divided by the total values
and this makes sense again it's one of
those things
I don't want to fall you know it depends
on what you're looking for are you
looking for uh not to miss any spam
mails are you looking to drive down the
road and not run anybody over
precision
is used to calculate the model's ability
to classify positive values correctly it
answers the question when the model
predicts a positive value how often is
it right it is the true positive divided
by the total number of predicted
positive values again in this one
depends on what project you're working
on whether this is what you're going to
be focusing on
so recall it is used to calculate the
model's ability to predict positive
values how often does the model actually
predict the correct positive values
it is a true positive divided by the
total number of actual positive values
and then your F1 score it is the
harmonic mean of recall and precision it
is useful when you need to take both
precision and recall into account
consider the following two confusion
Matrix derived from two different
classifier to figure out which one
performs better we can find the
confusion Matrix for both of them
and you can see we're back to uh does it
classify whether they can speak English
or are non-speaker they speak some they
don't know the English language and so
we put these two uh confusion matrixes
out here we can go ahead and do the math
behind that we can look up the accuracy
that's a tpn plus TN over the TF plus TN
plus FP plus FN and so we get an
accuracy of 0.8125
and we have a Precision if you do the
Precision which is your TP truth
positive over TP plus FP
we get 0.891
and if we do the recall we'll end up
with the 0.825 that's your TP over TP
plus FN
and then of course your F1 score which
is two times Precision times recall over
Precision plus recall
and we get the 0.857
and if we do that with another model
let's say we had two different models
and we're trying to see which one we
want to use for whatever reason we might
go ahead and compute the same things we
have our accuracy our precision and our
recall and our F1 score
and as we're looking at this we might
look at the accuracy because that's
really what we're interested in is uh
how many people are we able to classify
as being able to speak English I really
don't want to know if I'm you know I I
really don't want to know if they're
non-speakers
um I'd rather Miss 10 people speaking
English instead of 15. and so you can
see from these charts we probably go
with the first model because it does a
better job guessing who speaks English
and has a higher accuracy because in
this case that is what we're looking for
so uh with that we'll go ahead and pull
up a demo so you can see what this looks
like in the python setup in in the
actual coding for this we'll go into
Anaconda Navigator if you're not
familiar with Anaconda it's a really
good tool to use as far as doing display
in demos
and for quick development as a data
scientist I just love the package
now if you're going to do something
heavier lifting there's some limitations
with anaconda and with the setup but in
general you can do just about anything
in here with your python and for this
we'll go with Jupiter notebook Jupiter
lab is the same as Jupiter notebook
you'll see they now have integration
with pi charm if you work in pi charm uh
certainly there's a lot of other
Integrations that Anaconda has and we've
opened up
um I simply learned files I work on and
create a new file called confusion
Matrix demo and the first thing we want
to note is the data we're working with
here I've opened it up in a word pad or
notepad or whatever
uh you can see it's got a row of
headers comma separated and then all the
data going down below
and then I save this in the same file so
I don't have to remember what path I'm
working on uh of course if you have your
data separated and you're working with a
lot of data you probably want to put it
into a different folder or file
depending on what you're doing
and the first thing we want to do is go
ahead and import our tools we're going
to use the pandas that's our data frame
if you haven't had a chance to work with
the data frame please review Panda's
data frame and go into simply learn you
can pull up the pandas data frame
tutorial on there
and then we're going to use uh the side
kit framework which is all denoted as
sklearn and I can just pull this in you
can see here's the scikit dash learn.org
with the stable version that you can
import into your python
and from here we're going to use the
train test split
for splitting our data we're going to do
some pre-processing we're going to do
use the logistic regression model that's
our actual machine learning model we're
using and then with this core this
particular setup is about is we're going
to do the accuracy score the confusion
Matrix and the classifier report
so let me go ahead and run that and
bring all that information in
and just like we open the file we need
to go ahead and load our data in here so
we're going to go ahead and do our
pandas read CSV
and then just because we're in jupyter
Notebook we can just put data to read
the data in here a lot of times we'll
actually let me just do this I prefer to
do the just the head of the date or the
top part
and you can see we have age sex I'm not
sure what CP stands for test BPS
cholesterol so a lot of different
measurements if you were in this domain
you'd want to know what all these
different measurements mean
I don't want to focus on that too much
because when we're talking about data
science a lot of times you have no idea
what the data means if you've ever
looked up the breast cancer measurement
it's just a bunch of measurements and
numbers uh unless you're a doctor you're
gonna have no idea what those
measurements mean
but if it's your specialty in your
domain you better know them so we're
going to go ahead and create Y and it's
going to we're going to set it equal to
the Target so here's our Target value
here
and there it's either one or zero
so we have a classifier if you're
dealing with one zero true false what do
you have you have a classifier
and then our X is going to be uh
everything except for the Target so
we're going to go ahead and drop the
target axis equals one remember that's
columns versus the index for rows X is
equal zero would would give you an error
but you would drop like row two
and then we'll go ahead and just print
that out so you can see what we're
looking at and uh here we have Y data X
data and you can see from the X data we
have the X head and we can go ahead and
just do print
the Y head data
and run that
so this is all loading the data that
we've done so far if there's a confusion
in there go back and rewind the tape and
review it
and then we need to go ahead and split
our data into our X train X test y train
y test and then keep in mind you always
want to split the data before we do the
scalar and the reason is is that you
want the scalar on the training data to
be set on the training data data or fit
to it
but not on the test data think of this
as being out in the field you're not it
could actually alter your results so
it's always important to do make sure
whatever you do to the training data or
whatever fit you're doing is always done
on the training not on the test and then
we want to go ahead and scale the data
now we are working with linear
regression model and I'll mention this
here in a minute when we get to the
actual model
so some sometimes you don't need to
scale when you're working with linear
regression models it's not going to
change your result as much as say a
neural network where it has a huge
impact
uh but we're going to go ahead and take
here's our X train X test y train y test
we create our scalar we go ahead and
scale the scale is going to fit the X
train
and then we're going to go ahead and
take our X train and transform it and
then we also need to take our X test and
transform it based on the scale on here
so that our X is now between that nice
set minus one to one and so this is all
uh our pre data setup
and
hopefully all of that looks fairly
familiar to you if you've done a number
of our other classes and you're up to
the setup on here
and then we want to go ahead and do is
create our model and we're going to use
a logistic regression model
and from the logistic regression model
we're going to go ahead and fit our X
train and Y train and then we'll run our
predicted value on here
and let's just go ahead and run that and
so now we are we actually have like our
X test and our prediction so if you
remember from
our Matrix we're looking for the actual
versus the prediction and how those
compare
and if I take us back up here you're
going to notice that we imported the
accuracy score the confusion Matrix and
the classification report
and there's of course our logistic
regression the model we're using for
this
and I did mention I was going to talk a
little bit about scalar and the
regression model
the scalar on a lot of your regression
models uh your basic Mass standard
regression models and I'd have to look
it up for the logistic regression model
when you're using a standard regression
model you don't need to scale the data
it's already just built in by the way
the model works
in most cases but if you're in a neural
network and you're there's a lot of
other different setups than you really
want to take this and fit that on there
and so we can go in and do the accuracy
and this is if you remember correctly we
were looking at the accuracy
with the English speaking so this is
saying our accuracy as to whether this
person is I believe this is the heart
data set
um
it's going to be accurate about 85
percent of the time as far as whether
it's going to predict the person's going
to have a heart condition
or the one as it comes up with the zero
one on there
which would mean at this point that you
have an 85 percent being correct on
telling someone they're extremely high
risk for a heart attack kind of thing
and so we want to go ahead and create
our confusion Matrix and let me just do
that
of course the software does everything
for us so we'll go ahead and run this
and you can see right here
um here's our 25
uh
prediction uh correct predictions right
here
and if you remember from our slide I'll
just bring this over so it's a nice
visual we have our true positive false
positive
uh so we had 25 which were true that it
said hey this person is going to be high
risk at heart and we had four that were
still high risk that it said were false
so out of these 25 people or out of
these 29 people and that makes sense
because you have 0.85 out of 29 people
it was correct on 25 of them and so uh
here's our accuracy score we were just
looking at that our accuracy is your
true positive and your true negative
over all of them so how true is it and
there's our accuracy coming up here 0.85
and then we have our nice Matrix
generated from that
and you can see right here is a similar
Matrix we had going for that from the
slide and this starts to let's just
start asking questions at this point
um so if you're in a board meeting or
you're working with this you really want
to start looking at this data here and
saying well
is this good enough is uh this number of
people and hopefully you'd have a much
larger data set in my is my confusion
Matrix showing for the true positive and
false positive is that acceptable for
what we're doing uh and of course if
you're going to put together whatever
data you're putting out you might want
to separate the true negative false
positive false negative true positive
and you can simply do that by doing the
confusion Matrix and then of course the
Ravel part lets you set that up so you
can just split that right up into a nice
Tuple and the final thing we want to
show you here in the coding on this part
is the confusion Matrix metrics
and so we can come in here and just use
the Matrix equals classification report
the Y test and the predict
and then we're going to take that
classification report and go ahead and
print that out
and you can see here it does a nice job
uh giving you your accuracy your micro
average your weighted average you have
your Precision your recall your F1 score
and your support all in one window so
you can start looking at this data and
saying oh okay our precision's at 0.83
uh 0.87 for getting a a positive and
0.83 for the negative site for a zero
and we start talking about whether this
is a valid information or not to use and
when we're looking at heart attack
prediction we're only looking at one
aspect what's the chances of this person
having a heart attack or not you might
have something where we went back to the
languages maybe you also want to know
whether they speak English or Hindi or
French and you can see right here that
we can now take our confusion Matrix and
just expand it as big as we need to
depending on how many different
classifiers we're working on if you are
an aspiring machine learning engineer
looking for online training and
certifications from prestigious
universities and in collaboration with
leading experts then such no more simply
learns professional certification
program in Ai and machine learning from
Purdue University in collaboration with
IBM should be a right choice for more
details use the link in the description
box below with that in mind what is a
decision tree let's go through a very
simple example before we dig in deep
decision tree is a tree shape diagram
used to determine a course of action
each branch of the tree represents a
possible decision or currents or
reaction let's start with a simple
question how to identify a random
vegetable from a shopping bag so we have
this group of vegetables in here and we
can start off by asking a simple
question is it red and if it's not then
it's going to be the purple fruit to the
left probably an eggplant if it's true
it's going to be one of the red fruits
is a diameter greater than two if false
is going to be a what looks to be a red
chili and if it's true it's going to be
a bell pepper from the capsicum family
so it's a capsicum
problems that decision tree can solve so
let's look at the two different
categories the decision tree can be used
on it can be used on the classification
the true false yes no and it can be used
on regression where we figure out what
the next value is in a series of numbers
or a group of data in classification the
classification tree will determine a set
of logical if-then conditions to
classify problems for example
discriminating between three types of
flowers based on certain features in
regression a regression tree is used
when the target variable is numerical or
continuous in nature we fit the
regression model to the Target variable
using each of the independent variables
each split is made based on the sum of
squared error
before we dig deeper into the mechanics
of the decision tree let's take a look
at the advantages of using a decision
tree and we'll also take a glimpse at
the disadvantages the first thing you'll
notice is that it's simple to understand
interpret and visualize it really shines
here because you can see exactly what's
going on in a decision tree little
effort is required for data preparation
so you don't have to do special scaling
there's a lot of things you don't have
to worry about when using a decision
tree it can handle both numerical and
categorical data as we discovered
earlier and non-linear parameters don't
affect its performance so even if the
data doesn't fit an easy curved graph
you can still use it to create an
effective decision or prediction
if we're going to look at the advantages
of a decision tree we also need to
understand the disadvantages of a
decision tree the first disadvantage is
overfitting overfitting occurs when the
algorithm captures noise in the data
that means you're solving for one
specific instance instead of a general
solution for all the data High variance
the model can get unstable due to small
variation in data low bias tree a highly
complicated decision tree tends to have
a low bias which makes it difficult for
the model to work with new data
decision tree important terms before we
dive in further we need to look at some
basic terms we need to have some
definitions to go with our decision tree
in the different parts we're going to be
using we'll start with entropy entropy
is a measure of Randomness or
unpredictability in the data set for
example we have a group of animals in
this picture there's four different
kinds of animals and this data set is
considered to have a high entropy you
really can't pick out what kind of
animal it is based on looking at just
the four animals as a big clump of
entities so as we start splitting it
into subgroups we come up with our
second definition which is Information
Gain Information Gain it is a measure of
decrease in entropy after the data set
is split so in this case based on the
color yellow we've split one group of
animals on one side as true and those
who aren't yellow as false as we
continue down the yellow side we split
based on the height true or false equals
10 and on the other side High height is
less than 10 true or false and as you
see as we split it the entropy continues
to be less and less and less and so our
Information Gain is simply the entropy
E1 from the top and how it's changed to
E2 in the bottom and we'll look at the
deeper math although you really don't
need to know a huge amount of math when
you actually do the programming in
Python because it'll do it for you but
we'll look on the actual math of how
they compute entropy finally we went on
the different parts of our tree and they
call the leaf node Leaf node carries a
classification or the decision so it's a
final end at the bottom the decision
node has two or more branches this is
where we're breaking the group up into
different parts and finally you have the
root node the topmost decision node is
known as the root node
how does a decision tree work wonder
what kind of animals I'll get in the
jungle today maybe you're the hunter
with a gun or if you're more into
photography you're a photographer with a
camera so let's look at this group of
animals and let's try to classify
different types of animals based on
their features using a decision tree so
the problem statement is to classify the
different types of animals based on
their features using a decision tree the
data set is looking quite messy and the
entropy is high in this case so let's
look at a training set or a training
data set and we're looking at color
we're looking at height and then we have
our different animals we have our
elephants our giraffes our monkeys and
our tigers and they're of different
colors and shapes let's see what that
looks like and how do we split the data
we have to frame the conditions that
split the data in such a way that the
Information Gain is the highest note
gain is the measure of decrease in
entropy after splitting so the formula
for entropy is the sum that's what this
symbol looks like that looks like kind
of like a the funky e of K where I
equals 1 to k k would represent the
number of animal the different animals
in there where value or P value of I
would be the percentage of that animal
times the log base 2 of the same the
percentage of that animal let's try to
calculate the entropy for the current
data set and take a look at what that
looks like and don't be afraid of the
math you don't really have to memorize
this math and just be aware that it's
there and this is what's going on in the
background and so we have three drafts
two tigers one monkey two elephants a
total of eight animals gather and if we
plug that into the formula we get an
entropy that equals three over eight so
we have three drafts a total of eight
times the log usually they use base two
on the log so log base 2 of 3 over 8
plus in this case let's say it's the
elephants two over eight two elephants
over a total of eight times log base two
two over eight plus one monkey over
total of eight log base two one over
eight and plus two 2 over 8 of the
Tigers log base 2 over 8. and if we plug
that into our computer or calculator I
obviously can't do logs in my head we
get an entropy equal to
0.571 the program will actually
calculate the entropy of the data set
similarly after every split to calculate
the gain now we're not going to go
through each set one at a time to see
what those numbers are we just want you
to be aware that this is a Formula or
the mathematics behind it gain can be
calculated by finding the difference of
the subsequent entropy values after a
split now we will try to choose a
condition that gives us the highest gain
we will do that by splitting the data
using each condition and checking that
the gain we get out of them the
condition that gives us the highest gain
will be used to make the first split can
you guess what that first split will be
just by looking at this image as a human
is probably pretty easy to split it
let's see if you're right if you guessed
the color yellow you're correct let's
say the condition that gives us the
maximum gain is yellow so we will split
the data based on the color yellow if
it's true that group of animals goes to
the left if it's false it goes to the
right the entropy after the splitting
has to decreased considerably however we
still need some splitting at both the
branches to attain an entropy value
equal to zero so we decide to split both
the nodes using height as the condition
since every Branch now contains single
label type we can say that entropy in
this case has reached the least value
and here you see we have the giraffes of
the Tigers the monkey and the elephants
all separate into their own groups this
tree can now predict all the classes of
animals present in the data set with the
hundred percent accuracy that was easy
use case loan repayment prediction let's
get into my favorite part and open up
some Python and see what the programming
code and the scripting looks like in
here we're going to want to do a
prediction and we start with this
individual here who's requesting to find
out how good his customers are going to
be whether they're going to be pay their
loan or not for this bank and from that
we want to generate a problem statement
to predict if a customer will repay loan
amount or not and then we're going to be
using the decision tree algorithm in
Python let's see what that looks like
and let's dive into the code in our
first few steps of implementation we're
going to start by importing the
necessary packages that we need from
Python and we're going to load up our
data and take a look at what the data
looks like so the first thing I need is
I need something to edit my Python and
run it in so let's flip on over and here
I'm using the Anaconda Jupiter notebook
now you can use any python IDE you like
to run it in but I find the Jupiter
notebooks really nice for doing things
on the Fly and let's go ahead and just
paste that code in the beginning and
before we we start let's talk a little
bit about what we're bringing in and
then we're going to do a couple things
in here we have to make a couple changes
as we go through this first part of the
import the first thing we bring in is
numpy as NP that's very standard when
we're dealing with mathematics
especially with a very complicated
machine learning tools you almost always
see the numpy come in for your num your
number it's called number python it has
your mathematics in there in this case
we actually could take it out but
generally you'll need it for most of
your different things you work with and
then we're going to use pandas as PD
that's also a standard the pandas is a
data frame setup and you can liken this
to taking your basic data and storing it
in a way that looks like an Excel
spreadsheet so as we come back to this
when you see NP or PD those are very
standard uses you'll know that that's
the pandas and I'll show you a little
bit more when we explore the data in
just a minute then we're going to need
to split the data so I'm going to bring
in our train test and split and this is
coming from the sklearn package cross
validation and just a minute we're going
to change that and we'll go over that
too and then there's also the SK dot
tree import decision tree classifier
that's the actual tool we're using
remember I told you don't be afraid of
the mathematics it's going to be done
for you well the decision tree
classifier has all that mathematics in
there for you so you don't have to
figure it back out again and then we
have sklearn.metrix for accuracy score
we need to score our our setup that's
the whole reason we're splitting it
between the training and testing data
and finally we still need the sklearn
import tree and that's just the basic
tree function that's needed for the
decision tree classifier and finally
we're going to load our data down here
and I'm going to run this and we're
going to get two things on here one
we're going to get an error and two
we're going to get a warning let's see
what that looks like so the first thing
we had is we have an error why is this
error here well it's looking at this it
says I need to read a file and when this
was written the person who wrote it this
is their path where they stored the file
so let's go ahead and fix that
and I'm going to put in here my file
path I'm just going to call it full file
name and you'll see it's on my C drive
and this is very lengthy setup on here
where I stored the data2.csv file
don't worry too much about the full path
because on your computer it'll be
different the data.2 CSV file was
generated by simply learn
if you want a copy of that you can
comment down below and request it here
in the YouTube
and then if I'm going to give it a name
full file name
I'm going to go ahead and change it here
to full
file name so let's go ahead and run it
now and see what happens
and we get a warning
when you're coding understanding these
different warnings and these different
errors that come up is probably the
hardest lesson to learn
so let's just go ahead and take a look
at this and use this as a opportunity to
understand what's going on here if you
read the warning it says the cross
validation is depreciated so it's a
warning on it's being removed and it's
going to be moved in favor of the model
selection
so if we go up here we have
sklearn.cross validation and if you
research this and go to the sklearn site
you'll find out that you can actually
just swap it right in there with model
selection
and so when I come in here and I run it
again
that removes a warning what they've done
is they've had two different developers
develop it in two different branches
and then they decided to keep one of
those and eventually get rid of the
other one that's all that is and very
easy and quick to fix
before we go any further I went ahead
and opened up the data from this file
remember the the data file we just
loaded on here the data underscore2.csv
let's talk a little bit more about that
and see what that looks like both as a
text file because it's a comma separated
variable file and in a spreadsheet this
is what it looks like as a basic text
file you can see at the top they've
created a header and it's got one two
three four five columns and each column
has data in it and let me flip this over
because we're also going to look at this
in an actual spreadsheet so you can see
what that looks like and here I've
opened it up in the open Office calc
which is pretty much the same as Excel
and zoomed in and you can see we've got
our columns and our rows of data a
little easier to read in here we have a
result yes yes no we have initial
payment last payment credit score house
number if we scroll way down
we'll see that this occupies a thousand
and one lines of code or lines of data
with the first one being a column and
then 1000 lines of data
now as a programmer
if you're looking at a small amount of
data I usually start by pulling it up in
different sources I can see what I'm
working with
but in larger data you won't have that
option it'll just be too too large so
you need to either bring in a small
amount that you can look at it like
we're doing right now or we can start
looking at it through the python code so
let's go ahead and move on and take the
next couple steps to explore the data
using python let's go ahead and see what
it looks like in Python to print the
length and the shape of the data so
let's start by printing the length of
the database we can use a simple Lin
function from python
and when I run this you'll see that it's
a thousand long and that's what we
expected there's a thousand lines of
data in there if you subtract the column
head this is one of the nice things when
we did the balance data from the panda
read CSV you'll see that the header is
row zero so it automatically removes a
row
and then shows the data separate it does
a good job sorting that data out for us
and then we can use a different function
and let's take a look at that and again
we're going to utilize the tools in
panda
and since the balance underscore data
was loaded as a panda data frame
we can do a shape on it and let's go
ahead and run the shape and see what
that looks like
what's nice about this shape is not only
does it give me the length of the data
we have a thousand lines it also tells
me there's five columns so we were
looking at the data we had five columns
of data and then let's take one more
step to explore the data using Python
and now that we've taken a look at the
length and the shape let's go ahead and
use the pandas module for head another
beautiful thing in the data set that we
can utilize so let's put that on our
sheet here and we have print data set
and balance data.head and this is a hand
as print statement of its own so it has
its own print feature in there and then
we went ahead and gave a label for our
print job here of data set just a simple
print statement
and when we run that
and let's just take a closer look at
that let me zoom in here
there we go
pandas does such a wonderful job of
making this a very clean
readable data set so you can look at the
data you can look at the column headers
you can have it when you put it as the
head it prints the first five lines of
the data
and we always start with zero so we have
five lines we have zero one two three
four instead of one two three four five
that's a standard scripting and
programming set as you want to start
with the zero position and that is what
the data head does it pulls the first
five rows of data puts in a nice format
that you can look at and view very
powerful tool to view the data so
instead of having to flip and open up an
Excel spreadsheet or open Office Cal or
trying to look at a word doc where it's
all scrunched together and hard to read
you can now get a nice open view of what
you're working with we're working with a
shape of a thousand long five wide so we
have five columns and we do the full
data head you can actually see what this
data looks like the initial payment last
payment credit scores house number so
let's take this now that we've explored
the data and let's start digging into
the decision tree so in our next step
we're going to train and build our data
tree and to do that we need to First
separate the data out we're going to
separate into two groups so that we have
something to actually train the data
with and then we have some data on the
site to test it to see how good our
model is remember with any of the
machine learning you always want to have
some kind of test set to weigh it
against so you know how good your model
is when you distribute it let's go ahead
and break this code down and look at it
in pieces
so first we have our X and Y
where did X and Y come from well X is
going to be our data
and Y is going to be the answer or the
target you can look at it source and
Target
in this case we're using X and Y to
denote the data in and the data that
we're actually trying to guess what the
answer is going to be and so to separate
it we can simply put in x equals the
balance of the data.values the first
brackets
means that we're going to select all the
lines in the database so it's all the
data and the second one says we're only
going to look at columns one through
five remember always start with zero
zero is a yes or no and that's whether
the loan went default or not so we want
to start with one if we go back up here
that's the initial payment and it goes
all the way through the house number
well if we want to look at one through
five we can do the same thing for Y
which is the answers and we're going to
set that just equal to the zero row so
it's just the zero row and then it's all
rows going in there so now we've divided
this into two different data sets
one of them with the
data going in and one with the answers
next we need to split the data
and here you'll see that we have it
split into four different parts
the first one is your X training your X
test your y train your y test
simply put we have X going in where
we're going to train it and we have to
know the answer to train it with
and then we have X test where we're
going to test that data and we have to
know in the end what the Y was supposed
to be
and that's where this train test split
comes in that we loaded earlier in the
modules this does it all for us and you
can see they set the test size equal to
0.3 so that's roughly 30 percent will be
used in the test and then we use a
random state so it's completely random
which rows it takes out of there and
then finally we get to actually build
our decision tree and they've called it
here clf underscore entropy that's the
actual decision tree or decision tree
classifier and in here they've added a
couple variables which we'll explore in
just a minute and then finally we need
to fit the data to that so we take our
clf entropy that we created and we fit
the X train and since we know the
answers for X trade or the Y train we go
ahead and put those in and let's go
ahead and run this and what most of
these sklearn modules do is when you set
up the variable in this case when we set
the clf entropical decision tree
classifier it automatically prints out
what's in that decision tree there's a
lot of variables you can play Within
here and it's quite beyond the scope of
this tutorial able to go through all of
these and how they work but we're
working on entropy that's one of the
options we've added that it's completely
a random state of 100 so 100 percent and
we have a max depth of three now the max
depth if you remember above when we were
doing the different graphs of animals
means it's only going to go down three
layers before it stops and then we have
minimal samples of leaves as five so
it's going to have at least five leaves
at the end so I'll have at least three
splits I'll have no more than three
layers and at least five end leaves with
the final result at the bottom now that
we've created our decision tree
classifier not only created it but
trained it let's go ahead and apply it
and see what that looks like so let's go
ahead and make a prediction and see what
that looks like we're going to paste our
predict code in here
and before we run it let's just take a
quick look at what it's doing here we
have a variable y predict that we're
going to do
and we're going to use our variable clf
entropy that we created
and then you'll see dot predict and it's
very common in the SK learn modules that
they're different tools have the predict
when you're actually running a
prediction
in this case we're going to put our X
test data in here
now if you delivered this for use an
actual commercial use and distributed it
this would be the new loans you're
putting in here to guess
whether the person is going to be pay
them back or not in this case so we need
to test out the data and just see how
good our sample is how good of our tree
does at predicting the loan payments and
finally since Anaconda Jupiter notebook
is works as a command line for python we
can simply put the why predict en to
print it I could just as easily have put
the print
and put brackets around y predict en to
print it out and we'll go ahead and do
that it doesn't matter which way you do
it
and you'll see right here that it runs a
prediction this is roughly 300 in here
remember it's 30 percent of a thousand
so you should have about 300 answers in
here
and this tells you which each one of
those lines of our test went in there
and this is what our why predict came
out
so let's move on to the next step we're
going to take this data and try to
figure out just how good a model we have
so here we go since sklearn does all the
heavy lifting for you and all the math
we have a simple line of code to let us
know what the accuracy is and let's go
ahead and go through that and see what
that means and what that looks like
let's go ahead and paste this in and let
me zoom in a little bit
there we go
so you have a nice full picture
and we'll see here we're just going to
do a print accuracy is
and then we do the accuracy score
and this was something we imported
earlier if you remember at the very
beginning let me just scroll up there
real quick so you can see where that's
coming from
that's coming from here down here from
sklearn.metrix import accuracy score
and you could probably run a script make
your own script to do this very easily
how accurate is it how many out of 300
do we get right and so we put in our y
test that's the one we ran the predict
on and then we put in our y predict en
that's the answers we got and we're just
going to multiply that by a hundred
because this is just going to give us an
answer as a decimal and we want to see
it as a percentage and let's run that
and see what it looks like
and if you see here we got an accuracy
of 93.6667
so when we look at the number of loans
and we look at how good our model fit we
can tell people it has about a 93.6
fitting to it so just a quick recap on
that we now have accuracy set up on here
and so we have created a model that uses
a decision tree algorithm to predict
whether a customer will repay the loan
or not the accuracy of the model is
about 94.6 percent the bank can now use
this model to decide whether it should
approve the loan request from a
particular customer or not and so this
information is really powerful we may
not be able to as individuals understand
all these numbers because they have
thousands of numbers that come in but
you can see that this is a smart
decision for the bank to use a tool like
this to help them to predict how good
their profit is going to be off of the
loan balances and how many are going to
default or not if you are an aspiring
machine learning engineer looking for
online training and certifications from
prestigious universities and in
collaboration with leading experts then
search no more simply lens professional
certification program in Ai and machine
learning from Purdue University in
collaboration with IBM should be a right
choice for more details use the link in
the description box below with that in
mind let us dig deep into the theory of
exactly how it works and let's look at
what is random forests random forests or
random decision Forest is a method that
operates by constructing multiple
decision trees the decision of the
majority of the trees is chosen by the
random Forest as the final decision and
let's uh we have some nice Graphics here
we have a decision tree and they
actually use a real tree to denote the
decision tree which I love and given a
random some kind of picture of a fruit
this decision tree decides that the
output is it's an apple and we have a
decision tree two where we have that
picture of the fruit goes in and this
one decides that it's a limit and the
decision three tree gets another image
and it decides it's an apple and then
this all goes together and what they
call the random forest and this random
Forest then looks at it and says okay I
got two votes for apple one vote for
lemon the majority is Apples so the
final decision is apples to understand
how the random Forest works we first
need to dig a little deeper and take a
look at the random forest and the actual
decision tree and how it builds that
decision tree and looking closer at how
the individual decision trees work we'll
go ahead and continue to use the fruit
example since we're talking about trees
and forests a decision tree is a tree
shaped diagram to use to determine a
course of action each branch of the tree
represents a possible decision
occurrence or reaction so in here we
have a bowl of fruit and if you look at
that it looks like they switch from
lemons to oranges we have oranges
cherries and apples and the first
decision of the decision tree might be
is a diameter greater than or equal to
three and if it says false it knows that
they're cherries because everything else
is bigger than that so all the cherries
fall into that decision so we have all
that data we're training we can look at
that we know that that's what's going to
come up
is the color orange well goes hmm orange
or red well if it's true then it comes
out as the orange and if it's false that
leaves apples
so in this example it sorts out the
fruit in the bowl or the images of the
fruit a decision tree these are very
important terms to know because these
are very Central to understanding the
decision tree when working with them the
first is entropy everything on the
decision tree and how it makes this
decision is based on entropy entropy is
a measure of Randomness or
unpredictability in the data set then
they also have Information Gain
the leaf node the decision node and the
root node we'll cover these other four
terms as we go down the tree but let's
start with entropy so starting with
entropy we have here a high amount of
Randomness what that means is that
whatever's coming out of this decision
if it was going to guess based on this
data it wouldn't be able to tell you
whether it's a lemon or an apple it
would just say it's a fruit
uh so the first thing we want to do is
we want to split this apart and we take
the initial data set we're going to
create a data set 1 and a data set two
we just split it in two and if you look
at these new data sets after splitting
them the entropy of each of those sets
is much less so for the first one
whatever comes in there it's going to
sort that data and it's going to say
okay if this data goes this direction
it's probably an apple and if it goes
into the other direction it's probably a
lemon so that brings us up to
Information Gain it is a measure of
decrease in the entropy after the data
set is split what that means in here is
that we've gone from one set which has a
very high entropy to two lower sets of
entropy and we've added in the values of
E1 for the first one and E2 for the
second two which are much lower and so
that information gain is increased
greatly in this example and so you can
find that the information grain simply
equals decision E1 minus E2 and as we're
going down our list of definitions we'll
look at the leaf node and the leaf node
carries the classification or the
decision
so we look down here to the leaf node we
finally get to our set one or our set
two when it comes down there and it says
okay this object's gone into set one if
it's gone into set one it's going to be
split by some means and we'll either end
up with apples on the leaf node or a
lemon on the leaf node and on the right
it'll either be an apple or lemons those
Leaf nodes are those final decisions or
classifications that's the definition of
leaf node in here if we're going to have
a final Leaf where we make the decision
we should have a name for the nodes
above it and they call those decision
nodes a decision node decision node has
two or more branches and you can see
here where we have the five apples and
one lemon and in the other case the five
lemons and one apple they have to make a
choice of which tree It Goes Down based
on some kind of measurement or
information given to the tree and that
brings us to our last definition the
root node the top most decision node is
known as the root node and this is where
you have all of your data and you have
your first decision it has to make or
the first split in information
so far we've looked at a very general
image with the fruit being split let's
look and see exactly what that means to
split the data and how do we make those
decisions on there let's go in there and
find out how does a decision tree work
so let's try to understand this and
let's use a simple example and we'll
stay with the fruit we have a bowl of
fruit and so let's create a problem
statement and the problem is we want to
classify the different types of fruits
in the bowl based on different features
the data set in the bowl is looking
quite messy and the entropy is high in
this case so if this ball was our
decision maker it wouldn't know what
choice to make it has so many choices
which one do you pick Apple grapes or
lemons and so we look in here we're
going to start with a training set
so this is our data that we're training
our data with and we have a number of
options here we have the color and under
the color we have red yellow purple we
have a diameter three three one three
three one and we have a label Apple
lemon Grapes apple lemon grapes and how
do we split the data we have to frame
the conditions to split the data in such
a way that the Information Gain is the
highest it's very key to note that we're
looking for the best gain we don't want
to just start sorting out the smallest
piece in there we want to split it the
biggest way we can and so we measure
this decrease in entropy that's what
they call it entropy there's our entropy
after splitting and now we'll try to
choose a condition that gives us the
highest gain we will do that by
splitting the data using each condition
and checking the gain that we get out of
them the conditions that give us the
highest gain will be used to make the
first split so let's take a look at
these different conditions we have color
we have diameter and if we look
underneath that we have a couple
different values we have diameter equals
three color equals yellow red diameter
equals one and when we look at that
you'll see over here we have one two
three four threes that's a pretty hearty
selection so let's say the condition
gives us a maximum gain of three so we
have the most pieces fall into that
range so our first split from our
decision node is we split the data based
on the diameter is it greater than or
equal to three if it's not that's false
it goes into the great bolt and if it's
true it goes into a bowl fold of lemon
and apples the entropy after splitting
has decreased considerably so now we can
make two decisions if you look at
they're very much less chaos going on
there this node has already attained an
entropy value of zero as you can see
there's only one kind of label left for
this Branch so no further splitting is
required for this node however this node
on the right is still requires a split
to decrease the entropy further so we
split the right node further are based
on color if you look at this if I split
it on color that pretty much cuts it
right down the middle it's the only
thing we have left in our choices of
color and diameter too and if the color
is yellow it's going to go to the rifle
and if it's false it's going to go to
the left Bowl so the entropy in this
case is now zero so now we have three
moles with zero entropy there's only one
type of data in each one of those bowls
so we can predict a lemon with a hundred
percent accuracy and we can predict the
Apple also with 100 accuracy along with
our grapes up there so we've looked at
kind of a basic tree in our forest but
what we really want to know is how does
a random Forest work as a whole so to
begin our random Forest classifier let's
say we already have built three trees
and we're going to start with the first
tree that looks like this just like we
did in the example this tree looks at
the diameter if it's greater than or
equal to three it's true otherwise it's
false so one side goes to the smaller
diameter one side goes to larger
diameter and if the color is orange it's
going to go to the right true we're
using oranges now instead of limits and
if it's red it's going to go to the left
false we build a second tree very
similar but split differently instead of
the first one being split by a diameter
this one when they created it if you
look at that first Bowl it has a lot of
red objects so it says is the color red
because that's going to bring our
entropy down the fastest and so of
course if it's true it goes to the left
if it's false it goes to the right and
then it looks at the shape false or true
and so on and so on and tree three is
the diameter equal to one and it came up
with this because there's a lot of
cherries in this bowl so that would be
the biggest split on there is is the
diameter equal to one that's going to
drop the entropy the quickest and as you
can see it splits it into true if it
goes false and they've added another
category does it grow in the summer and
if it's false it goes off to the left if
it's true it goes off to the right let's
go ahead and bring these three trees so
you can see them all in one image so
this would be three completely different
trees categorizing a fruit and let's
take a fruit now let's try this and this
fruit if you look at it we've blackened
it out you can't see the color on it so
it's missing data remember one of the
things we talked about earlier is that a
random Forest works really good if
you're missing data if you're missing
pieces so this fruit has an image but
maybe as a person had a black and white
camera when they took the picture and
we're going to take a look at this and
it's going to have they put the color in
there so ignore the color down there but
the diameter equals three we find out it
grows in the summer equals yes and the
shape is a circle and if you go to the
right you can look at what one of the
decision trees did this is the third one
is the diameter greater than equal to
three is a color orange well it doesn't
really know on this one but if you look
at the value and say true and go to the
right tree two classifies it as cherries
is a color equal red is is a shape a
circle true it is a circle so this would
look at it and say oh that's a cherry
and then we go to the other classifier
and it says is the diameter equal one
well that's false does it grow in the
summer true so it goes down and looks at
as oranges so how does this random
Forest work the first one says it's an
orange the second one said it was a
cherry and the third one says it's an
orange
and you can guess that if you have two
oranges and one says it's a cherry when
you add that all together the majority
of the vote says orange so the answer is
it's classified as an orange even though
we didn't know the color and we're
missing data on it I don't know about
you but I'm getting tired of fruit so
let's switch and I did promise you we'd
start looking at a case example and get
into some python coding today we're
going to use the case the iris flower
analysis
oh this is the exciting part as we roll
up our sleeves and actually look at some
python coating before we start the
python coding we need to go ahead and
create a problem statement wonder what
species of Iris do these flowers belong
to let's try to predict the species of
the flowers using machine learning in
Python let's see how it can be done so
here we begin to go ahead and Implement
our python code and you'll find that the
first half of our implementation is all
about organizing and exploring the data
coming in let's go ahead and take this
first step which is loading the
different modules into Python and let's
go ahead and put that in our favorite
editor whatever your favorite editor is
in this case I'm going to be using the
Anaconda Jupiter notebook which is one
of my favorites certainly there's
notepad plus plus and eclipse and dozens
of others or just even using the python
terminal window any of those will work
just fine to go ahead and explore this
python coding so here we go let's go
ahead and flip over to our Jupiter note
book and I've already opened up a new
page for Python 3 code and I'm just
going to paste this right in there and
let's take a look and see what we're
bringing into our python the first thing
we're going to do is from the
sklearn.datasets import load Iris now
this isn't the actual data this is just
the module that allows us to bring in
the data the load Iris and the iris is
so popular it's been around since 1936
when Ronald Fisher published a paper on
it and they're measuring the different
parts of the flower and based on those
measurements predicting what kind of
flower it is and then if we're going to
do a random Forest classifier we need to
go ahead and import our random forest
classifier from the sklearn module so
sklearn dot Ensemble import random force
classifier and then we want to bring in
two more modules and these are probably
the most commonly used modules in Python
and data science with any of the other
modules that we bring in and one is
going to be pandas we're going to import
pandas as PD p D is a common term used
for pandas and pandas is basically
creates a data format for us where when
you create a pandas data frame it looks
like an Excel spreadsheet and you'll see
that in a minute when we start digging
deeper into the code panda is just
wonderful because it plays nice with all
the other modules in there and then we
have numpy which is our numbers Python
and the numbers python allows us to do
different mathematical sets on here
we'll see right off the bat we're going
to take our NP and we're going to go
ahead and Seed the randomness with it
with zero so
np.random.seed is seating that as zero
this code doesn't actually show anything
we're going to go ahead and run it
because I need to make sure I have all
those loaded and then let's take a look
at the next module on here the next six
slides including this one are all about
exploring the data remember I told you
half of this is about looking at the
data and getting it all set so let's go
ahead and take this code right here the
script and let's get that over into our
Jupiter notebook and here we go we've
gone ahead and run the Imports and I'm
going to paste the code down here
and let's take a look and see what's
going on the first thing we're doing is
we're actually loading the iris data and
if you remember up here we loaded the
module that tells it how to get the IRS
data now we're actually assigning that
data to the variable Iris and then we're
going to go ahead and use the DF to
Define data frame
and that's going to equal PD and if you
remember that's pandas as PD so that's
our pandas
and Panda data frame and then we're
looking at Iris data and columns equals
Irish feature names
and we're going to do the DF head and
let's run this so you can understand
what's going on here
the first thing you want to notice is
that our DF has created what looks like
an Excel spreadsheet and in this Excel
spreadsheet we have set the columns so
up on the top you can see the four
different columns and then we have the
data iris.data down below it's a little
confusing without knowing where this
data is coming from so let's look at the
bigger picture and I'm going to go print
I'm just going to change this for a
moment and we're going to print olivirus
and see what that looks like
so when I print all a virus I get this
long list of information and you can
scroll through here and see all the
different titles on there
what's important to notice is that first
off there's a brackets at the beginning
so this is a python dictionary
and in a python dictionary you'll have a
key or a label and this label pulls up
whatever information comes after it so
feature names which we actually used
over here under columns is equal to an
array of simple length simple width
petal length petal width these are the
different names they have for the four
different columns and if you scroll down
far enough you'll also see data down
here oh goodness it came up right
towards the top and data is equal to the
different data we're looking at
now there's a lot of other things in
here like Target we're going to be
pulling that up in a minute and there's
also the names the target names which is
further down and we'll show you that
also in a minute let's go ahead and set
that back
to the Head
and this is one of the neat features of
pandas and Panda data frames
is when you do df.head or the panda
dataframe dot head it will print the
first five lines of the data set in
there along with the headers if you have
them in this case we have the column
header set to Iris features and in here
you'll see that we have 0 1 2 3 4 in
Python most arrays always start at zero
so when you look at the first five it's
going to be zero one two three four not
one two three four five so now we've got
our IRS data imported into a data frame
let's take a look at the next piece of
code in here and so in this section here
of the code we're going to take a look
at the Target and let's go ahead and get
this into our notebook this piece of
code so we can discuss it a little bit
more in detail so here we are in our
jupyter notebook I'm going to put the
code in here and before I run it I want
to look at a couple things going on so
we have a DF species and this is
interesting because right here you'll
see where I have DF species in Brackets
which is the key code for creating
another column and here we have
iris.target now these are both in the
pandas setup on here so in pandas we can
do either one I could have just as
easily done Iris and then in Brackets
Target depending on what I'm working on
both are acceptable let's go ahead and
run this code and see how this changes
and what we've done is we've added the
target from the iris data set as another
column on the end
now what species is this is what we're
trying to predict so we have our data
which tells us the answer for all these
different pieces and then we've added a
column with the answer that way when we
do our final setup we'll have the
ability to program our our neural
network to look for these this different
data and know what a Sentosa is or a
Vera color which we'll see in just a
minute or virginica those are the three
that are in there and now we're going to
add one more column I know we're
organizing all this data over and over
again it's kind of fun there's a lot of
ways to organize it what's nice about
putting everything onto one data frame
is I can then do a printout and it shows
me exactly what I'm looking at and I'll
show you where you where that's
different where you can alter that and
do it slightly differently but let's go
ahead and put this into our script up to
that now and here we go we're going to
put that down here
and we're going to run that
and let's talk a little bit about what
we're doing now we're exploring data and
one of the challenges is knowing how
good your model is did your model work
and to do this we need to split the data
and we split it into two different parts
they usually call it the training and
the testing and so in here we're going
to go ahead and put that in our database
so you can see it clearly and we've set
it DF remember you can put brackets this
is creating another column is train so
we're going to use part of it for
training and this equals NP remember
that stands for numpy DOT random.uniform
so we're generating a random number
between 0 and 1 and we're going to do it
for each of the rows that's where the
length DF comes from so each row gets a
generated number and if it's less than
0.75 it's true and if it's greater than
0.75 it's false this means we're going
to take 75 percent of the data roughly
because there's a Randomness involved
and we're going to use that to train it
and then the other 25 percent we're
going to hold off to the side and use
that to test it later on on so let's
flip back on over and see what the next
step is so now that we've labeled our
database for which is training and which
is testing let's go ahead and sort that
into two different variables train and
test and let's take this code and let's
bring it into our project and here we go
let's paste it on down here and before I
run this let's just take a quick look at
what's going on here is we have up above
we created remember there's our def dot
head which prints the first five rows
and we've added a column is train at the
end and so we're going to take that
we're going to create two variables
we're going to create two new data
frames one's called train one's called
test 75 in train 25 in test
and then to sort that out
we're going to do that by doing DF our
main original data frame with the iris
data in it and if DF is trained equals
true
that's going to go in the train and if
DF is train equals false it goes in the
test and so when I run this
we're going to print out the number in
each one let's see what that looks like
and you'll see that it puts 118 in the
training module and it puts 32 in the
testing module which lets us know that
there was 150 lines of data in here so
if you went and looked at the original
data you could see that there's 150
lines and that's roughly 75 percent in
one and 25 percent for us to test our
model on afterward so let's jump back to
our code and see where this goes in the
next two steps
we want to do one more thing with our
data and let's make it readable to
humans I don't know about you but I hate
looking at zeros and ones so let's start
with the features and let's go ahead and
take those and make those readable to
humans and let's put that in our code
let's see here we go paste it in and
you'll see here we've done a couple very
basic things we know that the columns in
our data frame again this is a panda
thing the DF columns
and we know the first four of them 0 1 2
3 that'd be the first four are going to
be the features or the titles of those
columns and so when I run this
you'll see down here that it creates an
index sepa length sepa width petal
length and petal width and this should
be familiar because if you look up here
here's our column titles going across
and here's the first four
one thing I want you to notice here is
that when you're in a command line
whether it's Jupiter notebook or you're
running command line in the terminal
window if you just put the name of it
it'll print it out this is the same as
doing print
features
and the shorthand is you just put
features in here if you're actually
writing a code
and saving the script and running it by
remote you really need to put the print
in there but for this when I run it
you'll see it gives me the same thing
but for this we want to go ahead and
we'll just leave it as features because
it doesn't really matter and this is one
of the fun thing about jupyter notebooks
is I'm just building the code as we go
and then we need to go ahead and create
the labels for the other part so let's
take a look and see what that for our
final step in prepping our data before
we actually start running the training
and the testing is we're going to go
ahead and convert the species on here
into something the computer understands
so let's put this code into our script
and see where that takes us
all right here we go we've set y equal
to PD dot factorize train species of
zero so let's break this down just a
little bit we have our pandas right here
PD factorize what is factorize doing I'm
going to come back to that in just a
second let's look at what train species
is and why we're looking at the group 0
on there
and let's go up here and here is our
species
remember this and we created this whole
column here for species
and then it has setosis cytosis cytosis
cytosa and if you scroll down enough
you'd also see virginica and Vera color
we need to convert that into something
the computer understands zeros and ones
so the trained species of zero because
this is in the format of a of an array
of arrays so you have to have the zero
on the end and then species is just that
column factorize goes in there and looks
at the fact that there's only three of
them so when I run this you'll see that
y generates an array that's equal to in
this case it's the training set and it's
zeros ones and twos representing the
three different kinds of flowers we have
so now we have something the computer
understands and we have a nice table
that we can read and understand and now
finally we get to actually start doing
the predicting so here we go we have two
lines of code oh my goodness that was a
lot of work to get to two lines of code
but there is a lot in these two lines of
code so let's take a look and see what's
going on here and put this into our full
script that we're running and let's
paste this in here and let's take a look
and see what this is we have we're
creating a variable clf and we're going
to set this equal to the random forest
classifier and we're passing two
variables in here and there's a lot of
variables you can play with as far as
these two are concerned they're very
standard in jobs all that does is to
prioritize it not something to really
worry about usually when you're doing
this on your own computer you do in jobs
equals two if you're working in a larger
or big data and you need to prioritize
it differently this is what that number
does is it changes your priorities and
how it's going to across the system and
things like that and then the random
state is just how it starts zero is fine
for here
but let's go ahead and run this
we also have clf.fit train features
comma Y and before we run it let's talk
about this a little bit more clf dot fit
so we're fitting we're training it we
are actually creating our random Forest
classifier right here this is a code
that does everything and we're going to
take our training set remember we kept
our test off to the side and we're going
to take our training set with the
features and then we're going to go
ahead and put that in and here's our
Target the Y so the Y is 0 1 and 2 that
we just created and the features is the
actual data going in that we put into
the training set let's go ahead and run
that
and this is kind of an interesting thing
because it printed out the random Force
classifier
and everything around it
and so when you're running this in your
terminal window or in a script like this
this automatically treats this like just
like when we were up here and I typed in
y and it printed out y instead of print
y
this does the same thing it treats this
as a variable and prints it out but if
you're actually running your code that
wouldn't be the case and what is printed
out is it shows us all the different
variables we can change and if we go
down here you can actually see in jobs
equals two you can see the random State
equals zero those are the two that we
sent in there you would really have to
dig deep to find out all these the
different meanings of all these
different settings on here some of them
are self-explanatory if you kind of
think about it a little bit like Max
features is auto so all the features
that we're putting in there is just
going to automatically take all four of
them whatever we send it it'll take some
of them might have so many features
because you're processing words there
might be like 1.4 million features in
there because you're doing legal
documents and that's how many different
words are in there at that point you
probably want to limit the maximum
features that you're going to process in
leaf nodes that's the end notes remember
we had the fruit and we're talking about
the leaf nodes like I said there's a lot
in this we're looking at a lot of stuff
here so you might have in this case
there's probably only think three leaf
nodes maybe four you might have
thousands of leaf nodes at which point
you do need to put a cap on that and say
okay you can only go so far and then
we're going to use all of our resources
on processing this and that really is
what most of these are about is limiting
the process and making sure we don't
overwhelm a system and there's some
other settings in here again we're not
going to go over all of them warm start
equals false alarm start is if you're
programming it one piece at a time
externally since we're not we're not
going to have like we're not going to
continually to train this particular
Learning Tree and again like I said
there's a lot of things in here that
you'll want to look up more detail from
the SK learn and if you're digging in
deep and running a major project on here
for today though all we need to do is
fit or train our features and our Target
why so now we have our training model
what's next if we're going to create a
model
we now need to test it remember we set
aside the test feature test group 25 of
the data so let's go ahead and take this
code and let's put it into our script
and see what that looks like okay here
we go
and we're going to run this
and it's going to come out with a bunch
of zeros ones and twos which represents
the three type of flowers the setosa the
virginica and the Versa color and what
we're putting into our predict is the
test features and I always kind of like
to know what it is I am looking at so
real quick we're going to do test
features and remember features is an
array
of simple length simple width pedal
length pedal width so when we put it in
this way it actually loads all these
different columns that we loaded into
features so if we did just features let
me just do features in here seeing so
what features looks like this is just
playing with the with pandas data frames
you'll see that it's an index so when
you put an index in like this
into test features into test it then
takes those columns and creates a panda
data frames from those columns and in
this case
we're going to go ahead and put those
into our predict
so we're going to put each one of these
lines of data
the 5.0 3.4 1.5 0.2 and we're going to
put those in and we're going to predict
what our new Forest classifier is going
to come up with and this is what it
predicts it predicts uh zero zero zero
one two one one two two two and and
again this is the flower type sotosa
virginica and Versa color so now that
we've taken our test features let's
explore that let's see exactly what that
data means to us so the first thing we
can do with our predicts is we can
actually generate a different prediction
model when I say different we're going
to view it differently it's not that the
data itself is different so let's take
this next piece of code and put it into
our script
so we're pasting it in here and you'll
see that we're doing uh predict and
we've added underscore proba for
probability so there's our clf DOT
predict probability so we're running it
just like we ran it up here but this
time with this we're going to get a
slightly different result and we're only
going to look at the first 10.
so you'll see down here instead of
looking at all of them which was what 27
you'll see right down here that this
generates a much larger field on the
probability and let's take a look and
see what that looks like and what that
means
so when we do the predict underscore
praba for probability it generates three
numbers so we had three leaf nodes at
the end and if you remember from all the
theory we did this is the predictors the
first one is predicting a one for setosa
it predicts a zero for virginica and it
predicts a zero for Versa color and so
on and so on and so on and let's uh you
know what I'm going to change this just
a little bit let's look at 10
to 20 just because we can
and we start to get a little different
of data and you'll see right down here
it gets to this one this line right here
and this line has 0 0.5 0.5 and so if
we're going to vote and we have two
equal votes it's going to go with the
first one so it says uh satosha gets
zero votes virginica gets 0.5 votes
Versa color gets 0.5 votes but let's
just go with the virginica since these
two are equal and so on and so on down
the list you can see how they vary on
here so now we've looked at both how to
do a basic predict of the features and
we've looked at the predict probability
let's see what's next on here so now we
want to go ahead and start mapping names
for the plants we want to attach names
so that it makes a little more sense for
us and this we're going to do in these
next two steps we're going to start by
setting up our predictions and mapping
them to the name so let's see what that
looks like
and let's go ahead and paste that code
in here and run it and this goes along
with the next piece of code so we'll
skip through this quickly and then come
back to it a little bit so here's Iris
dot Target names
and uh if you remember correctly this
was the the names that we've been
talking about this whole time the setosa
virginica versus color and then we're
going to go ahead and do the prediction
again we've run we could have just hit a
variable equal to this instead of
re-running it each time but we're going
ahead and run it again clf dot predict
test features remember that Returns the
zeros the ones in the twos and then
we're going to set that equal to
predictions so this time we're actually
putting it in a variable and when I run
this
it distributes it it comes out as an
array and the array is setosis cytosis
cytosa we're only looking at the first
five we could actually do let's do the
first 25 just so we can see a little bit
more on there and you'll see that it
starts mapping it to all the different
flower types the Versa color and the
virginica in there and let's see how
this goes with the next one so let's
take a look at the top part of our
species in here and we'll take this code
and put it in our script
and let's put that down here and paste
it there we go and we'll go ahead and
run it and let's talk about both these
sections of code here
and how they go together the first one
is our predictions and I went ahead and
did predictions through 25 let's just do
five
and so we have cytosis cytosis cytosis
cytosis that's what we're predicting
from our test model
and then we come down here we look at
test species I remember I could have
just done
test.species.head and you'll see it says
cytosis cytosis cytosa and they match so
the first one is what our forest is
doing
and the second one is what the actual
data is now is we need to combine these
so that we can understand what that
means we need to know how good our
forest is how good it is at predicting
the features so that's where we come up
to the next step which is lots of fun
we're going to use a single line of code
to combine our predictions and our
actuals so we have a nice chart to look
at and let's go ahead and put that in
our script in our jupyter notebook here
let's see let's go ahead and paste that
in and then I'm gonna because I'm on the
jupyter notebook I can do a control
minus you can see the whole line there
there we go resize it and let's take a
look and see what's going on here we're
going to create in pandas remember PD
stands for pandas and we're doing a
cross tab this function takes two sets
of data and creates a chart out of them
so when I run it you'll get a nice chart
down here and we have the predicted
species
so across the top you'll see the Sentosa
versus color virginica and the actual
species cystosa versicolor virginica and
so the way to read this chart and let's
go ahead and take a look on how to read
this chart here when you read this chart
you have setosa where they meet you have
versicolor where they meet and you have
virginica where they meet and they're
meeting where the actual and the
predicted agree so this is the number of
accurate predictions so in this case it
equals 30. if you had 13 plus 5 plus 12
you get 30. and then we notice here
where it says virginica but it was
supposed to be versacolor this is
inaccurate so now we have two two
inaccurate predictions and 30 accurate
predictions so we'll say that the model
accuracy is 93 that's just 30 divided by
32 and if we multiply by a hundred we
can say that it is 93 accurate so we
have a 93 accuracy with our model I did
want to add one more quick thing in here
on our scripting before we wrap it up so
let's flip back on over to my script in
here we're going to take this line of
code from up above I don't know if you
remember it but predicts equals the iris
dot Target underscore names so we're
going to map it to the names
and we're going to run the prediction
and we read it on test features but you
know we're not just testing it we want
to actually deploy it so at this point I
would go ahead and change this and this
is an array of arrays this is really
important when you're running these to
know that
so you need the double brackets and I
could actually create data maybe let's
let's just do two flowers so maybe I'm
processing more data coming in and we'll
put two flowers in here
and then I actually want to see what the
answer is so let's go ahead and type in
preds and print that out and when I run
this
you'll see that I've now predicted two
flowers so maybe I measured in my front
yard as versacolor and versacolor
not surprising since I put the same data
in for each one
this would be the actual end product
going out to be used on data that you
don't know the answer for
so that's going to conclude our
scripting part of this if you are an
aspiring machine learning engineer
looking for online training and
certifications from prestigious
universities and in collaboration with
leading experts then search no more
simple learns professional certification
program in Ai and machine learning from
Purdue University in collaboration with
IBM should be a right choice for more
details use the link in the description
box below with that in mind by now we
all know machine learning models make
predictions by learning from the past
data available so we have our input
values our machine learning model Builds
on those inputs of what we already know
and then we use that to create a
predicted output is that a dog a little
kid looking over there and watching the
black cat cross their path no dear you
can differentiate between a cat and a
dog based on their characteristics cats
cats have sharp claws uses to climb
smaller length of ears meows and purrs
doesn't love to play around dogs they
have dull claws bigger length of ears
barks loves to run around you usually
don't see a cat running around people
although I do have a cat that does that
where dogs do and we can look at these
we can say we can evaluate their
sharpness of the claws how sharp are
their claws and we can evaluate the
length of the ears and we can usually
sort out cats from dogs based on even
those two characteristics now tell me if
it is a cat or a dog an odd question
usually little kids no cats and dogs by
now unless you live a place where
there's not many cats or dogs so if we
look at the sharpness of the claws the
length of the ears and we can see that
the cat has a smaller ears and sharper
claws than the other animals its
features are more like cats it must be a
cat sharp claws length of ears and it
goes in the cat group because KNN is
based on feature similarity we can do
classification using k n classifier so
we have our input value the picture of
the black cat it goes into our trained
model and it predicts that this is a cat
coming out so what is KNN what is the k
n algorithm K nearest neighbors is what
that stands for it's one of the simplest
supervised machine learning algorithms
mostly used for classification so we
want to know is this a dog or is not a
dog is it a cat or not a cat it
classifies a data point based on how his
neighbors are classified KNN stores all
available cases and classifies new cases
based on a similarity measure and here
we've gone from cats and dogs right into
wine another favorite of mine k n stores
all available cases and classifies new
cases based on a similarity measure and
here you see we have a measurement of
sulfur dioxide versus the chloride level
and then the different wines they've
tested and where they fall on that graph
based on how much sulfur dioxide and how
much chloride K and K N is a perimeter
that refers to the number of nearest
neighbors to include in the majority of
the voting process and so if we add a
new glass of wine there red or white we
want to know what the neighbors are in
this case we're going to put k equals
five we'll talk about K in just a minute
a day point is classified by the
majority of votes from its five nearest
neighbors here the unknown point would
be classified as red since four out of
five neighbors are red so how do we
choose K how do we know k equals five I
mean that's was the value we put in
there so we're going to talk about it
how do we choose the factor K and N
algorithm is based on feature similarity
choosing the right value of K is a
process called parameter tuning and is
important for better accuracy so at k
equals three we can classify we have a
question mark in the middle as either a
as a square or not is it a square or is
it in this case a triangle and so if we
set k equals to 3 we're going to look at
the three nearest neighbors we're going
to say this as a square and if we put k
equals to 7 we classify as a triangle
depending on what the other data is
around it you can see as the K changes
depending on where that point is that
drastically changes your answer and we
jump here we go how do we choose the
factor of K you'll find this in all
machine learning choosing these facts
factors that's the face you get he's
like oh my gosh you say choose the right
K did I set it right my values in
whatever machine learning tool you're
looking at so that you don't have a huge
bias in One Direction or the other and
in terms of knnn the number of K if you
choose it too low the bias is based on
it's just too noisy it's it's right next
to a couple things and it's going to
pick those things and you might get a
skewed answer and if your K is too big
then it's going to take forever to
process so you're going to run into
processing issues and resource issues so
what we do the most common use and
there's other options for choosing K is
to use the square root of n so N is a
total number of values you have you take
the square root of it in most cases you
also if it's an even number so if you're
using uh like in this case squares and
triangles if it's even you want to make
your K value odd that helps it select
better so in other words you're not
going to have a balance between two
different factors that are equal so
usually take the square root of n and if
it's even you add one to it or subtract
one from it and that's where you get the
K value from that is the most common use
and it's pretty solid it works very well
when do we use knnn we can use K N when
data is labeled so you need a label on
it we know we have a group of pictures
with dogs dogs cats cats data is Noise
free and so you can see here when we
have a class and we have like
underweight 140 23 Hello Kitty normal
that's pretty confusing we have a high
variety of data coming in so it's very
noisy and that would cause an issue data
set is small so we're usually working
with smaller data sets where you might
get into a gig of data if it's really
clean it doesn't have a lot of noise
because K N is a lazy learner I.E it
doesn't learn a discriminative function
from the training set so it's very lazy
so if you have very complicated data and
you have a large amount of it you're not
going to use the k n but it's really
great to get a place to start even with
large data you can sort out a small
sample and get an idea of what that
looks like using the knnn and also just
using for smaller data sets k n works
really good how does the K N algorithm
work consider a data set having two
variables height in centimeters and
weight in kilograms and each point is
classified as normal or underweight so
we can see right here we have two
variables you know true false are either
normal or they're not they're
underweight on the basis of the given
data we have to classify the below set
as normal or underweight using k n n so
if we have new data coming in this says
57 kilograms and 177 centimeters is that
going to be normal or underweight to
find the nearest neighbors we'll
calculate the euclidean distance
according to the euclidean distance
formula the distance between two points
in the plane with the coordinates x y
and a b is given by distance D equals
the square root of x minus a squared
plus y minus B squared and you can
remember that from the two edges of a
triangle we're Computing the third Edge
since we we know the X side and the Y
side let's calculate it to understand
clearly so we have our unknown point and
we placed it there in red and we have
our other points where the data is
scattered around the distance D1 is the
square root of 170 minus 167 squared
plus 57 minus 51 squared which is about
6.7 and distance 2 is about 13 and
distance 3 is about 13.4 similarly we
will calculate the euclidean distance of
unknown data point from all the points
in the data set and because we're
dealing with small amount of data that's
not that hard to do and it's actually
pretty quick for a computer and it's not
a really complicated Mass you can just
see how close is the data based on the
euclidean distance hence we have
calculated the euclidean distance of
unknown data point from all the points
as shown where X1 and y1 equal 57 and
170 whose class we have to classify so
now we're looking at that we're saying
well here's the euclidean distance who's
going to be their closest name neighbors
now let's calculate the nearest neighbor
at k equals three and we can see the
three closest neighbors puts them at
normal and that's pretty self-evident
when you look at this graph it's pretty
easy to say okay what you know we're
just voting normal normal three votes
for normal this is going to be a normal
weight so majority of neighbors are
pointing towards normal hence as per k n
algorithm the class of 57 170 should be
normal so a recap of knnn positive
integer K is specified along with a new
sample we select the K entries in our
database which are closest to the new
sample we find the most common
classification of these entries this is
the classification we give to the new
sample so as you can see it's pretty
straightforward we're just looking for
the closest things that match what we
got so let's take a look and see what
that looks like in a use case in Python
so let's dive into the predict diabetes
use case so use case predict diabetes
the objective predict whether a person
will be diagnosed with diabetes or not
we have a data set of 768 people who
were or were not diagnosed with diabetes
and let's go ahead and open that file
and just take a look at that data and
this is in a simple spreadsheet format
the data itself is comma separated very
common set of data and it's also a very
common way to get the data and you can
see here we have columns a through I
that's what one two three four five six
seven eight eight columns with a
particular attribute and then the ninth
column which is the outcome is whether
they have diabetes as a data scientist
the first thing you should be looking at
is insulin well you know if someone has
insulin they have diabetes that's why
they're taking it and that could cause
issue in some of the machine learning
packages but for a very basic setup this
works fine for doing the KNN and the
next thing you notice is it didn't take
very much to open it up I can scroll
down to the bottom of the data there's
768. it's pretty much a small data set
you know at 769 I can easily fit this
into my ram on my computer computer I
can look at it I can manipulate it and
it's not going to really tax just a
regular desktop computer you don't even
need an Enterprise version to run a lot
of this so let's start with importing
all the tools we need and before that of
course we need to discuss what IDE I'm
using certainly can use any particular
editor for python but I like to use for
doing very basic visual stuff the
Anaconda which is great for doing demos
with the Jupiter notebook and just a
quick view of the Anaconda Navigator
which is the new release out there which
is really nice you can see under home I
can choose my application we're going to
be using python36 I have a couple
different versions on this particular
machine if I go under environments I can
create a unique environment for each one
which is nice and there's even a little
button there where you can install
different packages so if I click on that
button and open the terminal I can then
use a simple pip install to install
different packages I'm working with
let's go ahead and go back under home
and we're going to launch our notebook
and I've already you know kind of like
the old cooking shows I've already
prepared a lot of my stuff so we don't
have to wait for it to launch because it
takes a few minutes for it to open up a
browser window in this case I'm going
it's going to open up Chrome because
that's my default that I use and since
the script is pre-done you'll see I have
a number of windows open up at the top
the one we're working in and since we're
working on the KNN predict whether a
person will have diabetes or not let's
go and put that title in there and I'm
also going to go up here and click on
Cell actually we want to go ahead and
first insert a cell below and then I'm
going to go back up to the top cell and
I'm going to change the cell type to
markdown that means this is not going to
run this python it's a markdown language
so if I run this first one it comes up
in nice big letters which is kind of
nice minus what we're working on and by
now you should be familiar with doing
all of our Imports we're going to import
the pandas as PD import numpy is NP
pandas is the pandas data frame and
numpy is a number array very powerful
tools to use in here so we have our
Imports so even brought in our pandas
are numpy or two general python tools
and then you can see over here we have
our train test split by now you should
be familiar with splitting the data we
want to split part of it for training
our thing and then training our
particular model and then we want to go
ahead and test the remaining data to see
how good it is pre-processing a standard
scalar preprocessor so we don't have a
bias of really large numbers remember in
the data we had like number of
pregnancies isn't going to get very
large where the amount of insulin they
take and get up to 256 so 256 versus 6
that will skew results so we want to go
ahead and change that so they're all
uniform between
-1 and 1. and then the actual tool this
is the K neighbors classifier we're
going to use
and finally the last three are three
tools to test all about testing our
model how good is it we just put down
test on there and we have our confusion
Matrix our F1 score and our accuracy so
we have our two general python modules
we're importing and then we have our six
modules specific from the SK learn setup
and then we do need to go ahead and run
this so these are actually imported
there we go and then move on to the next
step and so in this set we're going to
go ahead and load the database we're
going to use pandas remember pandas is
PD and we'll take a look at the data in
Python we looked at it in a simple
spreadsheet but usually I like to also
pull it up so we can see what we're
doing so here's our data set equals
pd.read CSV that's a pandas command and
the diabetes folder I just put in the
same folder where my IPython script is
if you put in a different folder you
need the full length on there we can
also do a quick Links of the data set
that is a simple python on command Len
for length we might even let's go ahead
and print that we'll go print and if you
do it on its own line link that data set
in the jupyter notebook it'll
automatically print it but when you're
in most of your different setups you
want to do the print in front of there
and then we want to take a look at the
actual data set and since we're in
pandas we can simply do data set head
and again let's go ahead and add the
print in there if you put a bunch of
these in a row you know the data set one
head data set two head it only prints
out the last one so I usually always
like to keep the print statement in
there but because most projects only use
one data frame pandas data frame doing
it this way it doesn't really matter the
other way works just fine and you can
see when we hit the Run button we have
the 768 lines which we knew and we have
our pregnancies it's automatically given
a label on the left remember the head
only shows the first five lines so we
have zero through four and just a quick
look at the data you can see it matches
what we looked at before we have
pregnancy glucose blood pressure share
all the way to age and then the outcome
on the end and we're going to do a
couple things in this next step we're
going to create a list of columns where
we can't have zero there's no such thing
as zero skin thickness or zero blood
pressure zero glucose any of those you'd
be dead so not a really good Factor if
they don't if they have a zero in there
because they didn't have the data and
we'll take a look at that because we're
going to start replacing that
information with a couple of different
things and let's see what that looks
like so first we create a nice list as
you can see we have the values talked
about glucose blood pressure skin
thickness and this is a nice way when
you're working with columns is to list
the columns you need to do some kind of
transformation on a very common thing to
do and then for this particular setup we
certainly could use the there's some
Panda tools that will do a lot of this
where we can replace the N A but we're
going to go ahead and do it as a data
set column equals dataset column dot
replace this is this is still pandas you
can do a direct there's also that you
look for your nan a lot of different
options in here but the Nan num pnan is
what that stands for is none it doesn't
exist so the first thing we're doing
here is we're replacing the zero with a
numpy none there's no data there that's
what that says that's what this is
saying right here so put the 0 in and
we're going to play zeros with no data
so if it's a zero that means a person's
well hopefully not dead hope they just
didn't get the data the next thing we
want to do is we're going to create the
mean which is the integer from the data
set from the column dot mean where we
skip in A's we can do that and that is a
pandas command there the skip n a so
we're going to figure out the mean of
that data set and then we're going to
take that data set column and we're
going to replace all the npnan with the
means why did we do that and we could
have actually just taken this step and
gone right down here and just replace 0
and Skip anything where except you can
actually there's a way to skip zeros and
then just replace all the zeros but in
this case we want to go ahead and do it
this way so you can see that we're
switching this to a non-existent value
then we're going to create the mean well
this is the average person so if we
don't know what it is if they did not
get the data and the data is missing one
of the tricks is you replace it with the
average what is the most common data for
that this way you can still use the rest
of those values to do your computation
and it kind of just brings that
particular value of those missing values
out of the equation let's go ahead and
take this and we'll go ahead and run it
doesn't actually do anything so we're
still preparing our data if you want to
see what that looks like we don't have
anything the first few lines just not
going to show up but we certainly could
look at a row let's do that let's go
into our data set with the printed data
set and let's pick in this case let's
just do glucose and if I run this this
is going to print all the different
glucose levels going down and we
thankfully don't see anything in here
that looks like missing data at least on
the ones that shows you can see I
skipped a bunch in the middle because
that's what it does we have too many
lines in Jupiter notebook he'll skip a
few and go on to the next in a data set
let me go and remove this okay we'll
just zero out that and of course before
we do any processing before proceeding
any further we need to split the data
set into our train and testing data that
way we have something to train it with
and something to test it on and you're
going to notice we did a little
something here with the pandas database
code there we go my drawing tool we've
added in this right here off the data
set and what this says is that the first
one in pandas this is from the PD pandas
it's going to say within the data set we
want to look at the eye location and it
is all rows that's what that says so
we're going to keep all the rows but
we're only looking at zero columns 0 To
8. Remember column nine here it is right
up here we printed it in here as outcome
well that's not part of the training
data that's part of the answer yes
column nine but it's listed as eight
number eight so zero to eight is nine
columns so 8 is the value and when you
see it in here zero this is actually
zero to seven it doesn't include the
last one and then we go down here to Y
which is our answer and we want just the
last one just column eight and you can
do it this way with this particular
notation and then if you remember we
imported the train test split that's
part of the SK learn right there and we
simply put in our X and our y we're
going to do random State equals zero you
don't have to necessarily seed it that's
a seed number I think the default is one
when you seated I have to look that up
and then the test size test size is 0.2
that simply means we're going to take 20
percent of the data and put it aside so
that we can test it later that's all
that is and again we're going to run it
not very exciting so far we haven't had
any printout other than to look at the
data but that is a lot of this is
prepping this data once you prep it the
actual lines of code are quick and easy
and we're almost there with the actual
running of our k n n we need to go ahead
and do a scale the data if you remember
correctly we're fitting the data in a
standard Taylor which means instead of
the data being from you know 5 to 303 in
one column and the next column is one to
six we're going to set that all so that
all the data is between minus one and
one that's what that standard scalar
does keeps it standardized and we only
want to fit the scalar with the training
set but we want to make sure the testing
set is the X test going in is also
transformed so it's processing it the
same so here we go with our standard
scalar we're going to call it SC
underscore X for the scalar and we're
going to import the standard scalar into
this variable and then our X train
equals SC underscore x dot fit transform
so we're creating the scalar on the X
train variable and then our X test we're
also going to transform it so we've
trained and transformed the X train and
then the X test isn't part of that
training it isn't part of the of
training the Transformer it just gets
transformed that's all it does and again
we're going to run this and if you look
at this we've now now gone through these
steps all three of them we've taken care
of replacing our zeros for key columns
that shouldn't be zero and we replace
that with the means of those columns
that way that they fit right in with our
data models we've come down here we
split the data so now we have our test
data and our training data and then
we've taken and we've scaled the data so
all of our data going in now no we don't
TR we don't train the Y part the Y train
and Y test that never has to be trained
it's only the data going in that's what
we want to train in there then Define
the model using K Nabors classifier and
fit the train data in the model so we do
all that data prep and you can see down
here we're only going to have a couple
lines of code where we're actually
building our model and training it
that's one of the cool things about
Python and how far we've come it's such
an exciting time to be in machine
learning because there's so many
automated tools let's see before we do
this let's do a quick link of and let's
do y we want yeah let's just do length
of Y and we get 768 and if we import
math we do math dot square root let's do
y train there we go that's actually
supposed to be X train before we do this
let's go ahead and do import math and do
math square root length of Y test and
when I run that we get 12.409 I want to
show you where this number comes from
we're about to use 12 is an even number
so if you know if you're ever voting on
things remember the neighbors all vote
don't want to have an even number of
neighbors voting so we want to do
something odd and let's just take one
away we'll make it 11. let me delete
this out of here that's one of the
reasons I love Jupiter notebook because
you can flip around and do all kinds of
things on the fly so we'll go ahead and
put in our classifier we're creating our
classifier now and it's going to be the
K neighbors classifier and neighbors
equal 11. remember we did 12 minus 1 for
11 so we have an odd number of neighbors
P equals 2 because we're looking for is
it are they diabetic or not and we're
using the euclidean metric there are
other means of measuring the distance
you could do like square square means
value there's all kinds of measure this
but the euclidean is the most common one
and it works quite well it's important
to evaluate the model let's use the
confusion Matrix to do that and we're
going to use the confusion Matrix
wonderful tool and then we'll jump into
the F1 score
and finally accuracy score which is
probably the most commonly used quoted
number when you go into a meeting or
something like that so let's go ahead
and paste that in there and we'll set
the cm equal to confusion Matrix why
test why predict so those are the two
values we're going to put in there and
let me go ahead and run that and print
it out and the way you interpret this is
you have the Y predicted which would be
your title up here we could do let's
just do p r e d
predicted across the top and actual
going down actual
it's always hard to write in here actual
that means that this column here down
the middle that's the important column
and it means that our prediction said 94
and prediction in the actual agreed on
94 and 32. this number here the 13 and
the 15 those are what was wrong so you
could have like three different if
you're looking at this across three
different variables instead of just two
you'd end up with the third row down
here and the column going down the
middle so in the first case we have the
the and I believe the zero has a 94
people who don't have diabetes the
prediction said that 13 of those people
did have diabetes and were at high risk
and the 32 that had diabetes it had
correct but our prediction said another
15 out of that 15 it classified as
incorrect so you can see where that
classification comes in and how that
works on the confusion Matrix then we're
going to go ahead and print the F1 score
let me just run that and you see we get
a 0.69 in our F1 score the F1 takes into
account both sides of the balance of
false positives where if we go ahead and
just do the accuracy account and that's
what most people think of is it looks at
just how many we got right out of how
many we got wrong so a lot of people
when you're a data scientist and you're
talking to other data scientists they're
going to ask you what the F1 score the F
score is if you're talking to the
general public or the decision makers in
the business they're going to ask what
the accuracy is and the accuracy is
always better than the F1 score but the
F1 scores more telling it lets us know
that there's more false positives than
we would like on here but 82 percent not
too bad for a quick flash look at
people's different statistics and
running an sklearn and running the k n n
the K nearest neighbor on it so we have
created a model using KNN which can
predict whether a person will have
diabetes or not or the very least
whether they should go get a checkup and
have their glucose checked regularly or
not the print accuracy score we got the
0.818 was pretty close to what we got
and we can pretty much round that off
and just say we have an accuracy of 80
percent tells us it is a pretty fair fit
in the model if you are an aspiring
machine learning engineer looking for
online training and certifications from
prestigious universities and in
collaboration with leading experts then
such no more simply learns professional
certification program in Ai and machine
learning from Purdue University in
collaboration with IBM should be a right
choice for more details use the link in
the description box below with that in
mind and find out why support Vector
machine so in this example last week my
son and I visited a fruit shop dad is
that an apple or a strawberry so the
question comes up what proof do they
just pick up from the Fruit Stand after
a couple of seconds you could figure out
that it was a strawberry so let's take
this model a step further and let's uh
why not build a model which can predict
an unknown data and in this we're going
to be be looking at some sweet
strawberries or crispy apples we wanted
to be able to label those two and decide
what the fruit is and we do that by
having data already put in so we already
have a bunch of strawberries we know our
strawberries and they're already labeled
as such we already have a bunch of
apples we know our apples and are
labeled as such then once we train our
model that model then can be given the
new data and the new data is this image
in this case you can see a question mark
on it and it comes through and goes it's
a strawberry in this case we're using
the support Vector Machine model svm is
a supervised learning method that looks
at data and sorts it into one of two
categories and in this case we're
sorting the strawberry into the
strawberry side at this point you should
be asking the question how does the
prediction work before we dig into an
example with numbers let's apply this to
our fruit scenario we have our support
Vector machine we've taken it and we've
taken labeled sample of data
strawberries and apples and we've drawn
a line down the middle between the two
groups this split now allows us to take
new data in this case an apple and a
strawberry and place them in the
appropriate group based on which side of
the line they fall in and that way we
can predict the unknown as colorful and
tasty as the food example is let's take
a look at another example with some
numbers involved and we can take a
closer look at how the math Works in
this example we're going to be
classifying men and women and we're
going to start with a set of people with
a different height and a different
weight and to make this work we'll have
to have a sample data set a female where
you have their height weight 174 65 174
88 and so on and we'll need a sample
data set of the male they have a height
179 90 180 to 80 and so on let's go
ahead and put this on a graph so we have
a nice visual so you can see here we
have two groups based on the height
versus the weight and on the left side
we're going to have the women on the
right side we're going to have the men
now if we're going to create a
classifier let's add a new data point
and figure out if it's male or female so
before we can do that we need to split
our data first we can split our data by
choosing any of these lines in this case
we draw in two lines through the data in
the middle that separates some men from
the women but to predict the gender of a
new data point we should split the data
in the best possible way and we say the
best possible way because this line has
a maximum space that separates the two
classes here you can see there's a clear
split between the two different classes
and in this one there's not so much a
clear split this doesn't have the
maximum space that separates the two
that is why this line best splits the
data we don't want to just do this by
eyeballing it and before we go further
we need to add some technical terms to
this we can also say that the distance
between the points and the line should
be as far as possible in technical terms
we can say the distance between the
support vector and the hyperplane should
be as far as possible and this is where
the support vectors are the extreme
points in the data set and if you look
at this data set they have circled two
points which seem to to be right on the
outskirts of the women and one on the
outskirts of the men and hyperplane has
a maximum distance to the support
vectors of any class now you'll see the
line down the middle and we call this
the hyperplane because when you're
dealing with multiple Dimensions it's
really not just a line but a plane of
intersections and you can see here where
the support vectors have been drawn in
dashed lines the math behind this is
very simple we take D plus the shortest
distance to the closest positive point
which would be on the Min side and D
minus is the shortest distance to the
closest negative point which is on the
women's side the sum of D plus and D
minus is called the distance margin or
the distance between the two support
vectors that are shown in the dashed
lines and then by finding the largest
distance margin we can get the optimal
hyperplane once we've created an optimal
hyperplane we can easily see which side
the new data fits in and based on the
hyperplane we can say the new data point
belongs to the male gender hopefully
that's clear and how that works on a
visual level as a data scientist you
should also be asking what happens if
the hyperplane is not optimal if we
select a hyperplane having low margin
then there is a high chance of
misclassification this particular svm
model the one we discussed so far is
also called referred to as the ls VM so
far so clear but a question should be
coming up we have our sample data set
but instead of looking like this what if
it looked like this where we have two
sets of data but one of them occurs in
the middle of another set you can see
here where we have the blue and the
yellow and then blue again on the other
side of our data line in this data set
we can't use a hyperplane so when you
see data like this it's necessary to
move away from a 1D view of the data to
a two-dimensional view of the data and
for the transformation we use what's
called a kernel function the kernel
function will take the 1D input and
transfer it to a two-dimensional output
as you can see in this picture here the
1 D when transferred to a
two-dimensional makes it very easy to
draw a line between the two data sets
what if we make it even more complicated
how do we perform an svm for this type
of data set here you can see we have a
two-dimensional data set where the data
is in the middle surrounded by the green
data on the outside in this case we're
going to segregate the two classes we
have our sample data set and if you draw
a line through it's obviously not an
optimal hyperplane in there so to do
that we need to transfer the 2D to a 3D
array and when you translate it into a
three-dimensional array using the kernel
you can see where you can place a
hyperplane right through it and easily
split the data before we start looking
at a programming example and dive into
the script let's look at the advantage
of the support Vector machine we'll
start with high dimensional input space
or sometimes referred to as the curse of
dimensionality we looked at earlier one
dimension two Dimension three dimension
when you get to a thousand dimensions a
lot of problems start occurring with
most algorithms that have to be adjusted
for for the svm automatically does that
in high dimensional space one of the
high dimensional space one high
dimensional space that we work on is
sparse document vectors this is where we
tokenize the words and documents so we
can run our machine learning algorithms
over them I've seen ones get as high as
2.4 million different tokens that's a
lot of vectors to look at and finally we
have regularization parameter the
realization parameter or Lambda is a
parameter that helps figure out whether
we're going to have a bias or
overfitting of the data whether it's
going to be overfitted to a very
specific instance or it's going to be
biased to a high or low value with the
svm it naturally avoids the overfitting
and bias problems that we see in many
other algorithms these three advantages
of the support Vector machine make it a
very powerful tool to add to your
repertoire of machine learning tools now
we did promise you a used case study
we're actually going to dive into some
Python Programming and so we're going to
go into a problem statement and start
off with the zoo so in the zoo example
we have of family members going to the
zoo we have the young child going dad is
that a group of crocodiles or alligators
well that's hard to differentiate and
zoos are a great place to start looking
at science and understanding how things
work especially as a young child and so
we can see the parents in here thinking
well what is the difference between a
crocodile and an alligator well one
crocodiles are larger in size alligators
are smaller in size snout width the
crocodiles have a narrow snout and
alligators have a wider snout and of
course in the modern day and age the
father's hitting there is thinking how
can I turn this into a lesson for my son
and he goes let a support Vector machine
segregate the two groups I don't know if
my dad ever told me that but that would
be funny now in this example we're not
going to use actual measurements and
data we're just using that for imagery
and that's very common in a lot of
machine learning algorithms and setting
them up but let's roll up our sleeves
and we'll talk about that more in just a
moment as we break into our python
script so here we arrive in our actual
coding and I'm going to move this into a
python editor in just a moment but let's
talk a little bit about what we're going
to cover first we're going to cover in
the code the setup how to actually
create our svm and you're going to find
that there's only two lines of code that
actually create it and the rest of it is
done so quick and fast that it's all
here in the first page and we'll show
you what that looks like as far as our
data because we're going to create some
data I talked about creating data just a
minute ago and so we'll get into the
creating data here and you'll see this
nice correction of our two blobs and
we'll go through that in just a second
and then the second part is we're going
to take this and we're going to bump it
up a notch we're going to show you what
it looks like behind the scenes but
let's start with actually creating our
setup I like to use the Anaconda Jupiter
notebook because it's very easy to use
but you can use any of your favorite
python editors or setups and go in there
but let's go ahead and switch over there
and see what that looks like so here we
are in the Anaconda python notebook or
anaconda Jupiter notebook with python
we're using python3 I believe this is
3.5 but it should be work in any of your
3x versions and and you'd have to look
at the SK learn and make sure if you're
using a 2X version an earlier version
let's go and put our code in there and
one of the things I like about the
jupyter notebook is I go up to view and
I'm going to go ahead and toggle the
line numbers on to make it a little bit
easier to talk about and we can even
increase the size because this is edited
in in this case I'm using Google Chrome
Explorer and that's how it opens up for
the editor although anyone any like I
said any editor will work now the first
step is going to be our Imports and
we're going to import four different
parts the first two I want you to look
at are line one and line two are numpy
as NP and
matplotlibrary.pi plot as PLT now these
are very standardized Imports when
you're doing work the first one is the
numbers python we need that because part
of the platform we're using uses that
for the numpy array and I'll talk about
that in a minute so you can understand
why we want to use a numpy array versus
the standard python array and normally
it's pretty standard setup to use NP for
numpy the matplot library is how we're
going to view our data so this has you
do need the NP for the sklearn module
but the matplot library is purely for
our use for visualization and so you
really don't need that for the svm but
we're going to put it there so you have
a nice visual aid and we can show you
what it looks like that's really
important at the end when you finish
everything so you have a nice display
for everybody to look at and then
finally we're gonna I'm gonna jump one
ahead to line number four that's the
sklearn.datasets.samples generator
import make blobs and I told you that we
were going to make up data and this is a
tool that's in the SK learning makeup
data I personally don't want to go to
the zoo get in trouble for jumping over
the fence and probably get eaten by the
crocodiles or alligators as I work on
measuring their snouts and width and
length instead we're just going to make
up some data and that's what that make
blobs is It's a Wonderful tool if you're
ready to test your your setup and you're
not sure about what data you're going to
put in there you can create this blob
and it makes it real easy to use and
finally we have our actual s svm the
sklearn import svm on line three so that
covers all our Imports we're going to
create remember I used the make blobs to
create data and we're going to create a
capital x and a lowercase y equals make
blobs in samples equals 40. so we're
going to make 40 lines of data it's
going to have two centers with a random
State equals 20. so each each group is
going to have 20 different pieces of
data in it and the way that lux is that
we'll have under X an X Y plane so I
have two numbers under X and Y will be 0
1. that's the two different centers so
we have yes or no in this case alligator
a crocodile that's what that represents
and then I told you that the actual SK
learner the svm is in two lines of code
and we see it right here with clf equals
svm dot SVC kernel equals linear and I
set SQL to one although in this example
since we are not regularizing the data
because we want to be very clear and
easy to see I went ahead you can set it
to a thousand a lot of times when you're
not doing that but for this thing linear
because it's a very simple linear
example we only have the two dimensions
and it'll be a nice linear hyperplane
it'll be a nice linear line instead of a
full plane so we're not dealing with a
huge amount of data and then all we have
to do is do clf dot fit X comma Y and
that's it clf has been created and then
we're going to go ahead and display it
and I'm going to talk about this display
here in just a second but let me go
ahead and run this code and this is what
we've done is we've created two blobs
you'll see the blue on the side and then
kind of an orangish on the other side
that's our two sets of data they
represent one represents crocodiles and
one represents alligators and then we
have our measurements in this case we
have like the width and length of the
snout and I did say I was going to come
up here and talk just a little bit about
our plot and you'll see PLT that's what
we imported we're going to do a scatter
plot that means we're just putting dots
on there and then look at this notation
I have the capital x and then in
brackets I have a colon comma zero
that's from numpy if you did that in a
regular array you'll get an error in a
python array you have to have that in a
numpy array it turns out that our make
blobs returns a numpy array and this
notation is great because what it means
is the first part is the colon means
we're going to do all the rows that's
all the data in our blob we created
under capital x and then the second part
has a comma zero we're only going to
take the first value and then if you
notice we do the same thing but we're
going to take the second value remember
we always start with zero and then one
so we have column 0 and column one and
you can look at this as our X Y plots
the first one is the X plot and the
second one is the Y plot so the first
one is on the bottom 0 2 4 6 8 and 10
and then the second one X of the one is
the four five six seven eight nine ten
going up the left hand side s equals 30
is just the size of the dot so we can
see them instead of little tiny dots and
then C map equals plt.cm dot paired and
you'll also see the C equals y That's
the color we're using two colors zero
one and that's why we get the nice blue
and the two different colors for the
alligator and the crocodile now you can
see here that we did this the actual fit
was done in two lines of code a lot of
times there'll be a third line where we
regularize the data we set it between
like minus one and one and we reshape it
but for this it's not necessary and it's
also kind of nice because you can
actually see what's going on and then if
we wanted to we wanted to actually run a
prediction let's take a look and see
what that looks like and to predict some
new data and we'll show this again as we
get towards the end of digging in deep
you can simply assign your new data in
this case I am giving it a width and
length three four and a with the length
five six and note that I put the data as
a set of brackets and then I have the
brackets inside and the reason I do that
is because when we're looking at data
it's designed to process a large amount
of data coming in we don't want to just
process one line at a time and so this
case I'm processing two lines and then
I'm just going to print and you'll see
clf.predict new data so the clf and the
dot predict part is going to give us an
answer and let's see what that looks
like and you'll see 0 1 so predicted the
first one the 3 4 is going to be on the
one side and the 5 6 is going to be on
the other side so one came out as an
alligator and one came out as a
crocodile now that's pretty short
explanation for this setup but really we
want to dug in and see what's going on
behind the scenes and let's see what
that looks like so the next step is to
dig in deep and find out what's going on
behind the scenes and also put that in a
nice pretty graph we're going to spend
more work on this and we did actually
generating the original model and you'll
see here that we go through a few steps
and I'll move this over to our editor in
just a second we come in we create our
original data it's exactly identical to
the first part and I'll explain why we
redid that and show you how not to redo
that and then we're going to go in there
and add in those lines we're going to
see what those lines look like and how
to set those up and finally we're going
to plot all that on here and show it and
you'll get a nice graph with the what we
saw earlier when we were going through
the theory behind this where it shows
the support vectors and the hyperplane
and those are done where you can see the
support vectors as the dashed lines and
the solid line which is the hyperplane
let's get that into our Jupiter notebook
before I scroll down to a new line I
want you to notice line 13 it has Plot
show and we're going to talk about that
here in just a second but let's scroll
down to a new line down here and I'm
going to paste that code in and you'll
see that the plot show has moved down
below let's scroll up a little bit and
if you look at the top here of our new
section one two three and four is the
same code we had before and let's go
back up here and take a look at that
we're going to fit the values on our svm
and then we're going to plot scatter it
and then we're going to do a plot show
if you are an aspiring machine learning
engineer looking for online training
answer applications from prestigious
universities and in collaboration with
leading experts then search no more
simple learns professional certification
program in Ai and machine learning from
Purdue University in collaboration with
IBM should be a right choice for more
details use the link in the description
box below with that in mind what is
naive days let's start with a basic
introduction to the Bayes theorem named
after Thomas pays from the 1700s who
first coined this in the western
literature naive Bayes classifier works
on the principle of conditional
probability as given by the Bayes
theorem before we move ahead let us go
through some of the simple Concepts in
the probability that we will be using
let us consider the following example of
tossing two coins here we have two
quarters and if we look at all the
different possibilities of what they can
come up as we get that they could come
up as head heads they come up as head
tell tell head and Telltale when doing
the math on probability we usually
denote probability as a p a capital P so
the probability of getting two heads
equals one-fourth you can see on our our
data set we have two heads and this
occurs once out of the four
possibilities and then the probability
of at least one tail occurs three
quarters of the time you'll see in three
of the toin tosses we have tails in them
and out of four that's three fourths and
then the probability of the second coin
being head given the first coin is tail
is one half and the probability of
getting two heads given the first coin
is a head is one half we'll demonstrate
that in just a minute and show you how
that math works now when we're doing it
with two coins it's easy to see but when
you have something more complex you can
see where these Pro these formulas
really come in and work so the Bayes
theorem gives us a conditional
probability of an event a given another
event B has occurred in this case the
first coin toss will be B and the second
coin toss a this could be confusing
because we've actually reversed the
order of them and go from B to a instead
of a to B you'll see this a lot when you
work in probabilities the reason is
we're looking for event a we want to
know what that is so we're going to
label that a since sets our focus and
then given another event B has occurred
in the Bayes theorem as you can see on
the left the probability of a occurring
given B has occurred equals the
probability of B occurring given a has
occurred times the probability of a over
the probability of B the simple formula
can be moved around just like any
algebra formula and we could do the
probability of a after a given B times
probability of b equals the probability
of B given a times probability of a you
can easily move that around and multiply
it and divide it out let us apply a
Bayes theorem to our example here we
have our two quarters and we'll notice
that the first two probabilities of
getting two heads and at least one tail
we compute directly off the data so you
can easily see that we have one example
HH out of four one fourth and we have
three with tails in them giving us three
quarters or three-fourths 75 percent the
second condition the second set three
and four we're gonna explore a little
bit more in detail now we stick to a
simple example with two coins because
you can easily understand the math the
probability of throwing a tail doesn't
matter what comes before it and the same
with the head so still going to be 50 or
one half but when that comes when that
probability gets more complicated let's
say you have a D6 dice or some other
instance then this formula really comes
in handy but let's stick to the simple
example for now in this sample space let
a be the event that the second coin is
head and B be the event that the first
coin is tells again we reversed it
because we want to know what the second
event is going to be so we're going to
be focusing on a and we write that out
as a probability of a given B and we
know this from our formula that that
equals the probability of B given a
times the probability of a over the
probability of B and when we plug that
in we plug in the probability of the
first coin being tells given the second
coin is heads and the probability of the
second coin being heads given the first
coin being over the probability of the
first coin being Tails when we plug that
data in and we have the probability of
the first coin being Tails given when
the second coin is heads times the
probability of the second coin being
heads over the probability of the first
coin being tails you can see it's a
simple formula to calculate we have one
half times one half over one-half or
one-half equals 0.5 or 1 4. so the Bayes
theorem basically calculates the
conditional probability of the
occurrence of an event based on prior
knowledge of conditions that might be
related to the event we will explore
this in detail when we take up an
example of online shopping further in
this tutorial understand standing naive
bees and machine learning like with any
of our other machine learning tools it's
important to understand where the naive
Bayes fits in the hierarchy so under the
machine learning we have supervised
learning and there is other things like
unsupervised learning there's also
reward system This falls under the
supervised learning and then under the
supervisors learning there's
classification there's also a regression
but we're going to be in the
classification side and then under
classification is your naive Bayes let's
go ahead and glance into where is naive
Bayes used let's look at some of the use
scenarios for it as a classifier we use
it in face recognition is this Cindy or
is it not Cindy or whoever or it might
be used to identify parts of the face
that they then feed into another part of
the face recognition program this is the
eye this is the nose this is the mouth
weather prediction is it going to be
rainy or sunny medical recognition news
prediction it's also used in medical
diagnosis we might diagnose somebody as
either as high risk or not as high risk
for cancer or heart disease ease or
other elements and news classification
we look at the Google news and it says
well is this political or is this world
news or a lot of that's all done with a
naive Bayes understanding naive Bayes
classifier now we already went through a
basic understanding with the coins and
the two heads and two tells and head
Telltale heads Etc we're going to do
just a quick review on that and remind
you that the naive Bayes classifier is
based on the Bayes theorem which gives a
conditional probability of event a given
event B and that's where the probability
of a given b equals the probability of B
given a times probability of a over
probability of B remember this is an
algebraic function so we can move these
different entities around we can
multiply by the probability of B so it
goes to the left hand side and then we
could divide by the probability of a
given B and just as easy come up with a
new formula for the probability of B to
me staring at these algebraic functions
kind of gives me a slight headache as
it's a lot better to see if we can
actually understand how this data fits
together in a table and let's go ahead
and start applying it to some actual
data so you can see what that looks like
so we're going to start with the
shopping demo problem statement and
remember we're going to solve this first
in table form so you can see what the
math looks like and then we're going to
solve it in Python and in here we want
to predict whether the person will
purchase a product are they going to buy
or don't buy very important if you're
running a business you want to know how
to maximize your profits or at least
maximize the purchase of the people
coming into your store and we're going
to look at a specific combination of
different variables in this case we're
going to look at the day the discount
and the free delivery and you can see
here under the day we want to know
whether it's on the weekday you know
somebody's working they come in after
work or maybe they don't work weekend
you can see the bright colors coming
down there celebrating not being in work
or holiday and did we offer a discount
that day yes or no did we offer free
delivery that day yes or no and from
this we want to know whether the person
is going to buy based on these traits so
we can maximize them and find out the
best system for getting somebody to come
in and purchase our goods and products
from our store now having a nice visual
is great but we do need to dig into the
data so let's go ahead and take a look
at the data set we have a small sample
data set of 30 rows we're showing you
the first 15 of those rows for this demo
now the actual data file you can request
just type in below under the comments on
the YouTube video and we'll send you
some more information and send you that
file as you can see here the file is
very simple columns and rows we have the
day the discount the free delivery and
did the person purchase or not and then
we have under the day whether it was a
weekday a holiday was it the weekend
this is a pretty simple set of data and
long before computers people used to
look at this data and calculate this all
by hand so let's go ahead and walk
through this and see what that looks
like when we put that into tables also
note in today's world we're not usually
looking at three different variables in
30 rows nowadays because we're able to
collect data so much we're usually
looking at 27 30 variables across
hundreds of rows the first thing we want
to do is we're going to take this data
and based on the data set containing our
three inputs Day discount and free
delivery we're going to go ahead and
populate that to frequency tables for
each attribute so we want to know if
they had a discount how many people buy
and did not buy did they have a discount
yes or no do we have a free delivery yes
or no on those dates how many people
made a purchase how many people didn't
and the same with the three days of the
week was it a weekday a weekend a
holiday and did they buy yes or no as we
dig in deeper to this table for our
Bayes theorem let the event buy be a now
remember we looked at the coins I said
we really want to know what the outcome
is did the person buy or not and that's
usually event a is what you're looking
for and the independent variables
discount free delivery and day BB so
we'll call that probability of B now let
us calculate the likelihood table for
one of the variables let's start with
day which includes weekday weekend and
holiday and let us start by summing all
of our our rows so we have the weekday
row and out of the weekdays there's nine
plus two so it's 11 weekdays there's
eight weekend days and eleven holidays
that's a lot of holidays and then we
want to sum up the total number of days
so we're looking at a total of 30 days
let's start pulling some information
from our chart and see where that takes
us and when we fill in the chart on the
right you can see that 9 out of 24
purchases are made on the weekday 7 out
of 24 purchases on the weekend and 8 out
of 24 purchases on a holiday and out of
all the people who come in 24 out of 30
purchase you can also see how many
people do not purchase on the weekdays
two out of six didn't purchase and so on
and so on we can also look at the totals
and you'll see on the right we put
together some of the formulas the
probability of making a purchase on the
weekend comes out at 11 out of 30. so
out of the 30 people who came into the
store throughout the weekend weekday and
holiday 11 of those purchases were made
on the weekday and then you can also see
the probability of them not making a
purchase and this is done for doesn't
matter which day of the week so we call
that probability of no buy would be 6
over 30 or 0.2 so there's a twenty
percent chance that they're not going to
make a purchase no matter what day of
the week it is and finally we look at
the probability of B of A in this case
we're going to look at the probability
of the weekday and not buying two of the
no buys were done on the weekend out of
the six people who did not make
purchases so when we look at that
probability of the week day without a
purchase is going to be 0.33 or 33
percent let's take a look at this at
different probabilities and based on
this likelihood table let's go ahead and
calculate conditional probabilities as
below the first three we just did the
probability of making a purchase on the
weekday is 11 out of 30 or roughly 36 or
37 percent 0.367 the probability of not
making a purchase at all doesn't matter
what day of the week is roughly 0.2 or
20 percent and the probability of a
weekday no purchase is roughly two out
of six so two out of six of our no
purchases were made on the weekday and
then finally we take our P of a b if you
look we've kept the symbols up there we
got P of probability of B probability of
a probability of B if a we should
remember that the probability of a if B
is equal to the first one times the
probability of no buys over the
probability of the weekday so we could
calculate it both off the table we
created we can also calculate this by
the formula and we get the 0.36 7 which
equals or 0.33 times 0.2 over 0.367
which equals 0.179 or roughly 17 to 18
percent and that'd be the probability of
no purchase done on the weekday and this
is important because we can look at this
and say as the probability of buying on
the weekday is more than the probability
of not buying on the weekday we can
conclude that customers will most likely
buy the product on a weekday now we've
kept our chart simple and we're only
looking at one aspect so you should be
able to look at the table and come up
with the same information or the same
conclusion that should be kind of
intuitive at this point next we can take
the same setup we have the frequency
tables of all three independent
variables now we can construct the
likelihood tables for all three of the
variables we're working with we can take
our day like we did before we have
weekday weekend and holiday we filled in
this table and then we can come in and
also do that for the discount yes or no
did they buy yes or no and we fill in
that full tape table so now we have our
probabilities for a discount and whether
the discount leads to a purchase or not
and the probability for free delivery
does that lead to a purchase or not and
this is where it starts getting really
exciting let us use these three
likelihood tables to calculate whether a
customer will purchase a product on a
specific combination of Day discount and
free delivery or not purchase here let
us take a combination of these factors
day equals holiday discount equals yes
free delivery equals yes let's dig
deeper into the math and actually see
what this looks like and we're going to
start with looking for the probability
of them not purchasing on the following
combinations of days we're actually
looking for the probability of a equal
no buy no purchase and our probability
of B we're going to set equal to is it a
holiday do they get a discount yes and
was it a free delivery yes before we go
further let's look at the original
equation the probability of a if B
equals a probability of B given the
condition a and the probability times
the probability of a over the
probability of B occurring now this is
basic algebra so we can multiply this
information together so when you see the
probability of a given B in this case
the condition is b c and d or the three
different variables we're looking at and
when you see the probability of B that
would be the conditions we're actually
going to multiply those three separate
conditions out probability of you'll see
that just a second in the formula times
the full probability of a over the full
probability of B so here we are back to
this and we're going to have let a equal
no purchase and we're looking for the
probability of B on the condition a
where a sets for three different things
remember that equals the probability of
a given the condition B and in this case
we just multiply those three different
variables together so we have the
probability of the discount times the
probability of freedom delivery times
the probability is the day equal holiday
those are our three variables of the
probability of a if B and then that is
going to be multiplied by the
probability of them not making a
purchase and then we want to divide that
by the total probabilities and they're
multiplied together so we have the
probability of a discount the
probability of a free delivery and the
probability of it being on a holiday
when we plug those numbers in we see
that one out of six were no purchase on
a discounted day two out of six or a no
purchase on a free delivery day and
three out of six or a no purchase on a
holiday those are our three
probabilities of a of B multiplied out
and then that has to be multiplied by
the probability of a no purchase and
remember the probability of a no buy is
across all the data so that's where we
get the 6 out of 30. we divide that out
by the probability of each category over
the total number so we get the 20 out of
30 had a discount 23 3 out of 30 had a
yes for free delivery and 11 out of 30
were on a holiday we plug all those
numbers in we get
0.178 so in our probability math we have
a 0.178 if it's a no buy for a holiday a
discount and a free delivery let's turn
that around and see what that looks like
if we have a purchase I promise this is
the last page of math before we dig into
the python script so here we're
calculating the probability of the
purchase using the same math we did to
find out if they didn't buy now we want
to know if they did buy and again we're
going to go by the day equals a holiday
discount equals yes free delivery equals
yes and let a equal buy now right about
now you might be asking why are we doing
both calculations why why would we want
to know the no buys and buys for the
same data going in well we're going to
show you that in just a moment but we
have to have both of those pieces of
information so that we can figure it out
as a percentage as opposed to a
probability equation and we'll get to
that normalization here in just a moment
let's go ahead and walk through this
calculation and as you can see here the
probability of a on the condition of b b
being all three categories did we have a
discount with a purchase do we have a
free delivery with a purchase and did we
is a day equal to Holiday and when we
plug this all into that formula and
multiply it all out we get our
probability of a discount probability of
a free delivery probability of the day
being a holiday times the overall
probability of it being a purchase
divided by again multiplying the three
variables out the full probability of
there being a discount the full
probability of being a free delivery and
the full probability of there being a
day equal holiday and that's where we
get this 19 over 24 times 21 over 24
times 8 over 24 times the P of a 24 over
30 divided by the probability of the
discount the free delivery times a day
or 20 over 30 23 over 30 times 11 over
30 and that gives us our
0.986 so what are we going to do with
these two pieces of data we just
generated well let's go ahead and go
over them we have a probability of
purchase equals 0.986 we have a
probability of no purchase equals
0.178 so finally we have a conditional
probabilities of purchase on this day
let us take that we're going to
normalize it and we're going to take
these probabilities and turn them into
percentages this is simply done by
taking these sum of probabilities which
equals
0.98686 plus 0.178 and that equals the
1.164 if we divide each probability by
the sum we get the percentage and so the
likelihood of a purchase is 84.71
percent and the likelihood of no
purchase is 15.29 percent given these
three different variables so it's if
it's on a holiday if it's a with a
discount and has free delivery then
there's an 84.71 percent chance that the
customer is going to come in and make a
purchase hooray they purchased our stuff
we're making money if you're owning a
shop that's like is the bottom line is
you want to make some money so you keep
your shop open and have a living now I
promised you that we were going to be
finishing up the math here with a few
pages so we're going to move on and
we're going to do two steps the first
step is I want you to understand why you
went under why you want to use the naive
Bayes what are the advantages of naive
bays and then once we understand those
advantages we just look at that briefly
then we're going to dive in and do some
python coding advantages of naive Bayes
classifier so let's take a look at the
six advantages of the naive Bayes
classifier and we're going to walk
around this lovely wheel looks like an
origami folded paper the first one is
very simple and easy to implement
certainly you could walk through the
tables and do this by hand you got to be
a little careful because the notations
can get confusing you have all these
different probabilities and I certainly
mess those up as I put them on you know
is it on the top of the bottom got to
really pay close attention to that when
you put it into python it's really nice
because you don't have to worry about
any of that you let the python handle
that the python module but understanding
it you can put it on a table and you can
easily see how it works and it's a
simple algebraic function it needs less
training data so if you have smaller
amounts of data this is great powerful
tool for that handles both continuous
and discrete data it's highly scalable
with number of predictors and data
points so as you can see just keep
multiplying different probabilities in
there and you can cover not just three
different variables or sets you can now
expand this to even more categories
number five it's fast it can be used in
real time predictions this is so
important this is why it's used in a lot
of our predictions on online shopping
carts referrals spam filters is because
there's no time delay as it has to go
through and figure out a neural network
or one of the other mini setups where
you're doing classification and
certainly there's a lot of other tools
out there in the machine learning that
can handle these but most of them are
not as fast as the naive Bayes and then
finally it's not sensitive to irrelevant
features so it picks up on your
different probabilities and if you're
short on date on one probability you can
kind of it automatically adjust for that
those formulas are very automatic and so
you can still get a very solid
predictability even if you're missing
data or you have overlapping data for
two completely different areas we see
that a lot in doing census and studying
of people and habits where they might
have one study that covers one aspect
another one that overlaps and because
the two overlap they can then predict
the unknowns for the group that they
haven't done the second study on or vice
versa so it's very powerful in that it
is not sensitive to the irrelevant
features and in fact you can use it to
help predict features that aren't even
in there so now we're down to my
favorite part we're going to roll up our
sleeves and do some actual programming
we're going to do the use case text
classification now I would challenge you
to go back and send us a note on the
notes below underneath the video and
request the data for the shopping cart
so you can plug that into python code
and do that on your own time so you can
walk through it since we walk through
all the information on it but we're
going to do a python code doing text
classification very popular for doing
the naive Bayes so we're going to use
our new tool to perform a text
classification of news headlines and
classify news into different topics for
a News website as you can see here we
have a nice image of the Google news and
then related on the right subgroups I'm
not sure where they actually pulled the
actual data we're going to use from it's
one of the standard sets but certainly
this can be used on any of our news
headlines and classification so let's
see how it can be done using the naive
Bayes classifier now we're at my
favorite part we're actually going to
write some python script roll up our
sleeves and we're going to start by
doing our Imports these are very basic
Imports including our news group and
we'll take a quick glance at the Target
names then we're going to go ahead and
start training our data set and putting
it together we'll put together a nice
graph because it's always good to have a
graph to show what's going on and once
we've traded it and we've shown you a
graphical what's going on then we're
going to explore how to use it and see
what that looks like now I'm going to
open up my favorite editor or inline
editor for python you don't have to use
this you can use whatever your editor
that you like whatever interface IDE you
want this just happens to be the
Anaconda Jupiter notebook and I'm going
to paste that first piece of code in
here so we can walk through it let's
make it a little bigger on the screen so
you have a nice view of what's going on
and we're using Python 3 in this case
3.5 so this would work in any of your 3x
if you have it set up correctly should
also work in a lot of the 2x you just
have to make sure all of the versions of
the modules match your python version
and in here you'll notice the first line
is your percentage matplot library in
line now three of these lines of code
are all about plotting the graph this
one lets the notebook notes and this is
an inline setup that we want the graphs
to show up on this page without it in a
notebook like this which is an Explorer
interface it won't show up now a lot of
Ides don't require that a lot of them
like on if I'm working on one of my
other setups it just has a pop-up and
the graph pops up on there so you have a
that set up also but for this we want
the matplot library in line and then
we're going to import numpy as NP that's
number python which has a lot of
different formulas in it that we use for
both of our sklearn module and we also
use it for any of the upper math
functions in Python and it's very common
to see that as NP numpy is NP the next
two lines are all about our graphing
remember I said three of these were
about graphing well we need our matplot
library.pi plot as PLT and you'll see
that PLT is a very common setup as is
the SNS and just like the NP and we're
going to import Seaborn as S and S and
we're going to do the sns.set now
Seaborn sits on top of Pi plot and it
just makes a really nice heat map it's
really good for heat maps and if you're
not familiar with heat maps that just
means we give it a color scale term
comes from the brighter red it is the
hotter it is in some form of data and
you can set it to whatever you want and
we'll see that later on so those you'll
see that those three lines of code here
are just importing the graph function so
we can graph it and as a data science
test you always want to graph your data
and have some kind of visual it's really
hard just to shove numbers in front of
people and they look at it and it
doesn't mean anything and then from the
sklearn.datasets we're going to import
the fetch 20 news groups very common one
for analyzing tokenizing words and
setting them up and exploring how the
words work and how do you categorize
different things when you're dealing
with documents and then we set our data
equal to fetch 20 news groups so our
data variable will have the data in it
and we're going to go ahead and just
print the target names data.target names
and let's see what that looks like and
you'll see here we have alt atheism comp
Graphics comp osms windows.miscellaneous
and it goes all the way down to talk
politics.miscellaneous talk
religion.missella genius these are the
categories we've already assigned to
this news group and it's called fetch20
because you'll see there's I believe
there's 20 different topics in here or
20 different categories as we scroll
down now we've gone through the 20
different categories and we're going to
go ahead and start defining all the
categories and set up our data so we're
actually going to here going to go ahead
and get it get the data all set up and
take a look at our data and let's move
this over to our Jupiter notebook and
let's see what this code does
first we're going to set our categories
now if you noticed up here I could have
just as easily set this equal to
data.target underscore names because
it's the same thing but we want to kind
of spell it out for you so you can see
the different categories it kind of
makes it more visual so you can see what
your data is looking like in the
background once we've created the
categories
we're going to open up a train set so
this training set of data is going to go
into fetch 20 news groups and it's a
subset in there called train and
categories equals categories so we're
pulling out those categories that match
and then if you have a train set you
should also have the testing set we have
test equals fetch 20 News Group subset
equals test and categories equals
categories let's go down one size so it
all fits on my screen there we go and
just so we can really see what's going
on let's see what happens when we print
out one part of that data so it creates
train and under train it creates
train.data and we're just going to look
at data piece number five and let's go
ahead and run that and see what that
looks like and you can see when I print
train dot data number five under train
it prints out one of the Articles this
is article number five you can go
through and read it on there and we can
also go in here and change this to test
which should look identical because it's
splitting the data up into different
groups train and test and we'll see test
number 5 is a different article but it's
another article in here and maybe you're
curious and you want to see just how
many articles are in here we could do
Links of train dot data and if we run
that you'll see that the training data
has 11
314 articles so we're not going to go
through all those articles that's a lot
of articles but we can look at one of
them just you can see what kind of
information is coming out of it and what
we're looking at and we'll just look at
number five for today and here we have
it rewarding the Second Amendment IDs
vtt line 58 lines 58 in article
Etc I'm going to scroll all the way down
and see all the different parts to there
now we've looked at it and that's pretty
complicated when you look at one of
these articles to try to figure out how
do you weight this if you look down here
we have different words and maybe the
word from well from is probably in all
the Articles so it's not going to have a
lot of meaning as far as trying to
figure out whether this article fits one
of the categories or not so trying to
figure out which category it fits in
based on these words is where the
challenge comes in now that we've viewed
our data we're going to dive in and do
the actual predictions this is the
actual naive Bayes and we're going to
throw another model at you or another
module at you here in just a second we
can't go into too much detail but it
deals specifically working with words
and text and what they call tokenizing
those words so let's take this code and
let's uh skip on over to our Jupiter
notebook and walk through it and here we
are in our jupyter notebook let's paste
that in there and I can run this code
right off the bat it's not actually
going to display anything yet but it has
a lot going on in here so the top we
have the print module from the earlier
one I didn't know why that was in there
so we're going to start by importing our
necessary packages and from the sklearn
features extraction dot text we're going
to import TF IDF vectorizer I told you
we're going to throw a module at you we
can't go too much into the math behind
this or how it works you can look it up
the notation for the math is usually
tf.idf
and that's just a way of weighing the
words and it weighs the words based on
how many times are used in a document
how many times or how many documents are
used in and it's a well used formula
it's been around for a while it's a
little confusing to put this in here but
let's let them know that it just goes in
there and waits the different words in
the document for us that way we don't
have to wait and if you put a weight on
it if you remember I was talking about
that up here earlier if these are all
emails they probably all have the word
from in them from probably has a very
low weight it has very little value in
telling you what this document's about
same with words like in an article in
articles in cost of on maybe cost might
or where words like criminal weapons
destruction these might have a heavier
weight because we describe a little bit
more what the article's doing well how
do you figure out all those weights in
the different articles that's what this
module does that's what the TF IDF
vectorizer is going to do for us and
then we're going to import our
sklearn.naive Bays and that's our
multinomial in B multinomial naive base
pretty easy to understand that where
that comes from and then finally we have
the skylearn pipeline import make
pipeline now the make pipeline is just a
cool piece of code because we're going
to take the information we get from the
TF IDF vectorizer and we're going to
pump that into the multinomial in B so a
pipeline is just a way of organizing how
things flow it's used commonly you
probably already guess what it is if
you've done any businesses they talk
about the sales pipeline if you're on a
work crew or project manager you have
your pipeline of information that's
going through or your projects and what
has to be done in what order that's all
this pipeline is we're going to take the
tfid vectorizer and then we're going to
push that into the multinomial NB now
we've designated that as the variable
model we have our pipeline model and
we're going to take that model and this
is just so elegant this is done in just
a couple lines of code model dot fit and
we're going to fit the data and first
the train data and then the train Target
now the train data has the different
articles in it you can see the one we
were just looking at and the train dot
Target is what category they already
categorized that that particular article
is and what's Happening Here is the
trained data is going into the tfid
vectorizer so when you have one of these
articles it goes in there it waits all
the words in there so there's thousands
of words with different weights on them
I remember once running a model on this
and I literally had 2.4 million tokens
go into this so when you're dealing like
large document bases you can have a huge
number of different words it then takes
those words gives them a weight and then
based on that weight based on the words
and the weights and then puts that into
the multinomial in B and once we go into
our naive Bayes we want to put the train
Target in there so the train data that's
been mapped to the tfid vectorizer is
now going through the multinomial in B
and then we're telling it well these are
the answers these are the answers to the
different documents so this document
that has all these words with these
different weights from the first part is
going to be whatever category it comes
out of maybe it's the talk show or the
article on religion miscellaneous once
we fit that model we can then take
labels and we're going to set that equal
to model.predict most of the sklearn use
the term dot predict to let us know that
we've now trained the model and now we
want to get some answers and we're going
to put our test data in there because
our test data is the stuff we held off
to the side we didn't train it on there
and we don't know what's going to come
up out of it and we just want to find
out how good our labels are do they
match what they should be now I've
already read this through there's no
actual output to it to show this is just
setting it all up this is just training
our model creating the labels so we can
see how good it is and then we move on
to the next step to find out what
happened to do this we're going to go
ahead and create a confusion Matrix and
a heat map so the confusion Matrix which
is confusing just by its very name is
basically going to ask how confused is
our answer did it get it correct or did
it Miss some things in there or have
some missed labels and then we're going
to put that on a heat map so we'll have
some nice colors to look at to see how
that plots out let's go ahead and take
this code and see how that take a walk
through it and see what that looks like
so back to our jupyter notebook I'm
going to put the code in there and let's
go ahead and run that code take it just
a moment and remember we had the inline
that way my graph shows up on the inline
here and let's walk through the code and
then we'll look at this and see what
that means so make it a little bit
bigger there we go no reason not to use
the whole screen too big so we have here
from sklearnmetrics import confusion
Matrix
and that's just going to generate a set
of data that says I the prediction was
such the actual truth was either agreed
with it or is something different and
it's going to add up those numbers so we
can take a look and just see how well it
worked and we're going to set a variable
matte equal to confusion Matrix and we
have our test Target our test data that
was not part of the training very
important in data science we always keep
our test data separate otherwise it's
not a valid model if we can't properly
test it with new data and this is the
labels we created from that test data
these are the ones that we predict it's
going to be so we go in we create our SN
heat map the SNS is our Seaborn which
sits on top of the pi plot so we create
a sns.heat map we take our confusion
Matrix and it's going to be
met.t and do we have other variables
that go into the sns.heat map we're not
going to go into detail what all the
variables mean The annotation equals
true that's what tells it to put the
numbers here so you have the 166 the one
the zero zero zero one format d and c
bar equals false have to do with the
format if you take those out you'll see
that some things disappear and then the
X tick labels and the y t labels those
are our Target names and you can see
right here that's the alt atheism comp
graphics composms windows.miscellaneous
and then finally we have our plt.x label
remember the SNS or the Seaborn sits on
top of our matplot library our PLT and
so we want to just tell that X label
equals a true is is true the labels are
true and then the Y label is prediction
label so when we say a true this is what
it actually is and the prediction is
what we predicted and let's look at this
graph because that's probably a little
confusing the way we rattled through it
and what I'm going to do is I'm going to
go ahead and flip back to the slides
because they have a black background
they put in there that helps it shine a
little bit better so you can see the
graph a little bit easier so in reading
this graph what we want to look at is
how the color scheme has come out and
you'll see a line right down the middle
diagonally from upper left to bottom
right what that is is if you look at the
labels we have our predicted label on
the the left and our true label on the
right those are the numbers where the
prediction and the true come together
and this is what we want to see is we
want to see those lit up that's what
that heat map does is you can see that
it did a good job of finding those data
and you'll notice that there's a couple
of red spots on there where it missed
you know it's a little confused we talk
about talk religion miscellaneous versus
talk politics miscellaneous social
religion Christian versus Alt atheism it
mislabeled some of those and those are
very similar topics you could understand
why it might mislabel them but overall
it did a pretty good job if we're going
to create these models we want to go
ahead and be able to use them so let's
see what that looks like to do this
let's go ahead and create a definition a
function to run and we're going to call
this function let me just expand that
just a notch here there we go I like
mine in big letters predict categories
we want to predict the category we're
going to send it as a string and then
we're sending it train equals train we
have our training model and then we had
our pipeline model equals model this way
we don't have to resend these variables
each time the definition knows that
because I said train equals train and I
put the equal for model and then we're
going to set the prediction equal to the
model dot predict s so it's going to
send whatever string we send to it it's
going to push that string through the
pipeline the model pipeline it's going
to go through and tokenize it and put it
through the TF IDF convert that into
numbers and weights for all the
different documents and words and then
I'll put that through our naive Bayes
and from it we'll go ahead and get our
prediction we're going to predict what
value it is and so we're going to return
train.target namespredict of zero and
remember that the train.target names
that's just categories I could have just
as easily put categories in there dot
predict of zero so we're taking the
prediction which is a number and we're
converting it to an actual category
we're converting it from I don't know
what the actual number numbers are let's
say 0 equals alt atheism so we're going
to convert that 0 to the word or one
maybe it equals comp Graphics so we're
going to convert number one into comp
Graphics that's all that is and then we
got to go ahead and and then we need to
go ahead and run this so I load that up
and then once I run that we can start
doing some predictions I'm going to go
ahead and type in predict category and
let's just do the predict category Jesus
Christ and it comes back and says it's
social religion Christian that's pretty
good now note I didn't put print on this
one of the nice things about the Jupiter
notebook editor and a lot of inline
editors is if you just put the name of
the variable out as returning the
variable train.target underscore names
it'll automatically print that for you
in your own IDE you might have to put in
print let's see where else we can take
this and maybe you're a space science
buff so how about sending load to
International
Space Station
and if we run that we get science space
or maybe you're a automobile buff and
let's do um oh they were going to tell
me Audi is better than BMW but I'm going
to do BMW is better than an Audi so
maybe you're a car buff and we run that
and you'll see it says recreational I'm
assuming that's what Rec stands for
Autos so I did a pretty good job
labeling that one how about uh if we
have something like a caption running
through there president of India and if
we run that it comes up and says talk
politics miscellaneous
so when we take our definition or our
function and we run all these things
through Kudos we made it we were able to
correctly classify text into different
groups based on which category they
belong to using the naive Bayes
classifier now we did throw in the
pipeline the TF IDF vectorizer we threw
in the graphs those are all things that
you don't necessarily have to know to
understand the naive Bayes setup or
classifier but they're important to know
one of the main uses for the naive Bays
is with the TF IDF tokenizer vectorizer
where it tokenizes the word and has
labels and we use the pipeline because
you need to push all that data through
and it makes it really easy and fast you
don't have to know those to understand
naive Bayes but they certainly help for
understanding the industry in data
science and we can see their categorizer
our naive Bayes classifier we were able
to predict the category religion space
motorcycles Autos politics and properly
classify all these different things we
pushed into our prediction and our
trained model if you are an aspiring
machine learning engineer looking for
online training and certifications from
prestigious universities and in
collaboration with leading experts then
search no more simple lens professional
certification program in Ai and machine
learning from Purdue University in
collaboration with IBM should be a right
choice for more details use the link in
the description box below with that in
mind
so what is cayman's clustering k-means
clustering is an unsupervised learning
algorithm in this case you don't have
labeled data unlike in supervised
learning so you have a set of data and
you want to group them and as the name
suggests you want to put them into
clusters which means objects that are
similar in nature similar in
characteristics need to be put together
so that's what K means clustering is all
about the term k is basically is a
number so we need to tell the system how
many clusters we need to perform so if K
is equal to 2 there will be two clusters
if K is equal to 3 3 clusters and so on
and so forth that's what the k stands
for and of course there is a way of
finding out what is the best or Optimum
value of K for a given data we will look
at that so that is K means cluster so
let's take an example K means clustering
is used in many many scenario use but
let's take an example of Cricket the
game of cricket let's say you received
data of a lot of players from maybe all
over the country or all over the world
and this data has information about the
runs scored by the people or by the
player and the wickets taken by the
player and based on this information we
need to Cluster this data into two
clusters batsman and Bowlers so this is
an interesting example let's see how we
can perform this so we have the data
which consists of primarily two
characteristics which is the runs and
the wickets so the bowlers basically
take wickets and the batsman score runs
there will be of course a few Bowlers
who can score some runs and similarly
there will be some batsmen who will Who
would have taken a few wickets but with
this information we want to Cluster
those players into batsmen and Ballers
so how does this work let's say this is
how the data is so there are information
there is information on the y-axis about
the runs code and on the x-axis about
the wickets taken by the players so if
we do a quick plot this is how it would
look and when we do the clustering we
need to have the Clusters like shown in
the third diagram out here so we need to
have a cluster which consists of people
who have scored High runs which is
basically the batsman and then we need a
cluster with people who have taken a lot
of wickets which is typically the
bowlers there may be a certain amount of
overlap but we will not talk about it
right now so with cayman's clustering we
will have here that that means K is
equal to 2 and we will have two clusters
which is batsman and Bowlers so how does
this work the way it works is the first
step in k-means clustering is the
allocation of two centroids randomly so
two points are assigned as so-called
centroids so in this case we want two
clusters which means K is equal to two
so two points have been randomly
assigned as centroids keep in mind these
points can be anywhere there are random
points they are not initially they are
not really the centroids centroid means
it's a central point of a given data set
but in this case when it starts off it's
not really the centroid okay so these
points though in our presentation here
we have shown them one point closer to
these data points and another closer to
these data points they can be assigned
randomly anywhere okay
so that's the first step the next step
is to determine the distance of each of
the data points from each of the
randomly assigned centroids so for
example we take this point and find the
distance from this centroid and the
distance from this center right this
point is taken and the distance is
formed from this centroid and the center
and so on and so forth so for every
point the distance is measured from both
the centroids and then whichever
distance is less that point is assigned
to that centroid so for example in this
case visually it is very obvious that
all these data points are assigned to
this centroid and all these data points
are assigned to this centroid and that's
what is represented here in blue color
and in this yellow color the next step
is to actually determine the central
point or the actual centroid for these
two clusters so we have this one initial
class faster this one initial cluster
but as you can see these points are not
really the centroid centroid means it
should be the central position of this
data set Central position of this data
set so that is what needs to be
determined as the next step so the
central point of the actual centroid is
determined and the original randomly
allocated centroid is repositioned to
the actual centroid of this new clusters
and this process is actually repeated
now what might happen is some of these
points may get reallocated in our
example that is not happening probably
but it may so happen that the distance
is found between each of these data
points once again with these centroids
and if there is if it is required some
points may be reallocated we will see
that in a later example but for now we
will keep it simple so this process is
continued till the centroid
repositioning stops and that is our our
final cluster so this is our so after
iteration we come to this position this
situation where the centroid doesn't
need any more repositioning and that
means our algorithm has converged
convergence has occurred and we have the
cluster two clusters we have the
Clusters with a centroid so this process
is repeated the process of calculating
the distance and repositioning the
centroid is repeated till the
repositioning stops which means that the
algorithm has converged and we have the
final cluster with the data points and
the centroids so this is what you're
going to learn from this session we will
talk about the types of clustering what
is k-means clustering application of
k-means clustering k-means clustering is
done using distance measure so we will
talk about the common distance measures
and then we will talk about how k-min's
clustering works and go into the details
of K Mains clustering algorithm and then
we will end with the demo and a use case
for k-means clustering so let's begin
first of all what are the types of
clustering there are primarily two
categories of clustering hierarchical
clustering and then partitional
clustering and each of these categories
are further subdivided into
agglomerative and divisive clustering
and k-means and fuzzy c means clustering
let's take a quick look at what each of
these types of clustering are
in hierarchical clustering the Clusters
have a tree-like structure and
hierarchical clustering is further
divided into agglomerative and divisive
agglomerative clustering is the
bottom-up approach we begin with each
element as a separate cluster and merge
them into successively larger clusters
so for example we have a b c d e f which
start by combining BMC form one cluster
DNA form one more then we combine d e
and f one more bigger cluster and then
add BC to that and then finally a to it
compared to that divisive clustering or
divisive clustering is a top-down
approach we begin with the whole set and
proceed to divide it into successively
smaller clusters so we have ABCDEF we
first take that as a single cluster and
then break it down
A B C D E and F then we have partitional
clustering split into two subtypes
k-means clustering and fuzzy c means in
k-min's clustering the objects are
divided into the number of clusters
mentioned by the number K that's where
the K comes from so if we say k is equal
to 2 the objects are divided into two
clusters C1 and C2 and the way it is
done is the features or characteristics
are compared and all objects having
similar characteristics are clubbed
together so that's how K means
clustering is done we will see it in
more detail as we move forward and fuzzy
c means is very similar to k-means in
the sense that it clubs objects that
have similar characteristics together
but while in k-means clustering two
objects cannot belong to or any object a
single object cannot belong to two
different clusters in c means objects
can belong to more than one cluster so
that is the primary difference between
k-means and fuzzy c means so what are
some of the applications of k-means
clustering k-means clustering is used in
a variety of examples or variety of
business cases in real life starting
from academic performance diagnostic
systems search engines and wireless
sensor networks and many more so let us
take a little deeper look at each of
these examples academic performance So
based on the scores of the students
students are categorized into a b c and
so on clustering forms a backbone of
search engines when a search is
performed the search results need to be
grouped together the search engines very
often use clustering to do this and
similarly in case of wireless sensor
networks the clustering algorithm plays
the role of finding the cluster heads
which collects all the data in its
respective cluster so clustering
especially k-means clustering uses
distance measure so let's take a look at
what is distance pressure so while these
are the different types of clustering in
this video we will focus on k-means
clustering so distance measure tells how
similar some objects are so the
similarity is measured using what is
known as distance measure and what are
the various types of distance measures
there is euclidean distance there is
Manhattan distance then we have squared
euclidean distance measure and cosine
distance measure these are some of the
distance measures supported by k-means
clustering let's take a look at each of
these what is euclidean distance measure
this is nothing but the distance between
two points so we have learned in high
school how to find the distance between
two points this is a little
sophisticated formula for that but we
know a simpler one is square root of Y2
minus y1 whole square plus x 2 minus X1
whole Square so this is an extension of
that formula so that is the euclidean
distance between two points what is the
squared euclidean distance measure it's
nothing but the square of the euclidean
distance as the name suggests so instead
of taking the square root we leave the
square as it is and then we have
Manhattan distance measure in case of
Manhattan distance it is the sum of the
distances across the x-axis and the
y-axis and note that we are taking the
absolute value so that the negative
values don't come into play so that is
the Manhattan distance measure then we
have cosine distance measure in this
case we take the angle between the two
vectors formed by joining the points
from the origin so that is the cosine
distance measure okay so that was a
quick overview about the various
distance measures that are supported by
k-means now let's go and check how
exactly k-means clustering works okay so
this is how k-mains clustering works
this is like a flowchart of the whole
process there is a starting point and
then we specify the number of clusters
that we want now there are a couple of
ways of doing this we can do by trial
and error so we specify a certain number
maybe K is equal to 3 or 4 or 5 to start
with and then as we progress we keep
changing until we get the best clusters
or there is a technique called elbow
technique whereby we can determine the
value of K what should be the best value
of K how many clusters should be formed
so once we have the value of K we
specify that and then the system will
assign that many centroid so it picks
randomly that to start with randomly
that many points that are considered to
be the centroids of this clusters and
then it measures the distance of each of
the data points from these centroids and
assigns those points to the
corresponding centroid from which the
distance is minimum so each data point
will be assigned to the centroid Which
is closest to it and thereby we have K
number of initial clusters however this
is not the final clusters The Next Step
it does is for the new groups for the
Clusters that have been formed it
calculates the main position thereby
calculates the new centroid position the
position of the centroid moves compared
to the randomly allocated one so it's an
iterative process once again the
distance of each point is measured from
this new centroid point and if required
the data points are reallocated to the
new centroids and the mean position or
the new centroid is calculated once
again if the centroid moves then the
iteration continues which means the
convergence has not happened the
clustering has not converged so as long
as there is a movement of the centroid
this iteration keeps happening but once
the centroid stops moving which means
that the cluster has converged or the
clustering process has converged that
will be the end result so now we have
the final position of the centroid and
the data points are allocated
accordingly to the closest centroid I
know it's a little difficult to
understand from this simple flowchart so
let's do a little bit of visualization
and see if we can explain it better
let's take an example if we have a data
set for a grocery shop so let's say we
have a data set for a grocery shop and
now we want to find out how many
clusters this has to be spread across so
how do we find the optimum number of
clusters there is a technique called the
elbow method so when these clusters are
formed there is a parameter called
within sum of squares at the lower this
value is the better the cluster is that
means all these points are very close to
each other so we use this within sum of
squares as a measure to find the optimum
number of clusters that can be formed
for a given data set so we create
clusters or we let the system create
clusters of a variety of numbers maybe
of 10 10 clusters and for each value of
K the within SS is measured and the
value of K which has the least amount of
within SS or WSS that's taken as the
optimum value of K so this is the
diagrammatic representation so we have
on the y-axis the within sum of squares
or WSS and on the x-axis we have the
number of clusters so as you can imagine
if you have K is equal to 1 which means
all the data points are in a single
cluster the witnesses value will be very
high because they are probably scattered
all over the moment you split it into
two there will be a drastic fall in the
Within ss1 that's what is represented
here but then as the value of K
increases the decrease the rate of
decrease will not be so high it will
continue to decrease but probably the
rate of decrease will not be high so
that gives us an idea so from here we
get an idea for example the optimum
value of K should be either 2 or 3 or at
the most 4 but beyond that increasing
the number of clusters is not
dramatically changing the value in WSS
because that pretty much gets stabilized
okay now that we have got the value of K
and let's assume that these are our
delivery points the next step is
basically to assign two centroids
randomly so let's say C1 and C2 are the
centroids assigned randomly now the
distance of each location from the
centroid is measured and each point is
assigned to the centroid Which is
closest to it so for example these
points are very obvious that these are
closest to C1 whereas this point is far
away from C2 so these points will be
assigned which are close to C1 will be
assigned to C1 and these points or
locations which are close to C2 will be
assigned to C2 and then so this is the
how the initial grouping is done this is
part of C1 and this is part of C2 then
the next step is to calculate the actual
centroid of this data because remember
C1 and C2 are not the centroids they've
been randomly assigned points and only
thing that has been done was the data
points which are closest to them have
been assigned but now in this step the
actual centroid will be calculated which
may be for each of these data sets
somewhere in the middle so that's like
the main point that will be calculated
and the centroid will actually be
positioned or repositioned there
same with C2
so the new centroid for this group is C2
in this new position and C1 is in this
new position once again the distance of
each of the data points is calculated
from these centroids now remember it's
not necessary that the distance Still
Remains the or each of these data points
still remain in the same group by
recalculating the distance it may be
possible that some points get
reallocated like so you see this so this
point earlier was closer to C2 because
C2 was here but after recalculating
repositioning it is observed that this
is closer to C1 than C2 so this is the
new grouping so some points will be
reassigned and again the centroid will
be calculated and if the centroid
doesn't change so that is the repetitive
process iterative process and if the
centroid doesn't change once the
centroid stops changing that means the
algorithm has converged and this is our
final cluster with this as the centroid
C1 and C2 as the centroids these days
data points as a part of each cluster so
I hope this helps in understanding the
whole process iterative process of K
means clustering so let's take a look at
the K means clustering algorithm let's
say we have X1 X2 X3 n number of points
as our inputs and we want to split this
into K clusters or we want to create K
clusters so the first step is to
randomly pick K points and call them
centroids they are not real centroids
because centroid is supposed to be a
center point but they are just called
centroids and we calculate the distance
of each and every input point from each
of the centroids so the distance of X1
from C1 from C2 C3 each of the distances
we calculate and then find out which
distance is the lowest and assign X1 to
that particular random centroid repeat
that process for X2 calculate its
distance from each of the centroid c 1 C
to C3 up to c k a and find which is the
lowest distance and assign X2 to that
particular centroid same with X3 and so
on so that is the first round of
assignment that is done now we have K
groups because there are we have
assigned the value of K so there are K
centroids and so there are K groups all
these inputs have been split into K
groups however remember we picked the
centroids randomly so they are not real
centroids so now what we have to do we
have to calculate the actual centroids
for each of these groups which is like
the mean position which means that the
position of the randomly selected
centroids will now change and they will
be the main positions of this newly
formed K groups and once that is done we
once again repeat this process of
calculating the distance right so this
is what we are doing as the part of Step
4 we repeat step two and three so we
again calculate the distance of X1 from
the centroid C1 C2 C3 and then C which
is the lowest value and assign X1 to
that calculate the distance of X2 from
C1 C to C3 or whatever up to c k and
find whichever is the lowest distance
and assign X2 to that centroid and so on
in this process there may be some
reassignment X1 Pro was probably
assigned to Cluster C2 and after doing
this calculation maybe now X1 is
assigned to C1 so that kind of
reallocation may happen so we repeat the
steps 2 and 3 till the position of the
centroids don't change or stop changing
and that's when we have convergence so
let's take a detailed look at each of
these steps so we randomly pick K
cluster centers we call them centroids
because they are not initially they are
not really the centroids so we let us
name them C1 C2 up to CK and then step
two we assign each data point to the
closest Center so what we do we
calculate the distance of each x value
from each C value so the distance
between X1 C1 distance between X1 C2 X1
C3 and then we find which is the lowest
value right that's the minimum value we
find and assign X1 to that particular
centroid then we go next to X2 find the
distance of X2 from C1 X2 from C2 X2
from C3 and so on up to c k and then
assign it to the point or to the
centroid which has the lowest value and
so on so that is Step number two in Step
number three We Now find the actual
centroid for each group so what has
happened as a part of Step number two we
now have all the points all the data
points grouped into K groups because we
we wanted to create K clusters right so
we have K groups each one may be having
a certain number of input values they
need not be equally distributed by the
way based on the distance we will have K
groups but remember the initial values
of the C1 C2 were not really the
centroids of these groups right we
assign them randomly so now in step 3 we
actually calculate the centroid of each
group which means the original point
which we thought was the centroid will
shift to the new position which is the
actual centroid for each of these groups
okay and we again calculate the distance
so we go back to step 2 which is what we
calculate again the distance of each of
these points from the newly positioned
centroids and if required we reassign
these points to the new centroids so as
I said earlier there may be a
reallocation so we now have a new set or
a new group we still have K groups but
the number of items and the actual
assignment may be different from what
was in Step 2 here okay so that might
change then we perform step 3 once again
to find the new centroid of this new
group so we have again a new set of
clusters new centroids and new
assignments we repeat this step two
again once again we find and then it is
possible that after iterating through
three or four or five times the centroid
will stop moving in the sense that when
you calculate the new value of the
centroid that will be same as the
original value or there will be very
marginal change so that is when we say
convergence has occurred and that is our
final cluster that's the formation of
the final cluster all right so let's see
a couple of demos of k-means clustering
we will actually see some live demos and
python notebook using python notebook
but before that let's find out what's
the problem that we are trying to solve
the problem statement is let's say
Walmart wants to open a chain of stores
across the State of Florida
and it wants to find the optimal store
locations now the issue here is if they
open too many stores close to each other
obviously the they will not make profit
but if they if the stores are too far
apart then they will not have enough
sales so how do they optimize this now
for an organization like Walmart which
is an e-commerce giant they already have
the addresses of their customers in
their database so they can actually use
this information or this data and use
k-means cluster to find the optimal
location now before we go into the
python notebook and show you the Live
code I wanted to take you through very
quickly a summary of the code in the
slides and then we will go into the
python notebook so in this block we are
basically importing all the required
libraries like numpy matplotlab and so
on and we are loading the data that is
available in the form of let's say the
addresses for simplicity's sake we will
just take them as some data points then
the next thing we do is quickly do a
scatter plot to see how they are related
to each other with respect to each other
so in the scatter plot we see that there
are a few distinct groups already being
formed so you can actually get an idea
about how the cluster would look and how
many clusters what is the optimal number
of clusters and then starts the actual
k-means clustering process so we will
assign each of these points to the
centroids and then check whether they
are the optimal distance which is the
shortest distance and assign each of the
points data points to the centroids and
then go through this iterative process
till the whole process converges and
finally we get an output like this so we
have four distinct clusters and which is
if we can say that this is how the
population is probably distributed
across Florida State and the centroids
are like the location where the store
should be the optimum location where the
store should be so that's the way we
determine the best locations for the
store and that's how we can help Walmart
find the best locations for the stores
in Florida area so now let's take this
into python notebook let's see how this
looks when we are learning running the
code live all right so this is the code
for k-means clustering in jupyter
Notebook we have a few examples here
which we will demonstrate how k-means
clustering is used and even there is a
small implementation of k-means
clustering as well okay so let's get
started okay so this block is basically
importing the various libraries that are
required like matplotlib and numpy and
so on and so forth which would be used
as a part of the code then we are going
and creating blobs which are similar to
clusters now this is a very neat feature
which is available in scikit-learn make
blobs is a nice feature which creates
clusters of data sets so that's a
wonderful functionality that is readily
available for us to create some test
data kind of thing
so that's exactly what we are doing here
we are using make blobs and we can
specify how many clusters we want so
centers we are mentioning here so it
will go ahead and so we just mentioned
four so it will go ahead and create some
test data for us
and this is how it looks as you can see
visually also we can figure out that
there are four distinct classes or
clusters in this data set and that is
what make blobs actually provides now
from here onwards we will basically run
the standard k-means functionality that
is readily available so we really don't
have to implement k-means itself the
k-means functionality or the function is
readily available you just need to feed
the data and we'll create the Clusters
so this is the code for that we import
k-means and then we create an instance
of k-means and we specify the value of K
this n underscore clusters is the value
of K remember K means in K means K is
basically the number of clusters that
you want to create and it is a integer
value so this is where we are specifying
that so we have K is equal to 4. and so
that instance is created we take that
instance and as with any other machine
learning functionality fit is what we
use the function or the method rather
fit is what we use to train the model
here there is no real training kind of
thing but that's the call okay so we are
calling fit and what we are doing here
we are just passing the data so X has
these values the data that has been
created right so that is what we are
passing here and this will go ahead and
create the Clusters and then we are
using
after doing uh fit We Run The predict
which basically assigns for each of
these observations which cluster it
belongs to all right so it will name the
Clusters maybe this is cluster one this
is two three and so on or I will
actually start from 0 cluster 0 1 2 and
3 maybe and then for each of the
observations it will assign based on
which cluster it belongs to it will
assign a value so that is stored in y
underscore K means when we call predict
that is what it does and we can take a
quick look at these y underscore K means
all with the cluster numbers that have
been assigned for each observation so
this is the cluster number assigned for
observation one maybe this is for
observation two observation three and so
on so we have how many about I think 300
samples right so all the 300 samples
there are 300 values here each of them
the cluster number is given and the
cluster number goes from 0 to 3 so there
are four clusters so the numbers go from
0 1 2 3 so that's what is seen here okay
now so this was a quick example of
generating some dummy data and then
clustering that okay and this can be
applied if you have proper data you can
just load it up into X for example here
and then run the game so this is the
central part of the k-means clustering
program example so you basically create
an instance and and you mentioned how
many clusters you want by specifying
this parameter and underscore clusters
and that is also the value of K and then
pass the data to get the values now the
next section of this code is the
implementation of a k means now this is
kind of a rough implementation of the
k-means algorithm so we will just walk
you through I will walk you through the
code at each step what it is doing and
then we will see a couple of more
examples of how k-means clustering can
be used in maybe some real life examples
real life use cases all right so in this
case here what we are doing is basically
implementing k-means clustering and
there is a function for a library it
calculates for a given two pairs of
points it will calculate the the
distance between them and see which one
is the closest and so on so this is like
this is pretty much like what k-means
does right so it calculates the distance
of each point or each data set from
predefined centroid and then based on
whichever is the lowest this particular
data point is assigned to that percent
right so that is basically available as
a standard function and we will be using
that here so as explained in the slides
the first step that is done in case of
k-means clustering is to randomly assign
some centroids so as a first step we
randomly allocate a couple of centroids
which we call here we are calling a
centers
and then we put this in a loop and we
take it through an iterative process
for each of the data points we first
find out using this function pairwise
distance argument for each of the points
we find out which one which Center or
which randomly selected centroid is the
closest and accordingly we assign that
data or the data point to that
particular centroid or class staff and
once that is done for all the data
points we calculate the new centroid by
finding out the mean position with the
center position right so we calculate
the new centroid and then we check if
the new centroid is the coordinates or
the position is the same as the previous
centroid the positions we will compare
and if it is the same that means the
process has converged so remember we do
this process till the centroids or that
centroid doesn't move anymore right so
the centroid gets relocated each time
this reallocation is done so the moment
it doesn't change anymore the position
of the centroid doesn't change anymore
we know that convergence has occurred so
till then so you see here this is like
an infinite Loop while true is an
infinite Loop it only breaks when the
centers are the same the new center and
the old Center positions are the same
and once that is done we return the
centers and the labels now of course as
explained this is not a very
sophisticated and advanced
implementation very basic implementation
because one of the flaws in this is that
sometimes what happens is the centroid
the position will keep moving but in if
the change will be very minor so in that
case also with that is actually
convergence right so for example the
change is 0.0001 we can consider that as
convergence otherwise what will happen
is this will either take forever or it
will be never ending so that's small
flaw here so that is something
additional checks may have to be added
here but again as mentioned this is not
the most sophisticated implementation
this is like a kind of a rough
implementation of the k-means cluster
ing okay so if we execute this code this
is what we get as the output so this is
the definition of this particular
function and then we call that find
underscore clusters and we pass our data
X and the number of clusters which is 4
and if we run that and plot it this is
the output that we get so this is of
course each cluster is represented by a
different color so we have a cluster in
green color yellow color and so on and
so forth and these big points here these
are the centroids this is the final
position of the centroids and as you can
see visually also this appears like a
kind of a center of all these points
here right similarly this is like the
center of all these points here and so
on so this is the example or this is an
example of a implementation of K means
clustering and and next we will move on
to see a couple of examples of how
k-means clustering is used in maybe some
real life scenarios or use cases in the
next example or demo we are going to see
how we can use k-means clustering to
perform color compression we will take a
couple of images so there will be two
examples and we will try to use cayman's
clustering to compress the colors this
is a common situation in image
processing when you have an image with
millions of colors but then you cannot
render it on some devices which may not
have enough memory so that is the
scenario where where something like this
can be used so before again we go into
the python notebook let's take a look at
quickly the the code as usual we import
the libraries and then we import the
image and then we will flatten it so the
reshaping is basically we have the image
information stored in the form of pixels
and if the images like for example 427
by 640 and it has three colors so that's
the overall dimension of the of the
initial image we just reshape it and
then feed this to our algorithm and this
will then create clusters of only 16
clusters so this this colors there are
millions of colors and now we need to
bring it down to 16 colors so we use K
is equal to 16 and this is uh when we
visualize this is how it looks there are
these are all about 16 million possible
colors the input color space has 16
million possible colors and we just
sub compressor to 16 colors so this is
how it would look when we compress it to
16 colors and this is how the original
image looks and and after compression to
16 colors this is a the new image looks
as you can see there is not a lot of
information that has been lost though
the image quality is definitely reduced
a little bit
so this is an example which we are going
to now see in Python notebook let's go
into the python node and once again as
always we will import some libraries and
load this image called
flower.jpg okay so let me load that and
this is how it looks this is the
original image which has I think 16
million colors and this is the shape of
this image which is basically what is
the shape is nothing but the overall
size right so this is 427 pixel by 640
pixel and then there are three layers
which is this three basically is for RGB
which is red green blue so color image
will have that right so that is the
shape of this now what we need to do is
data let's take a look at how data is
looking so let me just create a new cell
and show you what is in data basically
we have captured this information
so data is what let me just show you
here
all right so let's take a look at China
what are the values in China and if we
see here this is how the data is stored
this is nothing but the pixel values
okay so this is like a matrix and each
one has about for for this 427 by 640
pixel side so this is how it looks now
the issue here is these values are large
the numbers are large so we need to
normalize them to between 0 and 1 right
so that's why we will basically create
one more variable which is data which
will contain the values between 0 and 1
and the way to do that is divide by 255
so we divide China by 255 and we get the
new values in data so let's just run
this piece of code and this is the shape
so we now have also yeah what we have
done is we changed using reshape we
converted into the three dimensional
into a two-dimensional data set and let
us also take a look at how
let me just insert
probably a cell here and take a look at
how data is looking all right so this is
how data is looking and now you see this
is the values are between 0 and 1 right
so if you earlier noticed in case of
china the values were large numbers now
everything is between 0 and 1. this is
one of the things we
all right so after that the next thing
that we need to do is to visualize this
and we can take random set of maybe 10
000 points and plot it and check and see
how this looks so let us just plot this
there so this is how the original the
color the pixel distribution is these
are two plots one is red against Green
and another is red against Blue and this
is the original distribution of the
color so then what we will do is we will
use k-means clustering to create just 16
clusters for the various colors and then
apply that to the image now what will
happen is since the data is large
because there are millions of colors
using regular k-means may be a little
time consuming so there is another
version of k-means which is called mini
batch came in so we will use that which
is which processes in the overall
concept Remains the Same but this
basically processes it in smaller
batches that's the only thing okay so
the results will pretty much be the same
so let's go ahead and execute this piece
of code and also visualize this so that
we can see that there are this this is
how the 16 colors would look so this is
red against Green and this is red
against Blue there is quite a bit of
similarity between this original color
schema and the new one right so it
doesn't look very very completely
different or anything like
now we apply this the newly created
colors to the image and we can take a
look how this is looking now we can
compare both the images so this is our
original image and this is our new image
so as you can see there is not a lot of
information that has been lost it pretty
much looks like the original image yes
we can see that for example here there
is a little bit it appears a little
talish compared to this one right
because we kind of took off some of the
finer details of the color but overall
the high level information has been
maintained at the same time the main
advantage is that now this can be this
is an image which can be rendered on a
device which may not be that very
sophisticated now let's take one more
example with a different image in the
second example we will take an image of
the Summer Palace in China and we repeat
the same process this this is a high
definition color image with millions of
colors and also three-dimensional
had now we will reduce that to 16 colors
using k-means clustering and we do the
same process like before we reshape it
and then we cluster the colors to 16 and
then we render the image once again and
we will see that the color the quality
of the image slightly deteriorates as
you can see here this has much finer
details in this which are probably
missing here but then that's the
compromise because there are some
devices which may not be able to handle
this kind of a high density images so
let's run this chord in Python notebook
all right so let's apply the same
technique for another picture which is
even more intricate and has probably
much complicated color schema so this is
the image now once again we can take a
look at the shape which is 427 by 640 by
3 and this is the new data would look
somewhat like this compared to the
flower image so we have some new values
here and we will also bring this as you
can see the numbers are much bigger so
we will much bigger so we will now have
to uh scale them down to values between
0 and 1 and that is done by dividing by
255 so let's go ahead and do that
and reshape it okay so we get a
two-dimensional Matrix and we will then
as a next step we will go ahead and
visualize this how it looks the the 16
colors and this is basically how it
would look 16 million colors and now we
can
create the Clusters out of this the 16
k-means clusters we will create so this
is how the distribution of the pixels
would look with 16 colors and then we go
ahead and apply this
and visualize how it is looking for with
the with the new just the 16 color so
once again as you can see this looks
much richer in color but at the same
time and this probably doesn't have as
we can see it doesn't look as rich as
this one but nevertheless the
information is not lost the shape and
all that stuff and this can be also
rendered on a slightly a device which is
probably not that sophisticated okay so
that's pretty much it so we have seen
two examples of how color compression
can be done using k-means clustering and
we have also seen in the previous
examples of how to implement k-means the
code to roughly how to implement k-means
clustering and we use some sample data
using blob to just execute the cayman's
clustering if you are an aspiring
machine learning engineer looking for
online training and certifications from
prestigious universities and in
collaboration with leading experts then
search Nomo simply learns professional
certification program in Ai and machine
learning from Purdue University in
collaboration with IBM should be a right
choice for more details use the link in
the description box below with that in
mind so let's go a little deeper into
hierarchical clustering let's consider
we have a set of cars and we have a
group similar we want to group similar
ones together so below we have you'll
see four different cars down there and
we get two clusters of card types sedan
and SUV so if you're just looking at it
you can probably think oh yeah we'll put
the sedans together and the SUVs
together and then at last we can group
everything into one cluster so we just
have just cars so you can see as we have
this we make a nice little tree this is
very common we see anybody talks about
hierarchical clustering this is usually
what you see and what comes out of it we
terminate when we are left with only one
cluster so we have as you can see we
bring them all together we have one
cluster we can't bring it together
anymore because they're all together
hierarchical clustering is separating
data into different groups based on some
measure of similarity so we have to find
a way to measure what makes them alike
and what makes them different
agglomerative clustering is known as a
bottom up approach remember I said think
of that as bringing things together so
you see I think the Latin term aglo is
together because you have your glomerate
rocks where all the different pieces of
rocks are in there so we want to bring
everything together that's a bottom up
and then divisive is we're going to go
from the top down so we take one huge
cluster and we start dividing it up into
two clusters into three four five and so
on digging even deeper into how
hierarchical clustering Works let's
consider we have a few points on a plane
so or this plane is 2D so we have an X Y
coordinates kind of makes it easy we're
going to start with measure the distance
so we want to figure a way to compute
the distance between each point each
data point is a cluster of its own
remember if we're going from the bottom
up a glomerative then we have each point
being its own cluster we try to find the
least distance between two data points
to form a cluster and then once we find
those with the least distance between
them we start grouping them together so
we start forming clusters of multiple
points this is represented in a
tree-like structure called dendogram so
there's another key word dendrogram and
you can see it is it's just a branch
we've looked at before and we do the
second group the same so it gets its own
dendrogram and the third gets its own
dendrogram and then we might group two
groups together so now those two groups
are all under one dendogram because
they're closer together other than the
P1 and P2 and then we terminate when we
are left with one cluster so we finally
bring it all together you can see on the
right how we've come up all the way up
to the top whoops and we have the gray
hierarchical box coming in there and
connecting them so we have just one
cluster and that's a good place to
terminate because there is no way we can
bring them together any further so how
do we measure the distance between the
data points I mean this is really where
it starts getting interesting up until
now you can kind of eyeball it and say
hey these look together but when you
have thousands of data points how are we
going to measure those distances and
there is a lot of ways to get the
distance measure so let's go and take a
look at that distance measures will
determine the similarity between two
elements and it will influence the shape
of the Clusters and we have euclidean
distance measure we have squared
euclidean distance measure which is
almost the same thing but with less
computations and we have the Manhattan
distance measure which will give you
slightly different results and we have
the cosine distance measure which again
is very similar to the euclidean and
playing with triangles and sometimes it
can compute faster depending on what
kind of data you're looking at so let's
start with the clitian distance measure
the most common is we want to know the
distance between the two points so if we
have Point p and point Q the euclidean
distance is the ordinary straight line
it is the distance between the two
points in euclidean space and you should
recognize D equals in this case we're
going to sum all the points so if there
was more than one point we could figure
out the distance to the not more than
one points this is the sum of more than
two Dimensions so we can have the
distance between each of the different
dimensions squared and that will give us
and then take the square root of that
and that gives us the actual distance
between them and they should look
familiar from euclidean geometry maybe
you haven't played too much with
multiple Dimensions so the summation
symbol might not look familiar to you
but it's pretty straightforward as you
add the distance between each of the two
different points squared so if your y
difference was 2 minus 1 squared would
be 2 and then you take the difference
between the X again squared and if there
was a z coordinates it would be you know
Z1 minus Z2 squared and then take the
square root of that and sum it all or
sum it all together and then take the
square root of it so to make it compute
faster since the difference in distances
whether one is farther apart or closer
together than the other we can do What's
called the squared euclidean distance
measurement this is identical to the
euclidean measurement but we don't take
the square root at the end there's no
reason to it certainly gives us the
exact distance but as far as doing
calculations as to which one's bigger or
smaller than the other one it won't make
a difference so we'll just go with the
so we just get rid of that div that
final square root computes faster and it
gives us the pretty much the euclidean
squared distance on there now the
Manhattan distance measurement is a
simple sum of horizontal and vertical
components or the distance between two
points measured along axes at right
angles now this is different because
you're not looking at the direct line
between them and and in certain cases
the individual distances measured will
give you a better result now generally
that's not true most times you go with
euclidean squared method because that's
very fast and easy to see but the
Manhattan distance is you measure just
the Y value and you take the absolute
value of it and you measure just the X
difference you take the absolute value
of it and just the Z and if you had more
you know different dimensions in their a
b c d e f however many dimensions you
would just take the absolute value of
the difference of those dimensions and
then we have the cosine distance
similarity measures that angle between
the two vectors and as you can see as
the two vectors get further and further
apart the cosine distance gets larger so
it's another way to measure the distance
very similar to the euclidean so you're
still looking at the same kind of
measurement so should have a similar
result as the first two but keep in mind
the Manhattan will have a very different
result and you can end up with a bias
with the Manhattan if your data is very
skewed if one set of values is very
large and another set of values is very
small but that's a little bit beyond the
scope of this it's just important to
know that about the Manhattan distance
so let's dig into the agglomerative
clustering and a glometric clustering
begins with each element as a separate
cluster and then we merge them into a
larger cluster how do we represent a
cluster of more than one point so we're
going to kind of mix the distance
together with the actual agglomerative
and see what that looks like and we're
actually going to have three key
questions that are going to be answered
here so how do we represent a cluster of
more than one point so we want to look
at the math what it looks like
mathematically and geometrically how do
we determine The Nearness of clusters
when to stop combining clusters always
important to have your computer script
or your whatever you're working on have
a termination point so it's not going on
eternally we've all done that if you do
any kind of computer programming or
writing a script let's assume that we we
have six data points in a euclidean
space so again we're dealing with X Y
and Z in this case just X and Y so how
do we represent a cluster of more than
one point let's take a look at that and
first we're going to make use of
centroids very common terminology in a
lot of machine learning languages when
we're grouping things together so we're
going to make use of centroids which is
the average of its points and you can
see here we're going to take the 1 2 and
the 2 1 and we're going to group them
together because they're close I mean if
we were looking at all the points we'd
look for those that are closest and
start with those and we're going to take
those two we're going to compute a point
in the middle and we'll give that point
1 5 1.5 1.5 and that's going to be the
centroid of those two points and next we
start measuring like another group of
points we got four one five zero when
they're pretty close together so we'll
go ahead and set up a centroid of those
two points in this case it would be the
4.5 and 0.5 would be the measurements on
those two points and once we have the
centroid of the two groups we find out
that the next closest point to a
centroid is over on the left and so
we're going to take this and say oh 0 0
is closest to the 1.5 1.5 centroid so
let's go ahead and group that together
and we compute a new centroid based on
those three points so now we have a
centroid of 1.1 or 1 comma 1. and then
we also do this again with the last
point the 5 3 and it computes into the
first group and you can see our
dendrogram on the right is growing so we
have each of these points are become
connected and we start grouping them
together and finally we get a centroid
of that group two and then finally the
last thing we want to do is combine the
two groups by their centroids and you
can see here we end up with one large
group and it'll have its own centroid
although usually they don't compute the
last centroid we just put them all
together
so when do we stop combining clusters
well hopefully it was pretty obvious to
you in this case when they all got to be
one but there are actually many
approaches to it so first pick a number
of clusters K up front and this is done
in the fact that we don't want to look
at 200 in clusters we only want to look
at the top five clusters or something
like that so we decide the number of
clusters required in the beginning and
we terminate when we reach the value K
so if you looked back on our clustering
let me just go back a couple screens
you'll see how we clustered these all
together and we might want just the two
clusters and so we look at just the top
two or maybe we only want three clusters
and so we would compute which one of
these has a wider spread to it or
something like that there's other
computations to know how to connect them
and we'll look at that in just a minute
but to note that when we pick the K
value we want to limit the information
that's coming in so that can be very
important especially if you're feeding
it into another algorithm that requires
three values or you set it to four
values you need to know that value
coming in so we might take the
clustering and say okay only three
clusters that's all we want for K so the
possible challenges this only makes
sense when we know the data well so when
you're clustering with K clusters you
might already know that domain and know
that that makes sense but if you're
exploring brand new data you might have
no idea how many clusters you really
need to explore that data with let's
consider the value of K to be 2. so in
this case in our previous example we
stop and we are left with two clusters
and you can see here that this is where
they came together the best while still
keeping separate the data the second
approach is stop when the next merge
would create a cluster with low cohesion
so we keep clustering till the next
merge of clusters creates a bad cluster
low cohesion setup on there that means
the point is so close to being between
two clusters it doesn't make sense to
bring them together but how is cohesion
defined oh let's dig a little deeper
into cohesion the diameter of a cluster
so we're looking at the actual value
diameter of our cluster and the diameter
is the maximum distance between any pair
of points in the cluster we terminate
when the diameter of a new cluster
exceeds the threshold so as that
diameter gets bigger and bigger we don't
want the two circles or clusters to
overlap and we have radius of a cluster
radius is the maximum distance of a
point from centroid we terminate when
the radius of a new cluster exceeds the
threshold again we're not we don't want
things to overlap so when it crosses
that threshold and it's overlapping with
other data we stop so let's look at
divisive clustering remember we went
from the bottom up now we want to go
from the top down divisive clustering
approach begins with a whole set and
proceeds to divide it into smaller
clusters so we start with a single
cluster composed of all the data points
we split it into different clusters this
can be done using monothetic divisive
methods what is a monothetic divisive
method and we'll go backwards and let's
consider the example we took in the
agglomerative clustering to understand
this so we consider a space with six
points in it just like we did before
same points we had before and we name
each point in the cluster so we have in
this case we just gave it a letter value
a b c d e f since we follow top-down
approach in divisive clustering obtain
all possible splits into two columns so
we want to know where you could split it
here and we could do like a a b split
and a cdef split we could do BCE ADF and
you can see this starts generating a
huge amount of data a b c t e f and so
for each split we can compute cluster
sum of squares and we can see here the
we actually have the formula out for us
B J 12 equals N1 of absolute value of x
minus absolute value of x squared so
again we're Computing all the different
distances in there squared back to your
kind of euclidean distances on that and
so we can actually compute B A J between
clusters one and two and we have the
mean of the cluster and the grand mean
depending on the number of members in
the cluster and we select the cluster
with the largest sum of squares let's
assume that the sum of squared distance
is largest for the third split we had up
above and that's where we split the ABC
out and if we split the a b c out we're
left with the def on the other side we
again find the sum of squared distances
and split it into clusters so we go from
ABC we might find that the a is splits
into BC and D into EF and again you
start to see that hierarchical dendogram
coming down as we start splitting
everything apart and finally we might
have a splits in b and c and then each
one gets their own d e f and it
continues to divide until we get little
nodes at the end and every data has its
own point or until we get to K if we
have set a k value so we've kind of
learned a little bit about the
background and some of the math in
hierarchical clustering let's go ahead
and dive into a demo and our demo today
is going to be for the problem statement
we're going to look at U.S oil so a U.S
oil organization needs to know its cells
in various States in U.S and cluster of
the states based on the cells so what
are the steps involved into setting this
problem up so the steps we're going to
look at and this is really useful for
just about about any processing of data
although I believe we're going to be
doing this in R today we're going to
import the data set so we'll explore our
data a little bit there create a scatter
plot it's always good to have a visual
if you can once you have a visual you
can know if you're really far off in the
model you choose to Cluster the data in
or how many splits you need and then
we're going to normalize the data so
we're going to fix the data up so it
processes correctly we'll talk more
detail about normalization when we get
there and then calculate the euclidean
distance and finally we'll create our
dendogram so it looks nice and pretty
and we have something we can show to our
shareholders so that they have something
to go on and know why they gave us all
that money and salary for the year so we
go ahead and open up R and we're
actually using our studio which is the
really has some nice features in it it
automatically sets up the three Windows
where we have our script file on the
upper left and then we can execute that
script and it'll come down and put it
into the console bottom left and execute
it and then we have our plots off to the
right and I've got it zoomed in
hopefully not too large a font but large
enough that you can see it
and let's just go ahead and take a look
at some of the script going in here
it's clustering analysis and we're going
to work we'll call it my data and we're
going to assign it in R this is a symbol
for assigning and we're going to go read
CSV
read CSV file
and we'll put that in Brackets and let's
before we go any further let's just look
at the data outside of R it's always
nice to do if you can
and the file is going to be called
utilities.csv this would also be the
time to get the full path so you have
the right path to your file and remember
that you can always Post in the comments
down below
and when you post down there just let us
know you want to connect up with simply
learn so that they can get you this file
so you can get the same file we're
working on and you can repeat it and see
how this works this is utilities.csv
It's a comma separated variable file so
it's pretty straightforward and you can
see here they have the city fixed charge
and a number of different features to
the data and so we have our RoR cost low
demand cells
nuclear fuel cost on here and then going
down the other side we have U.S cities
Arizona Boston they have Central U.S I
guess they're grouping a number of areas
together the Commonwealth area you can
see down here in Nevada New England
Northern us Oklahoma the Pacific region
and so on so we have a nice little chart
of different data they brought in
and so I'm going to take that complete
path that ends in the utilities.csv
and we're going to import that file let
me just enlarge this all the way oops I
had an extra set of brackets here
somehow or maybe I missed a set of
brackets
this can happen if you're not careful
you can get brackets on one side and not
the other or in this case I got double
brackets on each side there we go and
then the magic hotkeys in this case are
your control enter which will let me go
ahead and run the script
and so I've now loaded the data and as
you can see I went ahead and shrunk the
plot since we're going to be looking at
the window down below
and we can simply convert the data to a
string
now all of us do this automatically the
first time we say hey just printed all
out as a string and then we get this
huge mess of stuff
that doesn't make a whole lot of sense
so and you can see here they have you
can probably kind of pull it together as
looking at it but let's go ahead and
just do the head
now we'll do the head of my data
there we go and control enter on that
and the head shows the first five rows
you'll see this in a lot of different
scripts in R it's you type in head and
then in Brackets you put your data and
it comes through and lists the first
five rows as you can see below
and it shows Arizona Boston Central and
it has the same columns we just looked
at so we have the fixed charge the RoR
the cost the load the D demand I'm not
an expert in oil so I'm not even sure
what D demand is cells I'm guessing
nuclear how much of it's supplied by
nuclear and the actual fuel cost
and then the different states that it's
in or different areas
and one of the wonders of R is all these
cool easy to use tools that are so quick
so we'll do pairs
and pairs creates a nice graph so let me
go ahead and run this
uh whoops the reason it gave me an error
is because I forgot to resize it so let
me bring my plot way out so we can see
it and let's run that again
and you'll see here that we have a nice
graph of the different data and how it
plots together how the different points
kind of come together
this is neat because if you look at this
I would look at this and say hey this is
a great candidate for some kind of
clustering and the reason is is when I
look at any two pairs let's go down to
say cells and fuel costs towards the
bottom right
and when you look at them where they
cross over you sort of see things how
they group together but it's a little
confusing you can't really pinpoint how
they group together you could probably
look at these two and say yeah there's
pretty good commonalities there and if
you look at any of the other pairs
you'll start seeing some patterns there
also and so we really want to know what
are the patterns on all of them put
together not just any two of them but
the whole setup
let me go ahead and Shrink my this down
for just a second just a notch here
and let's create a scatter plot oops
and this is simply just use the term
plot in Brackets and then which values
do we want to plot and if we remember
when we looked at the data earlier let
me just go back this way
in this case let's go ahead and compare
two just two values to see how they look
and we'll do fuel costs and cells
and it's in my data so we gotta let it
know which two columns we're looking at
next to each other and it will open up
our plot thing and then go ahead and
execute that
and we can see on those close-up what
we're just looking at in the pairs
and if I was eyeballing this I would say
oh look there's a kind of a cluster up
here of five items and this one is hard
to tell which cluster to be with but
maybe it's six you go in the top one and
you have a middle cluster and a bottom
cluster maybe two different clusters so
you can sort of group them together fuel
cost and the sales and see how they
connect with each other
and again that's only two different
values we're looking at so in the long
run we want to look at all of them
and then the people in the back
they sent me this grip so we can go
ahead and add labels so with my data
text fuel cost cells the labels equal
City
position four these are numbers you can
kind of play with till they look nice
and oops again I forgot to resize my
plot it doesn't like having it too small
and we'll run that
I must type something in here
oh I did a lowercase D and they did a
capital D there we go
so now we can go in here and do this
with my data and you can see a little
hard to see on my screen with all the
the different things in there plus the
actual cities so we can now see where
all the cities are in connection with in
this case fuel cost and sales
so you have a nice label to go with the
graph
I'll go ahead and plot in this case
let's do
oh the r o r oops
and we'll do that
also with the cells and do my data
remember to leave it lowercase this time
so we plot those two
we'll come over here and it's going to
I'm surprised to give me an error
and then we'll also add in the with
statement so we put some nice labels in
there
and it's going to be the same as before
except instead of doing the fuel cost
cells we want the r cells and we'll
execute that
oops and of course it gives me an error
because I shrunk it down so let's redo
those two again
there we go and we can see now we have
the RoR with cells and we'd probably get
a slightly different clustering here if
I was looking at these cities they're
probably different than we had before
but you could probably look at this and
say yeah these kind of go together and
those kind of go together but again
we're going to be looking at all of them
instead of just one or two
and so at this point we want to dive
into the next step where we're going to
start looking at a little bit of coding
or scripting here
this is very important because we're
going to be looking at normalization
we put that in there normalization and
if you've done any of the other machine
learning skills and setup this should
start to look very normal in your
pre-processing of data whether you're in
r or python or any of these scripts we
really want to make sure you normalize
your data so it's not biased
remember we're dealing with distances
and if I have let's say the RoR is even
look at this graph here on the right
you can see where my RoR varies between
8 and 14. that's a very small variable
and our cells varies between four
thousand and sixteen thousand so you can
imagine the distance between four
thousand and eight thousand which is the
distance of four thousand versus eight
to ten versus two the cells is going to
dominate so if we do any kind of special
work on this it's going to look at cells
and it's going to Cluster them just by
the cells alone and then RoR might have
a little tiny effect of two versus four
thousand we want to level the playing
field
turns out there's actually a number of
ways in script to normalize
so I'm just going to put in the code
that they put together in the back for
me and let's talk about it a little bit
so we have Z we're going to assign it to
my data
and let's go ahead and
we're going to do a little reshaping
across all rows
or I mean across all columns each of the
rows is going to have a little reshaping
there
and then we're going to get M which
stands for means
and we're going to apply it to my data
so again we want to go ahead and create
a the most common variable in there
and then s is going to be SD stands for
standard deviation
so instead of just doing a lot of times
what they do with normalization of data
is we just reshape the data everything
between 0 and 1. so that if the lower
end is eight that now becomes zero and
the upper end is 14 that now becomes 1.
that doesn't help if it is not a linear
set of data so with this we're going to
look for the means and the standard
deviation for reshaping the data
and that way the most common values now
become the kind of like the center point
and then the standard deviation is how
big the spread so we want the standard
deviation to be equal amongst all of
them and then finally we go ahead and
take Z and with the Z we're going to
reassign it and we're going to scale the
original my data which we re-shaped
based on M and based on the standard
deviation
and the 2 in here that just means we're
looking at everything in kind of a x y
kind of plot
and we can quickly run these control
enter control enter control enter
control enter so now we have Z which is
a scaled version of my data
and now we can go ahead and calculate
the euclidean distance
oops calcu
there we go
and in R this is so easy once you've
gotten to here we've done all that
pre-data processing
we'll call it distance
and we'll assign this to
dist so d-i-s-t
is the computation for getting the
euclidean distance and we can just put Z
in there because we've already
reformatted and scaled Z to fit what we
want let me go ahead and just hit enter
on that
and I'm going to widen my left hand side
again
I'm always curious what does this data
look like so let's just type in distance
which will print the variable down below
oops
you have to hit Ctrl enter
and this prints out a huge amount of
information
as you can see just kind of streams down
there
and let's go ahead and enlarge this
and I don't know about you but when I
look at something like this it doesn't
mean a whole lot to me other than I see
two three four five six
and then you kind of have the top part 6
17 18.
so I imagine this is like a huge chart
is what we're looking at
and we can go ahead and use print oh
distance
digits
equal three and let's run that
oops I keep forgetting that it has to go
through the graph on the right and we
see a different slightly different
output in here let me just open this up
so we can see we're looking at and by
cutting down the distance you can start
to see the patterns here if it's looking
at the different distances
so if I go to the top we have the
distance between one and two one and
three one and four one and five one and
six and then two and three and so on
obviously the distance between itself is
zero and it doesn't repeat the data so
we don't care to see two versus one
again because we already know the
distance between one and two
since we have a nice view of all the
distances in the chart and that's what
we're looking at right here and it's a
little easier to read that's why we did
the print statement up here to do digits
equals three make it a little bit
smaller we could even just do digits oh
let's just do two see what that looks
like we might lose some data on this one
if it's uh if something's way off
but we have a nice setup and we can see
the different distances and that's what
we were computed here between each of
the points
and then the whole reason we're doing
this is to get ourselves a nice
dendogram going a nice clustering
dendogram we'll do a couple of these
looking at different things
we'll take a variable hc.l and we're
going to assign it
H cluster
and then distance
that easy we've already computed the
distances so the H clustering does all
the work for us
and let me hit enter on there so now we
have our HCL which is assigned the H
clustering computation based on
distances and apart and then I'm going
to expand my graph because we would like
to go ahead and see what this looks like
we can simply plot that
and hit the control enter so it runs
and look at that we have a really nice
clustering dendrogram except when I look
at it the first thing I notice is it
really shows like numbers down below
now if you were a shareholder in some
data scientist came up to you and said
look at this this is what it means you'd
be looking at that going what the heck
does 3 9 14 19 1 18 mean so let's give
it some words there
so let's do the same plot with our HCL
HC there we go
and let's add in labels and this is just
one of the commands and plots
so we have labels equals my data
and then under my data we want to know
the city
and we'll have it hang minus one that's
just the instructions to make it pretty
so we'll run that
oops I accidentally ran just Tang my one
let me try that again
there we go okay so now you can see what
it's done in the hang my one turns it
sideways that way we can see Central
which is Central us and Kentucky
and we start to actually get some
information off our clustering setup and
the information you start looking at is
that when we put all the information
together you probably want to look at
Central America and Kentucky together
Oklahoma and Texas has a lot of
commonality as does Arizona and Southern
U.S and you can even group all five of
those Florida Oklahoma Texas Arizona and
Southern U.S these regions for some
reason share a lot of similarities and
so we want to start asking what those
similarities are
but this gives us a place to look it
says hey these things really go together
you should be grouping these together as
far as your cells and what's what you're
doing
and then one of the things you might
want to do is there's also we can do the
dendrogram average
this changes how we do the clustering
so it looks very similar like we had
before and those are HCL we're going to
assign it we're going to do an H cluster
we're still doing it on distance oops
distance
and this time we're going to set the
method to average so we can change the
methodology in which it computes the
values
and before if you remember correctly we
did median median's a little bit
different than means we did the most
common one and then we want the average
of the median
and let's go ahead and run that
and then we can plot
and here's our HCL
oops there we go here's our HCL and I
can run that plot and you can see this
changed a little bit so our way it
computes and groups things looks a
little different than it did before and
let's go and put the cities back in
there and do the hang
control copy let me just really quickly
copy that down here
because we want the same labels
and again you can see Nevada Idaho pujet
I remember we were looking at Southern
U.S and Arizona Texas and Oklahoma
Florida so the grouping really hasn't
changed too much so we still have a very
similar grouping
it's almost kind of flipped it as far as
the distance based on average has
but this is something you could actually
take to the shareholders and say hey
look these things are connected and at
which point you want to explore a little
deeper as to why they're connected
because they're going to ask you okay
how are they connected and why do we
care
that's a little bit beyond the actual
scope of what we're working on today
but we are going to cover membership
what's called a clustering membership on
there
and let's create a member we'll just
call it Member One oops remember dot one
and we're going to assign to this
we're going to do cut tree
and
cut tree
it limits it so what that means is I
take my HC Dot
l in here
oops there we go dot l and so I'm taking
the cluster I just built and we want to
take that cluster and we want to limit
it to just a depth of three so we go
ahead and do that and run that one oops
let me go run
there we go so now I've created my
Member One
and then whoops let me just move this
out of the way we're going to do an
Aggregate and we're going to use Z
remember Z from above and we're going to
turn Member One into a list and then
we're going to aggregate that together
based on the mean let me go ahead and
enter run that
Oops I did remember L it's actually
remember one
there we go
and if we take a look at this
we now have our group one fixed charge
and then all your different
columns listed there and most of them
should come up kind of looking between
zero and one but you'll see a lot of
variation because we're varying it based
on the means so it's a means the
standard deviation not just forcing it
in between 0 and 1.
which is a much better way usually to
normalize your data than just doing the
zero one setup
and finally we can actually look at the
actual values
and the same chart we just did
oops
I made a mistake on there with my data
there we go okay
and again we now have our actual data
instead of looking at just the if you
looked up here it's all between 0 and 1
and when we look down here
we now have some actual connections and
how far distance this different data is
again because more of a domain issue and
understanding the oil company and what
these different values means and you can
look at these as being the distances
between different items
so a little bit different View and you
have to really dig deep into this data
we really want you to take away from
this is the dendigram and the charts
that we did earlier
and that is the cluster output and our
nice dendogram so this would be stage
one in data analysis of the cells again
you'd have to have a lot more domain
experience to find out what all the
individual numbers we looked at mean and
what the distance is and what's
difference between Central America and
Kentucky and why they're similar and why
it groups all of Central Kentucky
Florida Oklahoma Texas Arizona and
Southern us together into one larger
group so I'd be Way Beyond the scope of
this but you can see how we start to
explore data and we start to see things
in here where things are grouped
together and ways we might not have seen
before and this is a good start for
understanding and giving advice for
cells and marketing maybe Logistics City
development there's all kinds of things
that kind of come together in the
hierarchical clustering as you begin to
explore data and we just want to point
out that we get three clusters of
regions with the highest cells region
with average cells region with the
lowest cells again those are some of the
things that they clustered it around and
you could actually see where things are
going on or lacking you know in this
case if you're the lowest sales no one
wants to be in the region of the lowest
sales
if you are an aspiring machine learning
engineer looking for online training and
certifications from prestigious
universities and in collaboration with
leading experts then search no more
simple learns professional certification
program in Ai and machine learning from
Purdue University in collaboration with
IBM should be a right choice for more
details use the link in the description
box below with that in mind regression
algorithms is used to find out the
connection between dependent and
independent variables dependent
variables are nothing but a variable
that we are trying to predict a forecast
and independent variables are the factor
that influence the analysis it is
usually used to make projections medical
researchers frequently utilize linear
regression to study the connection
between patient blood pressure and
dosage researcher may give patient
different quantities of a specific
medication and drag the how their blood
pressure changes a regression model
might use dosage as a predictor variable
and blood pressure as a response
variable
there are some popular regression
algorithms that come under supervised
machine learning first one is linear
regression regression trees non-linear
regression basal linear regression after
discussing what is supervised learning
and its types let's move forward to see
what actually regression analysis is
a stat technique known as iteration
analysis is used to simulate the
relationship between dependent and
independent variables using one or more
independent variables regression
analysis more precisely enables us to
comprehend and when other independent
variables are held constant
changes in the dependent variables value
that correspond to an independent
variables are changing prediction
include values that are continuous or
real such as temperature age pay and
cost
there are some following concept or
terminologies that must be understood in
order to completely grasp regression
analysis the first one is dependent
variable in a regression analysis the
primary variable we wish to predict or
comprehend is the dependent variable
here dependent variables are also known
as Target variable the next one is
independent variable
determine dependent variables also known
as predictor refers to the elements that
impact the dependent variables or are
used to forecast their values and the
third one is outliers an observation
that is extremely high or extremely low
in relation to the other observed values
is referred as an outlier an outlier
should be avoided as it might affect the
outcomes the fourth one is
multicolinarity the situation is set to
as occurring when independent variables
have a higher correlation with one
another than other variables it
shouldn't be included in the data set
because it causes issues when
determining which variable has the
greatest impact and the fifth one is
overfitting and underfitting overfitting
is the problem that occurs whenever
system problems well with the training
data set but poorly with the test data
set under fitting is the term used when
an algorithm does not perform well even
with the training data set after
understanding what regression analysis
is and its terminologies let's move
forward and see why we use regression
analysis
including those involving the weather
sales marketing Trends and other factors
in this situation we need regression
analysis that can make forecast more
precisely so let's understand the
concept of regression analysis using an
example
business frequently use linear
regression to understand the
relationship between advertising
spending and income for instance they
might run a simple linear model with
advertising as a response variable and
revenue as a predictor variable the
direction model would look like this the
van equals to beta0 plus B1 is AD
spending where there are no
advertisement the coefficient 0 would
indicate the whole expected Revenue when
advertising expenditures are increased
by one unit coefficient will represent
the typical change in the total revenue
that is one dollar if beta 1 is negative
then higher advertising expenditure will
result in lower Revenue if beta 1 is
nearly zero advertising expenditures
have little impact on revenue and if
beta 1 is positive it would imply that
more advertising expenditures are linked
to higher income
the amount of beta 1 will determine
whether a corporation decide to or
decrease its advertising budget
regression means creating a graph that
connects variable the best fit the given
data point the direction analysis model
can then make prediction about data
using the plot regression analysis is
defined as showing a line or a curve
that goes through all the data points on
the target predictive graph in such a
way that vertical distance between the
data points and the regression is
smallest whether a model has captured a
strong link between determined by the
distance between data points and the
line there are some more use case of
regression analysis like we can use
temperature another variable to predict
or forecast drain regression analysis
can be used for identification of Market
threads
for predicting traffic accidents caused
by a reckless driving we can use
regression analysis for the same and
many more
so by understanding why we need
regression analysis moving forward let's
see some popular regression algorithms
in detail
the first one is linear regression
linear deviation is one of the most
famous and straightforward machine
learning algorithm utilized for
predictive analysis linear regression
shows the linear connection between
dependent and independent factors the
line of the equation is y equals to MX
plus b here y stands for the response
variable or a dependent variable whether
X is for the predictor variable or an
independent variable here m is the
estimated slope and B is for the
estimated intercept
and the next one is regression trees a
regression trees is worked through a
cycle known as binary recursive which is
iterative interaction that divides the
information into segments of branches
and afterwards keep splitting the data
into a smaller group as the technique
claims each plant this tree is used for
the dependent variable with continuous
values for example a regression trees
name food which is divided into segments
veg and non veg further it keeps
splitting into smaller groups
and the third one is non-linear
regression nonlinear rejection is a type
of regression examination wherein
information is to fit a model and
afterward communicated with the
numerical function simple linear
regression relates to factor X and Y
with a straight line Y equals to MX plus
b while non-linear regression relates
the two factor in a non-linear
relationship non-linear reaction can be
predict population growth over time or
the relationship between GDP and a
country's time and the fourth one is
patient linear regression the algorithm
is a way to deal with a linear
regression in which statical examination
is attempted inside the setting of
Bayesian inference linear regression and
patient regression can generate the same
reduction and with the help of Bayesian
processing we can retrieve the complete
variety of inferential solution instead
of a point estimate
after seeing some regression analysis
algorithm let's move forward and see
advantages and disadvantages of
different regression analysis models
and the first model is linear regression
model the advantages are work value is
respective of data set size and the
second one is gives information about
the relevance of features and the
disadvantages are the assumptions of
linear regression and the next one is
polynomial regression
the advantages are works on any size of
the data set and the second one is works
very well on non-linear problems and
disadvantages are we need to choose the
right polynomial degree for the variance
trade-off the next one is support Vector
regression algorithms and the advantages
are easily adaptable works very well on
non-linear problems and disadvantages
are difficult to understand and not well
known and the next one is decision tree
regression
the advantages of decision trees are no
need to apply scaling and the second one
is works very well on both linear and
non-linear problems and disadvantages
are poor results on small data set and
overfitting can easily occur and the
last one is random Forest regression the
advantages are powerful and second one
is accurate and disadvantages are no
interpretably and the second one is
overfitting can easily occur
after seeing advantages and
disadvantages of different types of
regression analysis models let's move
forward and see some applications of
regression analysis
the first one is forecasting regression
analysis is frequently used in business
to predict potential opportunities and
dangers for example demand analysis
predicts how many items a buyer is
likely to purchase demand however is not
only the dependent variables when it
comes to business much more than just
direct income can be predicted using
regression analysis and the second one
is capm capital asset pricing model the
linear regression model is a key
component of the capital asset pricing
model capm which determines the
relationship between an asset expected
return and the associated Market risk
premium financial analyst typically use
it for forecast corporate return and
operational performance when doing
financial analysis and the third one is
comparing with competition it can be
used to evaluate how well a business is
doing financially in comparison to a
certain rival
it can also be used to figure out how
the stock prices of two companies are
related to one another this can be
extended to find the correlation between
two competing companies it might help
the company identifying the effectors
affecting the sales and contrast to the
comparable company
these methods can help small business
succeed quickly within a short period of
time and the last one is identifying
problem regression is a beneficial for
identifying incorrect judgment as well
as for providing factual support for the
management for instance a retail store
manager might believe that extending the
hours of operation will greatly increase
sales
if you are an aspiring machine learning
engineer looking for online training and
certifications from prestigious
universities and in collaboration with
leading experts then search no more
simple learns professional certification
program in Ai and machine learning from
Purdue University in collaboration with
IBM should be a right choice for more
details use the link in the description
box below with that in mind
so let's go ahead and talk about
overfitting when we talk about
overfitting it's a scenario where the
machine learning model tries to learn
from the details along with the noise
and the data tries to fit each data
point on the curve you can see that
um
if you plug in your coordinates you're
just going to get the whatever is fitted
every point on the data stream there's
no average there's no two points that
might have that you know y might have
two different answers because uh if the
wind blows a certain way
um and your efficiency of your car maybe
you have a headwind so your car might
alter how efficient it is as it goes and
so there's going to be this variance on
here and this says no you can't have any
variants what's you know the this is
it's going to be exactly this it can't
be any you can't be the same speed or
the same car and have a slightly
different efficiency
so as the model has very less
flexibility it fails to predict new data
points and thus the model rejects every
new data point during the prediction
so you'll get like a really high error
on here
and so uh reasons for overfitting data
used for training is not cleaned and
contains noise garbage values in it you
can spend so much time cleaning your
data and it's so important it's so
important that if you have if you have
some kind of something wrong with the
data coming in it needs to be addressed
whether it's the source of the data
maybe they use in medical different
measuring tools
so you now have to adjust for data that
came in from hospital a versus Hospital
b or even off of machine a and machine B
that's testing something and those those
numbers are coming in wrong
the model has a high variance again wind
is a good example I was talking about
that with the car you may have 100 tests
but because the wind's blowing it's all
over the place
size of training data used is not enough
so a small amount of data is going to
also cause this problem you only have a
few points and you try to plot
everything
the model is too complex this comes up a
lot
we put too many pieces together and how
they interact can't even be tracked and
so you have to go back break it up and
find out actually what correlates and
what doesn't
so what is underfitting a scenario where
machine learning models can either learn
the relationship between the data points
nor predict or classify a new data point
and you can see here we have our
efficiency of our car and our line drawn
and it's just going to be way off for
both the training and the predicting
data
as a model doesn't fully learn the
patterns it accepts every new data point
during the prediction
so instead of looking for a general
pattern we just kind of accept
everything
data used for training is not cleaned
and contains noise garbage and values
again under fitting and overfitting same
issue you got to clean your data
the model has a high bias
we've seen this in all kinds of things
from
uh the ma the most common is the driving
cars to facial identification or
whatever it is the model itself when
they build it might have a bias towards
one thing and this would be an
underfitted model but have that bias
because it's averaged it out so if you
have five people from India and 10
people from
Africa and 20 people from the U.S you've
created a bias because it's looking at
the 20 people and you only have a small
amount of data to work with
size of training data used is not enough
that goes with the size I was just
talking about
so we have a model with a high bias we
have size of training data used it's not
enough the model is too simple
again this is one straight line through
all the data when it needs as a slight
shift to it for other reasons
so what is a good fit a linear curve
that best fits the data is neither
overfitting or underfitting models but
is just right
and of course we have the nice examples
here where we have overfitting lines
going up and down every point is trying
to be include glueded under fitting
the line really is off from where the
data is and then a good fit is got to
get rid of that minimize that error
coming through
so this is all exciting but what does
this look like so we really need to jump
in and put a code together and see what
this looks like when we're programming
for this demo we'll bring up our trusty
anaconda and go into Jupiter notebook
for python
move myself out of the way here
and so we're going to start off this is
going to be a demo on overfitting and
underfitting using python
and let's start with our Imports
now if you've been through enough of
these tutorials we don't want to spend a
huge amount of time on what we're
bringing in and what we're doing so you
should be up on doing this with python
and how to bring in your different
modules
uh we're going to bring in the SK learn
or the psy kit processing skle
learn.neural Network Import in a MLP
regressor
so there's our regressor model right
there
that's going to be our linear regression
model
and we have our metrics mean absolute
error if you remember we had our that's
how we figure out how well it fits is
how far off that error is based on the
mean square error value MSE
and then of course numpy because we just
like to work with numpy it's a great
data array we always import it as MP
that's the most common way of doing it
and then we have SK learn model
selection import validation curve so
we're going to look at a validation
curve to see how good our models are
and then we have the data set we'll use
the very famous Iris data set and that's
embedded in the sci kit so the S key
learn data sets have a load Iris in
there
and then we have the matplot library
because if you're doing any kind of demo
or showing this off to your shareholders
we want to have something nice to
display it on
and then we have SK learn model
selection we're going to import import K
fold and we'll talk about that when we
get to it and then we're going to go
ahead and do just for our numpy we're
going to do like a random seed for
random numbers and then for our plot
style we'll use the GG plot that's just
some back end setup you could even
probably leave the plot style out
depending on what version of
you're using of
depending on what version you're using a
matplot library
and then we'll go ahead and run this
it's not going to do anything that we
can visibly see because it's just
loading those modules and then we also
want to load our Iris data in here and
the IRS data has an iris data and Iris
Target
we're going to load that as X and Y
and just so you can have an idea what
we're talking about we're going to go
ahead and print
X
and just the first bit of X we'll just
do the top of X and we'll also print y
so you can see what the top of Y looks
like print y
and since we're in numpy we're going to
go ahead and do our own thing if this
was uh of course pandas we could just do
the head of it and see what it looks
like and you can see here we've loaded
this up and in X we have these different
measurements that they take of the
flower the iris flowers from this
particular data set and what kind of
flower it is it's going to be a zero one
or a two is actually what the target
comes out of even though that doesn't
show in here
and so we're going to come in here and
we're going to use the k-folds cross
validation with 20 folds
and a good catch that this was a model
selection we're we're going through and
we're selecting different parts of the
data in here here we use k-fold cross
validation with 20 folds k equals 20 to
evaluate the generalization efficiency
of the model within each fold we will
then estimate the training and test
error using the training and test sets
respectfully
so here we have our KF equals KF k-fold
here's our splits on the top
then we need to go ahead and have our
list training error we're going to
create an array for that we're going to
list our testing error
and for train index and test index in k
f dot splitx X train y uh X train and X
test
we're going to go ahead and split up our
our data our X values and same thing
with the Y values so now we have an X
train and X test a y train and a y test
and then here's our model our
MLP regressor
that's your linear regressor model in
there and we have used a multi-layer
precipitron MLP so this is a neural
network a multi-layer precipitron that's
what the MLP is for regressor means that
it is dealing with numbers we're not
categorizing things
um
and then let's go ahead uh kind of went
off the screen here we'll just go ahead
and bring that down it's a class of feed
forward artificial neural networks and
they kind of loosely call it a n n don't
get caught up in the a n n n
there's NN is neural network and then
everybody puts their own flavor on it
depending on what they're doing uh so if
you see the NN you know you're dealing
with a neural network
so we go ahead and fit our data here's
our model.fit we have X train and Y
train
and the Y train data we're going to
predict equals model dot predict
X train so here's our prediction of what
it's going to be so we've trained it and
we've predicted it we've traded our the
train data and then we have our y train
and then we have our y test
and the Y test equals a model predict X
test
now notice what we did here is we're
going to use our model to predict what
we think y should be but this is the
training set so we've trained it with
this data and now we want to see how
good our model fits our training data
and then we want to see how well it fits
our testing data
so we take our fold training error mean
absolute error y train
y train data predict and we're going to
do our full testing error the mean
absolute error of Y test and why test
data predict
and we do this and here's our mean
absolute error there's our a little bit
different connotation but that's that's
taking the Square value and finding the
in this case it's using the absolute
value so instead of the Square value we
get rid of the minus and pluses by using
an absolute value and we find the
average of that and that works the same
way as doing a squared value
then we take our list training error and
we're going to just append it for each
each one of these runs we go through so
every time we fold the data
think of it like this uh we want to go
ahead and take a piece of data that's
going to be one piece of the data and
we're going to look at
each section and we want to go through
each section to see how well it does and
splits it up this way we have a nice
picture when we're looking at it from a
distance I do this a lot when I do X and
when I split my X train and my y train
I'll take two-thirds of the data and
then one third of the data and then I'll
switch it and I'll do three different
models so I can really see how well it
tests out and how that averages out
this is the same thing but with the with
the k-fold we're doing and we're doing
it across 20 sections
we'll go ahead and run this
and we run this it's not too exciting
because we're just loading up the data
and appending it into our list
and so we want to take with this is
we're going to go ahead and plot it and
this is where we can really see what's
going on this is where it gets exciting
uh so we take it and we're going to
create a couple subplots that way we
have a nice setup down here we're
splitting it up into a couple different
graphs
foreign
let's go ahead and run this and then
we'll walk through it a little bit so
our subplot comes in to
there's our subplot and then our PLT
plot we're going to do in there range
one we're going ahead and do the splits
plus one in pra list training error uh
Ravel um this is of course a just a code
to how we properly set it up on there so
that it sees it correctly
and then we have our X label which is
our number fold plot the Y label
training error plot the title training
error cross Folds
plot the tight layout plot the subplot
so we're going to move on to this is one
two one one two two there's our one at
just one and two
it has to do with how it how it layers
it on there for doing multiple plots
because you can do all kinds of cool
things with our plot our PI plot Library
uh and again we're going to go ahead and
do the same thing for the error and we
end up with our training error cross
folds and our testing error across Folds
and so you can see these different folds
how they kind of Spike and how they look
and so we're talking about overfitting
or under fitting we're comparing these
two graphs and if one of them
is more off than the other one
if you're looking at these two graphs
you got to say hey is this one over fit
or underfit and this is always a good
question to ask I mean what do we got
going here is that overfit or is that
underfit and I would say based on these
two graphs and the training data the
training data is more sporadic than the
testing data
so I would look at this and say hey this
might need to be fit a little bit better
maybe we don't have enough data with the
iris we probably don't
something else is going on here so it's
a little underfit maybe a different
model would fit better I would not use a
neural network model for this I would
actually use just a basic linear linear
model on this
a lot of different choices but this
gives you an idea what we're looking at
is how chaotic are these two is it
getting better or is it getting worse
if at some point the training data gets
so much better than the testing data you
know you've overfit it and that's where
you start running into the overfitting
this to me looks like it's under fit so
that concludes under fitting and
overfitting if you are an aspiring
machine learning engineer looking for
online training and certifications from
prestigious universities and in
collaboration with leading experts then
search Nomo simply learns professional
certification program in Ai and machine
learning from Purdue University in
collaboration with IBM should be a right
choice for more details use the link in
the description box below with that in
mind machine learning has improved our
lives in a number of wonderful ways
today let's talk about some of these I'm
Rahul from Simply learn and these are
the top 10 applications of machine
learning first let's talk about virtual
personal assistance Google Assistant
Alexa Cortana and Siri now we've all
used one of these at least at some point
in our lives now these help improve our
lives in a great number of ways for
example you could tell them to call
someone you could tell them to play some
music you could tell them to even
schedule an appointment so how do these
things actually work first they record
whatever you're saying send it over to a
server which is usually in a cloud
decoded with the help of machine
learning in neural networks and then
provide you with an output so if you
ever noticed that these systems don't
work very well without the internet
that's because the server couldn't be
contacted next let's talk about traffic
predictions now say I wanted to travel
from Buckingham Palace to large cricket
ground the first thing I'd probably do
is to get on Google Maps so search it
and let's put it here
so here we have the path you should take
to get to large cricket ground now here
the map is a combination of red yellow
and blue now the blue regions signify a
clear road that is you won't encounter
traffic there the yellow indicate that
they are slightly congested and red
means they're heavily congested so let's
look at the map a different version of
the same map and here as I told you
before red means heavily congested
yellow means slow moving and blue means
clear
so how exactly is Google able to tell
you that the traffic is clear slow
moving or heavily congested so this is
with the help of machine learning and
with the help of two important measures
first is the average time that's taken
on specific days at specific times on
that route the second one is the
real-time location data of vehicles from
Google Maps and with the help of sensors
some of the other popular map services
are Bing Maps maps.me and here we go
next up we have social media
personalization so say I want to buy a
drone and I'm on Amazon and I want to
buy a DJI mavic Pro the thing is it's
close to one lap so I don't want to buy
it right now but the next time I'm on
Facebook I'll see an advertisement for
the product next time I'm on YouTube
I'll see an advertisement even on
Instagram I'll see an advertisement so
here with the help of machine learning
Google has understood that I'm
interested in this particular product
hence it's targeting me with these
advertisements this is also with the
help of machine learning let's talk
about email spam filtering now this is a
spam that's in my inbox now how does
Gmail know what spam and what's not spam
so Gmail has an entire collection of
emails which have already been labeled
as spam or not spam so after analyzing
this data Gmail is able to find some
characteristics like the word lottery or
winner from then on any new email that
comes to your inbox goes through a few
spam filters to decide whether it's spam
or not now some of the popular spam
filters that Gmail uses is content
filters header filters General Blacklist
filters and so on next we have online
fraud detection now there are several
ways that online fraud can take place
for example there's identity theft where
they steal your identity fake accounts
where these accounts only last for how
long the transaction takes place and
stop existing after that and man in the
middle attacks where they steal your
money while the transaction is taking
place the feed forward neural network
helps determine whether a transaction is
genuine or fraudulent so what happens
with feed forward neural networks are
that the outputs are converted into hash
values and these values become the
inputs for the next round so for every
real transaction that takes place
there's a specific pattern a fraudulent
transaction would stand out because of
the significant changes is that it would
cause with the hash values Stock Market
trading machine learning is used
extensively when it comes to Stock
Market trading now you have stock market
indices like nikai they use long
short-term memory neural networks now
these are used to classify process and
predict data when there are time lags
the one known size and duration now this
is used to predict stock market trends
assist to Medical Technology now medical
technology has been innovated with the
help of machine learning diagnosing
diseases has been easier from which we
can create 3D models that can predict
where exactly there are lesions in the
brain it works just as well for brain
tumors and Ice chemic stock lesions they
can also be used in fetal Imaging and
cardiac analysis now some of the medical
fields that machine learning will help
assist in is disease identification
personalized treatment drug Discovery
clinical research and radiology and
finally we have automatic translation
now say you're in a foreign country and
you see Billboards and science that you
don't understand that's where automatic
translation comes of help now how does
automatic translation actually work the
technology behind it is the same as the
sequence of sequence learning which is
the same thing that's used with chatbots
here the image recognition happens using
convolutional neural networks and the
text is identified using optical
character recognition furthermore the
sequence to sequence algorithm is also
used to translate the text from one
language to the others
so first we will import some major
libraries of python so here I will write
import
ance as PD
and import
numpy
as NP
then
import
c bond
that's SNS
and import
SK learn
dot model selection
port
train underscore
test underscore split
before that
I will import
matplotlib
dot Pi plot
as PLT
okay then
I will write here from SK learn
Dot
Matrix
import
accuracy
for
than from
SK learn
dot matrix
import
classification
to report
and port
Ari
then import
string
okay
then press enter
so it is saying
okay here I have to write from
everything seems good
loading let's see
okay till then number is a python
Library used for working with arrays
which also has function for working with
domain of lineal algebra and matrices
it is an open source project and you can
use it freely
number stand for numerical python
pandas so panda is a software Library
written for Python programming language
for data manipulation and Analysis in
particular it offers data structure and
operation for manipulating numerical
tables and Time series
then
Seaborn
an open source python Library based on
matplotlib is called c-bone it is
utilized for data exploration and data
visualization with data frames and the
pandas Library c-bond functions with
ease
than matplotlib for Python and its
numerical extension numpy
matplotlib is a cross platform for the
data visualization and graphical
charting package
as a result it presents a strong open
source suitable for Matlab
the apis for matplotlib allow
programmers to incorporate graphs into
GUI applications then this train test
split we may build our training data and
the test data with the aid of SQL and
train test split function
this is so because the original data set
often serves as both the training data
and the test data starting with a single
data set we divide it into two data sets
to obtain the information needed to
create a model like hone and test
accuracy score the accuracy score is
used to Gorge the model's Effectiveness
by calculating the ratio of total true
positive to Total to negative across all
the model prediction
this re regular expression
the function in the model allow you to
determine whether a given text fits a
given regular expression or not
which is known as re
okay then string a collection of letters
words or other character is called a
string it is one of the basic data
structure that serves as the foundation
of manipulating data
the Str class is a built-in string class
in Python because python strings are
immutable they cannot be modified after
they have been formed
okay so now let's import the data set we
will be going to import two data set one
for the fake news and one for the True
News or you can say not fake news okay
so I will write here
EF underscore
big was to
PD Dot
read underscore CSV
or what can I say dear fake
okay
it underscore fake
then
pick
dot CSV
you can download this data set from the
description box below
then data Dot
true
plus so PD dot read
underscore CSV
sorry CSC
plan
fake news sorry true
dot CHP
then press enter
so these are the two data set
you can download these data set from the
description box below so let's see the
board data set okay
then I will write here data underscore
fake
dot head
so this is the fake data okay then
data underscore true
Dot
and this is the two data
okay this is not fake
so if you want to see your top five rows
of the particular data set you can use
head
and if you want to see the last five
rows of the data set you can use tail
instead of head
okay
so let me give some space for the better
visual
so now we will insert column class as a
Target feature okay then I will write
here data
let's go fake
Plus
equals to zero
then
Theta underscore true
and
Plus
was one
okay
then
I will write here data underscore fake
dot shape
and
data underscore true
dot ship
okay then press enter
so the shape method return the shape of
an array the shape is a tuple of
integers these number represent the
length of the corresponding array
dimension in other words a tuple
containing the quantities of entries on
each axis is an array shape dimension
so what's the meaning of shape
in the fake word
in this data set we have two three four
eight one rows and five columns
and in this data set true
we have two one four one seven rows and
five column okay so these are the rows
column rows column for the particular
data set
so now let's move
and let's remove the last 10 rows for
the manual testing okay
then I will write here data underscore
fake
foreign
testing
was to
data underscore fake
dot tail
for the last 10 rows I have to write
here 10.
okay so for I
in range
two three four
eight one
sorry zero
comma 2 3
4 7 0
comma minus 1.
okay
and
TF underscore not DF data
underscore fake
dot drop
one
yeah instead of one I can write here I
comma
this is equals to zero
place
equals to true
then
data
material
data underscore
same I will write for I will copy from
here
and I will paste it here
and I will make the particular changes
so here I can write true
that I can write true
okay
then I have to change a number
two one
six
right
2 1 4 0 6
-1
same
so press enter
X is equals to zero
valid since X maybe you mean double zero
or so of this
okay we will put here double course
and I am putting this
take dot drop i x is equal to zero okay
in place okay
and also write equals to a question
yeah
so
okay axis is not defined
now it's working so
let me see
now
did the
underscore
fake dot shape
okay
and data dot true
and
data underscore true
dot shape
as you can see
10 rows are deleted from each data set
yeah
so I will write here data underscore
fake underscore manual
testing
class
equals to zero
and data underscore
true
let's go
manual underscore testing
class equals to
one
okay
just ignore this warning
and
let's see
data underscore
fake underscore
manual
testing dot hat
as you can see we have this
and then data dot sorry underscore true
underscore
manual
testing
dot at
10.
this is this is the true data set
so here I will merge data
underscore merge
you
PD Dot
concat
concat is used for the concatenation
data underscore fake
data underscore
comma
axis
equals to zero
then data underscore merge
dot head
the top 10 rows
yeah
as you can see the data is merged
here
okay
first it will come for the fake news and
then with that for the True News
and let's merge true and fake data
frames okay
we did this and
let's merge the column then data dot
merge
Dot
columns or let's see the columns
it is not defined whatever data
underscore much
these are the column same title tag
subject date class okay
now
let's remove those columns which are not
required for the further process
so here I will write data underscore
or request to
data underscore merge
prop
title I don't need
that
subject
we don't need
and
so one
so let's check some null values
it's giving here
because of this
that's good then data
dot is null
Center
so no null values
okay then
let's do the random shuffling of the
data frames okay
for that we have to write here data
equals to
data dot sample
one
then
data
okay
dot hat
now you can see here the random
shuffling is done
and one for the
true data reset and zero for the fake
news on okay
then
let me write here data Dot
reset
underscore index
place
because you
true
dot drop
comma X is
equals to 1
then comma in place
true true
okay
then let me see columns now data Dot
columns
so here we have two columns only rest we
have deleted
okay
so
see data Dot at
yeah
everything seems good
let's proceed further and let's create a
function to process the text okay
for that I will write here
but
okay
you can use any name
text
and text equals to
text Dot lower
okay
and text
for the substring
remove these things
from the
datas
okay
so for that I'm writing here
comma
okay
then text equals to
re Dot substring
comma
comma text
okay
then I have to write text equals to
r e Dot substring
www
Dot
S Plus
comma
from our text
okay then text equals to
re Dot substring
then
oh
comma
okay
then
text equals to
re Dot substring
then
percentage
as
again percentage or
RG dot SK function
right here string
dot punctuation
comma
then comma then text
right
then text equals to re Dot substring
and n
comma
x equals to
re Dot
substring
right here
and again d
then again
then comma
and again
texture
okay then at the end after right here
return text
so everything like this these type of
special character will be removed from
the data set
okay let's run this let's see
yeah so here I will add DF sorry not DF
data
then
text
also
data
okay dot apply
to the function name wordpot what opt
okay
press enter
yeah so now let's define the dependent
and independent variables okay x equals
to
data
text
and Y equals to
data
class
okay
then splitting training and testing data
okay sorry
so here I will write X underscore train
comma X underscore test
uh then y underscore train
comma y underscore test equals to
train underscore test underscore split
then X comma y
comma test
let's go size equals to
0.25
okay press enter
so now let's convert text to vectors
for that I have to write here
that it's X
so here I will write from sqlarn
dot feature
extraction
Dot text import
t
vectorizer
okay
then vectorization
plus 2 tfid
factorizer
okay
then
three
underscore
train
equals to
vectorization
refactorization dot fit
that transform
X underscore train
okay
then
XV underscore test equals to
factorization
Dot transform
X underscore test
okay then press enter
[Music]
so now let's see our first model
logistic regression
so here I will write
from
sqlan Dot
linear underscore model
okay import
logistic
regression
then a lot
equals to
logistic
regression
and
have to write here LR Dot
fit
then XV
Dot
not DOT so dot train
comma
x v underscore test
okay
press enter
dot XV dot train
okay here I have to write y train
and press enter
will work so here I will write
prediction
underscore
linear regression
l r dot predict
XV underscore test
okay let's see the accuracy score
for that I have to write l r dot score
then XV underscore test
comma y underscore test
okay
let's see the accuracy so here as you
can see accuracy is quite good 98
percent
now let's print
the classification
code
by underscore test comma
prediction of linear regression
okay
so this is you can see Precision score
then F1 is code then support value
accuracy
okay
so now we will do this same for the
decision free gradient boosting
classifier random Forest classifier okay
then we will do model testing then we
will predict this score
so now for the decision tree
classification so for that I have to
import from SK learn
Dot 3
import
decision
free
classifier
okay
then at the short form I will write here
I will copy it from here
then
okay
then I have to write the same as this so
I will copy it from here
and
let's change linear regression
to
season three classifier
okay
then I will write here same
let's go DT
question
DT dot predict
XV underscore
test
it's me
still loading it's it will take time
okay
till then let me write here for the
accuracy
DT DOT score
V underscore test
comma y
let's wait okay
let's run
the accuracy
so as you can see accuracy is good than
this linear regression
okay logistic regression
okay so let me
show you the
let me predict
trend
okay
so this is the accuracy score this is
the all the report
yeah
so now let's move for the gradient
boosting classifier
okay for that I've read from
sqlan
dot ensemble
port
gradient
boosting
classifier
I will write here GB
equals to let me copy it from here
I will give here random
let's go state
equals to zero
wait wait wait wait so I will write here
GB Dot
fit
underscore train
comma
y underscore train okay then press enter
here I will write predict
underscore GB
also
GB Dot
wait sorry
predict
three
Dot test
dot dot underscore test
till then it's loading so I will write
here uh it's for this code then I will
add GB
DOT score
then
three underscore test
comma
y underscore test
okay
so let's wait it is running this part
till then let me write for the
printing this
case taking time
taking time still taking time
45 will run this
it's not coming because of this
yeah it's done now so you can see the
accuracies
not good then
decision tree but yeah it is also good
.4 something okay so
now let's check for the last one random
Forest
first I will do
for the random for us we have to write
from sqlarn Dot
symbol
import
random
Forest
classifier
okay
and here I will write RF
equals to
right I will copy it from here
then
random
date
question
RF Dot
fit
three underscore train
comma y underscore train
okay then press enter
and predict
underscore
RC
or F
equals to
RF dot predict
three underscore test
okay
till then I will write here still
loading it will take time
so till then I will write for the score
score accuracy score
XV underscore test comma y underscore
test
okay
then I will write here till then print
classification
port
and Y underscore test
comma
it will take time little bit
so
it run the accuracy score is 99 it is
also good
so now I will add the code for the model
testing so I will get back to you
but after writing the code so
so I have made two functions one for the
output label and one for the manual
testing okay
so it will predict
the all the from the all models from the
repeat so it will predict
the the news is fake or not from all the
models okay
so for that
let me write
your news
also string
what
okay
then I will write a manual underscore
testing
so
here I will you can add any news from
the you can copy it from the Internet or
whatever from wherever you want
so I'm just copying from the internet
okay from the Google
the news
which is not fake okay I'm adding which
is not fake because I already know I
searched on Google so I'm entering this
so just run it let's see what is showing
okay
string input object is not callable okay
let me check this first
a I have to give here Str only
yeah I check
okay I have to add here again the Escape
yeah
manual testing is not defined
let me see manual testing
okay I have to edit something
it is just GB and it is just RF
in GPS is not defined okay okay
so what I have to do
I have to remove this
this
everything seems sorted
now
as I said to you
I just copied this news from the
internet I already know the news is not
fake so it is showing not a fake news
okay so now what I will do I will copy
one fake news from the internet
and let's see it is detecting it or not
okay
so let me run this
and let me add the news for this
so
all the models are predicting right it
is a fake news
or you can add your own script like this
is the fake news okay
I hope you guys understand
till here
so I hope you guys must have understand
how to detect a fake news using machine
learning you can you can copy it any
news from the internet and you can check
it is fake or not okay or if your model
is predicting right or not if you are an
aspiring machine learning engineer
looking for online training and
certifications from prestigious
universities and in collaboration with
leading experts then search no more
simple lens professional certification
program in Ai and machine learning from
Purdue University in collaboration with
IBM should be a right choice for more
details use the link in the description
box below with that in mind
opencv open source computer vision
library is an open source computer
vision and machine learning software
Library it is written in C plus plus but
has a binding for various programming
languages such as python Java Matlab
opencv was designed with the goal of
providing a common infrastructure for
computer vision applications and to
accelerate the use of machine learning
perception in commercial product opencv
is widely used in a variety of indices
including robotics automotive and
Healthcare it's supported by a large
community of developers researchers and
users who contribute to its development
and provide supports to its users it is
supported by a large community of
developers researchers and users who
contribute to its development and
provide supports to its users so now
let's see what is object detection
object detection is a computer vision
technology that involves identifying and
localizing the object of interest within
an image or a video it is a challenging
task as it involves not only recognizing
the presence of an object but also
detecting its precise location and size
within the image or video object
detection algorithm typically used deep
learning techniques such as CNN to
analyze the image or video for
identifying the objects these algorithm
can also determine the boundaries of the
object by drawing a bounding box around
them so after understanding what is
object detection now let's move on to
the programming part so this is a kernel
python kernel here we will change this
name
so here I will write object
detection
demo
okay
so
first we will import some major Library
like opencv so for that we will write
import CB2 and the next one is import
matplotlab
dot Pi plot
as PLT
so why we are writing PLT because we
can't write again and again matplotlib
dot pipelot okay it's a long one so we
can write a short form PLT
so yeah
so let's run this
so what is opencv opencv is an open
source software library for computer
vision and machine learning the opencv
full form is open source computer vision
Library it was created to provide a
shared infrastructure for application
for computer vision and to speed up the
use of machine learning perception in
consumer products opencv has a BSD
license software make it simple for
companies to use and change the code
okay so there are some predefined
packages and libraries that make our
life simple and opencv is one of them
again one is matte broadly matte
bloodlib is a easy to use and an amazing
visualize library in Python it is built
on numpy array and designed to work with
broader sci-fi stack and consists of
several plots like line bars scatter
histogram and many others okay so moving
forward we will import our file okay so
here I will write config
file
equals to this is our file name SSD
underscore
mobilenet
to V3
large
Coco
22.
14 dot DB
okay
so you can find this file on the
description box below
model
question
explain you
every single thing
inference
graph
dot PV okay
so let me run it first
mobilenet as a name applied the mobile
net model is designed to use in mobile
application and its tensorflow first
mobile computer vision model mobilenet
use depth wise separable convolutions it
significantly reduces the numbers of
parameter when compared to the network
with regular convolutions with the same
depth in their heads this result in the
lightweight of the deep neural network
so mobilenet is a class of CNN that was
open source by Google and therefore this
gives us an excellent starting point for
training our classifiers that are
insanely small and insanely fast okay so
what is this large Coco this is a data
set Coco data set like with applications
such as object detection segmentation
and captioning the Coco data set is
widely understood by the state of the
art of neural network its versatility as
a multi-purpose scene variations of best
to train a computer vision model and
Benchmark its performance okay so what
is Coco the common object and context is
one of the most popular large scale
labeled images data available for public
use it represents a handful of objects
we encounter on a daily basis and
contains Imaging notations in 80
categories I will show you the
categories I have with over 1.5 million
object instances okay so modern day AI
driven solution are still not capable of
producing absolute accuracy and result
which comes down to the fact that Coco
dataset is a major Benchmark for CV to
drain test and polish refine models for
faster scaling of The annotation
Pipeline on the top of that the Coco
data set is a supplement to transfer
learning where the data used for one
model serves as a starting point for the
another so what is frozen Insurance
graph like freezing is the process to
identify and save all the required
graphs like weights and many others in a
single file that you can usually use a
typical tensorflow model contains
profile and this com contains a complete
graph okay so forward let's create one
model here I will add model
CV2 dot DNN
model
chosen
and
then
config file
so here I am giving the parameters two
parameters like frozen model and config
file
score here yeah we run it first
okay there is error
okay so either is cv2.dnn detection
model returned as resolved
with an exception set
the question comes what is the meaning
of detection model or DNN detection
model
for this class represent the high level
API for object detection networks
detection models allows to set
parameters for pre-processing input
image detection model creates net from
file and with trained weights and config
sets in processing input runs forward
pass and return the result detections
okay moving forward let's set the class
levels
class
labels
file name
txt
I will put this file on the description
box below you can download from there
open
file name
pass labels
the strip
so here I created one array of name
class labels so this is the file name
what I am doing I am putting this label
file into this class label okay so here
if I will print
class labels
so these are the 80
categories in the Coco data set
okay this person bicycle car motorbike
airplane bus train these all are the 80
categories
I will put this file label.txt in the
description box below you can download
from them
okay fine
so let's print the length of the Coco
data set or you can see class labels
this is 80 as you can see I have already
told you
the length will be 80.
so here let's
set this some model input size scaling
mean and all so I will write here model
Dot
set
eyes
320 comma 20.
set
input
scale
1.0
slash 127
0.5
okay I will explain you don't worry
model dot set
import
me
127.5
comma 127.5
okay and then model
dot set
to web
B
will be
what is set input size
okay
so set input size is a size of new frame
the shape of the new blob Less Than Zero
okay so this is the size of the new
frame the second one is set input scale
the set input scale is a scale factor of
the value for the frame
or you can say the perimeter will be the
multiplier of the frame values or you
can say multiplier for the frame values
okay so at input mean so it set the mean
value for the frame the frame in which
the photo will come the video will come
or my webcam will come so it set the
mean value for the frame or the four
parameters mean scalar with the mean
values which are subtracted from the
channels you can say and the last one is
set input swap RB so it set the flag
swap RB for the every frame we don't
have to put every time a single frame
for a particular image it will be set
the true for the all the images okay so
parameters will be swipe I'll be flagged
which indicates the swipe first and the
last channels so moving forward we will
put one image
M read
y dot jpg
Dot
I am sure
so this is the size of 320 by 320 okay
so first thing is
you can download this the random picture
from the Google I took from Google
itself so now what we will do
we will set the class index
the confidence value
box is the boundary box which I will
create for that particular person cycle
motorbike and the car
okay
because to model
kept
the confidence threshold
threshold is used for
if my model will confirm it's the
particular image which is detecting is
correct it will print the name
okay
so let me print
pass
class index is coming one two three four
okay so one means person
two means bicycle
three means car and four means motorbike
this is the class index index for
particular level what I will do I will
print the boxes
font
here
equals to 3
and the font equals to CV2 Dot
font Hershey
again
for
class
index and then
confidence and the boxes
and
x dot
pattern
100 days
box the boundary box
okay
and I will write here CV2 dot rectangle
make the rectangle
set the image
and boxes
I've
comma 0 comma zero
this is the color of the box and this
will be the thickness
okay
then I will write CV2 dot put
text
image then
first labels
I will write class
index minus 1
because always index start with 0.
that's fine and the boxes
zero
and
comma boxes
one
body
okay
font comma
scale
pursue font
color
question
this will be the text column
0 comma 255
comma 0
and the thickness
two three
let me run it
no error okay now PLT dot I am sure
then CV2 dot CBT
color
then
come on CV t two
dot color
me
hello
prg
that is why we wrote
swap RB equals to true because every
time we will convert pgr to brg
sorry
GB
RGB so we don't have to write again and
again it will convert all the files into
RGB okay run it
okay as you can see the motorbike is
coming
bicycle is coming the person is coming
the card will come the car is coming
okay so it's detecting the right
for the image now we will do this for
the video and for the webcam
we are done with this image one and then
now I will write here
okay
so this is will do for the video
for the video I will write here cap
equals to capture
you can write any name so CV2 Dot
video
capture
so you can take any random video I took
this pixels
George
you can comment down
share the link
for
app dot is open
so here I will add cap
equals to
be 2
sorry CV2
Dot video
capture
zero
and if not
cap
dot is open
then
and this
input output
error
and
open the video
and open the video
here everything will be the same font
scale
equals to 3
okay I want
equals to CV2 Dot
font
e
in
okay
so here I will write while true
from a frame
equals to cap dot sheet
this for the reading of the file
the same I will write class index
comma confidence
from a boundary box
question model
dot detect
game
and the confidence
threshold
so 0.55
okay everything is the same
we did before so here I will print
class
index
okay
so here I will write if
and
the class index
does not equals to zero
and what to perform is here I have to
add 4
class index
comma confidence
got my boxes
and zip
us
tax Dot
flatten
flatten is a layers
okay
go on for this
flatten
key box
and if
class
index is greater than equals to 80.
then
what to do
here
okay the same thing I have to write here
so here I will write CV2 Dot
I am sure
this will be the return in the frame
object detection
by simply learn
and frame
so if CV2 Dot
weight key
to
and 0
f of x
equals to
Ord
Q okay
then
here I will write Brink
will you break when
and get into two the weight key will be
2.
okay I will tell you what is the weight
key
so here I will write cap dot release
and CV2 Dot
destroy
or Windows
okay
so now let me run
it's here there will be better okay
CB Python programming language modules
we run it again
activate keys
okay
so video is here
the video is here as you can see see
bicycle
the person the person the bus car
traffic light the person person so it
our object detection for the video is
coming right
okay person
okay person traffic light bus
this is how you can do for the video
okay
so now let's we will do for the webcam
live
so this is for the video so
if
we want to do for the webcam we
okay
so we need to just change
one one thing only we have to change
instead of giving the file we have to
write one here
okay the rest will be the same
got it so I have to just shut down my
webcam
so
let me shut down the webcam and get back
to you
so as you can see
this is a 320 by 320 box so
so this is coming right okay so I if I
will show this the mobile phone is
coming right now okay so this is how you
can do the correct object detection if
you are an aspiring machine learning
engineer looking for online training and
certifications from prestigious
universities and in collaboration with
leading experts then search no more
simple lens professional certification
program in Ai and machine learning from
Purdue University in collaboration with
IBM should be a right choice for more
details use the link in the description
box below with that in mind so first we
will open command prompt to write a
command to open jupyter notebook so here
we will write Jupiter
notebook
then press enter
so it will take some time yeah
so this is the landing page of Jupiter
notebook and here we have to new then
python3
so this is how the jupyter notebook UI
look likes so at first we will import
some major libraries of python which
help in creating a mass detection system
so here I will write import
CV2 comma OS
and press enter then I will give the
path then data path
equals to
see
then slash
users
and Slash
SLP
zero nine three seven five
and Slash
desktop
then slash
and face
mask
detection
then slash
data set
okay
so here it will be slash my bad sorry
and Slash
okay let's look fine
so here I will write categories
equals to OS Dot
list
directory this dir
then I will assign data underscore path
then I will create some labels
equals to
here I will write
I will write here I
for
i n
range
then here I will give length
of
categories
yeah
then press enter Then here I will write
label
then detect
directory
pursue
directory then
zip then categories
comma labels
so here I will write print
then
label directory
okay then I will print
categories
then I will print labels
okay then press enter
yeah
so here CV means
capturing video the CV2 function in
opencv can read video video capture by
using pass zero as a function parameter
we can access our webcam
we may pass rtsp URL in the function
parameter to capture CCTV footage which
is quite helpful for video analysis then
OS this this OS module
the OS module in Python has function for
adding and deleting folders retrieving
their contents changing the directory
locating the current directory and more
before you can communicate with the
underlying operation system you must
import the OS module
and this OS list directory
to retrieve a list of all files and
folders in the given directory use
Python OS dot list directory method the
list of files are directory in the
current working directory will be
returned if no directory is specified
then label
the the TK enter widget class called a
label is used to show text or an image
the user views the label they cannot be
interact with it so moving forward I
will write code so just stay with me
after that I will explain you line wise
okay
so here
I will write
that
image underscore size
equals to 100
then I will create two classes data
then Target
okay
arrays
then I will write here for category
in categories
folder
underscore
path
equals to OS dot path
then dot join
then data
underscore path
comma
category
okay then IMG
image names equals to OS dot list
directory then folder path
just stay with me I will explain you
line wise
okay so here I will write for
IMG name
in IMG
names
IMG underscore path
equals to OS dot path
Dot
join
then I will write here folder
I repeat
I repeat so here we like folder
underscore path
then
IMG underscore name
so IMG equals to CV2
dot I am read
then IMG underscore path
so here I will try
that gray
equals to
CV2
dot CVT
and capital c color
then IMG comma CV2
Dot
then color
then underscore B gr to RGB
okay
so I will go for the gray one
CVT color pgr
towards you yeah
so I will write here resize okay not in
capital letter G size
equals to CV2
dot resize
then Gray
comma IMG
size
comma
I am Jason
why these two mg size because like
length and like width and breadth would
be same
like 100 so press enter
so I will write Theta Dot
a pen
then resized
then Target
dot append
then label
then directory
of category
okay
so
I will write here except
exception
as e
so here I will print
and
exception
comma e
okay then press enter let's see there
should be no error
so it is loading let's wait
okay no error
so image size should be like 100 by 100
so that is why I wrote here 100 the
enemy size 100 by 100. and I made two
arrays like for one for data then one
for targets
so
this for this great question cb2.cvt
color image so converting the image into
grayscale okay then this line resize
equals to CB2 dot resize gray IMG
so resizing the gray scale into like 100
by 100 since we need a fixed common size
for all the images in the data set okay
then this target a DOT append labeled
electrical so appending the image like
and the label categories into the list
list what is list data set
so like for the last print exception e
so if any exception raised the exception
will be printed here and the pass to the
next image okay
so moving forward let's import numpy and
save this data and the target okay so I
will write here
import
numpy
as NP
right
then I will write here data
equals to
NP dot array
then again data
by 255
.0
okay
then again data equals to NP Dot
reshape
then data
comma
data
dot shape
then zero
comma mg size
comma IMG size
comma one
okay
then press enter Then for Target
let me put those just like this then
Target equals to NP dot array
then Target
okay
so here I will write from
Keras Dot
utils
import
and be utils
okay
so here I will add new underscore Target
equals to
NP underscore utils
dot two
underscore categories
categorical I guess categorical
then Target
okay
then press enter
so here I will save NP dot save
this data
comma data
okay and NP dot save
this target
comma new Target
okay
so press enter
here
so numpy numpa is a python Library used
for working with Aris it also has a
function for working with in the domain
of linear algebra and matrices it is an
open source project and you can use it
freely numpy stands for numerical python
and they scared us a python interface
for artificial neutral network is
provided by the open source software
package known as Keras the tensorflow
library interface is provided by the
Keras a number of backends were
supported by krrs up until version 2.3
including tensorflow Microsoft cognitive
so this is the part of the data
processing this all this part of the
data processing so let me write here
data
pre-processing free processor
so the data preprocessing part is done
now we will create the another file of
this python for the training CNN CNN
means convocational neural network okay
test data
comma
train underscore Target
comma test underscore
Target
because you train
underscore split
then we will split on data and Target
comma S size should be
0.1
okay so now I will give a press enter
okay train speed train split is not
defined
okay
it is change
test split
yeah
so now I will write checkpoint
equals to model
checkpoint
then again
model
I repeat so here I will write model
comma
epoch
than 0 3D
dot model
okay
so here I have to write comma monitor
equals to Value loss
underscore
loss
comma
verbose
equals to zero
comma save
best
only
because you
through
drama mode
because two more should be Auto
okay
then I will press enter
then here I will write history
it goes to model
Dot
with
to train
underscore data
comma
okay then
underscore Target
comma
apoc is equals to 20
comma callbacks
callback is equals to
checkpoint
comma validation
validation underscore displayed
equals to 0.2 the best ratio okay
so let me press enter okay there is one
error model dot fit code 10x
okay there should be a spelling mistake
epoch
pochs
pursue 20.
foreign
model it is fine
then monitor
was to Value loss
then
bubbles equals to zero
save best only because it true then more
Okay so
here I have to write
oops
maybe it will so it will take some time
to go till 20 okay so it will download
one by one
so we will wait
for a while
so the model checkpoints are completed
so here I will write print
then model
dot evaluate
okay
here I will write test underscore data
comma test
underscore Target
then press enter
okay so I hope you guys understand till
here if you have any question or any
query regarding any code just put as in
comments our team will surely provide
you the correct solution okay so moving
forward we will do we will create
another file for detecting mask okay so
I will go here and then
new file
python
so I will write here detecting
okay
yeah
so I will import some libraries here
here as dot models
import load
models
we will import
CV2
and we will import
numpy
as NP
so press enter
okay number as anything
okay so press enter
so what I will do I will write here
model equals to load underscore model
then
okay
Keras model from chaos cannot import
name
Okay so
it is model only
yeah
so here I will add model equals to load
model
so I will write a model
dot model
okay
so here I will write face underscore
classifier
equals to CB2
Dot
Cascade
Cascade classifier
so this is one file for frontal phase
default so you can find this file on the
description box below so I will write
here
our Cascade
underscore
until
face
underscore default
dot XML
okay
so source
equals to
CV2
Dot
video
capture
zero it will open our camera
so labels
underscore
directory
question
must
and one for
no mask
okay
so colors
directory equals to
like no mask for red and mask for green
okay so here at zero
then 0 comma 2
55 comma 0
then again comma
for one that should be
0 comma zero comma 251
okay
so I hope you guys understand till here
so if you have any question or any query
regarding any code so just put as in
comments our team will surely provide
you the correct solution
so
the code is written
so let me run this
for this first I have to like
so first I have to close my this person
on screen camera
so
the code is running fine
now it is showing no Mass
now it is showing us
so I hope you guys understand till here
if you have any queries any question
regarding any code just put as his
comment our team will shortly provide
you the correct solution if you are an
aspiring machine learning engineer
looking for online training and
certifications from prestigious
universities and in collaboration with
leading experts then search no more
simply learns professional certification
program in Ai and machine learning from
Purdue University in collaboration with
IBM should be a right choice for more
details use the link in the description
box below with that in mind we'll talk
about interview questions
now this
this View
attending interviews or machine learning
positions and the attempt here is to
probably consolidate 30 most commonly
asked questions
and to help you in answering these
questions we tried our best to give you
the best possible answers but of course
what is more important here is rather
than the theoretical knowledge you need
to kind of add to the answers or
supplementary or answers with your own
experience
experience of the responses that we put
here are a bit more generic in nature so
that if there are some Concepts that you
are not clear this video will help you
in kind of getting those Concepts
cleared up as well but what is more
important is that you need to supplement
these responses with your own practical
experience okay so with that let's get
started so one of the first questions
that you may face is what are the
different types of machine
now what is the best way to respond to
this there are three types of machine
learning if you read any material you
will always be told there are three
types of machine but what is important
is you would probably be better of
emphasizing that there are actually two
main types of emotional learning which
is supervised and unsupervised and then
there is a third type which is
reinforcement learn so supervised
learning is where you have some
historical data and then you feed that
data to your model to learn now you need
to be aware of a keyword that they will
be looking for which is labeled data
right so if you just say pass data or
historical data the impact may not be so
much you need to emphasize on labeled
data so what is labeled data basically
let's say if you are trying to do train
your model for classification you need
to be aware of for your existing data
which class each of the observations
belong to right so that is what is
labeling so it is nothing but a fancy
name you must be already aware but just
make it a point to throw in that keyword
labeled so that will have the right
so that is what is supervised learning
when you have existing labeled data
which you then use to train your model
that is known as supervised learning and
unsupervised learning is when you don't
have this labeled data so you have data
it is not labeled so the system has to
figure out a way to do some analysis on
this okay so that is unsupervised
learning and you can then add a few
things like what are the ways of
performing a supervised learning and
unsupervised learning or what are some
of the techniques so supervised learning
we we perform or we do
regression and classification and
unsupervised learning we do clustering
and clustering can be of different types
similarly regression can be of different
types but you don't have to probably
elaborate so much if they are asking for
just the different types you can just
mention these and just at a very high
level but if they want you to elaborate
give examples then of course then I
think there is a different question
then the third so we have supervised and
we have unsupervised and then
reinforcement you need to provide a
little bit of information around that as
well because it is sometimes a little
difficult to come up with a good
definition for reinforcement so you may
have to little bit elaborate on how
reinforcement learning works works right
so reinforcement learning works in in
such a way that it basically has two
parts to it one is the agent and the N1
and the agent basically is working
inside of this environment and it is
given a Target that it has to achieve
and every time it is moving in the
direction of the target so the agent
basically has to take some action and
every time it takes an action which is
moving uh the agent towards the Target
right towards a goal a Target is nothing
but a goal then it is rewarded and every
time it is going in a direction where it
is away from the goal then it is
punished so that is the way you can
little bit explain and this is used
primarily or very very impactful or
teaching the system to learn games and
so on examples of this are basically
used in alphago you can throw that as an
example where alphaco used reinforcement
learning to actually learn to play the
game of Go and finally it defeated the
co-world champion right this much of
information that would be good enough
then there could be a question on
overfitting uh so the question could be
what is overfitting and how can you
avoid it so what is overfitting so let's
first try to understand the concept
because sometimes overfitting may be a
little difficult to understand
overfitting is a situation where the
model has kind of memorized the data so
this is an equivalent of memorizing the
data so we can draw an analogy so that
it becomes
explain this now let's say you're
teaching a child about recognizing some
fruits or something like that
and you're teaching this child about
recognizing let's say three fruits
apples oranges and pineapples
this is a small child and for the first
time you're teaching the child to
recognize fruits then so what will
happen so this is very much like that is
your training data set so what you will
do is you will take a basket of fruits
which consists of apples oranges and
pineapples
and you take this basket to this child
and there may be let's say hundreds of
these fruits so you take this basket to
this child and keep showing each of this
fruit and then first time obviously the
child will not know what it is so you
show an apple and you say hey this is
Apple then you show maybe an orange and
say this is orange and so on and so and
then again you keep repeating that right
so till that basket is over this is
basically how training work in machine
learning also that's how training works
so till the basket is completed maybe
100 fruits you keep showing this child
and then the process what has happened
the child has pretty much memorized
these so even before you finish that
basket right by the time you are halfway
through the child has learned about
recognizing the Apple orange and
pineapple now what will happen after
halfway through initially you remember
it made mistakes in recognizing but
halfway through now it has learned so
every time you show a fruit it will
exactly 100 accurately it will identify
it will say the child will say this is
an apple this is an orange and if you
show a pineapple it will say this is a
pineapple
app so that means it has kind of
memorized this data now let's say you
bring another basket of fruits and it
will have a mix of maybe apples which
were already there in the previous set
but it will also have in addition to
Apple it will probably have a banana or
maybe another fruit like a jackfruit
right so this is an equivalent of your
test data set which the child has not
seen before some parts of it it probably
has seen like the apples it has seen but
this banana and Jackfruit it has not
seen so then what will happen in the
first round which is an equivalent of
your training data set towards the end
it has 100 percent it was telling you
what the fruits are right Apple was
accurately recognized orange or I was
accurately recognized and pineapples
were accurately recognized right so that
is like a hundred percent accuracy but
now when you get another a fresh set
which we're not a part of the original
one what will happen all the apples
maybe it will be able to recognize
correctly but all the others like the
Jackfruit or the banana will not be
recognized by the child right so this is
an analogy this is an equivalent of
overfitting so what has happened during
the training process it is able to
recognize or reach 100 accuracy maybe
very high accuracy okay and we call that
as very low loss right so that is the
technical term so the loss is pretty
much zero and accuracy is pretty much
hundred percent whereas when you use
testing there will be a huge error which
means the loss will be pretty high and
therefore the accuracy will be also low
okay this is known as overfitting this
is basically a process where training is
done training processes it goes very
well almost reaching 100 accuracy but
while testing it really drops down now
how can you avoid it so that is the
extension of this question there are
multiple ways of avoiding overfitting
there are techniques like what you call
regularization that is the most common
technique that is used for avoiding
overfitting and within regularization
there can be a few other subtypes like
drop out in case of neural networks and
a few other examples but I think if you
give example or if you give
regularization as the technique probably
that should be sufficient so so there
will be some questions where the
interviewer will try to test your
fundamentals and your knowledge and
depth of knowledge and so on and so
forth and then there will be some
questions which are more like quick
questions that will be more to stump you
okay then the next question is around
the methodology so when we are
performing machine learning training we
split the data into training and test
right so this question is around that so
the question is what is training set and
test set machine learning model and how
is the split
the question can be
so in
learning when we are trying to train the
model so we have a three-step process we
train the model and then we test the
model and then once we are satisfied
with the test only then we deploy the
model so what happens in the train and
test is that you remember the labeled
data so let's say you have 1000 records
with labeling information now one way of
doing it is you use all the Thousand
records for training and then maybe
right which means that you have exposed
all this thousand records during the
training process and then you take a
small set of the same data and then you
say okay I will test it with this okay
and then you probably what will happen
you may get some good results right it
but there is a flaw there what is the
flaw this is very similar to human
beings it is like you are showing this
model the entire data as a part of
training okay so obviously it has become
familiar with the entire data so when
you're taking a part of that again and
you're saying that I want to test it
obviously you will get good results so
that is not a very accurate way of
testing so that is the reason what we do
is we have the label data of this
thousand records or whatever we set
aside before starting the training
process we set aside a portion of that
data and we call that test set and the
remaining we call as training set and we
use only this for training our model now
the training process remember is not
just about passing one round of this
data set so let's say now your training
set has 800 records it is not just one
time you pass this 800 records what you
normally do is you actually as a part of
the training you may ask this data
through the model multiple times so this
thousand records may go through the
model maybe 10 15 20 times still the
training is perfect till the accuracy is
high till the errors are minimized okay
now so which is fine which means that
your that is what is known as the model
has seen your data and gets familiar
with your data and now when you bring
your test data what will happen is this
is like some
because that is where the real test is
now you've trained the model and now you
are testing the model with some data
which is kind of new that is like a
situation like like a realistic
situation because when the model is
deployed that is what will happen it
will receive some new data not the data
that it has already seen right so this
is a realistic test so you put some new
data so this data which you have set
aside is for the model it is new and if
it is able to accurately predict the
values that means your training has
worked okay the model got trained
properly but let's say while you are
testing this with this test data you are
getting lot of errors that means you
need to probably either change your
model or retrain with more data and
things like that
coming back to the question of how do
you split this what should be the ratio
there is no fixed number again this is
like individual preferences some people
split it into 50 50 test and 50 training
Some people prefer to have a larger
amount for training and a smaller amount
for test so they can go by either 60 40
or 70 30 or some people even go with
some odd numbers like 65 35 or
63.33 and 33 which is like one third and
two-thirds so there is no fixed rule
that it has to be something that's has
to be this you can go by your individual
preference all right then you may have
questions around uh data handling data
manipulation or
data management or Preparation so these
are all some questions around that area
there is again no one answer one single
good answer to this it really varies
from situation to situation
and depending on what exactly is the
problem what kind of data it is how
critical it is what kind of data is
missing and what is the type of
corruption so there are a whole lot of
things this is a very generic question
and therefore you need to be little
careful about responding to this as well
so you probably have to illustrate this
again if you have experience in doing
this kind of work in handling data you
can illustrate with examples saying that
I was on one project where I received
this kind of data these were the columns
where data was not filled or these were
this many rows where the data was
missing that would be in fact a perfect
way to respond to this question but if
you don't have that obviously you have
to provide some good answer I think it
really depends on what exactly the
situation is and there are multiple ways
of handling the
data or corrupt data now let's take a
few examples now let's say you have data
where some values in some of the columns
are missing and you have pretty much
half of your data having these missing
values in terms of number of rows okay
that could be one situation another
situation could be that you have records
or data missing but when you do some
initial calculation how many records are
corrupt or how many rows or observations
as we call it has this missing data
let's assume it is very minimal like a
10 percent okay now then between these
two cases how do we so let's assume that
this is not a mission critical situation
and in order to fix this 10 percent of
the data the effort that is required is
much higher and obviously effort means
also time and money right so it is not
so Mission critical and it is okay to
let's say get rid of these records so
obviously one of the easiest ways of
handling the data part or missing data
is remove those records or remove those
observations from your analysis so that
is the easiest way to do but then the
downside is as I said in as in the first
case if let's say 50 percent of your
data is like that because some column or
the other is missing so it is not like
every in every place in every Row the
same column is missing but you have in
maybe 10 percent of the records column
one is missing and another 10 percent
column two is missing another 10 percent
column three is missing and so on and so
forth so it adds up to maybe half of
your data set so you cannot completely
remove half of your data set then the
whole purpose is lost okay so then how
do you handle then you
then you're with ways of filling up this
data with some meaningful value right
that is one way of handling so when we
say meaningful value what is that
meaningful value let's say for a
particular column you might want to take
a mean value for that column and fill
wherever the data is missing fill up
with that mean value so that when you're
doing the calculations your analysis is
not completely way off so you have
values which are not missing first of
all so your system will work number two
these values are not so completely out
of whack that your whole analysis goes
for a task right there may be situations
where if the missing values instead of
putting mean may be a good idea to fill
it up with the minimum value or with a
zero so or with a maximum value again as
I said there are so many possibilities
so there is no like one correct answer
for this you need to basically talk
around this and illustrate with your
experience as I said that would be the
best otherwise this is how you need to
handle this
okay so then the next question can be
how can you choose a classifier based on
a training set data size so again this
is one of those questions where you
probably do not have like a one size
fits-all answer first of all you
may not let's say decide your classifier
based on the training set size maybe not
the best way to decide the type of the
classifier and even if you have to there
are probably some thumb rules which we
can use but then again every time so in
my opinion the best way to respond to
this question is you need to try out few
classifiers irrespective of the size of
the data and you need to then decide on
your particular situation which of these
classifiers are the right ones this is a
very generic issue so you will never be
able to just buy if somebody defines a
problem to you and somebody even if they
show the data to you or tell you what is
the data or even the size of the data I
don't think there is a way to really say
that yes this is the classifier that
will work here no that's not the right
way so you need to still you know test
it out get the data try out a couple of
classifiers and then only you will be in
a position to decide which classifier to
use you try out multiple classifiers see
which one gives the best accuracy and
only then you can decide then you can
have a question around confusion Matrix
so the question can be explained
confusion Matrix right so confusion
Matrix I think the best way to explain
it is by taking an example and drawing
like a small diagram otherwise it can
really become tricky so my suggestion is
to take a piece of pen and paper and
explain it by drawing a small Matrix and
confusion Matrix is about to find out
this is used especially in
classification learning process and when
you get the results when the our model
predicts the results you compare it with
the actual value and try to find out
what is the accuracy okay so in this
case let's say this is an example of a
confusion Matrix and it is a binary
Matrix so you have the actual values
which is the labeled data right and
which is so you have how many yes and
how many Norms so you have that
information and you have the predicted
values how many yes and how many you
know right so the total actual values
the total yes is 12 plus 130 and they
are shown here and the actual value
those are 9 plus 3 12 okay so that is
what this information here is so this is
about the actual and this is about the
predicted similarly the predicted values
there are yes are 12 plus 3 15 yeses and
no are 1 plus 9 10 nodes okay so this is
the way to look at this confusion Matrix
okay and uh out of this what is the
meaning converting so there are two or
three things that needs to be explained
out right the first thing is for a model
to be accurate the values across the
diagonal should be high like in this
case right that is one number two the
total sum of these values is equal to
the total observations in the test data
set so in this case for example you have
12 plus 3 15 plus 10 25 so that means we
have 25 observations in our test data
set okay so these are the two things you
need to First explain that the total sum
in this Matrix the numbers is equal to
the size of the test data set and the
diagonal values indicate the accuracy so
by just by looking at it you can
probably have a idea about is this an
accurate model is the model being
accurate if they're all spread out
equally in all these four boxes that
means probably the accuracy is not very
good okay now how do you calculate the
accuracy itself right how do you
calculate the accuracy itself so it is a
very simple mathematical calculation you
take some of the diagonals right so in
this case it is 9 plus 12 21 and divide
it by the total so in this case what
will it be let me take a pen so your
your diagonal values is equal to if I
say t is equal to 12 plus 9 so that is
21 right and the total data set is equal
to right we just calculated it is 25 so
what is your accuracy it is 21 by your
accuracy is equal to 21 by 25 and this
turns out to be about 85 percent right
so this is 85 percent so that is our
accuracy okay so this is the way you
need to explain raw diagram Give an
example and maybe it may be a good idea
to be prepared with an example so that
it becomes easy for you don't have to
calculate these numbers on the Fly Right
so a couple of hints are that you take
some numbers which are with which add up
to 100 that is always a good idea so you
don't have to really do this complex
calculations so the total value will be
100 and then diagonal values you divide
once you find the diagonal values that
is equal to your percentage okay all
right so the next question can be a
related question about false positive
and false negative so what is false
positive and what is false negative now
once again the best way to explain this
is using a piece of paper and then
otherwise it will be pretty difficult to
so if we use the same example of the
confusion Matrix
and we can explain that so A confusion
Matrix looks somewhat like this and when
we just
look somewhat like this and we continue
with the previous example where this is
the actual value this is the predicted
value and in the actual value we have 12
plus 113 yeses and 3 plus 9 12 nodes and
the predicted values there are 12 plus
the 15 yeses and 1 plus 9 10 loss okay
now this particular case which is the
false positive what is a false positive
first of all the second word which is
positive okay is referring to the
predicted value so that means the system
has predicted it as a positive but the
real value so this is what the false
comes from but the real value is not
positive okay that is the way you should
understand this term false positive or
even false negative so false positive so
positive is what your system has
predicted so where is that system
predicted this is the one positive is
what yes so you basically consider this
row okay now you consider this row so
this is this is all positive values this
entire row is positive values okay now
the false positive is the one which
where the value actual value is negative
predicted value is positive but the
actual value is negative so this is a
false positive right and here is a true
positive so the predicted value is
positive and the actual value is also
positive okay I hope this is making
sense now let's take a look at what is
false negative false negative so
negative is the second term that means
that is the predicted value that we need
to look for so which are the predicted
negative values this row corresponds to
predicted negative values all right so
this row corresponds to predicted
negative values and what they are asking
for false so this is the row for
predicted negative values and the actual
value is this one right this is
predicted negative and the actual value
is also negative therefore this is a
true negative so the false negative is
this one predicted is negative but
actual is positive right so this is the
false negative so this is the way to
explain and this is the way to look at
false positive and false negative same
way there can be true positive and true
negative as well so again positive the
second term you will need to use to
identify the predicted row right so if
we say true positive positive we need to
take for the predicted part so predicted
positive is here okay and then the first
term is for the actual so true positive
so true in case of actual is yes right
so true positive is this one okay and
then in case of actual the negative now
we are talking about let's say true
negative true negative negative is this
one and the true comes from here so this
is true negative right 9 is true
negative the actual value is also
negative and the predicted value is also
negative okay so that is the way you
need to explain this the term false
positive false negative and true
positive true negative then uh you might
have a question like what are the steps
involved in the machine learning process
or what are the three steps in the
process of developing a machine learning
model right so it is around the
methodology that is applied so basically
the way you can probably answer in your
own words but the way the model
development of the machine learning
model
first of all you try to understand the
problem and try to figure out whether it
is a classification problem or a
regression problem based on that you
select a few algorithms and then you
start the process of training these
models
so you can either do that or you can
after due diligence you can probably
decide that there is one particular
algorithm which is more suitable usually
it happens through trial and error
process but at some point you will
decide that okay this is the model we
are going to use okay so in that case we
have the model algorithm and the model
decided and then you need to do the
process of training the model and
testing the model and this is where if
it is supervised learning you split your
data the label data into training data
set and test data set and you use the
training data set to train your model
and then you use the test data set to
check the accuracy whether it is working
fine or not so you test the model before
you actually put it into production
right so once you test the model you're
satisfied it's working fine then you go
to the next level which is putting it
for production and then in production
obviously new data will come and
the inference happens so the model is
readily available and only thing that
happens is new data comes and the model
predicts the values and whether it is
regression or
or no so this can be an iterative
process so it is not a straightforward
process where you do the training
through the testing and then you move it
to production now so during the training
and test process there may be a
situation where because of either
overfitting or things like that the test
doesn't go through which means that you
need to put that back into the training
process so that can be a an iterative
process not only that even if the
training and test goes through properly
and you deploy the model in production
there can be a situation that the data
that actually comes the real data that
comes with that this model is failing so
in which case you may have to once again
go back to the drawing board or
initially it will be working fine but
over a period of time maybe due to the
change in the nature of the data once
again the accuracy will iterate so that
is again a recursive process so once in
a while you need to keep checking
whether the model is working fine or not
and if required you need to tweak it and
modify it and so on and so forth so net
net this is a continuous as process of
tweaking the model and testing it and
making sure it is up to date then you
might have question around deep learning
so because deep learning is now
associated with AI artificial
intelligence and so on so it can be as
simple as what is deep learning so I
think the best way to respond to this
could be deep learning is a part of
machine learning and then obviously the
question would be then what is the
difference right so deep learning you
need to mention there are two key parts
that interviewer will be looking for
when you are defining deep learning so
first is of course deep learning is a
subset of machine learning so machine
learning is still the bigger let's say
scope and deep learning is one part of
it so then what exactly is the
difference deep learning is primarily
when we are implementing these our
algorithms or when we are using neural
networks for doing our training and
classification and regression and all
that right so when we use neural network
then it is considered as deep learning
and the term deep comes from the fact
that you can have several layers of
neural networks and these are called
Deep neural networks and therefore the
term deep you know deep learning uh the
other difference between machine
learning and deep learning which the
interviewer may be wanting to hear is
that in case of machine learning the
feature engineering is done manually
what do we mean by feature engineering
basically when we are trying to train
our model we have our training data
right so we have our training label data
and this data has several let's say if
it is a regular table it has several
columns now each of these columns
actually has information about a feature
right so if we are trying to predict the
height weight and so on and so forth so
these are all features of human beings
let's say we have census data and we
have all this so those are the features
now that may be probably 350 or 100 in
some cases there may be 100 such
features now all of them do not
contribute to our model right so we as a
data scientist we have to decide whether
we should take all of them all the
features or we should throw away some of
them because again if we take all of
them number one of course your accuracy
will probably get affected but also
there is a computational part so if you
have so many teachers and then you have
so much data it becomes very tricky so
in case of machine learning we manually
take care of identifying the features
that do not contribute to the learning
process and thereby we eliminate those
features and so on right so this is
known as feature engineering and in
machine learning we do that manual
whereas in deep learning where we use
neural networks the model will
automatically determine which features
to use and which to not use and
therefore feature engineering is also
done automatically so this is a
explanation these are two key things
from probably will add value to your
response all right so the next question
is what is the difference between or
what are the differences between machine
learning and deep learning so here this
is a quick comparison table between
machine learning and deep learning and
in machine learning learning enables
missions to take decisions on their own
based on Fast data so here we are
talking primarily of supervised learning
and it needs only a small amount of data
for training and then works well on low
end system so you don't need a large
machine and most features need to be
identified in advance and manually coded
so basically the feature engineering
part is done manually and the problem is
divided into parts and solved
individually and then combined so that
is about the machine learning part in
deep learning deep learning basically
enables machines to take decisions with
the help of artificial neural network so
here in deep learning we use neural line
so that is the key differentiator
between machine learning and deep
learning and usually deep learning
involves a large amount of data and
therefore the training also requires
usually the training process requires
high-end machines because it needs a lot
of computing power and the Machine
learning features are the or the feature
engineering is done automatically so the
neural networks takes care of doing the
feature engineering as well and in case
of deep learning therefore it is said
that the problem is handled end to end
so this is a quick comparison between
machine learning and deep learning in
case you have that kind of then you
might get a question around the uses of
machine learning or some real life
applications of machine learning in
modern business the question may be
worded in different ways but the meaning
is how exactly is machine learning used
or actually supervised machine learning
it could be a very specific question
around supervised decision learning so
this is like give examples of supervised
machine learning use of supervised
machine learning in modern business so
that
the next so there are quite a few
examples or quite a few use cases if you
will for supervised definition learning
the very common one is email spam
detection so you want to train your
application or your system to detect
between spam and non-span so this is a
very common business application of a
supervised machine learning so how does
this work the way it works is that you
obviously have historical data above of
your emails and they are categorized as
spam and not spam so that is what is the
labeled information and then you feed
this information or the all these emails
as an input to your model right and the
model will then get trained to detect
which of the emails are to detect which
is Spam and which is not spam so that is
the training process and this is
supervised machine learning because you
have labeled data you already have
emails which are tagged as spam or not
and then you use that to train your
model right so this is one example now
there are a few industry specific
applications for supervised machine
learning one of the very common ones is
a healthcare Diagnostics in healthcare
Diagnostics you have these images and
you want to train models to detect
whether from a particular image whether
it can find out if the person is sick or
not whether a person has cancer or not
right so this is a very good example of
supervised machine learning here the way
it works is that existing images it
could be x-ray images it will be MRI or
any of these images are available and
they are saying that okay this x-ray
image is deflective of the person has an
illness or it could be cancer whichever
illness right so it is stacked as
defective or clear or good image and
effective image something like that so
we come up with the binary or it could
be multi-class as well saying that this
is defective to 10 percent this is 25
percent and so on but let's keep it
simple you can give an example of just a
binary classification that would be good
enough so you can say that in healthcare
Diagnostics using which we need to
detect whether a person is ill or
whether a person is having cancer or not
so here the way it works is you feed
labeled images and you allow the model
to learn from that so that when New
Image is fed it will be able to predict
whether this person is having that
illness or not having cancer right so I
think this would be a very good example
for supervised machine learning in
modern business all right then we can
have a question like so we've been
talking about supervised and uh
unsupervised and so there can be a
question around semi-supervised machine
learning so what is semi-supervised
machine learning now semi-supervised
learning as the name suggests it falls
between supervised learning and
unsupervised learning but for all
practical purposes it is considered as a
art of supervised learning and the
reason this has come into existence is
that in supervised learning you need
labeled data so all your data for
training your model has to be labeled
now this is a big problem in many
Industries or in many under many
situations getting the able data is not
that easy because there's a lot of
effort in labeling this data let's take
an example of diagnostic images
extra images now there are actually
millions of x-ray images available all
over the world but the problem is they
are not labeled so their images are
there but whether it is effective or
whether it is good and information is
not available along with it right in a
form that it can be used by a machine
which means that somebody has to take a
look at these images and usually it
should be like a doctor and then say
that okay yes this image is clean and
this image is cancerous and so on and so
forth now that is a huge effort by
itself so this is where semi-supervised
learning comes into play so what happens
is there is a large amount of data maybe
a part of it is labeled then we try some
techniques to label the remaining part
of the data so that we get completely
labeled data and then we train our model
so I know this is a little long-winding
explanation but unfortunately there is
no quick and easy definition for
semi-supervised machine learning this is
the only way probably to explain this
concept
we may have another question as what are
unsupervised machine learning techniques
or what are some of the techniques used
for performing unsupervised machine
learning so it can be worded in
different ways so how do we answer this
question so unsupervised learning you
can say that there are two types
clustering and Association and
clustering is a technique where similar
objects are put together and there are
different ways of finding similar
objects so their characteristics can be
measured and if they have in most of the
characteristics if they are similar then
they can be put together
then Association you can I think the
best way to explain Association is with
an example in case of Association you
try to find out how the items are linked
to each other for example if somebody
bought maybe a laptop the person has
also purchased a mouse so this is more
in an e-commerce scenario for example so
you can give this as an example so
people who are buying and laptops are
also buying a mouse so that means there
is an association between laptop
people who are buying bread are also
buying butter so that is the association
that can be created so this is
unsupervised learning one of the
techniques
links all right then we have very
fundamental question what is the
difference between supervised and
unsupervised machine learning so machine
learning these are the two main types of
machine learning supervised and
unsurvested and in case of supervised
and again here probably the key word
that the person may be wanting to hear
is labeled data now very often people
say we have historical data and if we
run it it is supervised and if we don't
have historical data yes but you may
have historical data but if it is not
labeled then you cannot use it for
so it is it's very key to understand
that we put in that keyword label okay
so when we have labeled data for
training our model then we can use
supervised learning and if we do not
have labeled data then we use
unsupervised learning and there are
different algorithms available to
perform both of these
so there can be another question a
little bit more theoretical and
conceptual in nature this is about
inductive machine learning and
active machine the question can be what
is the difference between inductive
machine learning and deductive machine
learning or some what in that manner so
that the exact phrase or exact question
carry they can ask for examples and
things like that but that could be the
question so let's first understand what
is inductive and deductive training
inductive training is induced by
somebody and you can illustrate that
with a small example I think that always
helps so whenever you're doing some
explanation try as much as possible as I
said to give examples from your work
experience or give some analogies and
that will also help a lot in explaining
as well and for the interviewer also to
understand so here we'll take an example
or rather we will use an analogy so
inductive training is when we induce
some knowledge or the learning process
into a person without the person
actually experiencing it what can be an
example so we can probably tell the
person or show a person a video that
fire can burn the thing burn his finger
or fire can cause damage so what is
happening here this person has never
probably seen a fire or never seen
anything getting damaged by fire but
just because he has seen this video he
knows that okay fire is dangerous and if
a fire can cause damage
right so this is inductive learning
compared to that what is deductive
learning so here you draw conclusion or
the person draws conclusion out of
experience so we will stick to the
analogy so compared to the showing a
video Let's assume a person is allowed
to play with fire right and then he
figures out that if he puts his finger
it's burning or you throw something into
the fire it burns so he is learning
through experience so this is known as
deductive learning okay so you can have
applications or models that can be
trained using inductive learning or
deductive learning all right I think
probably that explanation will
be sufficient the next question is are
knnn and K means clustering similar to
one another or are they same right
because the letter K is kind of common
between them okay so let us take a
little while to understand what these
two are one is KNN another is K means k
n stands for K nearest neighbors and K
means of course is the clustering
mechanism now these two are completely
different except for the letter K being
common between them KN is completely
different K means clustering is complete
KNN is a classification process and
therefore it comes under supervised
learning whereas k-means clustering is
actually a unsupervised okay when you
have K and N when you want to implement
k n n which is basically K nearest
neighbors the value of K is a number so
you can say k is equal to 3 you want to
implement k n n with K is equal to 3 so
which means that it performs the
classification in such a way that how
does it perform the classification so it
will take three nearest objects and
that's why it's called nearest neighbor
so basically uh based on the distance it
will try to find out its nearest objects
that are let's say three of the nearest
objects and then it will check whether
the class they belong to which class
right so if all three belong to one
particular class obviously this new
object is also classified as that
particular
but it is possible that they may be from
two or three different classes okay so
let's say they are from two classes and
then they are from two classes now
usually you take a odd number you assign
odd number two so if there are three of
them and two of them belong to one class
and then one belongs to another class so
this new object is assigned to the class
to which the two of them belong now the
value of K is sometimes tricky whether
should you use three should you use five
should you use seven that can be tricky
because the ultimate classification can
also vary so it's possible that if
you're taking K as3 the object is
probably in one particular class but if
you take K is equal to 5 maybe the
object will belong to a different class
because when you're taking three of them
probably two of them belong to a class
one and one belong to class two whereas
when you take five of them it is
possible that only two of them belong to
class one and the three of them belong
to Class 2 so which means that this
object will belong to class 2 right so
you see that so it is the class
allocation can vary depending on the
value of K now K means on the other hand
is a clustering process and it is
unsupervised where what it does is the
system will basically identify how the
objects are how close the objects are
with respect to some of their features
okay and but the similarity of course is
the the letter K and in case of K means
also we specify its value and it could
be 3 or 5 or 7 there is no technical
limit as such but it can be any number
of clusters that you can create okay so
based on the value that you provide the
system will create that many clusters of
similar objects so there is a similarity
to that extent that K is a number in
both the cases but actually these two
are completely different processes
we have what is known as naive based
classifier and people often get confused
thinking that naive base is the name of
the person who found this classifier or
who developed this classifier which is
not 100 True base is the name of the
person bais is the name of the person
but naive is not the name of the person
right so naive is basically an English
word and that has been added here
because of the nature of his particular
classifier an ibase classifier is a
probability based classifier and it
makes some assumptions that presence of
one feature of a class is not related to
the presence of any other feature of
maybe other classes right so which is
not a very strong or not a very what do
you say accurate assumption because
these features can be related and so on
but even if we go with this assumption
this whole algorithm works very well
even with this assumption and that is
the good side of it but the term comes
from that
the explanation that you can then there
can be question around reinforcement
learning it can be paraphrased in
multiple ways one could be can you
explain how a system can play a game of
chess
or it can be any game so the best way to
explain this is again to talk a little
bit about what reinforcement learning is
about and then elaborate on that to
explain the process so first of all
reinforcement learning has an
environment and an agent and the agent
is basically performing some actions in
order to achieve a certain goal and this
goals can be anything either if it is
related to game then the goal could be
that you have to score very high score
or it could be that your number of lives
should be as high as possible don't lose
life so this could be some of them a
more advanced examples could be for
driving the automotive industry
self-driving cars they actually also
make use of reinforcement learning to
teach the car how to navigate through
the roads and so on and so forth that is
also another example now how does it
work so if the system is basically there
is an agent and environment and every
time the agent takes a step or performs
a task which is taking it towards the
goal the final goal let's say to
maximize the score or to minimize the
number of lives and so on or minimize
that
well it is rewarded and every time it
takes a step which goes against that
core right contrary or in the reverse
Direction it is penalized okay so it is
like a character
now how do you use this to create a game
of chess so to create a system to play a
game on chess now the way this works is
and this could probably go back to this
alphago example where alphaco defeated a
human Champion so the way it works is in
reinforcement learning this system is
allowed for example if in this case we
are talking about Chess so we allow the
system to first of all watch playing a
game of chess would be with a human
being or it could be the system itself
there are computer games of Chess right
so either this new learning system has
to watch that game or watch a human
being play the game because this is
reinforcement learning is pretty much
all visual so when you're teaching the
system to play a game the system will
not actually go behind the scenes to
understand the logic of your software of
this game or anything like that it is
just visually watching the screen and
then it learns okay so reinforcement
learning to a large extent works on that
so you need to create a mechanism
whereby your model will be able to watch
somebody playing the game and then you
allow the system also to start playing
the game so it pretty much starts from
scratch okay and as it moves forward it
it's at right at the beginning the
system really knows nothing about the
game of chess okay so initially it is a
clean slate it just starts by observing
how you are playing so it will make some
random moves and keep losing badly but
then what happens is over a period of
time so you need to now allow the system
or you need to play with the system not
just one two three four or five times
but hundreds of times thousands of times
maybe even hundreds of thousands of
times and that's exactly how alphago has
done it played millions of games between
itself and the system right so for the
game of chess also you need to do
something like that you need to allow
the system to play chess and and learn
on its own over a period of repetition
so I think you can probably explain it
to this much to this extent and I
now this is another question which is
again somewhat similar but here the size
is not coming richer so the question is
how will you know which machine learning
algorithm to choose for your
classification problem now this is not
only classification problem it could be
a regression problem I would like to
generalize this question so if somebody
asks you how will you choose how will
you know which algorithm to use the
simple answer is there is no way you can
decide exactly saying that this is the
algorithm I am going to use in a variety
of situations there are some guidelines
like for example you will obviously
depending on the problem you can say
whether it is a classification problem
or a regression problem and then in that
sense you are kind of restricting
yourself to if it is a classification
problem there are you can only apply a
classification algorithm right to that
extent you can probably let's say limit
the number of algorithms but now within
the classification algorithms you have
decision trees you have SPM you have
logistic regression is it possible to
outright say yes so for this particular
problem since you have explained this
now this is the exact algorithm that you
can use that is
okay so we have to try out a bunch of
algorithms see which one gives us the
best performance best accuracy and then
decide to go with that particular
algorithm so in machine learning a lot
of it happens through trial and error
there is no real possibility that
anybody can just by looking at the
problem or understanding the problem
tell you that okay in this particular
situation this is exactly the algorithm
that you should use then the questions
may be around application of machine
learning and this question is
specifically around how Amazon is able
to recommend other things to buy so this
is around recommendation engine how does
it work how does a recommendation engine
work is basically the question is all
about so the recommendation engine again
Works based on various inputs that are
provided obviously something like uh you
know Amazon on a website or e-commerce
site like Amazon collects a lot of data
around the customer Behavior who is
purchasing what and if somebody is
buying a particular thing they're also
buying something else so this kind of
Association right so this is the
unsupervised learning we talked about
they use this to associate and Link or
relate items and that is one part of it
so they kind of build association
between items saying that somebody
buying this is also buying this that is
one part of it then they also profile
the users right based on their age their
gender their geographic location they
will do some profiling and then when
somebody is logging in and when somebody
is shopping kind of the mapping of these
two things are done they try to identify
obviously if you have logged in then
they know who you are and your
information is available like for
example your age may be your gender and
where you're located what you purchased
earlier right so all this is taken and
the recommendation engine basically uses
all this information and comes up with
recommendations for a particular user so
that is how the recommendation engine
work all right then the question can be
something very basic like when will you
go for classification versus regression
right when do you do classification
instead of instead of regression or when
will you use classification instead of
regression now yes so so this is
basically going back to the
understanding of the basics of
classification and regression so
classification is used when you have to
identify or categorize things into
discrete classes so the best way to
respond to this question is to take up
some examples and use it otherwise it
can become a little tricky the question
may sound very simple but explaining it
can sometimes be very tricky in case of
regression we use of course there will
be some keywords that they will be
looking for so just you need to make
sure you use those keywords one is the
discrete values and other is the
continuous values so for regression if
we are trying to find some continuous
values you use regression whereas if you
are trying to find some discrete values
you use classification and then you need
to illustrate what are some of the
examples so classification is like let's
say there are images and you need to put
them into classes like cat dog elephant
title something like that so that is the
classification problem or it can be that
is a multi-class classification problem
it could be binary classification
problem like for example whether a
customer will buy or he will not buy
that is a classification binary
classification it can be in the weather
forecast area now weather forecast is
again combination of regression and
classification because on the one hand
you want to predict whether it's going
to rain or not it's a classification
problem that's a binary classification
right whether it's going to rain or not
rain however you also have to predict
what is going to be the temperature
tomorrow right now temperature is a
continuous value you can't answer the
temperature in a yes or no kind of a
response right so what will be the
temperature tomorrow so you need to give
a number which can be like 20 degrees 30
degrees or whatever right so that is
where you use regression one more
example is stock price prediction so
that is where again you will use
regression so these are the various
examples so you need to illustrate with
examples and make sure you include those
keywords like discrete and continuous so
the next question is more about a little
bit of a design related question to
understand your Concepts and things that
so it is how will you design a spam
filter so how do you basically design
our developers
so I think the main thing here is he is
looking at probably understanding your
Concepts in terms of uh what is the
algorithm you will use or what is your
understanding about difference between
classification and regression
regression things like that right and
the process of course now the Metallurgy
and the process so the best way to go
about responding to this is we say that
okay this is a classification problem
we want to find out whether an email is
a spam or not spam so that we can apply
the filter accordingly so first thing is
to identify what type of a problem it is
so we have identified that it is a
classification then the second step may
be to find out what kind of algorithm to
use now since this is a binary
classification problem logistic
regression is a very common very common
algorithm but however right as I said
earlier also we can never say that okay
for this particular problem this is
exactly the algorithm that we can use so
we can also probably try decision trees
or even support Vector machines for
example svm so we will kind of list down
a few of these algorithms and we will
say okay we want to we would like to try
out these algorithms and then we go
about taking your historical data which
is the labeled data which are marked so
you will have a bunch of emails and then
you split that into training and test
data sets you use your training data set
to train your model that or your
algorithm that you have used or rather
the model actually
so and you actually will have three
models let's say you are trying to test
out three algorithms so you will
obviously have three models so you need
to try all three models and test them
out as well see which one gives the best
accuracy and then you decide that you
will go with that model okay so training
and test will be done and then you zero
in on one particular model and then you
say okay this is the model will you use
we will use and then go ahead and
Implement that or put that in production
so that is the way you design a spam the
next question is about random Forest
what is random for so this is a very
straightforward question however the
response you need to be again a little
careful while we all know what is random
Forest explaining this can sometimes be
tricky so one thing is random Forest is
kind of in one way it is an extension of
decision trees because it is basically
nothing but you have multiple decision
trees and trees will basically you will
use for doing if it is classification
mostly it is classification you will use
the the trees for classification and
then you use voting for finding that the
final class so that is the underlyings
but how will you explain this how will
you respond to this so first thing
obviously we will say that random Forest
is one of the algorithms and the more
important thing that you need to
probably the interviewer is is waiting
to here is Ensemble learner right so
this is one type of Ensemble learner
what is Ensemble learner Ensemble
learner is like a combination of
algorithms so it is a learner which
consists of more than one algorithm or
more than one or maybe models okay so in
case of random Forest the algorithm is
the same but instead of using one
instance of it we use multiple instances
of it and we use so in a way that is a
random Forest is an ensemble there are
other types of Ensemble Learners where
we have like reuse different algorithms
itself so you have one maybe logistic
regression and a decision tree combined
together and so on and so forth or there
are other ways like for example
splitting the data in a certain way and
so on so that's all about on some
to that but random Forest itself I think
the interviewer will be happy to hear
this word Ensemble Learners and so then
you go and explain how the random Forest
works so if the random Forest is used
for classification then we use what is
known as a voting mechanism so basically
how does it work let's say your random
Forest consists of 100 trees and each
observation you pass through this forest
and each observation let's say it is a
classification problem binary
classification zero or one and you have
100 trees now if 90 trees say that it is
a zero and ten of the trees say it is a
one you take the majority you may take a
vote and since 90 of them are saying
zero you classify this as zero then you
take the next observation and so on so
that is the way random Forest works for
classification it is a regression
problem it's somewhat similar but only
thing is instead of 4 what we will do is
sorry in regression remember what
happens you actually calculate a value
right so for example you're using
regression to predict the temperature
and you have 100 trees and each tree
obviously will probably predict a
different value of the temperature they
may be close to each other but they may
not be exactly the same value so these
hundred trees so how do you now find the
actual value the output for the entire
Forest right so you have outputs of
individual trees which are a part of
this Forest but then you need to find
the final output of the forest itself so
how do you do that so in case of
regression you take like an average or
the mean of all the 100 trees right so
this is also a way of reducing the error
so maybe if you have only one tree and
that one tree makes a header it is
basically hundred percent wrong or 100
right right but if you have on the other
hand if you have a bunch of trees you
are basically medicating that reducing
that error okay so that is the way
random Forest works so the next question
is considering the long list of machine
learning algorithms how will you decide
on which one to use so once again here
there is no way to outright say that
this is the algorithm that we will use
for a given data set this is a very good
question but then the response has to be
like again there will not be a
one-size-fits all so we need to first of
all you can probably shorten the list in
terms of by saying okay whether it is a
classification problem or it is a
regression problem to that extent you
can probably shorten the list because
you don't have to use all of them if it
is a classification problem you only can
pick from the classification algorithm
right so for example if it's a
classication you cannot use linear
regression algorithm or if it is a
regression problem you cannot use svm or
maybe now you can use svm but maybe a
logistic regression right so to that
extent you can probably shorten the list
but still you will not be able to 100
decide on saying that this is the exact
algorithm that I am going to use so the
way to go about is you choose a few
algorithms based on what the problem is
you try out your data you train some
models of these algorithms check which
one gives you the lowest error or the
highest accuracy and based on that you
choose that particular algorithm
all right then they can be questions
around bias and variants so the question
can be what is bias and variance in
machine learning uh so you just need to
give out a definition for each of these
for example a bias in machine learning
it occurs when the predicted values are
far away from the actual value so that
is the bias okay and whereas they are
all all the values are probably they are
far off but they are very near to each
other though the predicted values are
close to each other right while they are
far off from the actual value but they
are close to each other you see the
difference so that is bias and then the
other part is your variance now variance
is when the predicted values are all
over the place right so the variance is
high that means it may be close to the
Target but it is kind of very scattered
so the points the predicted values are
not close to each other right in case of
bias the predicted values are close to
each other but they are not close to the
Target but here they may be close to the
Target but they may not be close to each
other so they are a little bit more
scattered so that is what in case of a
variance okay then the next question is
about again related to bias and variance
what is the trade-off between bias and
variance yes I think this is a
interesting question because these two
are heading in different directions so
for example if you try to minimize the
bias variance will keep going high and
if you try to minimize the variance bias
will keep going high and there is no way
you can minimize both of them so you
need to have a trade-off saying that
okay this is the level at which I I will
have my bias and this is the level at
which I will have variance so the
trade-off is that pretty much attack you
you decide what is the level you will
all rate for your bias and what is the
level you will tolerate for variance and
a combination of these two in such a way
that your final results are not way off
and having a trade-off will ensure that
the results are consistent right so that
is basically the output is consistent
and which means that they are close to
each other and they are also accurate
right that means they are as close to
the Target as possible right so if
either of these is high then one of them
will go off the track define precision
and Recall now again here I think it
would be best to draw a diagram and take
up in the confusion Matrix and it is
very simple the definition is like a
formula your Precision is true positive
by group positive plus false positive
and your recall is true positive by true
positive plus false negative okay so
that's you can just show it in a
mathematical way that's pretty much you
know
that's the easiest way to define so the
next question can be about decision tree
what is decision tree pruning and why is
it so basically decision trees are
really
supplement and understand but one of the
drawbacks of decision trees is that it
can become highly complicated as it
grows right and the rules and conditions
can become very
excited and this can also lead to
overfitting which is basically that
during training you will get 100
accuracy but when you're doing testing
you'll get a lot of Errors so that is
the reason pruning needs to be done so
the purpose or the reason for doing
decision tree pruning is to reduce
overfitting or to cut down on our
fitting and what is decision tree
rolling it is basically that you reduce
the number of branches because as you
may be aware a tree consists of the root
node and then there are several internal
nodes and then you have the leaf nodes
now if there are too many of these
internal nodes that is when you face the
problem of overfitting and pruning is
the process of reducing those internal
nodes all right so the next question can
be what is logistic regression uh so
basically logistic regression is one of
the techniques used for performing
classification especially binary
classification now there is something
special about logistic regression and
there are a couple of things you need to
be careful about first of all the name
is a little confusing it is called
logistic regression but it is used for
classification so this can be sometimes
confusing so you need to probably
clarify that to the interviewer if it's
really you know required and they can
also ask this like a request
request so that is one second thing is
the term logistic has nothing to do with
the usual Logistics that we talk about
but it is derived from log so that the
mathematical derivation was log and
therefore the name
so what is logistic regression and how
is it used so logistic regression is
used for binary classification and the
output of a logistic regression is
either a zero or a one and it varies so
it's basically it calculates a
probability between 0 and 1 and we can
set a threshold that can vary typically
it is 0.5 so any value above 0.5 is
considered as 1 and if the probability
is below 0.5 it is considered as zero so
that is the way we calculate the
probability of the system calculates the
probability and based on the threshold
it sets a value of 0 or 1 which is like
a binary classification zero or one okay
then we have a question around K nearest
neighbor algorithm so explain K nearest
neighbor algorithm so first of all what
is the K nearest neighbor algorithm this
is a classification algorithm so that is
the first thing we need to mention and
we also need to mention that the K is a
number it is an an integer and this is
variable and we can Define what the
value of K should be it can be 2 3 5 7
and usually it is an odd number so that
is something we need to mention
technically it can be even number also
but then typically it would be odd
number and we will see why that is okay
so based on that we need to classify
objects okay we need to classify objects
so again it will be very helpful to draw
a diagram you know if you're explaining
I think that will be the best way so
draw some diagram like this and let's
say we have three clusters or three
classes existing and now you want to
find for a new item that has come you
want to find out which class this
belongs right so you go about as the
name suggests it you go about finding
the nearest neighbors right the points
which are closest to this and how many
of them you will find that is what is
defined by K now let's say our initial
value of K was 5 okay so you will find
find the K the five nearest data points
so in this case as it is Illustrated
these are the five nearest data points
but then all five do not belong to the
same class or cluster so there are one
belonging to this cluster one the second
one belonging to this cluster two three
of them belonging to this third cluster
okay so how do you decide that's exactly
the reason we should as much as possible
try to assign an odd number so that it
becomes easier to assign this so in this
case you see that the majority actually
if there are multiple classes then you
go with the majority so since three of
these items belong to this class we
assign which is basically the in in this
case the green or the tennis or the
third cluster as I was talking
right so we assign it to this third
class so in this case it is uh that's
how it is decided okay so K nearest
neighbors the first thing is to identify
the number of neighbors that are
mentioned as K so in this case it is K
is equal to 5 so we find the five
nearest points and then find out out of
these five which class has the maximum
number in that and and then the new data
point is assigned to that class okay so
that's pretty much how K nearest
neighbors we have reached the end of
this session on the machine learning
full course should you have any
questions in mind need any assistance in
your Learning Journey or looking for
resources like the pbd project code and
other resources used in this session
please let us know in the comment
section below and our team of experts
will be happy to help you at the
earliest until next time thank you stay
safe and keep learning stay tuned for
more from Simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here